PARDON ME THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN
SESSION FORM IS NOT PRESENT.
MEMBERS PLEASE REPORT TO THE
FLOOR.
ASSEMBLY IS IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AND THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY
ALLEN
ARAMBULA. BAKER. BERMAN.
BIGELOW. BLOOM.
BONTA. BROUGH.
BURKE CABALLERO. CALDERON
CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHAVEZ
CHEN. DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY. COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY.
DALY EGGMAN FLORA. FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY GRAYSON
HARPER HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE. KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON OWN. LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES.
CARTY MEDINA. MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON.
QUIRK QUIRK SILVA. REYES
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO STEINORTH STONE.
THURMOND.
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER. WOOD. MISTER
SPEAKER
MEMBERS PLEASE COME TO THE
FLOOR WE HAVE QUITE A BIT OF
BUSINESS BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
TODAY.
MEMBERS I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
REPORT TO THE FLOOR AS SOON AS.
PRACTICABLE
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT
.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND PATTY OSHA. PRODUCTION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
OVER THE DECADES WHEN WE HAVE
COUNSELED COUPLES BEFORE
MARRIAGE.
ONE POINT WE HAVE EMPHASIZED
THIS THIS.
YOU WOULD NEVER HAVE CONSIDERED
MARRIAGE IF HE NEVER FIRST
BECAME FRIENDS.
YOUR FRIENDSHIP IS THE
FOUNDATION OF YOUR LOVE.
THE FRIENDSHIP YOU SHARE WILL BE
AT THE HEART OF ALL THAT YOU
WILL SHARE IN YOUR LIFE TOGETHER.
IN THIS SHOULD NEVER BE TAKEN
FOR GRANTED.
THE HISTORICAL GHATAM A BUDDHA
ONCE SAID.
FRIENDSHIP IS NOT SOMETHING WE
CAN ASK FOR LIKE A GLASS OF
WATER.
FRIENDSHIP IS SOMETHING WE ARE
OFFERED LIKE A CUP OF TEA.
LET US TRY TO BE GRATEFUL FOR
EVERY FRIENDSHIP WE HAVE IN OUR
LIVES.
FOR EVERY TRUE FRIENDSHIP
OFFERED. IS A GIFT OF LOVING
KINDNESS WE ARE FORTUNATE TO
RECEIVE.
NOW MAUREEN DOWD SAID WITH
KINDNESS INGRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND A SHOW OF
TOUCH PATH WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER FRAZIER.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SALUTING OUR FLAG.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY MAY
SIXTEENTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN THESE
ELEMENT AT SEVEN A. M. I WILL
CECILIA AGUIAR-CURRY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOURTH DISTRICT PRESIDING
CHIEF COOKIE DOTSON WILSON AT
THE DESK. MEANING LIKE CAPTAIN
AND MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS HAVE THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATION OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION REFERENCE
OF BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
WE TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
THE ABSENCES FOR THE DAY THERE
ARE NO ABSENCES TODAY
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
PERMIT THE BUDGET CONFEREES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STING ARAMBULA
BLOOM CHáVEZ AND OBERNOLTE. TO
ADD THEIR VOTES TO ROLL CALL
VOTES TAKEN ON THIS DAY AS IF
PRESIDENT WHILE THEY ATTEND
BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MISTER GALLAGHER FOR WHAT
PURPOSE SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I MOVED TO SUSPEND THE RULES
AND WITHDRAW AB TWENTY THREE
FIFTY SIX KILEY. FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
AND ORDER THE BILL BE TAKEN UP
IMMEDIATELY WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE.
THEY WAS GALLAGHER THAT REQUIRES
A SECOND MISTER KILEY SECONDS
THAT'S A MOTION TO SUSPEND THE
RULES BEFORE THE BODY MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE.
IN THIS CASE MISTER CALDERON HIS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE AND MISTER
GALLAGHER IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
IT'S NOT DEBATABLE IT'S A AB
SUSPENSION OF THE RULES
PROCEDURAL VOTE.
REQUIRES A MAJORITY.
CARPOOL OPEN THE ROLE MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
MISTER GALLAGHER IS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE MISTER CALDERON AND
NO.
MISTER GALLAGHER AND I.
IT'S REQUIRES A MAJORITY OF THIS
HOUSE.
THIS CALDERON HOUSING FOR A NO
AND MR MATHIS'S.
PARMI MISTER GALLAGHER IS ASKING
FOR.
AND I.
MEMBERS THIS IS PROCEDURAL
.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
TALBOT EYES TWENTY TWO KNOWS
THIRTY SEVEN.
THAT MOTION FAILS.
MEMBERS I BELIEVE WE'RE READY TO
MOVE TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE.
WE HAVE LOTS OF BUSINESS BEFORE
THE ASSEMBLY TODAY MEMBERS A FEW
OF NOT DONE SO PLEASE COME
FLOOR IMMEDIATELY
OKAY. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
PASS AND RETAIN A FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AYE CONCURRENCE.
ON MOTIONS TO RECONSIDER FILE
ITEMS FOR.
THROUGH TEN ARE TO BE CONTINUED.
LOOKING AT THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE WE ARE GOING TO
PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEMS ELEVEN AND TWELVE.
PASSER RETAIN ON THIRTEEN AND
FOURTEEN.
PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM FIFTEEN PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM SIXTEEN.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN.
BY MISTER HOLDEN.
IS FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN.
THIS IS A BE.
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY THREE ON THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
THREE BY SOME A MEMBER HOLDEN
AND ACTUALLY THE HEALING ARTS.
MR HOLDING. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY THREE A BILL THAT
WILL REMOVE A HARMFUL BARRIER
FOR STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
THAT WAS INADVERTENTLY CREATED
BY PRIOR LEGISLATION.
IF A CHILD HAS A DISABILITY
THE FEDERAL IDEA ACT AND
CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRE EDUCATORS
AND PARENTS TO COME TOGETHER.
AND CREATE A PLAN THAT ENABLES A
CHILD TO GET THE BEST EDUCATION
POSSIBLE.
THIS IS CALLED AN INDIVIDUALIZED
EDUCATION PLAN OR IEP.
THE I IF YOU CAN INCLUDE
ANYTHING FROM WHERE A STUDENT
SHOULD SIT IN CLASS TO THE TYPE
OF DUST THE NEED. TO HOW OFTEN
THEY NEED BREAKS.
IT CAN BE IT CAN ALSO RECOMMEND
VISITS BY A PHYSICAL THERAPIST
TO ENSURE THEIR MOBILITY ISSUES
ARE ADDRESSED. AND NOT A
HINDRANCE TO THE EDUCATION
PROCESS
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB ONE
THOUSAND WHICH ALLOWED PATIENTS
DIRECT ACCESS TO A PHYSICAL
THERAPIST. FOR FORTY FIVE DAYS
OR TWELVE VISITS BEFORE REVIEW
BY THE PATIENT'S PHYSICIAN.
THIS WAS A MAJOR CHANGE FOR
PATIENTS A PHYSICAL THERAPISTS
RELATED TO MEDICAL CONDITIONS
ARE RECEIVING EFFICIENT CARE.
HOWEVER IN PASSING THIS WE
INADVERTENTLY CREATED HURDLE FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES BY
CONFLICT BY CONFLICT WITH
FEDERAL LAW.
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY THREE WILL
CLARIFY THAT AB ONE THOUSAND
DOES NOT APPLY TO THE FEDERALLY
MANDATED SERVICES. THAT ARE
EDUCATIONALLY NECESSARY AND
PROVIDE TO IMPROVE STUDENTS
ACCESS TO EDUCATION AS CONTAINED
IN AN I EP.
WE HAVE WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
CMA AND OTHER POSITION GROUPS
AND THE EDUCATION COMMUNITY TO
MAKE SURE THE SUPPLIES STRICTLY
TO THESE SITUATIONS. AND IS NOT
A RE OPENING OF THE AGREEMENT
REACHED BETWEEN PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS AND ORGANIZED
MEDICINE. BUT IN A WAY THAT
MAKES SURE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AREN'T HINDERED
FROM GETTING THE HELP THEY
RECEDE BEFORE THE PRIOR LAW WAS
ENACTED. AND TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN.
SAME NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM.
CORPORAL OF THE ROLE. ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICD NINE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEMS
EIGHTEEN.
AND NINETEEN.
PARDON ME.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM.
TWENTY.
THAT IS AB TWENTY IN.
SORRY MEASURES HOW WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE BACK TO TAKE A FILE ITEM
NINETEEN BY MISS CARILLO IF YOU
ARE READY.
MYSTERY WE'RE GOING TO CLARIFY
ONE THING BEFORE WE TAKE THAT
ITEM UP IF WE MAY
MISS KOREA WE ARE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY.
ON YOUR RIGHT THEM.
THAT IS FILE ITEM NINETEEN.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE A
FILE ON TWENTY AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTY FIVE BY MR CHOW.
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY WILL
TWENTY NINE THIRTY FIVE BY SOME
THE MEMBER CHAO AND AFTER GOING
TO PRIVACY.
MR JOB. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY
NINE THIRTY FIVE WOULD PROHIBIT
THE OPERATOR OF THE COMMERCIAL
HEALTH MONITORING PROGRAM. FROM
INTENTIONALLY SHARING WHAT
DISCLOSING A CONSUMERS
INDIVIDUAL IDENTIFIABLE HEALTH
MONITORING INFORMATION WITH A
THIRD PARTY WITHOUT FIRST
OBTAINING THE CONSUMER'S CONSENT.
CURRENTLY AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
THE HEALTH INSURANCE PORTABILITY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY ACT OF
NINETEEN NINETY SIX WHAT HIPAA
PLACES STRICT REQUIREMENTS ON
THE SHARING OF PROTECTED HEALTH
INFORMATION AND PROVIDES
PROTECTION TO CONSUMERS. BY
GIVING THEM THE RIGHT TO KNOW
WHO HAS ACCESS TO THEIR PERSONAL
HEALTH DATA.
AT SAME TIME CALIFORNIA HAS
ESTABLISHED THE CONFIDENTIALITY
OF MEDICAL INFORMATION ACT OR
CMI EIGHT. TO PROTECT AN
INDIVIDUAL'S MEDICAL INFORMATION
FROM UNAUTHORIZED DISCLOSURE.
DESPITE THE PROTECTIONS UNDER
HIPAA AND CMI EIGHT THERE IS NO
FRAMEWORK OF PROTECTION FOR
HEALTH DATA WHICH IS GENERATED
OUTSIDE OF THE MEDICAL SETTING.
OPERATORS OF COMMERCIAL HEALTH
MONITORING PROGRAMS ARE
THEREFORE ABLE TO SHARE OR SELL
CONSUMERS PERSONAL IDENTIFIABLE
HEALTH DATA TO THIRD PARTY
WITHOUT OBTAINING THE CONSUMER'S
CONSENT. THIS BILL WAS SIMPLY
REQUIRED CONSUMER CONSENT BE
OBTAINED PRIOR TO SHARING OF THE
SENSITIVE OUR HEALTH INFORMATION
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
YOU CAN TAKE A SHALL. SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK LIBERAL. ON MEMBERS OF OUR
DESIRE TO VOTE ON THE
IT'S VOTERS ARE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF OF
SHAMUS CALL
.
OR TO PASS TEMPORARILY AND FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE.
FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO.
IS AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE BY MR
CHOW.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FIFTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHILD AND
ACTUALLY TO INFORMATION PRIVACY.
MICHELLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
NINE WILL REQUIRE. CONSUMER
CREDIT REPORTING AGENCIES OR CCR
REYES TO PATCH VULNERABLE
COMPUTER SYSTEMS IN A TIMELY
MANNER. THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EQUIFAX DATA BREACH RESULTED IN
THE LOSS OF A HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN MILLION. U. S. CONSUMERS
PERSONAL INFORMATION.
PRIOR TO THE BREACH ON MARCH THE
EIGHTH TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE US
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
NOTIFY EQUIFAX OF THE NEED.
THE PATCH SECURITY
VULNERABILITIES AND A SOFTWARE
CALL APACHE STRUTS.
HOWEVER EQUIFAX NEVER
IMPLEMENTED THE PATCH.
CONSEQUENTLY BETWEEN MAY
THIRTEEN AND JULY THIRTY OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN PACKERS
EXPLOITED THE VULNERABILITY TO
ACCESS SENSITIVE PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
INCLUDING CONSUMERS NAMES SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS BIRTH DATES AND
IN SOME INSTANCES DRIVER'S
LICENSE AND CREDIT CARD
INFORMATION.
THIS BILL AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE
WILL REQUIRE CREDIT REPORTING
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA TO BEGIN
TO IMPLEMENT A PATCH OF ITS
COMPUTER SYSTEM WITHIN THREE
DAYS. AND TO COMPLETE THE
INSTALLATION WITHIN THE MOST
EXPEDIENT TIME POSSIBLE
CONSISTENT WITH INDUSTRY BEST
PRACTICES BUT NO LONGER THAN
THIRTY DAYS.
IF THE ONE ABILITY COULD
COMPROMISE DISK SECURITY OF
COMPUTERIZED DATA CONTAINING
PERSONAL INFORMATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THINGS SHALL SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK GLOBAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS OF
THESE ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ON TIE VOTE
EYES FORTY TWO KNOWS TWELVE THAT
MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WERE TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON A VARIETY OF
ITEMS HERE TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE.
TWENTY SIX.
TWENTY SEVEN MISTER HYSTERIA IS
AT HIS DESK.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
MR HIS AREA IN THIS.
FILE ITEM TWENTY.
EIGHT.
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY.
THE CLERK WILL READ. AT SOME
LEGAL TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KNOWS ARIANNA
AND ACTUALLY THE SCHOOL
FACILITIES MISTER NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEKER I'M
PRESENTING AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY THAT CLEAN AND HEALTHY
SCHOOLS ACT.
SPELL REQUIRES ALL KEY THROUGH
TWELVE SCHOOLS WITH FIFTY OR
MORE STUDENTS TO SWITCH TO SAFER
ENVIRONMENTALLY PREFERABLE
CLEANING PRODUCTS. OR MORE
SIMPLY GREEN CLEANING PRODUCTS
A GREEN CLEANING PRODUCTS ARE
THOSE THAT ARE INDEPENDENTLY
CERTIFIED BY A THIRD PARTY. AS
HAVING GREATLY REDUCE THE FACTS
ON HUMAN HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT.
SCHOOLS ARE ONLY REQUIRED TO
SWITCH TO GREEN CLEANING
PRODUCTS IF IT IS ECONOMICALLY
FEASIBLE AND WILL. I HAVE NO NET
COST INCREASE
IN REALITY ALMOST EVERY
INSTITUTION ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AS ACTUALLY SAVE MONEY AFTER
SWITCHING TO GREEN CLEANING
PRODUCTS. BY REQUIRING SCHOOLS
TO SWITCH TO GOING GREEN
CLEANING PRODUCTS AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY WILL HELP AVOID THE USE
OF CLEANING PRODUCTS THAT ARE
HARMFUL TO TEACHERS.
STUDENTS CUSTODIAL STAFF OF THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF EXPOSURE MY
OFFICE HAS BEEN AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH INDUSTRY.
A A TO RECONCILE ANY REMAINING
DIFFERENCES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE.
THEY MISSION IS AREA. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
PURPLE OF THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
RUN TO SARAH VOTE.
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
MISTER THIS AREA
.
MR THIS AREA.
MISTER JERRY MOVES A CALL
.
OKAY MEMBERS IN FILE ORDER.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE.
AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FIVE I
MISS FRIEDMAN CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE WILD AND SCENIC RIVERS. WAS
FRIEDMAN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY FIVE REQUIRES THE
SECRETARY OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY AT THEIR
DISCRETION TO TAKE ACTION TO ADD
ANY CALIFORNIA RECOUP RIVER IN
THE NATIONAL WILD AND SCENIC
RIVERS SYSTEM. THAT IS REMOVED
DELISTED OR WHOSE PROTECTIONS
ARE WEAKENED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO THE STATE WILD AND
SCENIC RIVERS SYSTEM IF IT IS
NOT ALREADY PART OF THAT STATE
SYSTEM.
IT ALLOWS THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR TO STATUTORILY REPEAL
OR MODIFY THE DESIGNATION
ANYTIME IT LIMITS PROTECTION TO
FEDERAL REVERSE DESIGNATED AS OF
JANUARY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. AND THEIR EXISTING
GEOGRAPHIC LENGTH
AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FIVE ANY
PROTECTIONS GRANTED ANY RIVER
UNDER AT SUNSET ON DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
UNLESS THE LEGISLATURE ACTS TO
PROTECT THESE RIVERS PERMANENTLY.
MEMBERS WHEN WE BEGAN WITH THIS
BILL IT HAD A LOT OF OPPOSITION
AND WE DID WHAT EVERYBODY ASKS
US TO DO WE WORKED VERY VERY
HARD WITH THE OPPOSITION AND GOT
THEM THROUGH THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE TOOK. TO DROP THEIR
OPPOSITION THESE RECENT
AMENDMENTS REMOVE THE OPPOSITION
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THE FARM BUREAU WESTERN
GROWERS THE WINE INSTITUTE AND
THE ASSOCIATION OF WATER
AGENCIES AND MANY MANY OTHERS.
AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FIVE
SUPPORTED BY FRIENDS OF THE
RIVER SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA AND
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL I ASK YOU TO PLEASE.
GIVE US AN AYE VOTE AND HELP
PROTECT OUR RIVERS IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
THEY WAS FRIEDMAN MR MATHIS. YES
FROM US BIGGER MEMBERS AS A
PROUD SPORTSMEN AND SOMEBODY WHO
ACTUALLY LIKES TO GET OUT AND GO
FISHING WITH MY CHILDREN.
THIS ACTUALLY BLOCKS ACCESS.
FOR OUR FISHERMEN.
WHICH IS A HIGHLY.
ANTICIPATED EVENT SUPPORT MY
DISTRICT ARE MAKES SPECIALLY IN
MY LAKE ISABELLA AREAS AND IN MY
INYO COUNTY AREA.
WORRY OF SOME OF THE BEST TROUT
FISHING IN THE WORLD. MEMBERS I
ASK YOU TO OPPOSE THIS AND KEEP
OUTDOORSMAN SHIP ALIVE.
THEY WISH MATHIS SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM IS FRIEDMAN YOU MAY
CLOSE IF YOU WISH THANK YOU THIS
BILL CHANGES ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
NOTHING AT ALL AND LESSER RIVER
WHICH IS CURRENTLY PROTECTED IS
DELISTED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SO WILL NOT BLOCK
FISHING OR HAVE ANY OTHER
ADVERSE EFFECTS AND AGAIN I ASK
YOU IF YOU SUPPORTER WILD RIVERS
IN CALIFORNIA.
THROUGH THE PLEASE VOTE I THINK
YOU.
FAMOUS ROOM WITH THAT PURPLE THE
ROLE. ON MEMBERS OF.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR OWN TIME TO VOTE.
I FORTY THREE KNOWS NINETEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM THIRTY.
IS AB THIRTY THIRTY BY MISS
CABALLERO.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY THIRTY BY
SOME THE MEMBER CABALLERO
ACTUALLY THEM BY MENTAL QUALITY.
MISS CAMINO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AS ELECTED OFFICIALS.
WE REGULARLY HERE FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS
ABOUT PERVASIVE POVERTY.
AND HARDSHIP IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND COMMUNITIES.
POVERTY THAT RESULTS FROM THE
LACK OF ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AND
A GOOD PAYING JOB.
POVERTY THAT SCULPTURES AMBITION.
HOPE.
AN OPPORTUNITY.
POVERTY.
THAT LEADS TO RESIGNATION AND
DESPAIR.
AND A DEAD END STREET FOR TOO
MANY CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES.
MY BILL A. B. THIRTY THIRTY IS A
MODEST ATTEMPT.
I JOIN FORCES WITH A FEDERAL TAX
CREDIT. DESIGNED TO FUNNEL AN
ESTIMATED SIX TRILLION DOLLARS
I'M GONNA REPEAT THAT.
SIX
TRILLION DOLLARS FROM CAPITAL
GAINS EARNINGS INTO AMERICA'S
POOREST NEIGHBORHOODS.
EACH STATE WAS REQUIRED TO
IDENTIFY AS OPPORTUNITIES OWNS
THE CENSUS TRACKS WHERE POVERTY
IS THE HIGHEST.
AND THE MOST INTRACTABLE.
CALIFORNIA IDENTIFIED EIGHT
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE OPPORTUNITY
ZONES DESPITE HAVING THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
MEMBERS WE NEED TO ACT.
AB THIRTY THIRTY ATTACKS POVERTY
IN THE EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
NINE DESIGNATED OPPORTUNITIES
OWNS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
BY CREATING MARKET CONDITIONS
FOR PRIVATE INVESTMENT CAPITAL
TO REACH COMMUNITIES MOST
IMPACTED BY CHRONIC POVERTY.
AB THIRTY THIRTY MAKES
CALIFORNIA'S POOREST AREAS
ATTRACTIVE FOR OPPORTUNITIES OWN
FUND INVESTMENTS WITHOUT
COMMITTING A DOLLAR OF LOCAL. OR
STATE FUNDS
A LAKE A LACK OF ACCESS
TO INVESTMENT CAPITALS HEAPS
POOR PEOPLE POOR.
PRIVATE INVESTMENTS TO
OPPORTUNITIES OWN SPINES WILL
CLOSE IN TWENTY TWENTY SIX
SO THERE IS A VERY SHORT WINDOW
OF SEVEN YEARS TO TAP INTO THE
SIX.
TRILLION DOLLAR MARKET A PRIVATE
INVESTMENT.
THIS BILL CREATES OF FAST PATH
TO NEW ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN OUR
POOREST COMMUNITIES BY EXEMPTING
SEQUEL. FROM SEAQUEST CERTAIN
PROJECTS THAT PROVIDE FOR
COMMUNITY INPUT AND IS
CONSISTENT WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PERMITS ZONING AND LAND USE
DESIGNATIONS ARE FUNDED BY
FEDERAL FEDERALLY FUNDED A
QUALIFIED. OPPORTUNITIES OWN
FUNDS AND MEET STRINGENT
PRECONDITIONS TO PROTECT AGAINST
ANY DISPLACEMENT OF EXISTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS AND
NEIGHBORHOOD GENTRIFICATION.
ALONG WITH OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS.
OVER NINETY PER FIVE PERCENT OF
THE TRACKS IN CALIFORNIA'S
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS OVERLAP. WITH
AB FIFTY FIFTEEN FIFTY
DESIGNATIONS MEANING THAT THESE
AREAS ARE SLATED TO RECEIVE.
MONEY FROM THE CAP AND TRADE
FUNDS FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY INVESTMENTS.
THIS BILL CREATES A MULTIPLIER
EFFECT ON THOSE INVESTMENTS WITH
THE POTENTIAL TO DIRECTLY DRIVE
PRIVATE CAPITAL INTO POOR
COMMUNITIES AT NEVER AT LEVELS
NEVER BEFORE REACHED.
NEARLY EVERY MEMBER IN THIS
ASSEMBLY HAS OPPORTUNE
OPPORTUNITY ZONES DESIGNATED IN
THEIR DISTRICTS.
COMMUNITIES THAT WILL BENEFIT BY
ATTRACTING CAPITAL FROM PRIVATE
INVESTORS.
AT POLICY COMMITTEES AB THIRTY
THIRTY HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND HAS THE SUPPORT OF THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY AND THE
BUILDING TRADES.
MEMBERS ARE POOREST COMMUNITIES
NEED A ROBUST PLATFORM
TO GO INTO THE PRIVATE
MARKETPLACE AND COMPETE FOR
OPPORTUNITIES OWN FUNDS.
GIVE THEM THIS BY VOTING AYE ON
AB THIRTY THIRTY.
THINK IT WAS CARRIER SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
QUIRK LOVE THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
ICE FIFTY ONE KNOWS TEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS IN FILE ORDER FILE ITEM
THIRTY ONE IS AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY FOUR BY MISTER COOLEY THE
CLERK WILL READ.
AS A LEGAL TWENTY ONE SIXTY FOUR
BY FAMILY MEMBER COOLEY AND
ACTUALLY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
MISTER COOLEY.
COLLEAGUES I'M DELIGHTED TO
BRING AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY FOUR
BEFORE YOU TODAY.
THIS IS A MUNICIPAL ARCHERY BILL.
IT WILL AN ERROR THE QUIVER OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DEAL WITH ME.
DEALING WITH THE ILLEGAL
MARIJUANA CULTIVATION.
ADDING AN ERA THE QUIVER OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE QUESTION I
VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT MISTER COOLEY.
I MEAN I NEED ANOTHER CUP OF
COFFEE.
SCENE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CARPOOL OF THE ROLE.
I'M NOT VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TIED ON I FIFTY SIX
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS IN FILE ORDER.
THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO.
AB THIRTY ONE EIGHT NINETY FOUR
BY MISTER DALY THE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE NINETY
FOUR BY FAMILY MEMBER DALY
ACTUALLY TO HOUSING.
MISTER DALY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
THIS BILL MAKES SEVERAL CHANGES
TO THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT.
THE BILL WAS AMENDED A FEW DAYS
AGO TO REFLECT THE PROGRESS OF
EXTENSIVE NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN
THE SPONSOR.
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION.
AND VARIOUS OPPOSING PARTIES.
WITH MY STAFF IN THE MIDDLE OF
THOSE NEGOTIATIONS.
THE AMENDMENTS TAKE A
SIGNIFICANT STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
AND I REMAIN COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH ALL THE PARTIES AS
THE BILL MOVES ON TO THE SENATE.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I WANT TO SAY THAT
WE'RE VERY VERY CLOSE TO HAVING
A.
A COMPROMISE ON ALL THE
LANGUAGE.
.
I'M I'M VERY CONFIDENT THAT WE
WILL GET THERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS STATE MISTER
KILEY OR RECOGNIZE A POINT OF
ORDER MISTER SPEAKER.
MISTER KILEY STAGE A POINT OF
ORDER. AB THIRTY ONE NINETY FOUR
I BECAME PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
ONLINE AT NINE PM ON MAY TWENTY
NINTH.
AS SUCH THIS BILL HAS BEEN
AVAILABLE SOMETHING LIKE THIRTY
EIGHT HOURS OFF FOR THE PUBLIC
TO SEE NOT QUITE THE SEVENTY TWO
HOURS.
THAT'S OF AWFUL REQUIREMENT.
FOR US TO VOTE ON IT OF COURSE
THE SEVENTY TWO HOUR NOTICE
REQUIREMENT WAS.
IMPOSED ON THE LEGISLATURE BY
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AS A
CONDITION OF MAKING LAWS ON
THEIR BEHALF THEREFORE TO PLOT
COMPLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION.
THIS ITEM SHOULD NOT BE TAKEN
UP UNTIL SEVENTY TWO HOURS THE
LAPSED AND THE SAME POINT OF
ORDER WILL APPLY IF TAKEN UP
TODAY TO A. B. TWO FIVE FOUR SIX.
AB TO NINE TO FIVE WILL.
AB THREE TWO THREE TWO AB TWO
FOUR THREE FOUR THREE AND AB TWO
ONE TWO FIVE.
MR KILEY THE POINT OF ORDER IS
NOT WELL TAKEN THE BILL.
IN REFERENCE IS PROPERLY THE
BILL BEFORE THE BODY RIGHT NOW
IS PROPERLY BEFORE THIS BODY IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE ASSEMBLY
RULES AS CONTAINED IN HR ONE EN.
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION IF
THE BILL PASSES THE SENATE THE
MEASURE WILL BE WILL BE
RETURNING THE ASSEMBLY FOR
CONCURRENCE VOTE ON THE BILL IN
ITS.
FINAL FORM SO THAT POINT OF
ORDER.
IS NOT WELL TAKEN.
AND WE MAY PROCEED.
MS AGUILAR CURRY ON THE BILL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'D
LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
HAYWARD FIRST HARD WORK WITH
OPPONENTS AND REFINING THIS BILL.
I UNDERSTAND THAT I MIGHT NEED
SOME ADDITIONAL TWEAKS THE
SENATE BUT I WILL CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BECAUSE
OF THE WORK THE AT THAT THE
AUTHOR. AND SPONSOR HAVE DONE US
SINCE THE GUY ARRIVED AT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MS AGUIAR-CURRY C. NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM MISTER BAILEY YOU
MAKE CLOTHES IF YOU WISH.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
CLAIRE CLUB THEY'RE ALL. ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS.
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE AROUND HOW ABOUT I ASK YOU
TO KNOWS FOR THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM.
THIRTY THREE. PASS TEMPORARILY
AS WELL ON FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR.
AND THIRTY FIVE
WE PASS TEMPORARILY ON. FILE
ITEMS THIRTY FIVE THIRTY SIX.
AND THIRTY SEVEN.
AND PASS TEMPORARILY ON THIRTY
EIGHT.
I SEE MR O'DONNELL AT HIS DESK
THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE.
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY ONE
O'DONNELL CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE NINETY
ONE BY SOME REMEMBER O'DONNELL
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
OCEAN RESOURCES.
MISTER O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ARREST RESENT AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY ONE WHICH WILL DIRECT THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL.
TO CREATE THE WHITE SHARK
POPULATION MONITORING AND BEACH
SAFETY PROGRAM.
DURING THE LAST FEW YEARS
THERE'S BEEN A SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF SHARK
SIGHTING OFF THE CALIFORNIA
COAST AND ALSO. IN MY DISTRICT.
WELL THE INCREASE IS A POSITIVE
SIGN FOR THE MARINE ECOSYSTEM
THIS IS INCREASED ACTIVITY MAKES
HUMAN AND SHARK INTERACTIONS.
MORE LIKELY.
SIGHTINGS IN FEAR CANALS ALSO
IMPACT THE LOCAL ECONOMY.
THANKFULLY RESEARCHERS LIKE
THOSE WITH
THE SHARK LAB AT CSU LONG BEACH
IN MY DISTRICT A PARTNER WITH
LOCAL AGENCIES AND NON PROFITS
TO MONITOR SHARKS STUDY THEIR
BEHAVIORS AND EDUCATE THE PUBLIC.
THESE EFFORTS HELP PREVENT
INCIDENTS SQUALL UNJUSTIFIED
FEARS AND PROVIDE THE DATA
NEEDED TO UNDERSTAND AND
PRESERVE OUR MARINE ECOSYSTEM.
HOWEVER THESE EFFORTS CAN ONLY
BE SUCCESSFUL WHEN THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES NEEDED TO COMPLETE
THEIR WORK AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
ONE CREATES A GRANT PROGRAM THAT
WILL PROVIDE NEEDED FUNDING. FOR
THOSE STUDYING THESE ANIMALS AND
WILL PROTECT PEOPLE THAT THE THE
PEOPLE I'M.
PERSONS IN THE WATER ALONG OUR
BEACHES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THEY MISTER DONALD MISTER HARPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
AS FOR RARE HUNTINGTON BEACH
SURF CITY USA AND AS A REPRESENT
FROM THE MOST POPULAR BEACHES IN
OUR STATE. AYE RISES A COAUTHOR
OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO
NINETY ONE.
CALIFORNIA'S BEACHES ARE A BOON
TO OUR STATE'S ECONOMY
GENERATING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
EACH YEAR.
AS THE NUMBER OF SHARK ATTACKS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAS
INCREASED THIS BILL PROVIDES
FUNDING TO STUDY THE MOVEMENT OF
WHITE SHARKS IN BETTER TRACK.
WHERE THEY ARE IN THE AREA?
ADDITIONALLY LOCAL AGENCIES WILL
BE BETTER EQUIPPED WITH
INFORMATION TO KNOW WHEN TO
CLOSE THE BEACH DUE TO SHARK
ACTIVITY. AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
ONE WILL HELP ENSURE THE SAFETY
OF SURFERS SWIMMERS AND ALL
VISITORS TO OUR STATE'S
BEAUTIFUL BEACHES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS REYES
ON THIS A BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS HARPER SENIOR
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL UP THE ROLE.
I'M.
IS THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WAS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TIED BUT I SIXTY NO
ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE FILE FOURTY AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY THREE BY MR
MAIENSCHEIN THE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE NINETY
THREE BY SOME A MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND ACTUALLY THE
HEALTH CARE. MR MAIENSCHEIN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS MY MATERNAL DEPRESSION
IS THE MOST COMMON COMPLICATION
OF PREGNANCY IN THE UNITED
STATES. MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS INCLUDING DEPRESSION
ANXIETY AND THE MORE RARE BUT
SERIOUS POKE POSTPARTUM
PSYCHOSIS
AFFECT ONE IN FIVE WOMEN. DURING
PREGNANCY OR THE FIRST YEAR
FOLLOWING CHILDBIRTH.
SCREENING AND TREATMENT FOR
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS IS AN IMPORTANT TOOL.
TO PROTECT CHILDREN FROM THE
POTENTIAL ADVERSE PHYSICAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL EFFECTS OF THESE
CONDITIONS.
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY THREE ONE
SURE THAT PREGNANT PATIENTS OR
SCREEN FOR MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDERS DURING THE
PRENATAL PERIOD. ACCORDING TO
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS SCREENING MOTHERS
FROM MATERNAL DEPRESSION AS A
BEST PRACTICE FOR PRIMARY CARE
PEDIATRICIANS.
THE CALIFORNIA TASK FORCE ON
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH PRESENTED
A REPORT TO THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATOR THAT SET A GOAL TO
REACH AN EIGHTY PERCENT
SPRINGING RATE FOR MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS. BY
PROVIDERS BY THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THIS BILL WILL AID IN
ACHIEVING THEIR GOAL THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
MAIENSCHEIN.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN ALL. MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE ANTI ABOUT EYES
FIFTY KNOWS ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES WE'RE GOING
TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
FORTY ONE.
WHERE FILE ITEM FORTY TWO?
THIS IS AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
SIX BY MS RUBIO.
THE CLERK.
WILL READ.
SOME LEGAL TWENTY THREE TWENTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO AND
ACTUALLY THE COLOREDS.
MS RUBIO YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY
I'M ALSO I'M PRESENTING AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY SIX WHICH
ALLOWS PARENTS WITH A CHILD
TWENTY ONE FUND TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS. OF AGE OR YOUNGER TO BE
EXEMPT FROM THE COW WORKS WELL
FOR TO WORK EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM.
AND INSTEAD PROVIDE THEM WITH
THE OPTION TO VOLUNTEER. TO
PARTICIPATE.
AS NUMEROUS STUDIES HAVE
DEMONSTRATED INFANCY IS AN
IMPORTANT TIME FOR BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT.
THAT'S THIS BILL COMES IN AT
KNOWLEDGE MEANT OF THE IMPORTANT
ROLE WE NOW AND WE KNOW EARLY
BONDING TIME CAN HAVE ON A
CHILD'S LONG TERM HEALTH.
BY EXEMPTING THESE CAO WORK
FAMILIES FROM WELFARE TO WORK
ACTIVITIES AND INSTEAD PROVIDING
THEM WITH THE OPTION THE
VOLUNTEERING WE'RE EMPOWERING
THEM WITH THE ABILITY TO CHOOSE
WHAT IS BEST FOR THEIR OWN
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES. AND FOR
THE NEEDS OF THEIR FAMILIES.
FOR THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CORP OF NARAL.
AND MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT
CLARK WELL CLOSE YOUR ALL TIME
ABOUT AYE AYES FORTY ONE. KNOWS
TWELVE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE TO MOVE BACK IN THE
FILE TO FILE AND THIRTY FIVE.
MISTER KALRA IS READY TO TAKE UP
HIS ITEM.
THIS IS.
AB NINETEEN THIRTEEN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY LINE NINETEEN THIRTEEN
BY SOME THE MEMBER KALRA AND
ACTUALLY FOR FOREIGN LABOR
CONTRACTORS.
MISTER KALRA.
BUT HE WAS SPEAKER MEMBERS IN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE PASSED SP FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN BY THEN SENATOR
STEINBERG. A BILL TO PROTECT
INTERNATIONAL RECRUITER WORKERS
FROM DEBT BONDAGE CONTRACT FIVE
RETALIATION INDENTURED SERVITUDE
AND TRAFFICKING.
AFTER CONSIDERING THE BILL'S
PROTECTION OF AN ESTIMATED A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
INTERNATIONAL RECRUITER WORKERS
ACROSS BASIC CATEGORIES AND
INDUSTRY SECTORS. GOVERNOR BROWN
SIGNED THE BILL INTO LAW.
DURING THE LAWS DURING THE LAWS
IMPLEMENTATION THE DIVISION OF
LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT.
MISINTERPRETED THE LAW AS
CODIFIED AS APPLYING ONLY TO AGE
TO BE WORKERS.
A TINY FRACTION OF THOSE WORKERS
AS BEFORE SEVENTY SEVEN WAS
INTENDED TO PROTECT FROM
EXPLOITATION AND TRAFFICKING.
AB NINETEEN THIRTY WAS A
TECHNICAL FIX THAT WOULD
EFFECTUATE SB FORTY SET FOR
SEVEN SEVENS. ORIGINAL INTENT BY
STRIKING LANGUAGE OF THE BILL
WAS A ROLLED THE LANGUAGE THAT
RESULTED YA SEIZE INTERPRETATION
LIMITING LEGISLATION SCOPE.
CENTER STEINBERG MAYOR STEINBERG
GONNA STOP OF NOT ONLY CONFIRMED
THIS THAT TESTIFIED AT COMMITTEE
HEARINGS.
THAT THE ORIGINAL INTENTION OF
THE BILL A WILL BE AFFECTION
WAITED BY THIS BILL AND THAT
WHEN S. BEFORE SEVENTY SEVEN WAS
NEGOTIATED EVERYONE. A BUSINESS
LABOR EVERYONE WAS AT THE TABLE
AND SO THIS IS A TECHNICAL. TO
ENSURE THAT THE ORIGINAL
INTENTION OF THE BILL IS SEEN
THROUGH WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THEY WAS KALRA.
SECURE GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL JUST
SO YOU UNDERSTAND FARM LABOR
CONTRACTORS ARE GOVERNED BOTH
UNDER. FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS
THIS WOULD ADD A THIRD LEVEL OF
REGULATION TO AN INDUSTRY THAT'S
ALREADY.
VERY HIGHLY REGULATED.
THE AGE TO A.
AB LISA PROGRAM.
IS VERY VERY CUMBERSOME TO USE
ALREADY.
AND IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
BEEN DIFFICULT.
FOR OUR AGRICULTURE COMMUNITY
TO USE
THE AGE TO A VISA PROGRAM.
SO THIS BILL WHICH IS GOING TO
ADD YET ANOTHER LAYER OF
BUREAUCRACY THAT I THINK IS NOT
HELPFUL. TO FARMWORKERS AND IT'S
NOT HELPFUL TO.
THE AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY WHICH
THEY'RE SUCH AN INTEGRAL PART.
OF.
SO I ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON
THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
AIMS GALLAGHER DOCTOR WOULD.
YES THANK YOU THANK YOU SPEAK
MEMBERS IN I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD. I GREW WITH SUPPORTERS
THAT DAD DID THESE PROTECTIONS.
WERE INTENDED TO AND SHOULD BE
EXTENDED TO FOREIGN FARMWORKERS.
BUT I WOULD HOPE AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD A SOLUTION IS
FOUND FOR BUT THE BUSINESSES
THAT MUCH REGISTER BOTH AS A
FARM LABOR CONTRACTOR AND A
FOREIGN LABOR CONTRACTOR. AND
PAY TWICE THE FEES THERE'S SOME
DUPLICATION AND ADDITIONAL FEES
THAT I DON'T THINK I REALLY
NECESSARY AND I THINK THAT I
HOPE THAT WE AS WE MOVE FORWARD
THIS BILL WE CAN RECTIFY SOME
THOSE ISSUES AND AND MAKE IT A
LITTLE LESS. ONEROUS ON BUSINESS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT WOULD SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM MISTER KALRA YOU MAY CLOSE
IF YOU WISH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
HEALDSBURG.
FOR THE SUPPORT AND ABSOLUTELY
DO COMMIT AS THIS BILL GOES
FORWARD TO ENSURE THAT WE DON'T
HAVE.
ONEROUS ó RULES LET'S KEEP IN
MIND AS WELL THAT THIS BILL WAS
VIGOROUSLY DEBATED DISCUSSED AND
NEGOTIATED TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
WITH EVERYONE AT THE TABLE. SO
THIS IS SEEN THROUGH THE
ORIGINAL INTENTION OF THE BILL
OF THE GOVERNOR SIGNED IT NO
INDIVIDUAL ATTENTION OF APPLYING
TO OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
WORKERS. AND SO AGAIN I WOULD
URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL WHICH HAS ALREADY.
BEEN.
PERFECTLY THAT'D HOWEVER I
ABSOLUTELY TAKE TO HEART THE
CONSIDERATIONS OF MY COLLEAGUES
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
SOME OF THE DETAILS PARTICULARLY
AS IT APPLIES. TO ENSURING THAT
THERE ISN'T.
OVERLY BURDEN SOME OF THE FEES
THAT APPLY BECAUSE REALLY IT'S
ABOUT PROTECTING THE WORKERS NOT
PUTTING BURDENS ON EMPLOYERS.
WITH THAT CARCLUB KNOW ROLL-ON
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
MISTER KALRA. THIS COLUMN IS A
CALL.
BACK IN FILE ORDER.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY THREE AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY SEVEN.
REFEREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
THIRTY SEVEN BY SOME THE MEMBER
GIPSON AND OTHERS AND I JOINED
IN ON MINOR DEPENDED.
MEASURE GIPSON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
THIRTY SEVEN WHICH WILL
ELIMINATE BARRIERS TO ENSURE
THAT YOUTH. IN NEED OF
TRANSITIONAL SERVICES ARE ABLE
TO ENTER OR RE ENTER EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE. A NUMBER OF ISSUES
HAVE BEEN RAISED IN THE COURTS.
THAT PREVENTED A NARROW GROUP OF
FOSTER YOUTH FROM PER RECEIVING
BENEFITS.
THAT THEY'RE ELIGIBLE FOR
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
THIRTY SEVEN.
IT'S ABOUT CLOSING THE GAP
FOR VULNERABLE YOUTH.
IN THIS NARROW SPACE.
TO EXTEND FOSTER BENEFITS TO
THEM THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BROAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT I VOTE ONE
TWENTY THREE THIRTY SEVEN.
AIMS GIPSON. SEEN OUR DISCUSSION
BASED ON THE ITEM.
COR CLUB THERE ALL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF OUR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ROLE IN
THAILAND I SIXTY NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES STAYING WITH
MISTER GIBSON.
IS FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY NINE
COOPERATE.
SOME OF ALL TWENTY THREE THIRTY
NINE BY FAMILY MEMBER GIPSON AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO WATER
MISS GIPSON.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE THIRTY NINE
WHICH SEEKS TO IMPROVE WATER
SERVICE FOR CALIFORNIA MANY
CALIFORNIA'S RECEIVE THEIR
DRINKING WATER FROM SMALL PUBLIC
WATER SYSTEMS THAT ARE DIFFICULT
TO MAINTAIN. THESE TROUBLES
SYSTEMS OFTEN LACK THE RESOURCES
TO FUND THE ONGOING COSTS FOR
MAINTENANCE AND OTHER
OPERATIONAL EXPENSES SUCH SUCH
CHALLENGES CAN BE OVERCOME BY
CONSOLIDATING NEIGHBORING
SYSTEMS.
ONE BAY AREA TO CONSOLIDATING IS
THE COST OF HOLDING A FULL BLOWN
ELECTION TO APPROVE THE SALE OF
A SMALL PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM.
THIS BILL WOULD MODIFY THE
ELECTION REQUIREMENT AND ALLOW
CITIES TO SELL THEIR SMALL
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS IF IT IS
NOT IN THE BEST INTERESTS TO
OPERATED. YA FROM THAT COMMUNITY
THIS CHANGE WILL PROVIDE MORE
CALIFORNIA'S WE CLEANER AFER
DRINKING WATER THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS
RECEIVED NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHAT I VOTE.
THEY WAS GIPSON SEEM NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
THREE NO SEVEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM FORTY
FIVE.
OR FILE AM FORTY SIX AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY ONE BY DOCTOR WEBER
COOPERATE.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY THREE SIXTY
ONE BY SOME REMEMBER WEBER AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION.
DOCTOR WEBER YES MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS ARE RISE TO PRESENT TO
YOU TWENTY THREE SIXTY ONE
REGARDING LARGE TEMPORARY
SERVICE CONTRACTS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
IS A BILL ABOUT TRANSPARENCY EL
WITH THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA'S
OUTSOURCING REGARDING
CONTRACTORS PAY BENEFITS OF
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE.
OUTSOURCE CONTRACTORS WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
ABOUT PAY BENEFITS HAVE ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE TO THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA.
UNIVERSITY HEALTH ONE REQUIRED
TO POST THIS INFORMATION ON A
PUBLIC ACCESSIBLE WEBSITE.
THIS WOULD PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY
ABOUT HOW THESE CONTRACTS AFFECT
WORKERS THIS IS WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT TEMPORARY WORKERS THEY'RE
MORE LIKELY TO BE IMMIGRANT ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR. THERE ARE LOWER
WAGES THAN WITH FEW OR NO
BENEFITS THEY'RE LESS LIKELY TO
HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE AND
THE MORE LIKELY RELY ON PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE.
THE QUESTION ONCE AGAIN BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE'S WHETHER THE
UNIVERSE OF CALIFORNIA'S
CONTRACTING PRACTICES ARE
CONDEMNING LOW WAGE CONTRACTORS
TO POVERTY AND A RELIANCE ON
TAXPAYER FUNDED SOCIAL SERVICES.
THE STATE AUDITOR FOUND THAT
THERE IS NO WAY TO KNOW WHAT
KNOW THAT BECAUSE OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IT DOES
NOT KEEP TRACK OF THE OF THE
INFORMATION. AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY ONE WOULD PROVIDE CLARITY
ABOUT WHETHER THE UNIVERSITY IS
IS ENFORCING ITS OWN MINIMUM
WAGE POLICIES AND WHETHER THESE
EMPLOYEES RECEIVE ANY HELP THE
RETIREMENT BENEFITS.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY ONE BILL
WILL ALSO ALLOW LAWMAKERS TO
GAZE THE EXTENT TO WHICH THESE
CONTRACTS IF COST TO THE STATE
BODIES EMPLOYEES HAVING TO RELY
ON PUBLIC ASSISTANCE.
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
CALIFORNIA'S WHEN WORKING TO
ALLEVIATE POUT POVERTY THROUGH A
NUMBER OF MEASURES INCLUDING TAX
BREAKS FOR WORKING FAMILIES AND
A FIFTEEN DOLLAR MINIMUM WAGE.
WE NEED TO KNOW THAT WHEN THE
UNIVERSE OF CALIFORNIA'S COMES
TO US FOR ALLOCATION TO PAY FOR
THESE CONTRACTS THAT THEY ARE
REVERSED THEY'RE NOT REVERSING
THESE AFFECTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
BOTH PUT AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
ONE WHICH IS A BILL ABOUT
OUTSOURCING CONTRACTS
TRANSPARENCY IT DOES NOT PREVENT
THE OUTSOURCING OF CONTRACTS BUT
IT DOES REQUIRE INFORMATION BE
POSTED. CONCERNING THE PAY
BENEFITS AND ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I BOTH AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
ONE.
THEY DOCTOR WEBER SAY NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
WELL CLOSE ROADS HIGH ABOUT
EYES FORTY FOUR. KNOWS FIFTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
MR MCCARTY WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON YOUR ITEM FORTY
EIGHT WILL COME RIGHT BACK TO IT.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE CARE MISTER
BLOOM.
WHO IS ON THE BUDGET CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE MR PLUMBER GONNA TAKE?
FILE ITEM FORTY NINE.
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY THREE.
THEN WILL TAKE YOUR ADDITIONAL
ADAM.
CARPOOL RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR NINETY
THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER BLOOM
NATURALLY TO RECYCLING RICHARD
BLOOM EMAIL BEEN THANK YOU FOR
THE ACCOMMODATION MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THAT CALIFORNIA BEVERAGE
CONTAINER PROGRAM BETTER KNOWN
AS THE BOTTLE BILL PROGRAM. IS A
SELF FUNDED PROGRAM THAT
ENCOURAGES CONSUMERS TO RECYCLE
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS TO PREVENT
LETTERING.
OVER THE THREE DECADES OF
OPERATION THAT TO HAVE THUS FAR
TRANSPIRED THE BOTTLE BILL
PROGRAM. HAS DIVERTED TONS OF
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS FROM
LANDFILLS.
AND FOR MOST OF THE TIME IT'S
BEEN SEEN AS A MODEL RECYCLING
PROGRAM. HOWEVER SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN APPROXIMATELY ONE THIRD
OF THE TOTAL IN STATE RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS SHUTTERED
THEIR OPERATIONS.
THE VERY PLACES THESE OF THE
VERY PLACES WERE CONSUMERS
RETURN THEIR CONTAINERS TO GET
THEIR MONEY BACK INTO THE
PROGRAM IS ACTUALLY. ARE NOT
OPERATING AS EFFICIENTLY AS IT
SHOULD AND LESS MATERIALS
GETTING RECYCLED THAT HAS BEEN
RECYCLED IN THE PASS.
SO AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY THREE
WHILE NOT A SILVER BULLET MAKES
SMALL BUT IMPORTANT STEPS TO
MODERNIZE AND IMPROVE OUR BOTTLE
DEL PROGRAM. BY AUTHORIZING CAO
RECYCLE TO IMPROVE RECYCLING
CONVENIENCE FOR CONSUMERS AND
REMOVING OPERATIONAL
RESTRICTIONS TO ENABLE
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION WITHIN
THE BOTTOM BELL PROGRAM. THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT I'VE WORKED ON FOR
A COUPLE YEARS NOW I PROMISE YOU
THEY'LL BE MORE IN THE FUTURE
BUT THIS IS A SMALL STEP FORWARD.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLOAK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
OF THIS ADDED THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE A ROLL IN TOWN ABOUT ICE
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES STAYING WITH
MISTER BLOOM WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY.
IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
ONE BY SILLY MEMBER BLOOM AND
ACTUALLY TO HOUSING.
MR BLOW.
MISTER SPEAKER THANK YOU AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE IS FOCUSED
ON GETTING A MORE DATA DRIVEN AN
EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION. OF THE
HOUSING NEED WITHIN REGIONS TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY JURISDICTION
IS DOING ITS FAIR SHARE TO
ADDRESS OUR HOUSING CRISIS.
REFORMING THE RINA ALLOCATION
PROCESS IS CRUCIAL IN SUPPORTING
ALL OF OUR WORK FROM LAST YEAR
ON THE HOUSING PACKAGE. TO
ENSURE THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE APPROVING HOUSING PROJECTS.
THE RENO PROCESS IS CRITICAL THE
SETTING THE STAGE FOR HOUSING
PRODUCTION AND THE EXISTING
PROCESS TOO OFTEN IGNORES THE
DATA. AND ALLOW SOME CITIES TO
PUSH BACK TO NUMBERS THEY'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH RATHER THAN
WHAT THE DATA SHOWS IS NEEDED.
AND WHAT THEY COULD ACTUALLY
ACCOMMODATE WITH CHANGES IN
ZONING.
FLAWED PROCESS THAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE MEANS THAT WE OFTEN DON'T
GET HOUSING IN THE PLACES WHERE
IT'S NEEDED MOST
AND PLACES TOO HEAVY A BURDEN.
ON CITIES THAT HAVE TO ABSORB
HIGHER NUMBERS AS A RESULT.
WHEN JOB RICH JURISDICTIONS
DON'T HAVE A PLAN FOR HOUSING IT
ALSO COMPROMISES OUR ABILITY TO
MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE ADDS
MORE OVERSIGHT TO THE RING
ALLOCATION PROCESS PROVIDES FOR
GREATER TRANSPARENCY AND LIMITS
THE ROLE OF REGIONAL POLITICS.
WE HAVE TAKEN A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
AND ARE CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
OUR COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS TO
ENSURE THAT THE BILL'S NOT
ADDING COSTS. AND IS CONSISTENT
WITH OTHER MANDATES THAT THE
COGS HAVE PURSUANT TO SP THREE
SEVENTY FIVE AND OTHER LAWS.
THEREFORE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
MISTER FRAZIER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I AND I APPLAUD ON MY.
CALLING FROM SANTA MONICA.
WELL ABOVE ON THIS GOING FOR BUT
WITH THERE IS ONE.
COMPONENT SOCIETY THAT WE'VE.
NEVER ADDRESSED
AND WITH THE CLOSURE OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO INCLUDE
THE.
A SPECIAL NEEDS OR THE OR
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL.
.
DISABILITY POPULATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE REMAIN NUMBERS.
THE CENSUS IS GROWING
DRAMATICALLY EVERY TEN YEARS BY
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. AND WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE HOUSING.
WHENEVER I TALK TO AN ADULT WHO
HAS A CHILD WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY. THEY'RE ALWAYS
ASKING WHAT IS GONNA HAPPEN TO
MY CHILD.
WHEN I IE.
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN TO MY CHILD.
IF I CAN'T TAKE CARE OF THEM.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY WE CAN
OFFER APPS WE PUT IN RENO AND
HOUSING ELEMENTS TO ADDRESS THIS
POPULATION WE SHOULD BE DOING
THAT GOING FOR AND I HOPE YOU
OFFER WILL LOOK AT THAT. AS A
POSSIBLE AMENDMENT GOING FORWARD.
FAMOUS FRAZIER SAY NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION MISTER BLOOM YOU MAY
CLOSE WE WISH THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I SHARE UC.
ARC. COLLEAGUES CONCERNED ABOUT.
CALIFORNIA'S.
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
POPULATION I PROMISE TO WORK
WITH HIM TO SEE IF WE CAN'T
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE THROUGH
AMENDMENTS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
CLERK WILL OPEN ROLL-ON.
THE SAD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT
CLOSE ROLL TIDE EYES FORTY ONE.
KNOWS NINETEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO RETURN
IN FILE ORDERED THIS IS FILE
ITEM FORTY EIGHT AB TWENTY FOUR.
EIGHTY SIX BY MR MCCARTY.
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
SIX BY SOME A MEMBER MCCARTY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
MACHINE MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ALONG
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM EAST
NICHOLAS I PRESENT TO YOU A
BIPARTISAN BILL. THE OPIOID
ADDICTION PREVENTION RE OF THE
REHABILITATION ACT THIS BILL
WOULD PLACE A VOLUNTARY ONE CENT
PER MILLIGRAM.
SURCHARGE ON ACTIVE OPIOIDS FOR
MANUFACTURERS THAT CONTRACT WITH
THE STATE THROUGH THE PREFERRED
DRUG LIST ESSENTIALLY OUR
FORMULARY FOR MEDI CAL.
WE KNOW THAT THREE AND FOUR NEW
HEROIN USERS BEGIN THEIR
ADDICTION BY ABUSING.
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS PAINKILLERS
THIS INCREASES HEALTHCARE COSTS
PLACING ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL
BURDENS ON TAXPAYERS OUR
HOSPITAL SYSTEM AND OVERALL
REDUCING ACCESS TO OUR EMERGENCY
CARE.
WE'RE TOO FAMILIAR WITH THIS
DEVASTATING EPIDEMIC THERE OVER
TWENTY BILLS THIS SESSION
DEALING WITH THIS THIS IS A
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE.
MANY LIVES HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
AND. I WERE HERE WITH US TODAY
ON APPROACH TO WOULD PROVIDE
COUNTIES WITH RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO OFFER INPATIENT
OUTPATIENT REHAB PROGRAMS. BASED
ON THE NEEDS OF THE INDIVIDUAL
COUNTY. AT THIS IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS THAT MUST BE
ADDRESSED WE KNOW THAT THERE IS
A GREAT NEED FOR MORE SERVICES
PREVENTION AND TREATMENT. AND WE
THINK THE INDUSTRY HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY AND OPPORTUNITY
TO ENGAGE WITH US AS WELL. OTHER
IS A ON AN OPPOSITION LETTER WAS
SENT CONCERNS AND SOME PROPOSED
SUGGESTIONS AND WE ARE WORKING
WITH THE.
WITH THE WITH THE.
ASSOCIATION TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES AS THE BILL MOVES FOR.
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
OF THE JOINT AUTHOR I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
ODDS PROBABLY NOT OFTEN THAT YOU
SEE.
THE GENTLEMAN FROM SACRAMENTO
MYSELF JOINING UP ON BILLS.
ARMED ONE OF THE MOST
CONSERVATIVE ONE THE MOST
LIBERAL.
HOWEVER WE ARE IN AGREEMENT ON
THIS.
THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC.
IS A PRESSING PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS THEY CANNOT BE IGNORED.
AND IT IS NOT JUST GOVERNMENT'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO SOLVE.
DRUG US ESPECIALLY THOSE
ASSOCIATED WITH PRESCRIPTION
OPIOID DRUGS ARE RISING FASTER
THAN EVER AND ARE NOW THE
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG
AMERICANS UNDER THE AGE OF FIFTY.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN ALONE SIXTY
FOUR THOUSAND PEOPLE DIED FROM
DRUG OVERDOSES
THIS IS THE LARGEST ANNUAL JUMP
EVER RECORDED.
THIS EPIDEMIC IS HITTING THE
RULE AREAS.
THE HARDEST DRUG OVERDOSE DEATHS
ARE MOST COMMON IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
SOME RURAL COUNTIES HAVE MORE
OPIOID PRESCRIPTIONS
THEN PEOPLE.
AND LET ME JUST PUT A LITTLE
PICTURE ON THIS FOR YOU IN BUTTE
COUNTY RIGHT THAT I REPRESENT.
THEIR OVER ONE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED PRESCRIPTIONS PER ONE
THOUSAND RESIDENTS.
THE CDC AND OTHER HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS MEASURE OPIOIDS IN
A UNIT KNOWN AS M. EMMYS.
MORPHINE MILLIGRAM EQUIVALENCE.
BUTTE COUNTY IS AVERAGE IS.
ONE THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
EIGHTY M. M. EMMYS PRESCRIBE PER
RESIDENT ANNUALLY THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE IS SIX HUNDRED FORTY.
TO PUT THESE IN PERSPECTIVE A
TWO HUNDRED MILLIGRAM DOSE WOULD
BE LETHAL.
AB TWENTY FORTY SIX REQUIRES
THAT COMPANIES THAT WANT TO PUT
THEIR OPIOID PRODUCTS ON THE
MEDI CAL FORMULA VERY. PAYING
REBATE THAT GOES TOWARDS
ADDICTION TREATMENT.
THERE ARE MANY REASONS ADDICTION.
THE OPIOID ADDICTION HAS BECOME.
SUCH A HUGE PUBLIC HEALTH
PROBLEM.
AND IT'S NOT JUST THE ADDICTIVE
PROPERTIES OF THESE DRUGS.
BUT RIGHT NOW.
THE PROBLEM IS LARGELY
SHOULDERED BY THE TAXPAYER ALONE.
AND MANUFACTURES NEED TO BE PART.
OF THE SOLUTION.
THE MAJORITY OF THE PERSONS WITH
OPIOID ADDICTIONS.
AND EVEN THOSE WHO ARE NOW
ADDICTED TO HEROIN STARTED WITH
PRESCRIPTION PAIN KILLERS.
AB TWENTY FORTY SIX ONE SURE
THAT WE CAN EXPAND TREATMENT IN
AREAS THAT NEED IT THE MOST.
AND AS PART OF A MULTI PRONGED
BIPARTISAN APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING THE OPIOID CRISIS.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER MISS
WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE.
AS WE KNOW THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC
IS GROWING AND WE DESPERATELY
NEED ASSISTANCE FOR BOTH
PREVENTION AND TREATMENT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
WOEFULLY BEHIND. IN DEALING WITH
THIS ISSUE AND THE PROBLEM JUST
KEEPS GROWING OF THE MONEY
COLLECTED THROUGH THIS MEASURE
WILL BE ADMINISTERED AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL.
AND WILL BE DISTRIBUTED BASED ON
NEED AND POPULATION.
THE LACK OF AVAILABLE FARMS
TREATMENT CENTERS AND OPTIONS
FOR INDIVIDUALS SUFFERING FROM
OPIOID USE DISORDER. IS
CONTRIBUTING TO THE DEATH TOLL
AND THIS BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS
THE LACK OF FUNDING FOR
REHABILITATION. AND EDUCATIONAL
CAMPAIGNS WHICH ARE SO IMPORTANT
TO INFORM THE PUBLIC ON THE
RISKS OF OPIOID ABUSE AYE URGENT
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON.
AND MISTER DALLI.
THE USER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
IN SUPPORT I WANTED TO.
SHARE WITH YOU A LITTLE
CHILDHOOD HISTORY MY FATHER WAS
AN ALCOHOLIC.
AND.
.
YOU HAVE TO FIRST ADMIT YOU HAVE
A PROBLEM BEFORE YOU CAN SOLVE
THAT PROBLEM AND HE DID.
MY MOM LEFT HIM FOR TWO YEARS.
AND THEN HE REALIZED THAT HE HAD
AN ADDICTION ISSUE AND HE WENT
TO TREATMENT ANY NEVER DIRECTED
DROPPED FOR THIRTY YEARS. UNTIL
HE PASSED AWAY.
SO I'M EXCITED TO TELL YOU THAT
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED WE HAVE A
PROBLEM THAT WE'VE ADMITTED THAT
WE HAVE A PROBLEM WITH OPIOIDS
IT. IN OUR STATE.
I REPRESENT ONE THE MOST RULE.
PLACES IN CALIFORNIA AND HAS THE
HIGHEST.
EPIDEMIC OF OPIOID ABUSE.
IN OUR NATION.
I WANTED TO SAY THAT THERE'S
IT'S RARE THAT YOU FIND.
WHERE WE ACTUALLY HAVE GOOD
POLICY THAT COMES OUT? WORSE
BIPARTISANSHIP I WANT TO TAKE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM SACRAMENTO
AND MY GOOD FRIEND FROM. EAST
NICOLAS.
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
INCLUDING ME IN THE DIALOGUE IN
THE CONVERSATION. TOUR WE CAN
MAYBE GET SOME RESOURCES TO GO
OUT AND HELP THESE FOLKS CHANGE
THEIR LIVES LIKE MY FATHER DID.
AND CHANGE FAMILIES
SO I STRONGLY.
.
SUPPORT THIS AND I THANK YOU FOR
A WORKING HARD AND TIRES THE A
TO BRING A PRODUCT FORWARD THAT
WE CAN ALL GET BEHIND AYE
COURAGE AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER DALLI WE WILL
TAKE THAT AS A CLOSE.
CORD BLOOD THE ROLE. ON MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IN THE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL AND TALLY
THE VOTE. EYES FIFTY THREE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE A
FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE.
IT'S FIFTY ONE AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY THREE BY MR LOW.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER
LOW AND ACT AND ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES. MR LOW. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MS SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVEN THREE IS WITH
RESPECT TO BEER MANUFACTURERS TO
GIVE GLASSWARE DIRECTLY TO
RETAILERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
BROUGH.
THANK MISTER LO SI NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CLARK OPENED ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
VOTE WHO SIRED TO BLOW.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE NO CLERK
WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLLING TIDE ABOUT ICE
FIFTY NINE KNOWS ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES WE ARE
PASSING TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEMS.
FIFTY TWO AND FIFTY THREE.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY FOUR. AB TWENTY SIX
FOURTEEN BY MISS CARILLO
CORPORATION SOME LEGAL TWENTY
SIX FOURTEEN BY SELLING MEMBER
CARILLO AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES MISS CARILLO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN A BILL THAT
WOULD HELP PROVIDE OUTDOOR
EXPERIENCES FOR DISADVANTAGED
YOUTH. MANY YOUNG PEOPLE FROM
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE LITTLE TO NO
ACCESS TO OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY PERVASIVE IN
OUR URBAN AREAS AMONG
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WILL
CHILDREN HAVE LIMITED MEANS TO
TRAVEL TO AND FROM. OUTDOOR
AREAS IN MY FIFTY FIRST ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT WE HAVE CHILDREN WHO
LIVE MERELY FIFTEEN MILES FROM
THE BEACH.
YET HAVE NEVER SEEN IT OR
EXPERIENCE THAT. NO ONE SHOULD
BE DENIED SUCH AN OPPORTUNITY
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT IS SO CLOSE
BY.
AB TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN WILL TASK
THE NATIONAL NASH THEM SORRY THE
NATURAL RESOURCE AGENCIES WITH
COMPILING A LIST OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
THAT CONTRACT OUT THEIR SCHOOL
BUSES TO NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
AND STATE IN HIS OR STATE
AGENCIES. FOR TRANSPORT SERVICES
AND THEN MAKE THOSE LIST
AVAILABLE TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND STATE AGENCIES
THAT PROVIDE OUR DISADVANTAGED
YOUTH.
WITH OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES
AB TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN ALSO
CREATES A GRANT PROGRAM THAT
WOULD PROVIDE FUNDS TO FOSTER
MORE ACCESS TO OUTDOORS TO THE
OUTDOORS ENCOURAGE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT. OFFER THESE TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES TO DO SO IN LOW
EMISSION BUSES.
THIS BILL HELPS BRING ARTISTS
THE SERVING YOUTH TO POSITIVE
ENCOUNTERS WITH NATURE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THEY MISS CARILLO SENIORS GUSHER
DEBATE.
CLUB GLOVE THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
WHO IS OUR VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
?
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A
NICE FIFTY KNOWS ELEVEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PASSING TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
FIFTY FIVE.
WE ARE FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX AB
TWENTY SIX
SEVEN BY DR WEBER.
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX FIFTY SEVEN BY SOME
THE MEMBER WEBER AND ACTUALLY
THE PEOPLE DISCIPLINE.
DOCTOR WEBER. YES MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT
YOU TWENTY SIX AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY SEVEN THE RESTRAINTS AND
SECLUSION IN SCHOOLS ACT.
MODELED AFTER PROTOCOL IN
CURRENT LAW GOVERNING THE USE OF
RESTRAINTS AND SECLUSION AND
HEALTH AND COMMUNITY FACILITIES.
THIS BILL PREVENTS PERMITS A
TEACHER OR STAFF TO USE
BEHAVIORAL RESTRAINTS OR
SECLUSION ONLY IF THE STUDENTS
BEHAVIOR PRESENTS AN IMMINENT
DANGER OF SERIOUS HARM TO THE
STUDENT OR OTHERS.
RESTRAINTS AND SECLUSION
HOWEVER THIS IS NO LONGER THE
CASE.
THIS BILL STRESSES POSITIVE
BEHAVIOR INTERVENTION OVER
DANGEROUS DISCIPLINARY
TECHNIQUES BY PROVIDING PROTOCOL
ON THE USE OF RESTRAINTS AND
SECLUSION IN SCHOOLS.
I WANT TO STRESS THAT THIS BILL
DOES NOT PROHIBIT RESTRAINTS A
CONCLUSION WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MINIMUM MINIMUM SAFEGUARDS. THIS
BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS OF CALIFORNIA
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
BOTH THE TWENTY SIX
A SEVEN.
THEY DON'T WEBER. MISTER
NAZARIAN YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER JUST TO
GIVE A BRIEF EXAMPLE RECENTLY IN
THE LOS ANGELES AREA THE ELEVEN
YEAR OLD AUTISTIC BOY WAS TAKEN
TO URGENT CARE. BECAUSE OF HIS
MOTHER DID NOT KNOW THAT HE HAD
BEEN RESTRAINED A EVEN THOUGH
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT WAS SUPPOSED
TO LET THEM KNOW SO THIS IS THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE. AND
IMPACT CERTAIN COMMUNITIES
ADVERSELY SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THEY WHICH IS VERY MUCH MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER WILL WE
SPOKE ABOUT THIS IN EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND I I RAISE AN ISSUE
WHERE A LOCAL INSIDE AS WELL. A
SEVEN YEAR OLD AUTISTIC BOY WAS
PLACED A FACE DOWN WOULD THEN
NEED TO HIS BACK BY A TEACHERS
THEY. IN FRONT OF A PLAYGROUND
FULL OF CHILDREN AS SADLY THIS
ISN'T THE ONLY ISOLATED
INCIDENTS WE JUST HEARD. AND
THIS I REMEDY.
PROPOSED BY OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO IS THE RIGHT APPROACH
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE BILL
THANK YOU.
MISTER FRAZIER THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
AS CHAIR OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON A INTELLECTUALS IN
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES IRIS
RISE TO SUPPORT THIS WORTHY BILL.
CALIFORNIA USED TO BE A LEADER
IN STUDENT SAFETY BUT WE FALLEN
WAY BEHIND OTHER STATES.
RESTRAINT AND SECLUSION ARE
STILL SEEN AS IMPORTANT CONTROL
TOOLS LAWSUIT STUDENTS CONTINUE
TO SUFFER TRAUMA AND EMOTIONAL
PHYSICAL HARM WE SHOULD BE USING
BEHAVIORAL LIST INSTEAD OF
RESTRAINTS.
WE NEED TO INVEST IN BETTER
CLASSROOM. ATTENDANCE FOR
PROFESSIONALS TO HELP THESE
YOUNG CHILDREN.
IT'S TIME AND CONSISTENT WITH
NATIONWIDE TREND IN FEDERAL
GUIDANCE TO LIMIT THE USE OF
THESE DANGEROUS PRACTICES OF
SECLUSION RESTRAINTS IN PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE SCHOOLS. I APPLAUD
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO FOR
HER EFFORTS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST RIVAL.
NAMES FRAZIER SEEM KNOW
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK ALL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF.
THIS ADDED THAT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL TIEVOTE.
ICE FORTY TWO KNOWS NINE THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM FIFTY
SEVEN IS AB TWENTY SEVEN OH FOUR
FOUR COREY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN A FOR
BY FAMILY MEMBER O'DONNELL AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS MISTER
O'DONNELL MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY SEVEN OH FOR. THIS BILL
EXPANDS THE NUMBER OF FAMILY
EMPOWERMENT CENTERS AND
INCREASES THE BASE FUNDING OF
EACH CENTER TO ENSURE THAT
FAMILIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
HAVE ACCESS TO VALUABLE SERVICES.
THE CENTERS PROVIDE.
THE CENTERS HELP PARENTS AND
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES GAIN
ACCESS TO CRITICAL PROGRAMS AND
RESOURCES.
WITHOUT HAVING TO RESORT TO
LITIGATION.
THEY ALSO HELP RESOLVE
DISAGREEMENTS BETWEEN PARENTS
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS BEFORE THEY
ESCALATE INTO COSTLY.
SPIRITS.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
THEY Q. MISTER O'DONNELL SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CORD BLOOD NARAL. ON VARIOUS
ARAB VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE.
I SHOULD BE A NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM FIFTY EIGHT.
THAT'S MY BRING US FILE ITEM
FIFTY NINE BY MR MAIENSCHEIN
THIS IS AB.
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY EIGHT THE
CORPORATE RATE. ASSEMBLY WILL
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO HEALTH
FACILITIES. THIS RACE TRACK
THANK YOU ARE MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
EIGHT WILL IMPROVE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH APPLICATION PROCESSING
REQUIREMENTS.
TO REDUCE APPLICATION WAIT
PERIODS FOR HEALTH FACILITIES
THAT WISH TO EXPAND ADD AND
CHANGE THE LOCATION OF A SERVICE.
OR MAKE OTHER CHANGES CURRENTLY
TAKES OVER TEN MONTHS
REPLICATIONS TO BE ASSIGNED TO
AN OUT ANALYST AND AN ADDITIONAL
FOUR TO FIVE MONTHS TO APPROVE
THE APPLICATION AND COMPLETE.
AND ONSITE EXPECTATION IF NEED
AT THE BACKLOG HAS REACHED THE
POINT OF ENDANGERING THE HEALTH
OF CALIFORNIA CITIZENS.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS MAJOR I'M SAYING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK LOVE
IN THE ROLE. MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAH VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
TELL YOU THAT I FIFTY SIX.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM SIXTY.
AB TWENTY EIGHT OH EIGHT BY
MISTER MURATSUCHI.
QUACKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT OO
EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER WHERE
SAID SHE AND OTHERS AND I TRIED
TO EDUCATION FINANCE.
WHICH MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE FROM LARGE URBAN DISTRICTS
LIKE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED OAKLAND
UNIFIED SACRAMENTO AND SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED.
TO SUBURBAN DISTRICTS TO RULE
DISTRICTS.
THEY'RE ALL SAYING THE SAME
THING WHICH IS. BETTER DESPITE
THE SIGNIFICANT SCHOOL FUNDING
RESTORATION THAT WE HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED IN RECENT YEARS.
THOSE FUNDING INCREASES ARE NOT
KEEPING PACE WITH THE INCREASE
INCREASES AND FIX COSTS THE
STUDENT DISTRICTS ARE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE FACING AN UPCOMING
YEARS.
AB TWENTY EIGHT OH EIGHT IS
PROPOSING.
ASPIRATIONAL FUNDING TARGETS TO
NEED TO.
BATES GRANT SELF FUNDING TARGETS
THAT WILL HELP ALL DISTRICTS.
BUT TO ACHIEVE FULL AND FAIR
FUNDING A FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
SOBRE REGARDLESS OF WHO YOU ARE
WHERE YOU LIVE.
SPILL IS A SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA AND
SUPPORTED. BY ALL EDUCATION.
LEADERSHIP GROUPS INCLUDING THE
TEACHERS ADMINISTRATORS THE
SCHOOL BOARD ASSOCIATION. ALSO
COSPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION TEACHERS I ASK FOR A
AYE VOTE.
MS BAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION
AS A CO AUTHOR.
A BECAUSE WE WITH THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS HAVE BEEN
LOOKING BACKWARDS.
AND WHILE I'VE BEEN PLEASED TO
SUPPORT ALMOST NINE BILLION
DOLLARS MORE IN EDUCATION
FUNDING IN MY SHORT TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE IT'S TIME FOR US TO
LOOK FORWARDS.
WITH NOT JUST ASPIRATIONAL BUT A
SUFFICIENT FUNDING FOR OUR
SCHOOLS.
IT PARTICULARLY THE WAY THAT
THIS BILL TWENTY EIGHT AWAY DOES
WHICH IS IT HELPS ALL SHIPS RISE
BECAUSE IT PUTS THE DOLLARS INTO
THE BASE GRANT INSTEAD OF. A
MORE SPECIFIC FUNDING FOR
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS
AND I GIVEN EXAMPLE OF WHY THAT
IS SO IMPORTANT. ONE OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN MY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT ALL THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS MY ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
ARE ARE LOOKING AT TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN FUNDING LEVELS.
IT'S ELEVEN YEARS LATER THAT
WE'VE WE'VE PUT THAT FUNDING IN.
BUT ONE IN PARTICULAR LIVERMORE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
IT DOESN'T REACH THE THRESHOLD
FOR ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE
STUDENTS
WHO WOULD THEN GET THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING UNDER THE
EXISTING LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA BUT THERE ARE SCHOOL
SITES IN THAT ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
THAT HAVE SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT
OF THE STUDENT POPULATION. IT'S
ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T REACH THE
FIFTY FIVE PERCENT LEVEL IN THE
FUNDING FORMULA THOSE KIDS AND
THE INTERVENTION PROGRAMS THAT
HELP THOSE KIDS DON'T GET A
SINGLE PENNY MORE. THAT'S WHY WE
NEED TO MAKE A COMMITMENT IN THE
YEARS GOING FORWARD TO MORE
FUNDING FOR ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS
IN THE BASS GRANT AND MAKE IT A
SIGNIFICANT FINDING SUPPORT. YOU
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
INVESTMENTS THAT WE COULD BE
MAKING RIGHT NOW EDUCATION IS
WHERE WE SHOULD BE MAKING IT.
NOW I WILL ADD OUR WORK IS NOT
DONE.
CINDY MORE MONEY AT OUR SCHOOLS
WITHOUT REFORMING HOW WE OPERATE
THEM WITHOUT BRINGING GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE EFFECTIVE
QUALITY TEACHERS IN EVERY SINGLE
CLASSROOM ACROSS OF THIS STATE
AND THAT WE HAVE GREAT
PRINCIPLES FOR MANAGERS OF EVERY
SINGLE SCHOOL. THAT MEANS OUR
WORK IS INCOMPLETE.
BUT IT STARTS BY BACKING THOSE
SCHOOLS UP WITH THE FUNDING THEY
DESERVE WHAT OUR KIDS DESERVE
AND PUTTING IT INTO THE BASE
GRANT.
AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE I LOOK FORWARD IN THE
COMING MONTHS AND YEARS
HOPEFULLY TO BE ABLE TO COUPLE
THIS FUNDING WITH THE TYPES OF
REFORMS OUR KIDS ALSO DESERVE.
AND I AM PLEASED TO WORK WITH
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM.
TORRANCE ON THIS LEGISLATION
THANK YOU.
THING IS BAKER MISTER KILEY.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER YOU
KNOW ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE MANY MANY OUTSTANDING
SCHOOLS
I INCLUDING TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS CHARTER PUBLIC SCHOOLS
SCHOOLS OF ALL KINDS.
THEY GET TREMENDOUS RESULTS
OFTEN WITHOUT THE OPTIMAL LEVEL
OF RESOURCES.
BUT LOOKING BEYOND THESE
EXAMPLES OF SUCCESS OUR PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM REMAINS IN
CRISIS.
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR STUDENTS WHO
ARE LIVING IN POVERTY.
TO ACHIEVE AT LEVELS AS ALLOW
HERE AS ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY
WITH UNCONSCIONABLE.
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
WHAT THIS CRISIS DEMANDS OF US
IS THE SENSE OF URGENCY?
BUT TODAY'S BILL REPRESENTS
NOTHING.
THE KIND.
INSTEAD IT BUT FOR ITS PUTS
FORWARD A PROPOSAL THAT IS AS
INEFFECTUAL AS IT IS ON
IMAGINATIVE MORE FUNDING. FOR A
BROKEN SYSTEM.
SINCE GOVERNOR BROWN TOOK OFFICE
ANNUAL SPENDING ON EDUCATION HAS
INCREASED BY THIRTY BILLION
DOLLARS.
PER PUPIL SPENDING WAS THIS BILL
CAUSED INCREASED SUBSTANTIALLY
HAS GROWN FROM JUST OVER TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN. TO
PROPOSE SIXTEEN SIXTEEN THOUSAND
EIGHTY FIVE. IN THE CURRENT
BUDGET.
AND YET STILL SEVENTY THREE
PERCENT OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS
SEVENTY TWO PERCENT OF LATINO
STUDENTS SEVENTY EIGHT PERCENT
OF AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS AND
EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT OF ENGLISH
LEARNERS. ARE NOT MEETING
STANDARDS IN FOURTH GRADE MATH.
COMPARED TO OTHER STATES FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS WE ARE FORTY
FOUR FOR EIGHTH GRADE READING.
FORTY SIX FOR FOURTH GRADE
READING.
AND FIFTY S..
FOR FOURTH GRADE MATH SO THE
QUESTION WE HAVE TO ASK IS.
IF THE LAST THIRTY BILLION
DIDN'T MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
WHY WILL THE NEXT THIRTY BILLION?
WHAT'S MOST TRAGIC IS THAT ALL
OF THIS WAS ENTIRELY PREDICTABLE
IN FACT
IT WAS PREDICTED.
IN A TWO THOUSAND SEVEN REPORT
COMMISSIONED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ITSELF.
THAT REPORT TITLED GETTING DOWN
TO FACTS CONCLUDED.
MORE MONEY IN THE CURRENT SYSTEM
IS UNLIKELY TO DRAMATICALLY
IMPROVE STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT TO
MEET EXPECTATIONS.
IN LAS ACCOMPANIED BY
SIGNIFICANT.
STOMACH REFORMS.
NOTABLY THE REPORT ALSO STATED
THAT PRINCIPLE SITE GREATER
FLEXIBILITY IN DISMISSING
INEFFECTIVE TEACHERS AT THE MOST
ESSENTIAL CHANGE NEEDED TO
IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES
OF COURSE LAST YEAR WE HAD A
BILL THAT WOULD HAVE DONE JUST
THAT. AND MEAN TO REFORM
CALIFORNIA'S TENURE POLICY WHICH
IS A NATIONAL OUT LIAR AND IS
OPPOSED BY EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT
OF OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHERS.
THAT BELL AB TWELVE TWENTY BY
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM SAN
DIEGO WAS GUIDED BY THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
ULTIMATELY STALLED IN THE SENATE
AND OF COURSE THAT IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE. OF THIS LEGISLATURE'S
HOSTILITY
TO THE TYPE OF STUDENT CENTERED
REFORM THAT WOULD MAKE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. MILLIMETERS
O'DONNELL COULD COULD THE GEL
MODEL STATE YOUR POINT OF ORDER.
THE GENTLEMAN FROM GRANITE MAY
SPEAK TO THE BILL HE'S NOT
SPEAKING TO THE BILL.
THAT'S A POINT OF ORDER THAT IS
WELL TAKEN. THEIR REFERENCES TO
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION IN THIS
BODY MISTER KILEY PLEASE REFER
TO THE BILL IN FRONT OF THE BODY
AT THIS POINT.
YOU MAY DO YOU THINK OUR
EDUCATION CHAIRMAN FOR MAKING
THE POINT MORE BEAUTIFULLY THAN
I EVER COULD. THAT THERE IS ALL
THE APPETITE IN THE WORLD FOR
MORE FUNDING BUT IT IS
CONSIDERED IRRELEVANT TO EVEN
ASK WHETHER THE SYSTEM IS
WORKING IN A WAY THAT FUNDING
WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE FOR OUR
STUDENTS.
NOW TO FINISH MY STATEMENT.
AND THANK YOU FOR RIGHTFULLY
DENYING THAT POINT OF ORDER.
THIS IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE PART OF
HIS LEGISLATURE EILEEN
MUSTELIDAE TO CLARIFY MR KILEY.
THE POINT OF ORDER WAS WELL
TAKEN.
AND I ISSUED MY RULING YOU MAY
PROCEED ON THE ITEM YOU HAVE A
MINUTE THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU
FOR THAT CLARIFICATION.
AS I WAS SAYING THIS IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF OUR LEGISLATURE'S
HOSTILITY TO THE TYPE OF STUDENT
CENTER REFORM THAT WOULD MAKE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. MEANINGFUL.
INCLUDING BY THE WAY I ARE
STATES ONGOING FAILURE TO MEET
MINIMUM ACCOUNTABILITY STANDARDS
ESTABLISHED BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
TODAY'S BILL ALSO RAISES THE
QUESTION AS TO WHERE ALL OF THIS
MONEY HAS BEEN GOING. AND THERE
ARE TWO ANSWERS TO THAT.
THE FIRST IS THAT INCREASINGLY
IT'S GOING NOT TO THE CLASSROOM
BUT TO IMPLEMENT RETIREMENT
COSTS
THERE ARE A LOT OF DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT OF AB SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND I
DON'T BLAME THEM BECAUSE THIS IS
OVERWHELMING. THEIR BUDGETS
SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED FOR
EXAMPLE IS DIVERTING A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO RETIREMENT
COST THIS YEAR THAT'S TWO
THOUSAND PER STUDENT THIS YEAR
TWICE AS MUCH AS JUST FIVE YEARS
AGO SOCIAL WE SHOULD BE CLEAR.
THAT WITHOUT MEANINGFUL PENSION
AND HEALTH CARE REFORM WE TALK
ABOUT ADDITIONAL FUNDING WE ARE
NOT TALKING ABOUT FUNDING THAT'S
GOING TO ACTED TEACHERS ARE TO
SCHOOLS.
BUT THE SECOND ANSWERED THAT
QUESTION AS TO WHERE THE MONEY'S
GOING AS WE REALLY DON'T KNOW.
THIRTY SECOND THE GOVERNOR ABOUT
PROPOSED BUDGET REPORTS TO ADD
ANOTHER ELEMENT OF TRANSPARENCY
AS TO HOW FUNDING IS BEING
DELIVERED TO DISTRICTS WE STILL
HAVE A LITTLE INFORMATION ON
WHAT ACTUALLY MATTERS.
HOW MUCH OF THIS MONEY IS
ACTUALLY REACHING SCHOOLS TO
EIGHT ARE HARD WORKING
PRINCIPLES TEACHERS SUPPORT
STAFF IN HELPING STUDENTS LEARN?
IN CLOSING MISTER SPEAKER WHAT
TODAY'S BILL REALLY IS IT'S AN
EXCUSE
SO WE CAN TELL OURSELVES THAT
THERE ARE JUST MORE MONEY.
EVERYTHING WILL BE FINE.
INSTEAD OF COMPLACENCY AND
EXCUSES DESIGNED TO PRESERVE THE
STATUS QUO WE NEED URGENCY AND
ACTION
THAT WAS SURE EVERY CHILD IN
CALIFORNIA HAS A CHANCE AT A
GREAT EDUCATION. TIME HOBBY
VOTING NOW IN THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU.
SEEN NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
MR MERCY CHI YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE
THE.
ALL OF THE COMMENTS.
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN RAMON AS WELL AS MY COME THE
COMMENTS FROM.
A COLLEAGUE FROM THE ROSEVILLE.
CLEARLY.
EDUCATION REFORM IS A COMPLEX
SUBJECT.
IT CANNOT BE SOLVED JUST BY
THROWING MORE MONEY AT THE
PROBLEM.
BUT.-MONEY DOES MAKE A DIFFERENCE WE
ARE IN THE BOTTOM TENTH IN THE
NATION IN PER PUPIL SPENDING.
WHERE THE WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY WE ARE WAY BELOW THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE IN PART PEOPLE
SPENDING AND THERE'S NO GOOD
EXCUSE? FOR WHY. WE SHOULD NOT.
BE ABLE TO.
PROVIDE MORE FUNDING FOR WHAT
ONE OF OUR WHAT SHOULD BE OUR
TOP BUDGET PRIORITY A WHICH IS.
OUR CAPE A TWELVE SCHOOLS TO
INVEST IN OUR CHILDREN INVEST IN
OUR FUTURE AND SO.
THIS SPELL WHILE THEY WILL NOT
SOLVE ALL THE PROBLEMS IT IS A
BILL.
THAT PARENTS TEACHERS
ADMINISTRATORS SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS.
ALL AGREE UPON.
AND ASK FOR A VOTE.-CLERK OF NARAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
THREE KNOWS THREE THAT MEASURE
PASSES WERE FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTEEN AGAIN BY
MISTER MURATSUCHI CORPORATION.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI AND ACTUALLY TO
PESTICIDES. THIS RESEARCHING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I AM HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTEEN
WHICH WILL REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION.
TO SURVEY SCHOOL DISTRICT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AS TO
WHETHER THERE ARE COMPLYING WITH
THE HEALTH. HEALTHY SCHOOLS ACT
OF TWO THOUSAND THIS BILL IS
SEEKS TO ADDRESS WHETHER OUR
SCHOOLS ARE PROPERLY AND SAFELY
IMPLEMENTING AND ADOPTING. A
PATH SIDE POLICIES BUT AS WE ALL
KNOW PASSED SIZE BECAUSE OF THE
MOST DAMAGE TO CHILDREN. WHO
STEP BODIES ARE STILL GROWING
AND DEVELOPING?
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTEEN WILL
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN BY LOOKING
AT THEM BUT IMPLEMENTATION.
OF THE HEALTH TO SCHOOLS ACT AS
IT RELATES TO PESTICIDE USE.
WELL AND TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
TO THE LEGISLATURE AS TO ABOUT
WHAT IF ANY PATH SIZE SHOULD BE
BANNED FROM OUR SCHOOLS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
VEGAS MURATSUCHI SEEING.
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK OF
NARAL.
IS OUT A VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DECIDED THOUGH.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLLS HOW
ABOUT ICE FORTY NINE NO SEVEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM SIXTY
TWO AND SIXTY THREE THAT BRINGS
US FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR. AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY THREE BY MR
SHOE COOPERATE.
AS I'M ABLE TWENTY NINE TWENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU AND OTHERS IN ATLANTA
TRANSPORTATION. RESEARCH YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY
THREE IS A BAY AREA BILL THAT
REQUIRES BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT
OR PART. TO SALVAGE TRANSIT
ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT ZONING
STANDARDS THAT WOULD SUPPORT
SMART GROWTH. ONLY ON PART ONLY
IN YOUR STATION.
THE BAY AREA LIKE MANY OTHER
PARTS OF OUR STATE ARE SUFFERING
FROM THE TWIN CRISES OF HOUSING
AND TRAFFIC CONGESTION.
BECAUSE OF A LACK OF HOUSING
WITH COUNTLESS RESIDENTS
SPENDING HOURS DRIVING BETWEEN
WHERE THEY WORK AND WHERE THEY
LIVE AN AVERAGE OF SEVENTY NINE
HOURS SITTING IN GRIDLOCK ON TOP
OF LONG COMMUTES.
UNFORTUNATELY TODAY MANY BART
STATION SO SURROUNDED BY
HUNDREDS OF ACRES OF ASPHALT
SURFACE PARKING LOTS FILLED BY
CARS. FILLED WITH CARS BY DAY
AND VACANT LOTS BY NIGHT.
THIS BILL IS NEEDED BECAUSE PART
HAS BEEN AROUND FOR FORTY FIVE
YEARS BUT NINETY FIVE PERCENT OF
DEVELOP ALL PARCELS ARE STILL
PARKING LOTS.
TOO MANY CITIES HAVE BUILT NO
HOUSING NEXT TO STATIONS AND THE
ONES THAT DID WATER DOWN
PROJECTS. THAT TOOK TEN TO
THIRTY YEARS FOR APPROVAL.
THIS IS A NARROWLY TAILORED
TRANSIT OR IN DEVELOPMENT BILL.
IT ONLY APPLIES TO PARK ON LAND
THE THREE HUNDRED OR SO ACRES
THAT ARE NOW NINETY FIVE PERCENT
PARKING LOTS IN THEIR DEVELOP A
AREAS.
BART TODAY IRONICALLY COULD
BUILD TRANSIT MAINTENANCE OR
PARKING FACILITIES WITHOUT ANY
ADDITIONAL PROOF WALLS BUT CAN'T
PERMIT HOUSING OR MIXED USE
DEVELOPMENT.
IT ONLY APPLIES TO SOME BART
STATIONS IN AREAS DIRECTLY
REPRESENTED OF ON THE ELECTED
PARK BOARD TO CREATE DIRECT AND
LOCAL POLITICAL ACCOUNTABILITY.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE BART
BOARD TO ESTABLISH BROAD TOT
ZONING STANDARDS.
WITH TWENTY PERCENT HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY AND THE CITY WOULD
HAVE TWO YEARS TO UPDATE MORE
SPECIFIC ZONING.
BART WOULD BE ALSO REQUIRED TO
INCORPORATE LOCAL DESIGN
GUIDELINES IN DEVELOPMENT
AGREEMENTS WITH PART TOT
DEVELOPERS AND CITIES THAT MEET
MARKET RATE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OBLIGATIONS UNDER ARENA.
WOULD BE EXEMPTED.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW TWENTY
THOUSAND HOUSING UNITS TO BILL
TO BE BUILT NEAR BART STATIONS
IT WOULD INCREASE TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP SUSTAINABILITY WALK
ABILITY. AND REDUCE CAR USE
CONGESTION AND GREENHOUSE GASES
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER MISTER GRAYSON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO RISE AS A
JOINT AUTHOR ON THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE.
AS THE FORMER MAYOR OF CONCORD I
TAKE LAND USE AND ZONING
AUTHORITY VERY VERY SERIOUSLY AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY THREE GRANTS
BART. A NARROWLY TAILORED
AUTHORITY TO ESTABLISH BASIC
DENSITY AND PARKING STANDARDS ON
BART OWN LAND.
THE EXISTING APPROACH TO HOUSING
AND TRANSIT DEVELOPMENT IS NOT
WORKING.
THE PROBLEM IS NOT THAT
DEVELOPMENT AROUND BART
CONFLICTS WITH LOCAL POLICY
GENERALLY THESE COMMUNITIES ARE
STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF WALKABLE
MIXED USE COMMUNITIES ADJACENT
TO BART. BUT LOCAL FACTIONS
AROUND BART STATIONS ARE ABLE TO
CREATE EXTRAORDINARY DELAYS AS
AN EXAMPLE. THE PLEASANT HILL
BART TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT TOOK OVER
ELEVEN YEARS TO DELIVER EARLY
PHASES
KEY SITES REMAIN UNDEVELOPED
EVEN AFTER TWENTY YEARS.
IT TAKES TOO LONG TO DELIVER
HOUSING AND JOBS AT THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY LOCATIONS IN THE BAY
AREA INCREDIBLY THE LARGEST CITY
AND CONTRA COSTA COUNTY PRODUCED.
A NET INCREASE OF ONLY ONE
HUNDRED AND NINE LIVING UNITS
AND THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
IT'S NO WONDER WE ARE
EXPERIENCING A HOUSING CRISIS
WE HAVE WORKED EXTENSIVELY AND
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
CITY'S COVERED BY THIS BILL TO
ADDRESS THEIR LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS. ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL
AND MAINTAINING COMMUNITY
CHARACTER AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY
THREE. ISN'T IT INNOVATIVE
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH TO
DELIVERING PROJECTS THAT REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS MANAGE
CONGESTION AND MEET INFILL
HOUSING NEEDS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS MISSION.
THINGS GRAYSON MISS BAKER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
OF FIRST UP QUESTION THE AUTHOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AM I UNDERSTAND IN YOUR OPENING
REMARKS IS A STATEMENT THAT.
ARE THERE SOME PLACES THAT ARE
NOT BUILDING ENOUGH HOUSING
WHICH SPECIFIC AREAS.
TO WHICH THIS BILL WOULD APPLY
ARE NOT BUILDING ENOUGH HOUSING.
THERE ARE TWENTY SIX PART
STATIONS AROUND WHICH THERE ARE
SURFACE PARKING LOTS AND IT'S AN
ALL OF THOSE JURISDICTIONS
INCLUDING AS YOU KNOW MANY IN
YOUR DISTRICT. ARE THAT HAVE
REFUSED TO BUILD HOUSING THAT WE
THINK OUGHT TO BUILD HOUSING.
AND DENSITY AROUND APART
STATIONS THAT WE'VE INVESTED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND WHAT
WHAT SPECIFIC.
MS BAKER LOCATIONS IS BIGGER WE
GENERALLY DON'T. EXACTLY THE
COLLOQUY AND BACK AND FORTH
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS.
.
I WOULD SUGGEST MAYBE AT PRESENT
YOUR QUESTION MISTER CHIU CAN
ADDRESS THAT IN HIS CLOTHES THEN
YOU MAY PROCEED WITH THANK YOU
ADDITIONAL THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I IF IF IT'S
POSSIBLE TO ADDRESS IN THE CLOSE
MY ADDITIONAL QUESTION WHICH
WHICH. SPECIFIC CITIES WILL THIS
APPLY TO
WHICH SPECIFIC TOWNS HAVE NOT
DONE THEIR PART AND ALLOWED TO
THAT QUESTION. FOR THOSE FOR
WHOM THE HALF MILE RADIUS IS
OPEN SPACE.
AND PARK LANDS WHICH PARKS AND
OPEN SPACE WOULD BE PROPOSED TO
TEAR UP. AND DATA AND ALLOW PART
TO BUILD HOUSING ON MY OWN TIME.
I RESPECTFULLY RISE IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIS LEGISLATION
FOR A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT
REASONS FIRST AND FOREMOST IT IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
SECTION ELEVEN.
ARTICLE ELEVEN SECTION ELEVEN
SPECIFICALLY SAYS IN OUR
CONSTITUTION THAT IT'S OUR
CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER THEIR POLICE
POWERS WHICH FUNDAMENTALLY
INCLUDES.
HOUSING.
AND THERE'S A REASON WHY THIS
MAKES COMPLETE AND TOTAL SENSE
IN OUR CONSTITUTION AND THAT IS
BECAUSE HOUSING WHAT YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD LOOKS LIKE HOW
YOU'VE DESIGNED IT WHAT THE
HEIGHT IS GOING TO BE WHAT THE
DENSITY IS GOING TO BE THE
PARKING AND THE EFFECT IT HAS ON
YOUR. LOCAL COMMUNITY SHOULD BE
DECIDED.
BY THAT LOCAL COMMUNITY WHOSE
BOARD MEMBERS WHETHER TO CITY
COUNCILOR COUNTY BOARD ACTUALLY
LIVE IN THAT COMMUNITY SO THIS
BILL IN I REALIZE WE DON'T
ALWAYS VOTE BASED ON WHETHER NOT
SOMETHING IS CONSTITUTIONAL THIS
BILL IS A COMPLETE VIOLATION. OF
VERY EXPLICIT PROVISIONS OF OUR
STATE CONSTITUTION BUT ASIDE
FROM THAT.
IF THIS WERE CONSTITUTIONAL THIS
BILL IS ALSO WHEN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE BECAUSE IT TAKES AN
AGENCY THAT HAS ONE JOB AND THAT
IS DELIVERING SAFE AND RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION.
AND GIVES IT A COMPLETE EXPANDED
AUTHORITY OVER SOMETHING IN
WHICH IT HAS NO EXPERTISE AT ALL.
YOU HEARD THE LANGUAGE HERE THAT
THIS IS NARROWLY TAILORED THIS
BILL IS NOT NARROWLY TAILORED IT
SAYS TO A TRANSIT AGENCY UNIT
MAY NOW BE THE EXCLUSIVE
AUTHORITY. THAT IS GOING TO
DECIDE HOW MUCH HOUSING IS
WITHIN A HALF MILE OF APART
STATION HOW DENSITY IS HOW MUCH
IS AFFORDABLE WHETHER OR NOT IT
HAS CERTAIN HEIGHTS HOW MUCH
PARKING SPACES GO WITH IT. AND
ALL OF THE ELEMENTS THAT GO
WITHOUT.
AND TRANSIT AGENCIES SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON DELIVERING RELIABLE
CONTINUOUS AND SAFE SERVICE.
NOW THIS IS BASICALLY LIKE
TAKING.
YOUR LOCAL DOG CATCHER.
AND SAYING YOU KNOW WHAT WE
DON'T THINK YOU'RE DOING THE
FIRE DEPARTMENT WORK CORRECTLY
WE KNOW BETTER THAN YOU SERVICE
TAKE THE LOCAL DOT CATCHER AND
PUT THEM IN CHARGE OF. YOUR FIRE
DEPARTMENT.
WHEN THE LOCAL DOG CATCHER HAS
NO EXPERTISE AND HOW TO DO A
FIRE DEPARTMENT AND IT'S WORSE.
BECAUSE THE DOG CATCHER DOESN'T
HAVE TO LIVE IN THE TOWN IN
WHICH THE FIRE DEPARTMENT IS
BECAUSE IN THIS BILL YOU CAN
HAVE BART CONTROLLING HOUSING IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD FOR WHICH THERE
IS ZERO REPRESENTATION ON THE
BART BOARD. IF YOU'RE A PART
DIRECTOR YOU DON'T HAVE TO LIVE
IN THAT AREA WHERE YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE CONTROL.
SO YOU'RE ACTUALLY TELLING THEM
THAT YOU WILL ALLOW BART TO
CONTROL HOUSING IN YOUR AREA BUT
BART DOESN'T HAVE TO LIVE THERE
YES THERE'S A PART BOARD
DIRECTOR WHO REPRESENTS A
VARIETY OF TALENTS BUT THEY'RE
GONNA BE MAKING THE DECISIONS
FOR TOWNS I DON'T EVEN LIVE IN.
SO EVEN IF IT WERE
CONSTITUTIONAL EVEN IF IT MADE
SENSE TO MAKE A TRANSIT AGENCY
RESPONSIBLE FOR HOUSING THIS IS
ALSO ABOUT BILL BECAUSE IT PUTS
BART IN CHARGE OF HOUSING.
BART HAS ENOUGH PROBLEMS RIGHT
NOW AND THAT'S GIVEN THE TRAINS
TO RUN ON TIME GIVING THE DRUG
ADDICTS OUT OF THE STATIONS ALL
THROUGHOUT THE BAR AREA WHO ARE
LINING. THE STATION'S AND FOR
WHOM THEY CAN'T ENSURE SAFETY
FOR THE WRITERS THERE IS A
WRITER RECENTLY IN THE LAST FEW
WEEKS WHO SITS ON A TRAIN AND
SITS ON A. A NEEDLE FROM A
HEROIN USER. BART HAS ENOUGH
PROBLEMS WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
GETTING THEIR ORIGINAL JOB DONE
CORRECTLY.
AND FINALLY.
I ASK YOU MEMBERS IFYOU WOULD
WANT TO GO BACK TO YOUR
DISTRICTS FOR THOSE MEMBERS WHO
ARE BAY AREA MEMBERS YOU HAVE
BART STATIONS ARE YOU READY TO
GO BACK TO YOUR DISTRICT AND SAY.
I'M SORRY SAN MATEO.
I'M SORRY MILLBRAE THIRTY
SECONDS I'M SORRY ANTIOCH AND
I'M SORRY ALL THE OTHERS PLACES
WHERE THERE'S A BART STATION NOW
OR IN THE FUTURE WE DON'T THINK
YOU'RE CAPABLE OF DOING YOUR
JOBS ARE GONNA HAVE BART DO IT
FOR YOU AND YOU CAN SAY NOTHING
ABOUT IT.
NOW IF YOUR ANSWER IS YES SIGN
ME UP DO A DISTRICT BILL FOCUSED
ON THOSE SPECIFIC STATIONS THAT
YOU THINK ARE DOING THEIR JOB IF
YOUR ANSWER IS NO. THEN VOTE NO
ON THIS BILL DO NOT PUT PART IN
CHARGE OF HOUSING IN THE BAY
AREA I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS BAKER SEEN NO DISH
I'M SORRY MISTER FRASIER'S
RAISES MICROPHONE MISTER FRAZIER
THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND.
BEING THE FORMER TRANSPORTATION.
CHAIR OF THESE COUNTY.
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY.
WE HAD AN ADDITIONAL BART
STATION BROUGHT INTO ANTIOCH.
FROM THE START BART WAS VERY
VERY HESITANT.
TO ADD ADDITIONAL PARKING SPACES
MATTER OF FACT FOR A FOURTEEN
THOUSAND A DAY RIDERSHIP
PROJECTION. THEY ONLY WANTED TO
PUT IN A THOUSAND PARKING SPACES
AND THEY SAID OTHER PEOPLE WILL
GET THERE. WHAT HAS BEEN A
HABITUAL PROBLEM WITH THIS
AGENCY AND DON'T GET ME WRONG
THEY HAVE A VERY GOOD PURPOSE
THE SHUTTLE FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE BAY AREA?
EVERY DAY. THAT TAKE THOSE%
PEOPLE OFF THE HIGHWAYS AND
THREE WASN'T. IN THAT DISTRICT.
IN THAT AREA.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HAS BEEN
VERY GLARINGLY A.
AWARE IS THAT EVERY TIME THAT
THEY DO PARKING. THEY DO A
MINIMALIST APPROACH.
AND NOW WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
DO IS SAY WELL. LETS MAKE IT SO
NOBODY CAN GET THEIR CONVENIENCE
AND CONNECTIVITY WILL GO AWAY.
AND THEY ALSO AS I GREW MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE THE SAN RAMON
VALLEY. THAT.
NUMBER ONE.
THEY ARE NOT COMPETENT TO BE
HOUSING ELEMENT OF.
PEOPLE.
NOW THAT IS A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
DECISION. THAT SHOULD BE KEPT IN
THAT REALM.
AND NEVER EVER BREACHED BY A
TRANCE TRANSIT AUTHORITY.
THEY WOULD PROVE THEMSELVES WHEN
THEY DID SOMETHING WITH THE
PLEASANT HILL. OF STATION IN.
IN THE EARLY EIGHTIES AND
NOTHING FLOUNDERED FOR MANY MANY
YEARS UNDER THEIR. PROGRESS.
I ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND. WHY
THEY'RE TRYING TO?
BUT AGAIN.
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND
AND MAKE SURE THAT TRANSIT IS.
IS
CONNECTIVE HAS CONNECTIVITY.
IT'S CONVENIENT.
AND IF WE KEEP PEOPLE AWAY FROM
THE WITH THE ROAD DIET.
THAT THEY CAN'T GET THEIR IN
PARK.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE USING
THAT FACILITY.
I URGE YOU.
ABSOLUTELY RESPECTFULLY URGE A
NO VOTE MAKING SURE THAT WE DO
NOT CIRCUMVENT LOCAL CONTROL.
THANK YOU.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL I CAME TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE.
IT ONCE AGAIN GOES TO THE
COMMENTS THAT.
MISS BAKER MADE REGARDING.
LOCAL CONTROL.
CONSTITUTIONALITY THAT'S IN THE
CONSTITUTION SAYS THE LOCAL
CONTROL BASICALLY RAINES AND
REMINDS ME OF WHO'S GETTING THE
POWER IT GOES FROM LOCAL CONTROL
THE BAR IS NOW BARGAIN HAVE MORE
CONTROL THANLOCALS. AND I'M
CONCERNED THAT WE'RE GONNA OPEN
A CAN OF WORMS WE NEED TO SPEND
MORE TIME ON THIS I ABSOLUTELY
AGREE THAT WE NEED TO HAVE MORE
HOUSING IS AT THE BEST SPOT JUST
BECAUSE THE LOCALS DON'T WANT ME.
WANT TO MOVE FORWARD ON HOUSING.
LET THEM MAKE THAT DECISION SO
AGAIN.
I RESPECTFULLY WANT TO SAY THAT
I MISTER CHIU MISTER GRACE WE
HAVE LONG DISCUSSIONS REGARDING
THIS BILL. A BUT AT THIS TIME I
DO OPPOSE IT.
ALL DEBATE AND DISCUSSION HAVING
CEASED.
YOUR CHIU YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER FIRST
OF ALL COLLEAGUES I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION ON THIS THIS IS
WHY IT'S BEEN SO CHALLENGING FOR
US TO ADDRESS OUR HOUSING. AND
TRANSIT CONGESTION CRISES.
AND AND I WANNA IN PARTICULAR I
RESPECT THE PERSPECTIVE OF OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM DUBLIN.
I DO KNOW SHE'S RESPECTING THE
PERSPECTIVE THAT HER DISTRICT
HAS BUT I WOULD SUGGEST THAT IS
THAT PERSPECTIVE WHICH IS
EXACTLY WHY WE NEED THIS BILL.
AND LET ME JUST PROVIDE A FEW
FACTS OF IN CONTEXT AND I WANT
TO ANSWER HER QUESTIONS ON THIS
ONE TALK ABOUT WHAT CITIES. ARE
NOT DOING LET ME TO SHARE SOME
OF THE FACTS ABOUT WHAT SOME OF
THE CITIES AND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
SIXTEEN HAVE NOT DONE AROUND
BART STATION.
IN DUBLIN THIS PAST MARCH THE
DUBLIN CITY COUNCIL VOTED DOWN
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY UNITS NEAR
THE DOUBLE IN PLEASANTON BART
STATION.
LAFAYETTE.
A DIP A DEVELOPER RECENTLY HAD
TO CHANGE PLANS FOR THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN UNITS TO
REDUCE IT TO FORTY FOUR HIGH AND
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES WITHIN
WALKING DISTANCE OF A BART
STATION.
IN WALNUT CREEK THE SITE OF
ANOTHER PART STATION THAT CITY
KILLED HOUSING DEVELOPMENT ON A
FORMER GOLF COURSE BY COLLECTING
SIGNATURES TO PUT THE
DEVELOPMENT. TO A PUBLIC VOTE.
ANOTHER TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT ON PARK LAND
STARTED TO BE DEVELOPED IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN YEARS LATER
HAS ONLY RECENTLY BROKEN GROUND.
PLEASANTON AGAIN THE SIDE OF
ANOTHER BART STATION HAS HAD AN
ABSOLUTE HOUSING CAP FOR YEARS.
JUST THIS PAST MONTH PART CHOSE
NOT TO SUPPORT A NEW PROPOSED
LIVERMORE PARK STATION WHICH
DOLLARS IN PART. BECAUSE THAT
CITY.
IN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTEEN
DERAILED THE ORIGINAL PROPOSED
SITE IN THE DOWNTOWN AREA.
NOW LET ME JUST SUGGEST IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO ONE PART
STARTED.
MS BAKER IS THE POINT OF ORDER.
POINT OF ORDER IF WE COULD
PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT THE AUTHOR
IS FACTUALLY BASED AND
RESPONDING TO THE MERITS OF THE
BILL THIS DOES NOT GO TO THE
MERITS OF THE BILL IT GOES TO
FALSE INFORMATION SOMEONE WHO
DOESN'T LIVE IN THE DISTRICT AND
KNOW. THAT IN FACT.
IT IN THE LOCATION THAT WE'RE
REFERRING TO HERE THEY HAVE
APPROVED THEIR RINA NUMBERS
THEY'VE MET.
SEVEN YEARS IN ADVANCE.
SO PLEASE SPEAK TO THE MERITS OF
THE BILL AND BE BASED IN FACT
ABOUT THE DISTRICT WHICH YOU ARE
REFERRING.
AND I WOULD JUST SAY I'VE
EVERYTHING I'VE SAID IS BASED IN
FACT WILL BE HER FRIEND A
DIFFERENT FACTORS YOU.
EACH YEAR WE HAVE A POINT OF
ORDER. UP BEFORE THE BODY.
I'M GOING TO SAY THAT THAT
POINT OF ORDER.
IS WELL TAKEN WITH RESPECT TO
FOCUSING ON THE MERITS OF THE
BILL.
MISTER CHU YOU MAY PROCEED AND
ADDRESSING.
MS BAKER'S
QUESTIONS.
THAT WERE POSED DURING HER
PRESENTATION AND I EXPECT WE'LL
EXPECT THAT MR CHU WILL TO SELL
SO MISTER CHIU YOU MAY PROCEED
ON ITEM AND IF I MAY THE REASON
I'D REFER TO THE CITY'S WAS OUR
COLLEAGUE. ASKED FOR WHAT CITIES
ARE NOT DOING THEIR WORK OF
BUILDING AROUND BART STATIONS.
DUBLIN LAFAYETTE WALNUT CREEK
PLEASANTON THIS IS THE CHALLENGE
THAT WE HAVE IN THE BAY AREA. A
FEW OTHER ON ANSWERS TO
QUESTIONS WERE TALKING ABOUT.
THE PARK OWN LAND.
OF WHICH NINETY FIVE PERCENT OF
THAT DEVELOP A LAND OUR SURFACE
PARKING LOTS
THIS BILL LIMITS.
THE USE OF THIS TO CONTINUOUS
PARCELS WITHIN A HALF A MILE
STATION. ARM AND AGAIN.
AT THE END OF THE DAY WE NEED TO
BUILD HOUSING WE NEED MIXED USE
DEVELOPMENT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BUILDING VIBRANT AFFORDABLE
WALKABLE COMMUNITIES. IT'S ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY SECURITY
WALKABILITY SUSTAINABILITY AND
THE LOCAL ECONOMY AND WITH THAT.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR SUPPORT SO WE CAN HELP
ADDRESS THE HOUSING AND TRANSIT
CRISES THAT WE HAVE INTERSTATE
THE PARTICULARLY IN THE BAY AREA.
AND ASK ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHIU.
WITH THAT CAR WILL BE THERE ALL
ON VOTE THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
MR MOVES A CALL.
MISTER CALDERON YOUR RECOMMENDS.
THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO A
THE TWO DAY FOUND THOSE
REQUIREMENTS TO ALLOW THE RULES
COMMITTEE TO HEAR A. B..
TWENTY FIFTY FIVE LEVINE TODAY
IN ROOM THIRTY. ROOM THIRTY ONE
SIXTY TWO UPON THE CALL OF THE
CHAIR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE OTHER
PLEASE MOVE ITEM THIRTEEN AB
THIRTY ONE TWENTY FIVE MAYES TO
THE NECK TO FILE.
A CLERK WILL NOTE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
THIRTY MINUTE RECESS UNDER CALL
OF THE SPEAKER. THERE IS LUNCH
FOR THE REPUBLICANS IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE ROOM AND LUNCH FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS.
IN THE CAUCUS ROOM. MEMBERS THIS
IS GOING TO BE THIRTY MINUTES
PROBABLY.
WE HAVE.
LOTS TO DO THIS AFTERNOON PLEASE
RETURN TO THE FLOOR.
SHORTLY AFTER ONE O'CLOCK WE
WILL RESUME BUSINESS AT ONE ó
FIVE PM ONE OH FIVE P. AND WE'RE
GOING TO RESUME BUSINESS AND
VOTING ON THIS FLOOR.
THIS IS RECESS UNDER CALL
ONE OF FIVE WE ARE BACK IN
SESSION.
PLEASE RETURN TO THE FLOOR.
PLEASE RETURN TO THE FLOOR AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE WE ARE GOING TO
RESUME VOTING ON THIS FLOOR.
MOMENTARILY
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN SESSION.
PLEASE RETURN TO THE FLOOR
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN TO THE
FLOOR IMMEDIATELY MEMBERS PLEASE
RETURN TO THE FLOOR SO WE MAY
RESUME TAKING ADAMS UP
MEMBERS WE ARE GETTING READY TO
TAKE UP BILLS.
THOSE WHO ARE NOT ON THE FLOOR
PLEASE RETURN TO THE FLOOR NOW
.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK ON THE FILE.
FILE ITEM SIXTY FIVE AB TWENTY
NINE THIRTY THREE.
STIR MADE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
SIXTY FIVE AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY
THREE MEDINA THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE THIRTY
THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER MEDINA
AND ACTUALLY A PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES. MR MEDINA THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE THIRTY
THREE WOULD REQUIRE COUNTIES TO
DESIGNATE A LIAISON IN THEIR
WELFARE DEPARTMENTS.
SERVE AS A SINGLE POINT OF
CONTACT.
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE COUNSELORS.
THIS WILL HELP PROVIDE THE
STUDENTS WITH SOCIAL HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
PROVIDED BY THE COUNTY.
SEVERAL COUNTIES OF UTILIZE A
SIMILAR MODEL IN ORDER TO
CONNECT SOCIAL WORKERS.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COUNSELORS AND
THIS IS PROVEN TO BE.
A PERFECT COMING TOGETHER.
THANK YOU AN I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE BILL.
CARPOOL OPEN THE RIGHT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT ICE FIFTY
SIX NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES WE'RE GOING
TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
SIXTY SEVEN AB THIRTY TWO OH
SEVEN BY MS AMONG THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TEO SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON AND
ACTUALLY TO FINANCE LENDING. MS
AMONG.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A. B.
THIRTY TWO OH SEVEN UPDATE THE
CALIFORNIA FINANCE THE LAW TO
REFLECT THE NEW WAYS THAT
COMPANY BROKER LOANS. ONLINE AND
ENSURES THAT THE STATE'S
FINANCIAL REGULATOR IS EQUIPPED
TO ENFORCE THE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS PROVIDED BY THE
CALIFORNIA FINANCING LAW.
UNDER EXISTING LAW THE
DEFINITION OF BROKER IS VAGUE
AND CIRCULAR LEADING TO
CONFUSION FROM LENDERS ABOUT
WHICH COMPANIES THEY CAN PARTNER
WITH WHEN ARRANGING LOANS.
FURTHER THE DEFINITION OF BROKER
IN EXISTING LAW WAS FORMULATED
LONG BEFORE THE RISE OF THE
INTERNET AND THE EVOLUTION OF
ONLINE LEAD GENERATION.
SO OUR LAWS NEED TO BE UPDATED
WITH THIS ONLINE ACTIVITY IN
MINE THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
ON LINE THE GENERATOR'S FOLLOW
COMMONSENSE CONSUMER PROTECTION
SUCH AS DISCLOSURE OF POTENTIAL
CONFLICT OF INTEREST. AND A
REQUIREMENT THAT THE LEE
GENERATORS RECEIVE A CONSUMERS
PERMISSION BEFORE TRANSMITTING
OR SELLING CONSUMER SENSITIVE
PERSONAL DATA. I WORK ON THIS
BILL WITH THE BROAD GROUP OF
STRAIGHT QUARTERS AND TOOK
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS.
THOSE AMENDMENTS BROUGHT ON THE
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
FINANCIAL SERVICES ASSOCIATION
AS WELL AS CALIFORNIA'S
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THEY WAS AMONG.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WILL. OPEN RURAL. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WAS OUT OF VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF OF
MISS THEM ON
PARA PASSED I AM.
CA.
WHERE FILE ITEM SIXTY NINE?
AB THIRTY TO THIRTY TWO BY MISS
FRIEDMAN CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TO THIRTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
ENERGY.
MS FRIEDMAN YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
THIRTY TO THIRTY TWO REQUIRES
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
TO ASSESS THE POTENTIAL FOR
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS FROM BUILDINGS IN LINE
WITH OUR STATES CLIMATE CALLS.
THIS ASSESSMENT WILL NOT ONLY
CUT CONSIDER COST EFFECTIVE
STRATEGIES TO REDUCE EMISSIONS
FROM SPACE HEATING WATER HEATING.
AND BOTH NEW AND EXISTING
RESIDENTIAL AND COMMERCIAL
BUILDINGS TAKING INTO ACCOUNT
POTENTIAL IMPACTS ON CUSTOMER
COSTS AND GRID RELIABILITY. IT
REQUIRES A CC TO CONSIDER THE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED
WITH LOW INCOME HOUSING MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING AND HIGH RISE
BUILDINGS.
IT ALSO REQUIRES A CC TO ACCOUNT
FOR THE IMPACT FROM THE NEW
REQUIREMENT FOR ALL SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES TO BE BUILT WITH
SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEMS ALBUM
INCREASING TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION. THE BILL HAS NO
MANDATES IT DOES NOT REQUIRE.
THE ELECTRIFICATION OF BUILDINGS
IT IS NOT REQUIRE ANY FUEL
SWITCHING BY ANYONE RECENT
AMENDMENTS REMOVED THE
OPPOSITION FROM SOCAL GAS
SEPARATE PGA ANNIE COUNTY FORTY
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. THE FARM BUREAU THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATIONS AND MANY OTHERS. AB
THIRTY TO THIRTY TWO IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
ADOBE SYSTEMS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON EBAY AND THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THERE'S FRIEDMAN SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK LIBERAL ON MEMBERS.
WHOSE ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO GO.
CLARK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE AYES FORTY THREE DOES
EIGHTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE HAVE DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM
SEVENTY.
WHERE FILE ITEM SEVENTY ONE A.
B. SEVENTEEN NINETY THREE BY
MISTER BONTA THE CLERK WILL READ?
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN NINETY
THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER BONTA AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAINED CANNABIS
MISTER BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
THREE CREATES A SIMPLER PATHWAY.
FOR CALIFORNIANS TO TURN THE
PAGE BY EXPEDITING THE EXISTING
PROCESS OR PROP SIXTY FOUR FOR
REMOVING OR REDUCING.
CERTAIN CANNABIS RELATED
CONVICTIONS ON THEIR RECORDS
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR WHICH
VOTERS PASSED WITH A
SUPERMAJORITY FIFTY SEVEN
PERCENT APPROVAL IN NOVEMBER
TWENTY SIXTEEN CONTAIN
PROVISIONS THAT NOT ONLY
PROSPECTIVELY REDUCED OR
ELIMINATED. MANY CANNABIS LAW
VIOLATIONS BUT MADE THOSE
CHANGES RETROACTIVE TO BE CLEAR
COLLEAGUES
THIS BILL DOES NOT CREATE ANY
NEW SUBSTANTIVE RIGHT.
IT MERELY MAKES MORE EFFICIENT
THE PROCESS FOR QUALIFIED
INDIVIDUALS TO REALIZE AN
ALREADY. EXISTING RIGHT
SPECIFICALLY AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
THREE PROVIDES.
INCREASED EFFICIENCY BY
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO SEARCH THE CRIMINAL
RECORD DATABASE TO IDENTIFY ALL
CALIFORNIANS POTENTIALLY
ELIGIBLE FOR REDUCTION OR
EXPUNGEMENT AND THEN PROVIDE
THIS INFORMATION TO DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS BY JULY FIRST TWENTY
NINETEEN. AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN
TO GIVE THEPROSECUTION MORE
TIME A FULL YEAR. TO REVIEW EACH
OF THE CASES AND TO CHALLENGE IF
ANY OF THE CASES PRESENT A RISK
TO PUBLIC SAFETY. AFTER THE
REVIEW PROCESS THE COURT AND
THEN MODIFY THE RECORD AT
THERE'S NO CHALLENGED BY THE
PROSECUTION
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND HAVE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE ALL
OPPOSITION. THIS INCLUDES LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHICH IS NOW NEUTRAL.
LOS ANGELES DISTRICT ATTORNEY
JACKIE LACEY IS OFFICIALLY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR COLLEAGUES FOR
CONSIDERATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THINGS BONTA SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CORPORATE ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS AN.
MISTER BONTA MOVES A CALL
.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY TWO.
IS AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY THREE BY
DR WEBER.
CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
THREE BY SOME A MEMBER WEBER AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE CHILD
CARE.
DOCTOR WEBER. YES MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS SAW A. B. EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY THREE IS A MUCH NEEDED
LEGISLATION TO ALLOW OUR ACTIVE
MILITARY FAMILIES THE OPTION OF
APPLYING TO CHOP HERE WITHOUT
HAVING TO COUNT. THE BASIC
ALLOWANCE FOR HOUSING AS PART OF
THE INCOME DETERMINATION.
LET ME BE CLEAR THIS BILL DOES
NOT GIVE PRIORITY TO THESE
ACTIVITIES HERE FAMILIES OVER
THOSE THAT ARE LOW INCOME
ELIGIBLE BUT ALLOWS FAMILIES TO
HAVE THEIR NAMES PUT ON AN
ELIGIBILITY LIST SHOULD A CHILD
CARE SLAP BECOME AVAILABLE.
THE BILL HAS AS INTRODUCED ALSO
ATTEMPTED TO ADDRESS ISSUES OF
HOME OF FOOD INSECURITY AMONG
THE MILITARY. BUT THIS COMPONENT
WAS REMOVED BECAUSE OF COSTS AND
POTENTIAL FEDERAL ACTIONS IN
THIS ISSUE. SO NEVERTHELESS HIS
BODY IS LIKELY GOING TO HAVE TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE THE FUTURE OF
FOOD INSECURITY AMONG OUR
MILITARY FAMILIES. HOW SO AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY THREE IT HAS
BEEN A BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES AND I'D
LIKE TO?
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU I VOTE
FOR AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY THREE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK OF THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON
VOTERS OUT OF THEM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOUGH.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIX YOU KNOW ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM SEVENTY THREES
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY CORPORATE.
pBY ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA AND EXPLAIN GREENHOUSE
GASES MISTER GARCIA.
AND MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES A. B. NINETEEN
SEVENTY DIRECTS THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION.
CREATE THREE PILOT PROJECTS THAT
WAS SPUR INNOVATION AND CLEAN
FUELS AND TRANSPORTATION
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
THINGS ARE CO SINGER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
QUIRK CORPORAL.
THE SAD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
ICE FORTY ONE. KNOWS TWENTY.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
SEVENTY FOURS AB TWENTY TWENTY
THREE QORQORI.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWENTY
THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER CABALLERO
AND OTHERS ACTUALLY TO TAXATION.
THIS COMING YEAR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY TWENTY THREE A PRIORITY
BILL OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS WHICH
WOULD ALLOW WORKING FAMILIES TO
RECEIVE A SMALL TAX REFUND. FOUR
QUALIFIED CHILDCARE EXPENSES TO
DEFRAY THE HIGH COST OF CARE.
THE CHILD INDEPENDENT TAX CREDIT
ALLOWS TAXPAYERS WITH ADJUSTED
GROSS INCOMES BELOW A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO REDUCE THEIR
TAX LIABILITY BY A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF ELIGIBLE CHILDCARE
EXPENSES. IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
THE STATE MADE THE CREDIT NON
REFUNDABLE DUE TO BUDGET
SHORTFALLS.
AND LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
FAMILIES WHERE THEREBY EXCLUDED
FROM THE CREDIT EVEN THOUGH THEY
FACED HIGH OUT OF POCKET
EXPENSES PER CHILD CARE.
THIS BILL MAKES THE CREDIT
REFUNDABLE SOLOING COME FAMILIES
CAN AGAIN BENEFIT ASSISTING THEM
TO MEET THEIR BASIC EXPENSES
LIKE FOOD HOUSING TRANSPORTATION
AND UTILITIES.
REFUNDABLE CREDITS HAVE BEEN
PROVEN TO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
POSITIVE EFFECT.
ON LOW INCOME FAMILIES BY
IMPROVING CHA CHILDREN'S HEALTH
AND EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES AND THE
FAMILY'S INCOME. I RESPECT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
MAKING HIS CABALLERO SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
FOR FLOOD CONTROL. ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE OWNERS VOTERS OUT OF.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE CUBES
TO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE IS AB
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ ACTUALLY PRESENTS THIS
RODRIGUEZ.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
WHICH ENSURES THAT CALIFORNIA'S
PRISONS. ARE SECURE SITES FOR
INMATE STAFF IN THE PUBLIC.
IN JANUARY OF THIS YEAR IN IN ME
ESCAPE FROM THE CHINO
INSTITUTION FOR MEN. OKAY
LOCATED MY DISTRICT DUE TO A
BROKEN FENCE CENSOR THIS COULD
HAVE BEEN PREVENTED WITH MORE
OVERSIGHT. AND TOM REPAIRS TO
PRISON GROUNDS
UNDER CURRENT LAW THERE IS NO
REQUIREMENT A REGULATION FOR
PRISON SECURITY TO BE. ASSESSED
AB TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT OR
REQUIRE CDC ARE TO CONDUCT
PHYSICAL SECURITY EXPECT
INSPECTIONS AND PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR REPAIR BASED
ON RISK.
A RESPECT WE ASK FOR A VOTE.
THINGS RODRIGUEZ SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLUB LIBERAL.
ON MEMBERS VETERANS ARE TO VOTE
ON THE WRIST VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX AB
TWENTY THIRTY CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THIRTY BY
FAMILY MEMBERS AMOUNT AND
ACTUALY AND CAL WORKS.
MS AMONG YOU MAY OPEN. THINK USE
AT MISTER SPEAKER AB TWENTY
THIRTY WILL MAKE SURE VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES ARE IDENTIFIED
IN PROVIDED WITH THE PROPER
SERVICES WHEN PARTICIPATING
CALIFORNIA WORK OPPORTUNITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY. TO
KIDS ALSO KNOWN AS CAL WORKS.
FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS REQUIRE
MUNICIPALITIES LIKE CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO PROVIDE REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES AND VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
CURRENTLY BOTH THE INITIAL
APPLICATION FOR APPLYING FOR CAL
WORKS AND OR CAL FRESH AND THE
SEMI ANNUAL LEGIBILITY REPORT
FORM DO NOT INCLUDE A QUESTION
ABOUT THE APPLICANTS NEED FOR
AMERICAN DISABILITIES EIGHTY
EIGHT. ACCOMMODATIONS AND OR IF
THE VICTIM IF THEY ARE VICTIMS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AB TWENTY
THIRTY WOULD MAKE SURE THAT THE
CASE WORKERS ARE MADE AWARE OF
THE APPLICANTS OR RECIPIENTS
NEED FOR ACCOMMODATIONS.
I REQUEST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTES
THEY WAS AMONG SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
COR CALDERON I'M UNDERSTANDS OUR
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ALL TIME ABOUT AYE
SIXTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN
IS AB TWENTY FIFTY EIGHT
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIFTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAO AND ACTUALLY DRIVING UNDER
THE INFLUENCE MR CHOW YOU MAIL
BUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY
FIFTY EIGHT WOULD ESTABLISH
CANNABIS AS A SEPARATE CHARGING
SUBSECTION WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
THE YOU AYE CODE. AS WE HAVE
SEEN IN OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
LEGALIZED CANNABIS AN INCREASE
IN CANNABIS DRUG DRIVING CAN BE
EXPECTED DUE TO LEGALIZATION.
AFTER LEGALIZATION THE STATES OF
COLORADO AND WASHINGTON BOTH
EXPERIENCED AN INCREASE IN
CANNABIS INVOLVED ACCIDENTS
INCLUDING FATALITIES. WITH
WASHINGTON STATE EXPERIENCING AN
INCREASE OF EIGHTY ONE PERCENT
IN THESE ACCIDENTS AND DAHLE
COLORADO EXPERIENCING AT ONE
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE PERCENT
INCREASE. ID'S ACCIDENTS BETWEEN
THE YEARS TWENTY THIRTEEN AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN.
ALLOWING CANNABIS TO HAVE ITS
OWN SUBSECTION WITHIN THAT THE
YOU AYE CODE WILL GIVE OFFICERS
THE ABILITY TO SPECIFICALLY
CHARGE SOMEONE WITH DRIVING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF CAT OF
CANADA'S. AS OPPOSED TO THE
CURRENT SYSTEM OUGHT WORD IT IS
A CHARGE UNDER DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE OF DRUGS.
AS A RESULT OF THIS CURRENT
SYSTEM THE STATE HAS NO WAY OF
DETERMINING HOW MANY CANNABIS
THE U. ICE OCCUR. ANNUALLY
BECAUSE TO SPECIFIC SUBSTANCE
ISN'T SPECIFIED WHEN SOMEONE IS
CHARGED.
ADDING CANNABIS IT HAS ITS OWN
SUBSECTION WILL ALLOW THE STATE
TO HAVE ACCURATE AND RELIABLE
INFORMATION OF HOW MANY CANNABIS
DO YOU WISE OCCUR IN THE STATE
ANNUALLY. WHICH WILL BE HELPFUL
IN ASSISTING THE STATE TO COME
UP WITH AN INFORMED POLICY
AROUND CANNABIS THE U. EYES. AS
WE TRANSITION INTO THE LEGALIZE
CANNABIS MARKET WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU AYE
VOTE.
MISTER LACKEY YEAR RECOMMENDS
YEAH QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
IS YOUR ATTENTION TO EXCLUDE DO
YOU AYE FOR DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE OF CANNABIS AND OTHER
DRUGS.
THE INTENT IS JUST TO PROVIDE
ACCURATE INFORMATION ON THE U. I
DIRECT DRIVING ARE I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
THAT MAYBE EXTRANEOUS OF THE
INTENT IS TO REMOVE THAT
LANGUAGE WHEN WE GET TO THE
SENATE. THE ONLY OBJECTIVE OF
THIS BILL IS TO OUR PROVIDED
DATA WE NOT GONNA CHANGE THE
PENALTY OR THE THE SYSTEM UNDER
WHICH.
AT THE OFFICERS CURRENTLY
OPERATE.
YEAH THANK YOU I'VE I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO SAY TO THE SPEAKER
MEMBERS. THAT THIS PARTICULAR
BILL IS A GOOD BILL BECAUSE IT
HELPS US CAPTURE THE INFORMATION
SPECIFIC. TO A CANNABIS
IMPAIRMENT AND THIS A VERY VERY
GOOD BILL AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOUR.
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY S. YOU
MISTER FRASIER'S MICROPHONE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
SPEAKER OF JUST BEING THE CHAIR
TRANSPORTATION WANT TO CLARIFY
SOMETHING ALSO. IS THERE'S A
THREE MILLION DOLLAR STUDY THE
HIGHWAY PATROL IS DOING IN
PARALLEL WITH THIS.
FOR THE ENFORCEMENT OF
IMPAIRMENT BY MARIJUANA THIS
JUST STRENGTHENS THE ABILITY TO
GET. ENFORCEMENT GOING SO THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY EMBRACE TO THE
LEGALIZATION AND UNDERSTAND WHO
AND WHO IS NOT IMPAIRED. AYE AYE
URGENT AYE VOTE.
THEY WAS FRAZIER SEE NO DIGITAL
DISCUSS OR DEBATE MACHINE SHALL
YOU MAY CLOSE WE WISH.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK ARRIVAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CLERK WILL OPEN
RIGHT. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TELL YOU ABOUT AYE
AYES FORTY EIGHT NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES WORD FILE
ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT.
AB TWENTY SIXTY CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIXTY BY
FAMILY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA AND
ACTUALLY THE WATER. MR SEO. AB
TWENTY SIXTIES ABOUT ENSURING
CLEAN SAFE DRINKING WATER AND
THE PROPER TREATMENT OF
WASTEWATER FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND SMALLER.
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THE BILL EXPAND
ELIGIBILITY FOR AN EXISTING.
PROVEN ADVANCE PAYMENT MECHANISM
CREATED BY S. B. TO AWAIT IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
OUR CLUB ON A ROLL. MEMBER
SHARON THIS OUT OF VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE TO HOW
ABOUT AYE SIXTY ONE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES WE'RE GOING
TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
SEVENTY NINE.
MISTER CALDERON.
DO YOU THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I JUST WANT TO ASK OUR MEMBERS
THAT WHILE MEMBERS OF PRESENTING
A BILL THAT WOULD KEEP THE
CONVERSATIONS DOWN A LITTLE BIT
IT'S GETTING A LITTLE BIT LOUD.
AS OUR COLLEAGUES ARE PRESENTING
THEIR BILLS THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE THEIR MIND WHICH
CALDERON.
BACK ON THE FILE.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM EIGHTY.
AB THIRTY.
EIGHTY ONE CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY EIGHTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AND OTHERS AND EXPLAIN
TO EMPLOYMENT. THIS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THE ME TOO MOVEMENT HAS
GONE A LONG WAY TO FURTHER THE
DIALOGUE ABOUT HOW TO BETTER
PROTECT WORKING AND WORKERS FROM
SEXUAL HARASSMENT THE WORKPLACE.
UNFORTUNATELY MOST THAT FOCUS
HAS BEEN ON POLITICIANS AND
HOLLYWOOD.
HOWEVER WE KNOW THAT THE
EXPERIENCES OF WORKERS IN
AGRICULTURE HOSPITALITY RETAIL
RESTAURANT JANITORIAL AND OTHER
SERVICE INDUSTRIES ARE FAR WORSE
INTO OFTEN LEFT OUT OF THE
CONVERSATION.
AB THIRTY EIGHTY ONE TAKE THE
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING THE THREAT OF
RETALIATION IS A BARRIER FOR
WORKERS TRYING TO SECURE SAFETY
AND JUSTICE IN THE WORKPLACE
AFTER FACING SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
THIS BILL WILL EXTEND THE STATUE
OF LIMITATIONS FOR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT RELATED RETALIATION
CLAIMS TO THREE YEARS IF WORKER
CHOOSES TO FILE CLAIM THE BILL
WOULD ESTABLISH A NINETY DAY
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION OF
UNLAWFUL RETALIATION. THIS IS IN
PART BECAUSE WE ARE IN OUT WILL
STAY IN CALIFORNIA WHICH MEANS
EVEN THOUGH YOU CANNOT BE. A
FIRED FOR FOR AYE PUTTING
THROUGH A SEXUAL HARASSMENT
CLAIM YOU COULD BE FIRED FOR
JUST ABOUT ANY OTHER REASON THIS
MAKE SURE THAT.
THERE HAS TO BE CAUSE TO FIRE
YOU AFTER A SEXUAL HARASSMENT
CLAIM FOR THE NEXT NINETY DAYS.
UNDER THIS BILL THE WORKERS
WOULD HAVE WAITED ANONYMOUSLY
REPORT SEXUAL HARASSMENT CLAIMS
TO THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S
OFFICE.
ADDITIONALLY IT WOULD HAVE HOLD
LABOR CONTRACTORS ACCOUNTABLE BY
REQUIRING CIVIL LIABILITY FOR
CASES OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
ASSAULT DISCRIMINATION WHERE THE
ACTION TOOK PLACE ON.
THAT THE PRIMARY EMPLOYERS WORK
SITE IN THE PRIMARY EMPLOYER WAS
TOLD ABOUT THE ACTION ABOUT A.
B. THIRTY EIGHTY ONE WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE EMPLOYERS WITH AT LEAST
TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES TO PROVIDE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT. TRAINING TO
THE EMPLOYEES THEMSELVES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
MR BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AT THE JOINT AUTHORED
ON THIS BILL I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY EIGHTY ONE AT A
TIME IN WHICH THAT ME TO
MOVEMENT HAS TAKEN CENTER STAGE
IT'S BECOME CLEAR. THAT WE MUST
DO MORE TO PROTECT SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN THE
WORKPLACE IN CALIFORNIA WITH
THIS BILL CAN SET THE BAR HIGHER.
A. B. THIRTY EIGHTY ONE IS A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESS SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN THE
WORKPLACE AND WILL EXTEND
EMPLOYMENT PROTECTIONS IN ORDER
TO CREATE A SAFE. WORKING
ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL. OUR AS LEAD
AUTHOR MENTIONED WE'VE ADDED MY
BILL AND INTO THAT AUTHORS SPELL
WHICH HAS A REALLY PART
PROVISIONS AROUND SAFE DAYS FOR
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
GIVING THEM THE ABILITY TO
ACCESS JOB PROTECTED LEAVE.
ALREADY AVAILABLE FOR SURVIVORS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL
ASSAULT OR STOCKING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA.
YOUR GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS.
.
YOU KNOW OVER THE LAST COUPLE
DAYS YOU KNOW IT'S.
THIS BILL WILL BE HARD TO SAY
HERE.
AS WE HEAR.
YOU KNOW ALL THESE THIS I'VE
HEARD SEVERAL TIMES NOW.
YOU KNOW THAT SEXUAL HARASSMENT
GOES BEYOND THE HALLS OF
GOVERNMENT.
AND THERE'S ALL THESE OTHER
PLACES WHERE THIS IS HAPPENING.
BUT I'M JUST REMINDED OF OF THE
BIBLICAL VERSE.
BEFORE YOU ARE TAKE THE LOG.
OR IS BEFORE YOU TAKE THIS BACK
OUT OF YOUR BROTHER'S EYE.
REMOVE THE LOG FROM YOUR OWN.
NO BECAUSE THERE IS A PROBLEM
GOING ON IN GOVERNMENT.
AND SEVERAL OF THESE BILLS HAVE
BEEN PASSED IN THIS BODY
ACTUALLY EXEMPT GOVERNMENT.
AND IN SOME CASES EXEMPT THE
LEGISLATURE.
FROM THE RULES THAT THEY WANT TO
APPLY TO EVERYBODY ELSE.
BUT BEFORE YOU START DOWN THAT
ROAD FIRST OF ALL THERE'S A
PROBLEM RIGHT HERE. THERE'S A
PROBLEM IN GOVERNMENT.
WITH SEXUAL HARASSMENT THAT
HASN'T BEEN SOLVED.
AND THEIR END AND THERE IS A
PROBLEM.
IT YOU NOTICE I BOS NOT JUST
HOLLYWOOD.
WELL IT IS IN HOLLYWOOD ACTUALLY
IN HOLLYWOOD THERE'S THERE WAS A
VERY BIG PROBLEM THAT I STILL
THINK IS. NOT RESOLVED.
AND YET.
WE JUST GAVE HOLLYWOOD A BIG TAX
BREAK YESTERDAY.
DO WE REALLY HOLD THEM TO
ACCOUNT.
NO BUT WE HAVE ALL THESE BILLS
NOW.
THEY GO WAY BEYOND.
FOR IT FOR INSTANCE THIS BILL.
I AGREE THAT WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN THE
WORKFORCE
BUT THIS BILL GOES WAY BEYOND
THAT.
IN A AND OCUSES ON ALL A WHOLE
HOST OF OTHER EMPLOYMENT CLAIMS.
THIS JUST THE BASICALLY IS JUST
SAYING UP A HEYDAY FOR TRIAL
LAWYERS.
TO BRING CLAIMS AGAINST.
THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
WELL FIRST OF ALL FOCUS FOCUS ON
YOURSELF FIRST.
RIGHT.
WHAT WE HAVE WE CHANGED OUR
PROCESS USE HAS GOVERNMENT HELD
ITSELF ACCOUNTABLE?
BROUGH THINGS IT THAT IT'S DONE.
WE'RE GOING TO REVIEW ALL THE
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES THAT WAS A
BILL THAT WAS PASSED YESTERDAY.
WE'RE GONNA TRACK ALL THE CLAIMS
THAT ARE IN THERE. BUT WE
SPECIFICALLY EXEMPTED THE
LEGISLATURE.
SHOULD WE BE KEEPING TRACK
SALUTE OF OF THE CLAIMS IN OUR
OWN HOUSE.
I AM SO LET'S NOT GET ON OUR
HIGH HORSE AND USE
THE SEXUAL HARASSMENT ISSUE.
AND THE ME TO MOVEMENT TO DO A
WHOLE BUNCH OF OTHER STUFF THAT
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND LET'S NOT BE
HYPOCRITES.
AND NOT DEAL WITH THE ISSUES
THAT ARE RIGHT HERE IN OUR OWN
HOUSE.
AND ARE RIGHT HERE IN THE HALLS
OF GOVERNMENT.
BEFORE WE GO IN AND AND SAY THAT
WE'RE GOING TO APPLY THIS IN A
WHOLE HOST OF OTHER AREAS BEEN
REMOVED WHEN YOU LOG FROM YOUR
PHONE ON FLETCHER STATE YOUR
POINT OF ORDER. AND HE'S NOT
SPEAKING TO THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
IT DOES INCLUDE THE LEGISLATURE.
MR GALLAGHER IS CONCLUDED HIS
REMARKS.
A POINT OF ORDER IS WELL TAKEN
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU MAY
PROCEED WITH YOUR CLOTHES SEEING
NO OTHER DISCUSS.
I JUST WANT TO BE HEARD A LETTER
YOU YOU CONCLUDED YOUR REMARKS.
I'M I I APPRECIATE MY MY
COLLEAGUE AND I DON'T
NECESSARILY DISAGREE WITH HIS
ASSERTION BUT THIS BILL INCLUDES
EVERY SINGLE EMPLOYER IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING OURSELVES
AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY.
CLICK LIBERAL. ON THE RESERVES
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE.
VOTE
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER. ALL MOVED
TO CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
I'M FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE.
AND EIGHTY TWO.
WE ARE AT.
MEMBERS IF YOU HAVE ITEMS
PRESENT IN THE FLOWER PLEASE
FIND YOUR DESK AND BE READY TO
PRESENT.
WHERE PASS TEMPORARILY IN FILE
ITEM EIGHTY THREE FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FOUR?
HE IS AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN BY MISS CARILLO.
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN BASICALLY MEMBER CARILLO
AND ACTUALLY THAT COMMUNICATIONS
WAS CARILLO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RIGHTS TO PREVENT AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN.
THE BILL THAT HELPS PROVIDE
BETTER REDUCE COSTS FELL.
COSTELLO HOME PHONE SERVICES FOR
LOW INCOME FAMILIES LIFELINE
THAT THE PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION OR THE CPUC FAR LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT HELPS OFFSET THE COST OF
THEIR HOME PHONE AND CELL PHONE
BILLS.
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
ESTABLISHES THE LIFELINE
OVERSIGHT BOARD OR AL AL OP TO
ADVISE THE CPUC ON THE EFFECTIVE
DEVELOPMENT IMPLEMENTATION AND
ADMINISTRATION OF THE LIFELINE
PROGRAM. B. L. L. OB RESTRUCTURE
THING CODIFIES AN EXISTING
ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR LIFELINE.
THIS WAS STRUCTURE WILL CLARIFY
THE SCOPE OF THE DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE BOARD
WHILE ENCOURAGING GREATER
CONSUMER PARTICIPATION. AND
INPUT REGARDING HOW LIFELINE IS
RUN.
THIS WHAT'S RAIN THE ABILITY OF
THIS PROGRAM TO PROVIDE BETTER
SERVICES TO A LARGER NUMBER OF
DESERVING LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THEY MISS CARILLO.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK LIBERAL. ON MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE A ROLE TOWN
ABOUT ICE FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FIVE IS AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY THREE COOPERATE ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FIVE NINETY THREE BY
SOME THE MEMBER GRAYSON AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE AIR
AMBULANCE SERVICES. MISTER
GRAYSON. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
THREE.
IT WILL INCREASE MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR
EMERGENCY AIR AMBULANCE
PROVIDERS AIR AMBULANCE.
AMBULANCES PROVIDES LIFESAVING
SERVICES AND ARE CRITICAL
TRANSPORT RIGHT IN TRANSPORTING
PATIENTS FROM THE SIDE OF
EMERGENCY TO HOSPITALS AND
TRAUMA CENTERS IMPORTANTLY EVER
OUT EMERGENCY AIR AMBULANCES.
TRANSPORT ALL EMERGENCY PATIENTS
WITHOUT REGARD TO THE MEDICAL
INSURANCE OR TO ABILITY TO PAY.
CURRENTLY THE MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR
PROVIDERS ARE FAR BELOW THE COST
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES AND THE
RATES HAVE NOT BEEN ADJUSTED FOR
OVER TWENTY TWO YEARS.
AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY THREE WILL
INCREASE MEDICARE RATES FOR AIR
AMBULANCE SERVICES TO THE RULE
MEDICARE LEVEL WHICH WILL BRING
AIR AMBULANCE PROVIDERS CLOSER
TO ACTUAL COST THIS'LL.
THIS WILL NOT COVER ALL OF THE
COST BUT ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF THE
COST OF ONE FLIGHT.
RECENT AMENDMENTS MAKE SURE THAT
PATIENTS ARE HELD HARMLESS AND
NOT BUILT FOR MORE THAN THEIR
SHARE OF THE COST OF EMERGENCY
FLIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR.
THEY WAS GRAYSON SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE. LOCAL RUN. ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
ICE FORTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM EIGHTY SIXES AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY SIX COOLEY
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE NINETY
SIX BY SOME A MEMBER COOLEY AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT MISTER COOLEY.
COLLEAGUES MPS RESENT AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETY SIX WHICH WOULD
DIRECT THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF.
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TO PREPARE A
CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ACTION PLAN.
OUR RECENT MOVE FROM THIS WORLD
SIX THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
NOTWITHSTANDING.
THERE IS AN ONGOING NEED AROUND
CALIFORNIA PROMOTE STRONG
ECONOMIC GROWTH. IN ALL REGIONS
OF CALIFORNIA THIS MEASURE WILL
SUPPORT DATA RICHARD AYE VOTE.
MISTER KILEY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AS
JOINT OFFICER AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL AYE I ENCOURAGE EVERYONE
SUPPORT FOR THE CREATION OF A
STATEWIDE. ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
STRATEGY FOR CALIFORNIA.
THIS WILL CREATE A BLUEPRINT FOR
UNLEASHING OUR STATES FOR
POTENTIAL IN A WAY THAT LIFTS UP
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THIS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
STRATEGIC ACTION PLAN IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP.
TOWARDS CLOSING THE YAWNING GAP
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA'S VAST
ECONOMIC POTENTIAL AND THE
CURRENT ECONOMIC REALITY.
WELL WE CELEBRATE HAVING THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD THAT DESIGNATION CONCEALS
MORE THAN IT REVEALS.
DESPITE OUR TREMENDOUS ECONOMIC
OUTPUT WITCHES CLUSTERED IN
PARTICULAR AREAS OF THE STATE
AND DESPITE ALL OF THE INHERENT
ADVANTAGES
CALIFORNIA ENJOYS WE ALSO HAVE
THE HIGHEST REAL POVERTY RATE IN
THE NATION. AND FACE SEVERE
CHALLENGES WITH HOMELESSNESS
INFRASTRUCTURE DEFICITS
AND AFFORDABILITY CALIFORNIA
ALSO REGULARLY RANKS WORST IN
THE NATION.
THE COST OF DOING BUSINESS AND
BUSINESS FRIENDLINESS WE MUST
WORK TO CHANGE THAT PERCEPTION.
AND THAT BEGINS WITH AN
INDEPENDENT ASSESSMENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S COMPETITIVENESS AND
A STATEWIDE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
PLAN TO ENSURE ECONOMIC SECURITY
AND INCLUSIVITY. IN ALL PARTS OF
THE STATE.
THIS DEBT BILL WILL DO THAT BY
IDENTIFYING CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC CHALLENGES
EXAMINING EXAMINING THE IMPACT
OF POLICIES AND REGULATIONS THAT
ARE HOLDING US BACK AND CREATING
A COMPREHENSIVE AGENDA FOR
INCLUSIVE STATEWIDE ECONOMIC
GROWTH. THAT MEANS ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL REGIONS OF
OUR VAST AND DIVERSE STATE NORTH
AND SOUTH RURAL AND URBAN
COASTAL AND INLAND I THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM RANCHO CORDOVA
OFFERS PARTNERSHIP. IN THIS
IMPORTANT INITIATIVE AND I ASK
FOR ANOTHER.
THANK YOU MISCARRY.
MS QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
AFTERNOON MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AS THE CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE I AM
PROUD TO RISE AS A JOINT AUTHOR
OF AB TWO FIVE NINE SIX.
FOR MANY OF US WE HAVE RESPONDED
TO BRANDING BRANDING OF UP MANY
WELL NOW NO ONE NAMES WHETHER IT
BE MCDONALD'S ARE NIKE BUT ONE
OF THE THINGS WE HAVE NOTICED
WITH CALIFORNIA ALTHOUGH WE ARE
THE GOLDEN STATE. WE HAVE NOT
SET UP PRIORITIES PRIORITIES
DO DETERMINE OUR STORY OUR OUR
NARRATIVE FOR CALIFORNIA AND AS
WE GO THROUGH THIS PROCESS IT
WILL NOT ONLY ALLOW WAS TO CHEER
OUR STATE ON BUT TO SHOW OUR
STRENGTH AS AN ECONOMIC. POWER
HOUSE NOW THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD SO I DO
STAND WITH A THE AUTHOR. AND
SUPPORT THIS AND HOPE YOU WILL
TOO THANK YOU.
AMOS QUIRK SILVA SEE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENT ON THE BILL.
MR COOL YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH EXCEPT MY COLLEAGUES
REMARKS FROM ORANGE COUNTY AND
GRANITE BASE MY CLOTHES.
CLICK LIBERAL. ON MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE.
WORK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
AYE SIXTY TWO NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES WERE PASSING
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM EIGHTY
SEVEN.
FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY EIGHT. BY MISTER HOLDEN.
SAYS AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE NINETY
NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN AND
ACTUALLY THE CHEMICAL CRIMINAL
RECORDS. CHRIS HOLDEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I'M PRESENTING
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE NINETY
NINE THAT WILL INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF INFORMATION AVAILABLE
ABOUT. CLEARING ARREST OR
CONVICTION RECORDS.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF PROPOSITION
FORTY SEVEN A NEW LAWS CREATED
BY THIS BODY THERE ARE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PERSON. TO
HAVE THE RECORD CLEAR.
IF THEY'RE CONVICTED MORE PEOPLE
THAN EVER HAVE THE CHANCE TO
SEEK EXPUNGEMENT. OF THE RECORD.
IF THEY ARE ARRESTED AND NOT
CONVICTED MANY DO NOT KNOW THE
IMPACT OF THAT ARREST ON THEIR
RECORD. OR THEY CAN BE SEALED
AND THERE IS A SHORT TWO YEAR
TIME LIMIT TO GET IT DONE.
THIS BILL WILL INCREASE
AWARENESS OF THE OPPORTUNITIES
BY ADDING INFORMATIONAL SIGNAGE
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND
DURING THE PROBATION PROCESS.
THIS BILL SIMPLY MAKE THE
INFORMATION AVAILABLE AT THE
POINT OF ARREST AND TELLS THEM
WHERE TO GO FOR THE NEXT STEPS.
NO ONE SHOULD BE DEFINED SOLELY
BY THEIR PAST BUT THEY SHOULD BE
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY THE CHANCE
TO CREATE A FUTURE. THAT THEY
AND THEIR FAMILIES CAN BE PROUD
OF.
THIS BILLHAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU MISS HOLDEN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE RAW. NUMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF VOTE ON
VOTERS OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
LOCAL CLOSE ROLL TIDE LOT I
FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM EIGHTY NINE IS
AB TWENTY SIX OF SIX COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX OF SIX
BY FAMILY MEMBER FONG AND
ACTUALLY THE HAZARDOUS WASTE.
MISTER FONG EMAIL BUT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY SIX OH SIX A BILL THAT
CREATES A STREAMLINED PROCESS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXICS AND
IT. IS TOXIC AND SUBSTANCES
CONTROL PROCESS NO PERMIT
APPLICATIONS FOR CERTAIN
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITIES WHEN
I THINK ASSEMBLYMAN BILL QUIRK
FIRST PARTNERSHIP ON THIS BILL
IS THE CHAIR OF THE TOXIC
SUBSTANCES COMMITTEE.
DID YOU SEE HAS BEEN FACING A
SEVERE BACKLOG TO BUT HAS BEEN
FACING SEVERE BAD LUCK THE
PROCESS REAL PERMITS IN THE
WORKING WITH THEM TO SEE HOW WE
CAN ADDRESS THIS ISSUE TOGETHER.
IN MY DISTRICT NAVAL WEAPONS
STATION CHINA LAKE OUR NATION'S
PREMIERE MILITARY DEVELOPMENT
TEST AND EVALUATION CENTER HAS
BEEN OPERATING WITH AN EXPIRING
PERMIT THE LAST SIX YEARS
DESPITE THE FACT. TO THE MISSION
OF CHINA LAKE HAS NOT CHANGED IS
MAINTAINED FOR COMPLAINTS OTHER
FACILITIES AFFECTED HER. OUR
EDWARDS AIRFORCE BASE TRAVIS
AIRFORCE BASE IN THE NAVAL BASES
IN SAN DIEGO AND CORONADO AMONG
OTHERS.
AB TWENTY SIX OH SIX CREATING
MORE EFFICIENT PERMITTING
PROCESS FIRST FACILITIES LIKE
CHINA LAKE HAVE NO MAJOR CHANGES
THAT OPERATIONS NO MAJOR
VIOLATIONS AND NO SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS RAISED IN THE PUBLIC
HEARING PROCESS.
THE BILL CREATES.
THE BILL CAPS OF FEES THAT CAN
BE CHARGED UNDER THE EXPEDITED
PROCESS BUT ALSO RETAINS THIS
QUESTION FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
ADJUST THOSE CAPS ABSENT
SUFFICIENT FUNDS FROM THE
APARTMENTS OPERATING ACCOUNT. TO
FUND ITS DUTIES.
THIS IS THE COMMON SENSE BILL TO
TO HELP OUR GOVERNMENT WORK
BETTER FOR FACILITIES ARE IN
FULL COMPLIANCE WITH STATE RULES
THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY UNITED
STATES NAVY AND RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ALL
COMMITTEES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR THE I AND I VOTE. THEY
RESPOND DUCKED QUIRK.
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX OH SIX AND THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD.
FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD AND WORKING WITH ME TO
STRENGTHEN THE BILL.
IT'S SUCH A GREAT BILL I'VE
AGREED TO BE PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR.
HE'S BROUGHT UP ALL THE MAJOR
POINTS I CAN TELL YOU THAT THIS
IS ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND.
AND THAT IT WILL STRENGTHEN OF
THE DEPARTMENT'S ABILITY BECAUSE
SOME OF THESE VERY GOOD ACTORS.
WILL NEED LESS WORK.
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO WORK MORE ON
THE LAST GOOD ACTORS THAT'S WHAT
WE WANT. THAT'S WHAT MAKES THIS
IS STRONG. PLEASE VOTE I.
THINK THAT QUIRK SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
FONG ME CLOSE WHO WISH I WON I
THINK MY COLLEAGUES OF MAYOR FOR
HIS COMMENTS AND FORGIVE ME ON
THIS IMPROVING THIS BILL HAS
PROGRESSED AND I'VE.
THANK YOU SIR WITH THAT CLERK
LIBERAL. VOTERS OUT OF VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE TELL VERY NICE
FORTY EIGHT NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE AT IN FILE ORDER FILE
ITEM NINETY AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN BY MISTER KALRA.
CLERK. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER
KALRA AND ACTUALLY THE MIGRATORY
BIRDS.
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ADOPTION PRESENT AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SEVEN TODAY FOR ONE
HUNDRED YEARS THE FEDERAL
MIGRATORY BIRD TREATY ACT HAS
BEEN THE PRIMARY PROTECT OF LAW
FOR BIRDS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
BUT RECENTLY THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED WE GO
AGAINST DECADES A PRECEDENT AND
NO LONGER APPLY THE LAW TO
INCIDENTAL TAKE A BIRDS.
THIS LEAVES HUNDREDS OF BIRD
SPECIES UNPROTECTED AT A TIME
WHEN MANY SPECIES CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE POPULATION DECLINES.
AND BASIC DIFFICULT FUTURE WITH
INCREASE HUMAN ACTIVITY CLIMATE
CHANGE AND DROUGHT.
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN
PROMOTES THE CONSERVATION
MIGRATORY BIRDS WHILE PROVIDING
GUIDANCE ON THE TO INDUSTRY ON
COMPLIANCE WITH LAWS PROTECTING
MIGRATORY BIRDS.
MY JERRY BROWN'S ARE ESSENTIAL
TO CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL HISTORY
BIODIVERSITY AND ECONOMY.
AS CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION GROWS
INDUSTRIES CONTINUE TO EXPAND
THE CLIMATE CHANGES AND RESOURCE
BECOME SCARCER.
RECENT ACTIONS BY THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION AND MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS HAVE BEEN AIMED AT
WEAKENING THE MBTA ALARMING
CONSERVATIONISTS AND CREATING
UNCERTAINTY. FOR REGULATED
INDUSTRIES.
UNFORTUNATELY LIVE IN A TIMELY
ACTIONS LIKE THESE BECOMING THE
NORM. WHERE STATES ARE HAVING TO
UNDERTAKE THEIR OWN ACTIONS TO
KEEP IN PLACE FEDERAL
PROTECTIONS WILDLIFE THEY'RE
UNDER THREAT BY THE CURRENT
FEDERAL MINISTRATION?
AS FEDERAL ROLL BACKS TO THE
MBTA OF CREATIVE BACK HUMAN
WILDLIFE PROTECTION CERTAINTY IS
NEEDED BOTH FOR CONSERVATION
EFFORTS AND INDUSTRY. TO ENSURE
THAT BIRDS AND OTHER NATURAL
RESOURCES ARE PROTECTED.
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN
PICTURES THIS PROBLEM BY
CREATING A VOLUNTARY PATHWAY FOR
COMPLIANCE THE EXISTING LAW FOR
ENTITIES WAS OTHERWISE LEGAL
ACTIVITIES RESULTANT BIRD DEATHS.
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN
DIRECT DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE TO IDENTIFY ALREADY
EXISTING BEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES.
THAT HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED
COLLABORATIVELY BETWEEN INDUSTRY
CONSERVATION GROUPS AND
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND PROVEN
TO REDUCE HARM TO BIRDS.
CONSERVATION IS THEN HAVE
GREATER ASSURANCES THAT BIRDS
ARE BEING PROTECTED AND ENTITIES
ARE INCENTIVIZE TO IMPLEMENT
BEST MANAGED PROP MANAGER
PRACTICES. AFTER YEARS OF
RELYING ON THE FEDERAL
APPLICATION MBTA THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MUST NOW CONSIDER HOW
WOULD FORCES OWN EXISTING LAWS.
THAT PROHIBIT THE KILLING OF NON
GAME MIGRATORY BIRDS.
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN AS A
WAY FOR CALIFORNIA TO PROTECT
BIRDS PROVIDE CERTAINTY FOR
INDUSTRIES ABOUT TIMING ECONOMIC
GROWTH AND AVOIDING THE
CONFLICTS AND LITIGATION THAT
SURROUND. THE MBTA TODAY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOOK.
DOCTOR WHAT.
YES HAVE I THINK MY THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AND I I WILL BE SUPPORTING IT
SAY ON THE FLOOR ARE WILL KNOW
THAT THERE STILL ARE SOME
CONCERNS BY SOME. SOME OF THE
INDUSTRY AND I HOPED THAT MOVING
FORWARD YOU COMMIT TO CONTINUE
TO WORKING WITH INDUSTRY ON ON
SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD.
KALRA MY CLOTHES YOU WISH.
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FOR
THOSE COMMENTS AND YES NOT BE.
BEEN WORKING WITH INDUSTRY THERE
BEEN NUMEROUS AMENDMENTS AND
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO BE
NUMEROUS AMENDMENTS AS WE WORK
TO TRY TO MITIGATE AYE ANY
NEGATIVE IMPACT INDUSTRY BUT
AGAIN THIS IS A. AYE AT TREATY
ACT THAT'S BEEN IN PLACE FOR A
CENTURY WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO PROTECT
MIGRATORY BIRDS.
LOCAL PAYROLL. NUMBERS VOTERS
ARAB VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
MISTER KALRA MOVES A CALL
.
MEMBERS ARE FILE ITEM NINETY ONE
AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY NINE BERMAN.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX THIRTY
NINE BY SOME REMEMBER BERMAN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE
HEALTH.
MISTER BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES EXISTING LAW REQUIRES
SCHOOLS TO ADOPT SUICIDE
PREVENTION POLICIES.
I ALONG WITH THE CHAIR OF THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE HAVE JOINT
AUTHORED AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
NINE WHICH WOULD BUILD UPON
EXISTING LAW BY OFFERING ONLINE
SUICIDE PREVENTION TRAINING. TO
ALL SCHOOL STAFF AND STUDENTS AT
SCHOOL SERVING GRADES SEVEN TO
TWELVE.
NUMEROUS POLICY DOCUMENTS ON
SUICIDE PREVENTION RECOMMEND
THAT TEACHERS AND OTHER SCHOOL
STAFF BE TRAINED ON THIS TOPIC
GENERALLY VIEWING SCHOOL STAFF
AS GATEKEEPERS. CAN PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN PREVENTING
SUICIDE.
THE GOAL OF AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
NINE IS TO BETTER EQUIP. AND
SUPPORTER SCHOOLS BY PROVIDING
ACCESS TO TRAINING IN A COST
EFFECTIVE AND CONVENIENT MANNER.
TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF OUR
STUDENTS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
DAVIS BERMAN SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK OPEN
RIGHT. MEMBERS.
IS THERE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
FORECLOSURE ALL TIE VOTE. AYE
SIXTY.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM NINETY TWO IS AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY ONE DOCTOR WOULD COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY SIX FORTY
ONE BY SOME REMEMBER WHAT AND AT
TWENTY CANNABIS DOCTOR WOULD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS IN NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN VOTERS APPROVE PROPS XDP
OR WHICH LEGALIZED THE
PURCHASING CONSUMPTION OF
CANNABIS BY ADULTS.
ALTHOUGH CURRENT LAW AUTHORIZES
THE SALE AND CONSUMPTION OF
CANNABIS AT COUNTY FAIRS OR
DISTRICT AGRICULTURAL ADVANCE
THEIR CURRENTLY ONLY RETAIL. OR
OR MICRO BUSINESS LICENSEES WERE
PERMITTED TO SELL DIRECTLY TO
CONSUMERS.
SMALL AND MEDIUM PRODUCERS FACE
MANY CHALLENGES IN THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO MAKE
THEIR TO MARKET THEIR OWN
PRODUCTS HAS PROVEN TO BE
BENEFICIAL IN BUILDING PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIPS WITH CONSUMERS. AS
WELL AS INCREASING CONSUMER
KNOWLEDGE WITH THE PRODUCTS ON
THE MARKET WHEN THEY DECIDE TO
VISIT TRADITIONAL RETAIL
SETTINGS.
HISTORICALLY PRODUCERS HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN CANADA SPECIAL
EVENTS SUCH AS THE EMPEROR
EMERALD CUP WHICH IS IN MY
DISTRICT.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY CONTINUE FOSTERING
REALLY THAT RELATIONSHIPS WITH
CONSUMERS AB TWENTY SIX FORTY
ONE WILL ALLOW THE BUREAU
CANNABIS CONTROL TO ISSUE. THE
STATE.
ISSUE THE STATE TEMPORARY
RETAILER LICENSE TO A SMALL
LICENSE CANNABIS CULTIVATORS.
EMPHASIS ON LICENSED
OR MANUFACTURE AT ATTEMPT AT A
LICENSE TEMPERATE CANNABIS EVENT
THAT HAS BEEN APPROVED BY A
LOCAL JURISDICTION.
CONTRARY TO THE OPPOSITION'S
CLAIMS WHICH COME FROM A LIMITED
GROUP WITHIN THE INDUSTRY THIS
BILL DOES NOT.
ALLOW A CULTIVATOR TO SET UP AN
EVENT EVERYDAY OF THE WEEK. THE
BILL CLEARLY STATES THERE'S A
CAP ON FOUR EVENTS PER YEAR FOR
EACH LICENSEE. I LISTEN TO THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS TOOK
AMENDMENTS AND APPROPRIATIONS TO
ADDRESS THEM.
THE BILL IS ONE MORE WAY WE CAN
FURTHER INCENTIVIZE OUR
PRODUCERS PARTICIPATION IN THE
REGULATED MARKET I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY DOT WOOD MISTER LACKEY. A
QUESTION THE AUTHOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION YOU KNOW WHAT
BUSINESSES WOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE SPECIAL
EVENTS.
DOCTOR WITH THE ONLY BUSINESSES
ELIGIBLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THESE
EVENTS WILL BE LICENSED STATE
CULTIVATORS AND LICENSE ANYBODY
WHO'S HAS A WHAT CURRENT LICENSE
WITH THE STATE.
THANK GOD WOULD.
MISTER JONES SAWYER A QUESTION
FOR THE AUTHOR. WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
ARM WILL GROWERS BE ALLOWED TO
SET UP SPECIAL EVENTS LIKE EVERY
DAY OF THE YEAR. AREN'T REALLY
KINDA UNDERCUT A DISPENSARIES IN
WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
DOCTOR WOULD KNOW.
AS I SAID THE LICENSE CATEGORY
WOULD ALLOW LIMIT A LICENSEE TO
FOR ADVANCE ANY YEAR THE REALITY
IS THAT THERE ARE VERY FEW THESE
EVENTS HEADACHES EVEN HAPPENED
STATEWIDE. A ONE IN MY DISTRICT
IS ONE IN SAN FRANCISCO ONE IN
OAKLAND I BELIEVE AND THERE'S
ONE IN SACRAMENTO SO.
NO THE ANSWER IS ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WHAT. DO WE
HAVE ANY MORE PLANET QUESTIONS.
SEEMS.
SAME NINE HEARING NONE.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THESE ARE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT
DOCTOR WOULD MOVES A CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM NINETY
THREE.
WE'RE GOING TO.
GO BACK.
IN THE FILE.
TAKE UP.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE.
VIOLATED NUMBER TWELVE.
AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX BY MR
CHOW CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE FORTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAU AND
ACTUALLY INTO COMMERCIAL EMAIL
ADVERTISEMENTS
MISSION CHALUMEAU OPEN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX
WAS STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S
PROHIBITIONS ON FALSE AND
DECEPTIVE SPAM EMAILS. IN A
NUMBER OF WAYS AS FOLLOWS. ONE
HOLDING SPAM NETWORKS AND THE
ACTUAL SANDERS LIABLE FOR FALSE
AND DECEPTIVE SPAMMING.
TO APPLY THE LAW TO FALSEHOODS
OR MISREPRESENTATIONS IN THE
BODY OF THE EMAIL NOT JUST THE
HEADERS. THREE ESTABLISHING THAT
TRUTHFUL CONTENT IN ONE PART OF
A SPAM EMAIL DOES NOT CURE
FALSITY IN ANOTHER PART.
FOUR PROHIBITING SPAMMING FROM
MULTIPLE DOMAIN NAMES.
FOR THE SOLE PURPOSE OF
BYPASSING SPAM FILTERS
FIVE PROHIBITING FROM NAMES THAT
MISREPRESENT WHO THE SPAM EMAILS
OF FROM.
SIX AUTHORIZING THE COURTS TO
IMPOSE INJUNCTIONS.
STOP UNLAWFUL SPAMMING AND
FINALLY SEVEN ALLOWING DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND CITY ATTORNEYS TO
BRING ACTIONS AGAINST UNLAWFUL
SPAMMERS. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU I'VE.
THEY'VE SHALL. I SAY NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
MR CHOW WUSA CALL.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY SIX
TO TAKE THAT ITEM UP THIS IS
FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX.
FOR WHICH WE PREVIOUSLY PASS
TEMPORARILY THIS IS MR MCCARTY.
IS MISTER MCCARTY IN THE ROOM
AREAS.
YES THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX
AB NINETEEN FORTY. CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FORTY BY
FAMILY MEMBER MCCARTY AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY PEARL THIS MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER PROUD
TO PRESENT AB NINETEEN FORTY
WHICH WILL HELP REDUCE
RECIDIVISM IN CALIFORNIA. BY
ALLOWING PAROLEES TO EARN A RE
INTEGRATION CREDITS TWO WORDS
ARE TERM UP FOR ALL.
SPECIFICALLY THE CREDITS OR GO
TO INDIVIDUALS WHO GO ABOVE AND
BEYOND THEIR PAROLE THE
REQUIREMENTS.
NOT JUST FOR SERVING GOOD TIME
BUT BY DOING THINGS LIKE
COMPLETING AN EDUCATIONAL DEGREE.
A COLLEGE COURSE OR CLASS
ATTAINMENT OR A THAT ATTENDING
IN FINISHING A SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT PROGRAM NOT MANDATED
BY THE COURTS.
WE KNOW THAT BY ENCOURAGING
PAROLEES TO TAKE ADDITIONAL
POSITIVE STEPS TOWARDS
REINTEGRATION WE WILL LOWER
RECIDIVISM PROMOTE EDUCATIONAL
AND JOB TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS TO MAKE. A
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION INTO OUR
SOCIETY AND MAKE CALIFORNIA A
SAFER I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT I
HAVE TAKEN RECENT AMENDMENTS AND
THAT CCPOA HAS REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION.
STILL WORKING WITH THE OTHER
GROUPS TO HAVE EXPRESSED SOME
CONCERNS AND HOW ARE WHO ARE
OUTLINING SOME SUGGESTION SO WE
WORKING WITH THEM. IN THE SENATE
SIDE OF IT PASSES TODAY WILL
KNOW THAT THIS MEASURE DOES HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THIS MORNING THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER MCCARTY DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THINK YOU SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE IS A CO AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL. AND WE HAVE TO GIVE
PEOPLE AN OPPORTUNITY TO RE
INTEGRATED INTO OUR SOCIETY AND
WE PARTLY WE DO THAT BY
INCENTIVIZING THINGS THAT
PROMOTE GOOD BEHAVIOR.
PEOPLE GETTING THERE BUT I'D
COLLEGE DEGREE PEOPLE GOING TO
KELSEY PEOPLE DOING ALL KINDS OF
THINGS A AND AGAIN THE STILL
JUST COMES UNDER DID THE
DISCRETION OF A JUDGE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TO HELP PEOPLE RE INTEGRATE
INTO OUR SOCIETY AND REDUCE
RECIDIVISM.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN THIS
MELENDEZ YOUR RECOMMENDS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN AS YOU PROBABLY
ALL WELL KNOW THOSE WHO ARE.
INCARCERATED ALREADY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET TIME TAKEN
OFF THEIR SENTENCE UP TO FIFTY
PERCENT THIS BILL SEEKS TO
REDUCE FURTHER THE TIME THAT
THEY'RE ON PAROLE I WILL REMIND
ALL OF YOU. THAT SINCE
REALIGNMENT THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO
WERE ACTUALLY ON SUPERVISED
PAROLE OR SOME OF THE WORST
OFFENDERS
EVERYONE ELSE IS ON POST RELEASE
COMMUNITY SUPERVISION WHICH IS
ME WHICH MEANS THAT THEY ARE
MONITORED. TO A CERTAIN EXTENT
BY COUNTY PROBATION IT IS NOT
THE SAME THING AS PAROLE.
SO.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS
ARE.
CAN INCLUDE HIGH RISK SEX
OFFENDERS.
AND THOSE WHO MOST RECENT HAD
MOST RECENT CONVICTION FOR
SERIOUS OR VIOLENT FELONY.
STATE THEY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO REDUCE THEIR SENTENCE WHILE
THEY'RE INCARCERATED THIS IS A
FURTHER OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO
REDUCE HOW MUCH TIME THEY'RE
UNDER SUPERVISION.
AGAIN PEOPLE WHO.
ARE.
THEY ARE ON PAROLE FOR A REASON.
THEY'RE NOT ON POST COMMUNITY.
I.
RELEASE.
FURTHER BEFORE YOU DECIDE TO
VOTE ON THIS BILL AND I KNOW
THERE. MEMBERS WHO ARE
DISTRACTED WITH A NUMBER OF
OTHER BILLS THAT COME UP BUT I
WOULD JUST LIKE YOU TO PAY
ATTENTION TO ME FOR ONE MINUTES.
AND BECAUSE I HAVE A FEW
EXAMPLES TO SHARE WITH THE OF
THE TYPE OF PERSON THAT YOU
WOULD BE ALLOWING TO BE TAKEN
OFF OF PAROLE OP ED SUPERVISE
PRO EARLY.
LOVELL MIXIN VIOLATED PAROLE
MULTIPLE TIMES AFTER BEING
RELEASED FROM JAIL HE EVENTUALLY
MURDERED FOR POLICE OFFICERS IN
OAKLAND IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE.
HE WAS ON PAROLE AFTER SERVING A
SENTENCE OF SIX YEARS IN JAIL
FOR ASSAULT WITH A DEADLY WEAPON
IN CONNECTION WITH AN ARMED
ROBBERY IN SAN. CISCO DOCTOR
EGGMAN STATE YOUR POINT OF ORDER.
BUT MY POINT ORDER IS IF STEP
THE THE AUTHOR OR THE.
MY COLLEAGUES SPEAKING TO THE
MERITS OF THIS BILL IS IN ONE OF
THE PEOPLE THAT SHE IS LISTING
ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE THAT THEN
GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE DURING
THEIR PAROLE. IF THEY'RE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE COMPLETED ENTIRE
PROGRAMS WELL UNDER PAROLE OR
THESE ARE JUST PEOPLE WHO WERE
ON PAROLE.
DOCTOR EGGMAN NOT KNOWING THE
SPECIFICS OF THE PARTICULAR
SITUATION.
MS MELENDEZ IS BRINGING UP.
I WAS GOING TO SAID THE POINT OF
ARE NOT WELL TAKEN I WOULD JUST
SUGGEST THAT MS MELENDEZ. A
REFRAIN FROM ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENT BEYOND THE FOCUS OF THE
BILL BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT.
THAT WOULD YOU ARE. POINTING TO
IS ILLUSTRATIVE OF THE ISSUES IN
THIS BILL. THAT WOULD BE MY HOPE
IF YOU ARE GOING TO PROCEED DOWN
THIS LINE.
MISS MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I MEAN
THAT IS MY INTENT IS NOT TO JUST
BRING FORWARD SOME
I'M A RANDOM EXAMPLES BUT TO
ILLUSTRATE THE TYPES OF PEOPLE
WHO WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS
TYPE OF RELEASED BUT I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS.
I'M.
WE HAVE ANOTHER.
PERSON.
FROM THOUSAND PALMS WHO WAS ON
PAROLE FIRST SO WITH A DEADLY
WEAPON ON MAY EIGHTEENTH HE
OPENED FIRE INTO A CAR WITH FIVE
CHILDREN AND IT. I'M VERY
TRAGICALLY.
A FOURTEEN YEAR OLD GIRL WAS
SHOT IN THE HEAD ANOTHER WHO IS
IN AND OUT OF PRISON SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT A MULTIPLE
CONVICTIONS LIKE UNLAWFUL
POSSESSION OF A FIREARM BURGLARY.
INFLICTING CORPORAL INJURY
EARLIER THIS YEAR HE VIOLATED
HIS PAROLE THEN LED POLICE
OFFICERS ON THE DANGERS CHASE
HEARINGS COUNTY HITTING SEVERAL
OTHER DRIVERS.
HE WAS CHARGED WITH AGGRAVATED
ASSAULT ASSAULT WITH A DEADLY
WEAPON OCCURS ON AND ON AND ON.
AND WE HAVE ANOTHER PERSON WHO
WAS ON PAROLE FOR SECOND DEGREE
MURDER IN GRAND THEFT AUTO WHILE
ON PAROLE HE MURDERED HIS COUSIN
AND THEN MURDERED WITH YOUR
POLICE OFFICER KEITH BOYER AND
SHOT THAT OFFICER PATRICK HITE
HAZEL. SO I BRING THIS TO YOUR
ATTENTION TO ILLUSTRATE AGAIN
THE TYPES OF PEOPLE THAT WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS TYPE OF.
REDUCTION OF SUPERVISED PAROLE.
THE.
I I THINK THERE'S PROBABLY NOT A
PERSON THE CHAMBERS WHO DOES NOT
BELIEVE AND THEY'VE REDEMPTIVE
QUALITY OF EVERY HUMAN BEING BUT
I THINK WE ALSO HAVE TO BE
CAUTIOUS.
ABOUT HOW WE WATER DOWN OUR
LIVES AND HOW WE WATER DOWN THE
ABILITY WITH WHICH WE CAN
MONITOR THOSE IN OUR COMMUNITY
WHO ALREADY HAVE A PROVEN TRACK
RECORD. OF WANTING TO DO HARM TO
OTHERS.
REMEMBER THIS IS PEARL THEY ARE
NO LONGER INCARCERATED THIS IS
NOT KEEPING THEM FROM BEING ABLE
TO GET A JOB OR INTEGRATE BACK
INTO THEIR FAMILIES IN THEIR
SOCIETY AND COMMUNITY.
BUT I THINK WE DO WANT TO BE
CAREFUL WITHOUT I WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR AYE BUT FOR YOUR YOU KNOW
ABOUT.
THANK YOU MS MELENDEZ DOCTOR
CHOI.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
I ALSO RISE SO IN OPPOSITION TO
OUR.
AB IN NINETEEN FORTY. I'VE BEEN
TRYING TO REFRAIN NOW. MY
COMMENTS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
REPORT THIS ONE I HAVE TO SPEAK
ON.
FOLLOWING THE FOOTSTEPS OF OUR
AB OUT ONE ON NINE A PROPOSITION
THE FORTY SEVEN AND THE
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN. THIS
ARE INTRODUCTION OFFER RE
INTEGRATION OF ACCREDITED.
INTO THE UPPER OR PROCESS.
FOR HIGH RISK GO OFFENDERS IS SO
YET ANOTHER. INSTALLMENT.
IN NOT CALIFORNIA SO SOFT ON
CRIME LEGISLATIVE APPROACH.
THE PURPOSE SAVA PRO WAR IS SO
TO PROVIDE THE IMPERIAL AT THOSE.
PEORIA DOT LOS SUPERVISION
DURING WHICH PROTEUS UP PROVE.
THAT THE ARE READY TO RE
INTEGRATE THEMSELVES.
S. A PRODUCTIVE ONE MEMBER OF A
SOCIETY.
THIS.
RE OUR INTEGRATION THE CREDITS.
WANT A CUP.
THIS PROCESS UP BY REDUCING UP
TO FIFTY PERCENT OF OUR.
THIS SUPERIOR DOLL FOR.
OF RE INTEGRATION.
WITHOUT THE HAVING PROVEN THAT
THE UPROAR LEE. HAS SO ABANDONED
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY OR BEEN RE
HEAVILY TAPED IT.
THE LAST THING OUT WE NEED THE
S. R. AND KNOW THE BILL.
LEADING CRIMINOLOGISTS IN NORTH
AFRICA
SACRAMENTO IS SO LOOKING OUT OF
FOR THE BEST INTEREST.
IF THE EXCLUSION OF ALL CRIME
VICTIMS RIGHTS.
I STRONGLY URGE AND THE RESPECT
REALLY YEAH ASCA MY COLLEAGUES
TO VOTE AGAINST OR A. B.
NINETEEN FORTY. THANK YOU.
THE SHARPER YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
FEEDBACK I'M GETTING FROM
CITIZENRY IN MY DISTRICT IS THAT
THEY'RE INCREASINGLY CONCERNED
ABOUT CRIME CRIME AGAINST
THEMSELVES CRIME AGAINST THEIR
HOMES CRIMES AGAINST THEIR
BUSINESSES.
CRIMES AGAINST THEIR PROPERTY.
NOW IS NOT THE TIME FOR US TO BE
GETTING SOFT ON CRIME NOW'S THE
TIME FOR US TO BE WORKING HARDER
IN TERMS OF OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
I STRONGLY URGE A VOTE AGAINST
THIS BILL.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED
ON THE ITEM MR MCCARTY MAKE
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IS ONE
TO CLARIFY A FEW THINGS FOR FOR
THE RECORD.
I WON THERE WAS AN EXIT THAT
AMENDMENT EARLIER IN THE PROCESS
THAT WE. I DO NOT INCLUDE SEX
OFFENDERS ON PAROLE.
AND NUMBER TWO THERE IS THAT
CLARIFICATION THAT THE PAROLE
OFFICERS CAN REVOKE THE
REINTEGRATION CREDITS OF A
PERSON RE OFFENSE.
NOW OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
STOCKTON NOTED.
THE EXAMPLES LISTED AS FAR AS
SOME PEOPLE ON PEARL WORK
INDIVIDUALS WHO WENT AND GOT. A
DEGREE AND A STOCK CERTIFICATE
FROM A COMMUNITY COLLEGES CT
<c.green> PROGRAM.</c>
VOLUNTARILY WENT THROUGH EVERY
HAVE.
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE OR
PARTICIPATED IN A RECOGNIZE
COMMUNITY SERVICE OPPORTUNITY
AND I GUESS THAT THAT THAT NEXUS
OF THIS AND WHATEVER FOCUSED ON
THIS IS PRO OFFICERS DO HAVE AN
IMPORTANT JOB TO SUPERVISE.
THOSE OUT THERE WHO PROPOSE A
RISK AND WE DO KNOW THAT SOME
PEOPLE ARE MODEL PAROLEES AND
THE IDEA HERE IS TO INCENTIVIZE
PEOPLE ON PAROLE. TO OUR TO DO
GOOD IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
TO NOTS.
RE OFFENSE
IT'S BECOME OUTSTANDING MEMBERS
OF OUR CALIFORNIA SOCIETY.
SO AGAIN WITH US TODAY IS A
BIPARTISAN MEASURE PROUD OF THE
WORK WE'VE BEEN DOING WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THOSE WHO
HAVE.
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS SOME
GOOD IDEAS I'VE BEEN PROPOSED TO
US THIS MORNING ON THE FLOOR NOW
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING.
IN THE SENATE AS WELL THANK YOU.
WITH THAT CLERK LIBERAL. MEMBERS.
IS THERE TO VOTE HOME NUMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
MISS TERROR MCCARTY MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN.
THIS IS AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY ONE
BY MR ARMOR SUIT.
OPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN SIXTY
ONE BY SOME A MEMBER MURATSUCHI
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
EMPLOYMENT.
MISTER MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER THAT MEMBERS AB
HOUSEKEEPER PROTECTION ACT.
WHICH SEEKS TO PROTECT HOTEL
HOUSEKEEPERS ANOTHER HOTEL
EMPLOYEES FROM SEXUAL ASSAULT
AND SEXUAL HARASSMENT. FROM
HOTEL GAS.
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE ME TO
MOVE MY LEASE TO SAFER
WORKPLACES FOR ALL WOMEN.
INCLUDING HOTEL HOUSEKEEPERS.
HOTEL HOUSEKEEPERS ARE AMONG.
THE MOST VULNERABLE TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND SEXUAL ASSAULT.
MANY ARE WORKING CLASS
IMMIGRANTS OFTEN WORKING ALONE
IN HOTEL ROOMS SOMETIMES OF MALE
GAS PLACING THEM AT HEIGHTENED
RISK OF SEXUAL ASSAULT OR
HARASSMENT.
A RECENT SURVEY OF CHICAGO AREA
HOSTS HOTEL HOUSEKEEPERS FOUND
THAT ALMOST HALF. OF ALL. HOTEL
HOUSEKEEPERS HAVE EXPERIENCED
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OR SEXUAL SO.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY ONE PROPOSES
SOME COMMON SENSE PROTECTIONS
FROM THESE WORKING WOMEN. ARE BY
PER PROVIDING AMONG OTHER THINGS
A PANIC BUTTON TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
SUMMON IMMEDIATE ASSISTANCE IN
THE CASE OF AN EMERGENCY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
MISS CARILLO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY THE PROUD
JOINT AUTHOR OF AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY ONE.
OUR TIRELESS HOTEL HOOK
HOUSEKEEPERS WHO ARE
PREDOMINANTLY MINORITY WOMEN.
LIVE WITH THE DANGER OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT EVERY DAY
THEY GO TO WORK.
ACCORDING TO A SURVEY OF CHICAGO
AREA HOUSE KEEPERS FIFTY EIGHT
PERCENT SAID THEY HAVE BEEN
SEXUALLY HARASSED BY A GUEST.
AND FORTY NINE PERCENT SAID THEY
HAVE BEEN THEY HAVE HAD A GUEST
ANSWER THE DOOR NUDE. AND EXPOSE
THEMSELVES OR FLASH THEM IN
RESPONSE TO A CARGO AND SEVERAL
OTHER LARGE CITIES ACROSS THE U.
S. HAVE ADOPTED. LOCAL ORDINANCE
TO EQUIP HOTEL WORKERS WITH
PANIC BUTTONS.
CALIFORNIA'S THE STATE MUST LEAD
THE WAY IN WORKER PROTECTIONS
AND OUR HOTEL HOUSEKEEPER SHOULD
BE ABLE TO GO TO WORK WITHOUT
FEAR OF HARASSMENT. OR ASSAULT.
I THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
TORRANCE FOR OFFERING THIS BILL
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTES.
DOCTOR WOULD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AND I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING
THIS BILL FORWARD AFTER MEETING
WITH SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
AND HEARING THEIR STORIES I
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT EMPLOYEES
SHOULD HAVE A PANIC BUTTON.
BUT I DO THINK THAT THE
OPPOSITION HAS A VALID POINT
WITH REGARDS TO A STATEWIDE
STANDARD RATHER THAN A PIECEMEAL
JURISDICTION BY JURISDICTION
APPROACH.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY BUT I HOPE BEFORE THIS
BILL COMES BACK AT THE END OF
SESSION.
WE ARE PROVIDED WITH SOME
CERTAINTY ABOUT WHAT PROCEDURES
AND PROTOCOLS FOR USING THIS
TECHNOLOGY IN COMMUNITIES WILL
BE.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
AND I THERE'S A PROUD.
CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL AND I AND
I APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LOS ANGELES IN THE STATISTICS
THERE'S EVEN MORE TO THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY THE INDUSTRY
ITSELF HASN'T DONE THE STUDIES
AMONG THEIR HOUSEKEEPERS TO FIND
OUT HOW VULNERABLE THEY ARE.
BUT THERE HAVE BEEN STUDIES DONE
AND WHAT THEY FOUND IS TEN
PERCENT OF ALL HOUSEKEEPERS
HOTEL HOUSEKEEPERS HAVE BEEN
ASSAULTED THEY'VE BEEN TOUCHED
ON WANTONLY.
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT HAVE BEEN
ACCOSTED IN ASK FOR SEXUAL
FAVORS.
IT'S CLEAR THAT THESE WORKERS IN
A VULNERABLE POSITION THAT HAS
BEEN LEFT UNADDRESSED FOR FAR
TOO LONG THIS IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE.
NAME IS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM MISTER AMER
SU CHI.
YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH PASSED
VERY AYE VOTE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO GO
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
MR ARE MURATSUCHI.
THE CALL MISTER MURATSUCHI WAS A
CALL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION MEMBERS ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM.
THIRTY THREE.
THIS IS A B. THIRTY ONE THIRTY
ONE BY MISTER GLORIA.
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE THIRTY
ONE BY SOME THE MEMBER GLORIA
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
MILITARY EQUIPMENT.
MISTER GLORIA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I RISE
TODAY TO ASK MY COLLEAGUES
SUPPORT ON A BILL.
THIS IMPORTANT FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
RECOGNIZING THE HEIGHTENED
TENSION BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND THE COMMUNITIES
THEY SERVE. THEN PRESIDENT OBAMA
O. CONVENED A FEDERAL
INTERAGENCY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
WORKING GROUP.
UNDER EXECUTIVE ORDER NUMBER
THIRTEEN SIX EIGHTY EIGHT IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN.
EXECUTIVE ORDER EMPHASIZE THE
NEED TO BETTER COORDINATE
FEDERAL SUPPORT FOR THE
ACQUISITION OF CERTAIN FEDERAL
EQUIPMENT BY STATE LOCAL AND
TRIBAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
AMONG OTHER ISSUES THE WORKING
GROUP DEVELOPED A LIST OF ITEMS
THAT THEY DETERMINED AFTER
CAREFUL CONSIDERATION.
SHOULD BE SUBJECTED TO CERTAIN
CONTROLS PRIOR TO THEIR TRANSFER
TO OTHER AL ON FORSMAN EACH.
SADLY LAST SUMMER THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION RESCINDED THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER ALONG WITH MANY
OF THE OTHER POLICIES AND
PROTOCOLS GOVERN APPROPRIATE
CONSTITUTIONALLY SOUND USES OF
CONTROLLED MILITARY EQUIPMENT.
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE
REQUIRES THAT ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
OBTAIN APPROVAL FOR THEM FROM
THEIR GOVERNING BODIES PRIOR TO
THE ACQUISITION OF MILITARY
EQUIPMENT.
EARLIER THIS WEEK I TOOK
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY MEMBERS AND
COMMITTEE ABOUT VAGUENESS OF
CERTAIN TERMS AS WELL AS THE
APPLICABILITY OF MUTUAL AID
SITUATIONS.
BY REQUIRING UP A PUBLIC FORUM
TO ALLOW COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THESE DISCUSSIONS.
THIS BILL WILL IMPROVE
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN POLICE AND
THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE WHEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS SEEN AS A
PUBLIC SERVICE RATHER THAN
OCCUPYING FORCE I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA MISTER
LACKEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YEAH I'VE SPOKEN TO THIS BEFORE
I I TAKE IT AS AN AFFRONT.
WHEN.
BOND PORTION IS CHARACTERIZED
AS THE ENEMY.
WE'RE HERE. TO DO WHAT I SAY WE
ARE NO LONGER MEMBER BUT.
I'M RETIRED MEMBERS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
BUT I HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT WE.
OUR GROUP OF PEOPLE THEY'RE
WILLING TO DIE FOR THEIR
COMMUNITY.
AND.
.
TO CHARACTERIZE THIS AS AN
OCCUPYING FORCE IS OFFENSIVE AND
I HOPE YOU VOTED DOWN JUST FOR
THAT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
NOW MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTY ONE.
ANY OF YOU HAVE SERVED ON THE
SCHOOL BOARD BEFORE KNOW THAT
THESE THINGS HAPPEN IN YOUR
COMMUNITY THAT HAPPENED IN SAN
DIEGO.
WE DISCOVERED THERE WAS AN AWFUL
LOT OF EQUIPMENT BROUGHT INTO
THE SAN DIEGO CITY WAS PLACED IN
SOME SCHOOLS SOME TANKS AND A
HOST OF OTHER THINGS.
AND THE PEOPLE ARE MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THEY KNOW ABOUT IT.
A MUCH I DIDN'T HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE INPUT INTO
WHAT THE PARENTS AND AS A RESULT.
HIT DOES A LOT OF BLOWBACK TO
IT WITHOUT ACTUALLY KNOWING WHAT
WAS GOING ON IN DISCOVERING IT
WAS IT WAS ALMOST LIKE IT WAS AN
UNDERCOVER ACTIVITY THAT
OCCURRED. NOT AS A FALL TO THE
PLEASE ANYBODY ELSE WHAT THE
SCHOOL BOARD SHOULD HAVE
NOTIFIED INDIVIDUALS IF THEY
WERE EVEN CONSIDERING DOING THIS.
AND ALL AND SO I I SUPPORT THIS
BECAUSE IT GIVES AT LEAST BUT I
DO THAT THERE HAS TO BE POLICY.
THERE HAS TO BE SOME
COMMUNICATION WITH BOTH PARENTS
AND WHOSE CHILDREN IN THOSE
SCHOOLS SO THEY KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT THEY'RE ASKING FOR WHAT
THEY'RE GETTING IN RETURN. AND I
THINK IS JUST SO AS MOST OF YOU
TALK ABOUT TRANSPARENCY AND YOU
WANT FOLKS BUILDING IN YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD WHO DON'T KNOW WHO
YOU ARE. I DON'T THINK PEOPLE
ALSO WANT. OF FOLKS BRING IN
MILITARY EQUIPMENT WITHOUT
PARENTS KNOWING THAT IT'S AT
THEIR SCHOOL THAT THE COMMUNITY
KNOWS THIS THERE AND THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT FAIRNESS AND
OPENNESS WITH REGARDS TO. THE
PARENTS AND THE PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY SO I SUPPORT A. B.
THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE I THINK
IT'S A REASONABLE POSITION TO BE
TAKEN IN ITS NOT POSED IN. THE
HAVING IT'S REALLY TALKS ABOUT
THE PROCESS STAR I HOPE THAT YOU
WILL BOTH AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY
ONE SPECIALLY THOSE WHO BELIEVE
IN LOCAL CONTROL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER EMIGRATE
TO RESPECT MY COLLECTING SAN
DIEGO INFORMING THE BILL FORWARD
THINKER SOME ISSUES WITH THE
PROPONENTS DIDN'T TALK ABOUT.
THE BILL STATES ANY PERSON MAIN
FORCES MEASURE AGREE A CIVIL
ACTION AGAINST ANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
ACCORDING THE BILL ANYONE TO
BRING A LAWSUIT AGAINST THE
COUNTY OR CITY.
IF THEY FILL MILITARY TYPE%
EQUIPMENT WAS NOT NEEDED BECAUSE
THERE IS A VIABLE ALTERNATIVE.
OR IF THERE WAS OTHER COST
EFFECTIVE OPTIONS.
WITH THE EQUIPMENT WAS USED TO
CRITICAL INCIDENTS
AGREEMENT FOR A MYRIAD OF
SUBJECTIVE MATTERS INCLUDING
POLITICAL VIEWPOINTS.
WITHOUT PROTEST THE BAY AREA AND
MUTUALLY WHICH REQUESTED SO.
SO WE CAN HAVE MUTUALLY AND USE
SOME TYPE OF EQUIPMENT BELT OPEN
THAT JURISDICTION THAT'S IN YOUR
COUNTY. UP TO LAWSUIT.
THE BILL GETS TEETH TO FRIVOLOUS
LAWSUITS AGAINST CITIES AND
COUNTIES.
FOR EXAMPLE.
SO YOU CAN COUNTY WILL BE A RISK
OF SO LAWSUIT SIMPLY BECAUSE
THIS OPEN RIGHT HERE.
RETAIN A VIOLENT PROTEST
WE DO USE WHY GIVEN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
ALSO PERSONS COMMITTEE CLAIMS
THAT THERE WAS MORE COST
EFFECTIVE RESPONSES TREE
CRITICAL INCIDENT.
MOST LOVED ONE PERSON SEES CAN
HAVE LONG GUNS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THEY GOT.
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THAT?
BULLET PROOF VEST HELMETS LA
EQUIPMENT WITH THE LOWEST
SHOOTING INCIDENTS WE HAVE
RESCUE VEHICLES ARMORED CARS
THAT COME UP.
EVACUATE SOME THE SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS
SO THEY'RE A GOOD EFFECTIVE
TOOLS.
AND.
APART A POEM ALSO THE SHERIFF
SHERIFF IS A CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICER
SO WHY THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
TO ASSURE IF WE CAN OR CANNOT
GET.
SURE IF IS ALL TO BE RESPONSIBLE
TO THE CITIZENS OF HIS COUNTY.
SO I I THINK IS GOOD INTENTIONS
HERE BUT.
BUT I MEAN YEAH THERE ARE BAD
ACTORS THE SWISS COMMUNITY
ABSOLUTELY NOT. BUT FOR THE MOST
PART MOST OF US COULDN'T IS USE.
FOR GOOD EFFORTS.
IT'S LIKE IN SECOND ROW COUNTY
LAW DEPARTMENTS OFFICERS BY
THEIR OWN WEAPONS
BECAUSE YOU GET A BETTER WEAPON
DEPARTMENT TO FOR TO GIVE YOU.
THINK ABOUT OF SOMEONE'S BRING
LONG GUNS ALL THE CARS WAS ABOUT
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS A PIECE
WITH OPTICS.
THAT WE CAN THAT THE GENERAL
FUND THAT'S WELL DEPARTMENTS
RELY UPON SURPLUS MILITARY ITEMS
SO. I THINK THIS COMMONSENSE
WITH THIS IN MY AUTHOR I THINK
ITS GOOD INTENTIONS.
PROPONENTS WE DIDN'T.
BIG THAT DEEP IN THE BILL WE
HAVE THIS ISSUE BEFORE AND
ULTIMATELY FOR SCHOOL SHOOTING
HAPPENS.
OR YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD YOU'RE
TRAPPED IN YOUR HOUSE IT'S
ALWAYS COME RESCUE GOODYEAR
ARMOR TYPE VEHICLE.
THERE I CAN GET IT LOT CHEAPER
GIVEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN
THE PIT OF QUARTER OF A MILLION
DOLLARS OR MORE.
FOR THAT VEHICLE AT YOUR GENERAL
FUND.
SO IT'S JUST UP THE THINK ABOUT
THERE'S A LOT OF MOVING PARTS TO
IT IS NOT THAT SIMPLE SO.
ARE STRICTLY URGE YOUR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU A SUMMER DAVID CHIU
YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND I WANT
TO BUILD ON THE COMMENTS THAT WE
JUST HEARD. THERE'S NOTHING IN
THIS BILL THAT PREVENTS ANY
LOCAL JURISDICTION FROM
RECEIVING THE EQUIPMENT THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE ALL WANT
TO HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
EQUIPMENT IF THERE IS A SCHOOL
SHOOTING THE TYPE OF ARMORED
VEHICLES A TYPE OF WEAPONS THAT
WE MIGHT NEED. ALL THIS BILL
SAYS
IS THAT IF YOU WANT TO RECEIVE
THIS INFORMATION TO THIS THIS SO
EQUIPMENT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT YOU NEED TO GO
THROUGH A PUBLIC PROCESS YOU
NEED TO HAVE A PUBLIC HEARING.
THERE NEEDS TO BE JUST A LITTLE
BIT OF TRANSPARENCY THE REASON
FOR THIS IS WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO BUILD TRUST BETWEEN THE
PUBLIC. AND OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND THERE NEEDS TO BE
SOME OVERSIGHT ON WHY AND WHEN
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
MIGHT NEED TO ACQUIRE MILITARY
GRADE WEAPONS.
OUR CITIZENS ARE NOT ENEMY
COMBATANTS ARE POLICE ARE NOT
MILITARY GENERALS WE NEED THIS
TRANSPARENCY AND BECAUSE THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION REPEAL
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL. THIS
IS WHY THIS BILL IS NECESSARY AT
THIS TIME.
I THINK AND I THINK WE ALL
WOULD AGREE THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
NEEDS TO BE A PARTNER IN PUBLIC
SAFETY AND THE WEAPONS THAT THEY
CARRY SHOULD REFLECT THAT
REALITY. THIS BILL WILL HELP
CREATE THAT TRANSPARENCY PROVIDE
FOR THAT MEANINGFUL PUBLIC INPUT
AND I'M PROUD TO BE A JOINT
AUTHORED THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SOME EVER MATHIS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN OPPOSITION AND.
I'M QUITE FRANKLY I'M SICK OF
HEARING ABOUT. HOW WE NEED TO?
TAKE AWAY TOOLS FROM OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AYE WE NEED TO MAKE
IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR THEM.
YOU KNOW THIS ISN'T ABOUT.
LAW ENFORCEMENT INNER CITIZENS
THIS IS ABOUT LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND CRIMINAL ELEMENTS.
WHEN WE'RE DEALING WITH THINGS
LIKE CARTELS WHEN WE'RE DEALING
WITH HUMAN TRAFFICKING WHEN
WE'RE DEALING WITH.
GANGS WERE DEALING WITH THINGS
LIKE SCHOOL SHOOTINGS.
AND AS SO MY COLLEAGUES STATED
EARLIER. YOU KNOW THIS IS ABOUT
PROVIDING TOOLS FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO KEEP OUR CITIZENS
SAY.
YOU CAN.
DO A HEY LET'S HAVE A TOWN HALL
TIME NOW THERE'S SOMETHING GOING
ON AND MAKE SURE WE CAN GET THE
EQUIPMENT NEEDED. THE EQUIPMENTS
NEEDED.
IN AN EMERGENCY.
AND WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAVE THESE TOOLS
WE NEED TO STOP MAKING OUR
PUBLIC.
FEAR OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT IN FEAR
THAT THE TOOLS THAT THEY HAVE TO
USE.
BELIEVE ME I'M I'M PRETTY SURE A
LOT OF THEM WOULD PREFER NOT TO
HAVE TO USE THESE TOLD THEM.
PRETTY SURE THAT OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT WOULD RATHER WORK
WITH OUR SCHOOL CHILDREN AND
OTHERS TO RELIEVE THAT FEAR.
WE HAD HERE WE ARE AGAIN AS A
BODY.
TRYING TO DRAW DIVIDE BETWEEN
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT OUR
COMMUNITIES WHEN WE NEED TO BE
WORKING MORE TOGETHER. TO LESSEN
THAT DIVIDE TO PROVIDE SECURITY
TO OUR CITIZENS.
YOU KNOW QUITE FRANKLY YOUR FOR
MYSELF IS SO MANY THERE'S
ACTUALLY SEEING COMBAT FIRST
HAND.
AND OF COURSE THE BODY CONTINUES
TO TAKIN IN MOBILE OVER EACH
OTHER.
BECAUSE TO HAVE THE MEMBERS
HERE DON'T EVEN REALLY CARE
ABOUT WITH ACTUALLY GOING ON.
SO.
MEMBERS I I URGE YOU KNOW VOTE
ON THIS I URGE THAT WE ACTUALLY.
GIVE OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT THE
TOOLS NECESSARY. AND FOR THOSE
OF YOU ARE HAVING OTHER
CONVERSATIONS OBVIOUSLY DON'T
CARE. ABOUT OUR CITIZENS ARE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO.
ANYWAY ASK FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU PLEASE GIVE YOUR FULL
ATTENTION TO A SOME MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM.
MADAM SPEAKER.
I JUST ASK YOU TO CONSIDER THE
FOLLOWING FACT BEFORE WE VOTE TO
ADD ANOTHER LAYER OF BUREAUCRACY.
TO THE ACQUISITION OF.
THINGS THAT OUR SHARES AND OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT NEED TO
EFFECTIVELY KEEP PEOPLE OUR
COMMUNITY.
SAFE AND I THINK THAT'S.
MAKE NO MISTAKE I THINK THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO IT WOULD
IMPACT TAKE THE DECISION MAKING
OUT OF THE HANDS.
OF OUR SHARES.
AND PUT IT IN THE HANDS OF
ANOTHER BODY.
WE RECENTLY HAD MUDSLIDES IN
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY WE RECENTLY
HAD TERRIBLE FIRES IN SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY.
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT RESCUED
PEOPLE USING HELICOPTERS IF YOU
LOOK AT THE DEFINITION OF
MILITARY GRADE EQUIPMENT THIS
BILL IT INCLUDES AIRPLANES AND
HELICOPTERS.
INCLUDES THOSE THINGS THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OUR SHARES USED TO
GO SAVE PEOPLE THAT WERE TRAPPED
IN A MUD SLIDE FIRE SITUATION.
PLEASE ON BEHALF OF ALL OF ALL
OF US THAT REPRESENT RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
THERE MAY BE ISOLATED LITTLE BIT
MORE THAT SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE.
PLEASE.
DON'T VOTE FOR THIS BILL BECAUSE.
IT WILL MAKE OUR CITIZENS LESS
SAFE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
ARE YOU ARE YOU.
NOT.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES SO I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE. I
I'D LIKE TO SIMPLY JUST.
CLARIFY.
.
REGARDING A FEW STATEMENTS THAT
I'VE HEARD I BELIEVE DISTORT
WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT ONE.
THERE'S NOTHING IN THIS BILL
THAT SAYS THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
CANNOT SECURE ON THE TYPE OF
EQUIPMENT THEY NEED TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE THAT STATEMENT
WAS MADE. AND IT DOES NOT DO
THAT IT SIMPLY SAYS THAT THE
GOVERNING BODY. OF MUSS
I BE INVOLVED IN THE DECISION
MAKING WHICH MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE BECAUSE IF COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. HAVE A QUESTION OR
CONCERN ABOUT WHY.
TANK OR SOME OTHER TYPE OF
EQUIPMENT WAS PURCHASE.
THEY'RE GONNA GO DIRECTLY TO THE
ELECTED GOVERNING BODY TO
EXPRESS THEIR CONCERNS. AND SO
THERE SHOULD BE THAT LEVEL OF
CONSULTATION.
SECONDLY THE STATEMENT WAS MADE.
THAT VOTING FOR THIS BILL MEANS
YOU'RE AGAINST LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND THAT IS AN UTTER MISS
CHARACTERIZATION OF WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS WE
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND WHAT THEY DO TO
HELP KEEP OUR COMMUNITY SAFE IN
TO BE OUR PARTNERS IN THE
COMMUNITY. OF THIS SIMPLY SAYS
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE OF THE
GOVERNING BODY HAS TO BE
INVOLVED IN THIS DECISION MAKE
DECISIONS MADE. TO ACQUIRE
CERTAIN TYPES OF EQUIPMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MELINDA'S YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
I JUST WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE
THAT.
EVERY CONTRACT SITTING
CALIFORNIA HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WEIGH IN ON THE PURCHASE OF
THIS TYPE OF EQUIPMENT I KNOW
MANY OF YOU WHO WERE ON CITY
COUNCIL. RECALLED THE WARRANT
LAST THAT YOU WOULD GET TO TO
COUNCIL MEETINGS THAT LIST ALL
OF THE THINGS THAT CHECKS WERE
ISSUED FOR. AND WHAT YOU'RE CITY
SPENT MONEY ON AND YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO QUESTION THAT.
AND MOST POLICE CHIEFS ARE
SMART ENOUGH OF THE GONNA MAKE A
BIG PURCHASE PARTICULARLY
SOMETHING LIKE I WANT TO KNOW
SAY HELICOPTER. A BIT THEY'RE
GOING TO RUN THAT PASTOR CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS ARE THE CITY
MANAGER SAID THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY AT LEAST WITH
CONTRACT CITIES WERE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS FOR COUNCIL MEMBERS
TO SAY NO WE DON'T FIND THAT
THAT'S AN APPROPRIATE USE. OF
CITY TAX DOLLARS OR WE DO I AM
IN ADDITION NOT ONLY DOES THE
CITY COUNCIL GET TO WEIGH IN ON
THAT BUT ALSO THE CITIZENS.
BECAUSE CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS ARE
CITY COUNCIL MEETINGS.
SO I'M LIKE WHAT WE.
ENGAGING APPEAR YOUR YOUR
RESIDENTS COME FORWARD IN THE
LIGHT YOU KNOW IN NO UNCERTAIN
TERMS EXACTLY HOW THEY FEEL.
ABOUT CERTAIN THINGS THAT YOU'RE
VOTING ON SO I JUST WANTED TO
POINT THAT OUT FOR ONE THAT THIS
IS NOT AN UNCHECKED SYSTEM I'M
AS SOME MIGHT THINK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KAMLAGER-DOVE YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER YOU KNOW
I WAS ACTUALLY ORIGINALLY GOING
TO LAY OFF THIS BILL BUT AFTER
READING AND TALKING TO THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS IT IS A
GOOD BILL.
IT IS A VERY GOOD BILL IT DOES
NOT ADD AN EXTRA LAYER OF
BUREAUCRACY.
IT ADDS A LAYER OF COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT.
AND PART OF COMMUNITY SAFETY
SHOULD INCLUDE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT
WE HAVE HAD A COUPLE OF YEARS.
OF WATCHING.
WHAT IT'S LIKE WHEN COMMUNITIES
ARE IN? RELATIONSHIPS
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THIS OPENS THE DOOR.
FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES IN OTHER
COMMUNITIES TO BEGIN TO.
HAVE A RELATIONSHIP AND ENGAGE
IN THE KIND OF A PARTNERSHIP YOU
WOULD WANT TO HAVE WITH YOUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
I REPRESENT THE CITY OF CULVER
CITY AND WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH
AN ISSUE AROUND THE PURCHASE OF
DRONES AND THAT LITTLE CITY
WANTS TO KNOW WHAT ITS POLICE
DEPARTMENT IS DOING SO IT CAN BE
HELPFUL. IN WORKING WITH ITS LAW
ENFORCEMENT DESERVED DIVISION TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT CITY AND ITS
COMMUNITY RESIDENTS ARE SAFE SO
I WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT AB
THREE THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE AND
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAY AS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
DECEMBER SECOND.
CITY OF SAMBA DINO SUFFERED A
TERRORIST ATTACK.
BUT BECAUSE THE OUR SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT OF POLICE DEPARTMENT
HAD THE NECESSARY TOOLS THEY
WERE ABLE TO ADDRESS AND PROTECT
THOSE WHO'D BEEN INVOLVED IN
THIS TERRORIST ATTACK.
THE BILL CLEARLY DOES NOT TAKE
THE RIGHT AWAY FROM MY CD IN MY
COUNTY FROM GETTING THESE TYPES
OF OF.
SURPLUS ITEMS.
SIMPLY SAYS THAT THE COMMUNITY
HAS A RIGHT TO KNOW ABOUT THIS
REPORTS ACTUALLY DONE.
THE OUR OUR OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM
MY COLLEAGUE FROM VICTORVILLE.
THERE A VERY IMPORTANT PART OF
OUR COMMUNITY THEY ARE THERE TO
SERVE AND PROTECT I WANT TO BE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE. EVERYTHING
THEY NEED TO SERVE AND PROTECT.
BUT WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS JUST
PROVIDES AN EXTRA.
AND NEXT TO SAID A VOTE OF I USE
IT BUT PROVIDES A TRANSPARENCY
THAT EVERY COMMUNITY WANTS AND
DESERVES.
FOR THAT REASON I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER OF THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER NOT. I TOO AM IN FULL
SUPPORT. OF THIS BILL AND AND
REALLY IT IS. ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL.
AND IT'S A BAO.
GOVERNING BODIES HAVING ABILITY
AND DISSIDENTS THE RING TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THEIR CONTROL OVER
WHAT GOES ON IN THE COMMUNITY.
MANY OF YOU IN THIS IN THIS ON
THIS FLOOR WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT
CANNABIS AND OTHER THINGS YOU
WANTED LOCAL CONTROL TO YOU
COULD DECIDE WHAT TO DO AND HOW
MUCH IT CAN BE REGULATED.
YOU YOU ENJOYED MAKING SURE THAT
YOUR LOCAL ENTITIES HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN ON WHAT
TO DO.
REALLY THIS IS WHAT THIS BILL IS
REALLY ABOUT.
I KNOW YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT WE SUPPORT LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE DON'T. WE SUPPORT
LAW ENFORCEMENT LET'S NOT.
LET'S NOT KID OURSELVES EVERYONE
IN THIS BODY DOES SUPPORT BUT WE
ALSO TRULY TRULY.
SUPPORT THE ABILITY ESPECIALLY
ONES THAT HAVE BEEN ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
YOU KNOW YOU WANTED TO KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON IN YOUR
COMMUNITY AND ESPECIALLY. WHEN
IT COMES TO LAW ENFORCEMENT BOTH
ON THE LAW ENFORCEMENT SIDE IN
THE CRIMINAL SIDE YOU WANT TO
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON AND HOW
IT'S BEING ADDRESSED.
AND SO THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS
BILL IS ALL ABOUT IS HAVING THE
ABILITY TO HAVE LOCAL CONTROL TO
MAKE DECISIONS ON WHAT YOU THINK.
BEST FOR YOUR COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU.
ALL DEBATE DISCUSSION HAVE INC
CEASED MISTER GLORIA WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE JUST VERY BRIEFLY
MADAM SPEAKER I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THE RECORD IS CLEAR AND I
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST DEBATE
THAT WE HAD THIS AFTERNOON. IT
SHOULD THAT SHOULD BE HAPPENING
WHATEVER WE TALK ABOUT THE
SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITIES WHICH
IS EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IT CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE PROCUREMENT
OF MILITARY GRADE EQUIPMENT. BY
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND WITH
THE GUARDS MIGHT MY GREAT
COLLEAGUE FROM ELK GROVE WHO I
DO HAVE A GREAT DEAL OF RESPECT
FOR WHOSE WALK IN THE SHOES OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT. I HEAR WHAT
HE'S SAYING BUT I WANT TO THE
RECORD IS REFLECTIVE OF THE FACT
THAT THIS BILL IS NOT INTENDED
TO OPEN THE FLOODGATES OF
LITIGATION NOR WILL IT. A BY
DOUG FOLLOWING THE PROCEDURES IN
THIS BILL LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
WILL BE ABLE TO DETERMINE THE
POLICIES THEY WISH TO FOLLOW
WHICH I THINK AS THEY'D ADOPT
THEM THE BILL TO FOLLOW THEIR
OWN SETS OF POLICIES. PRETTY
PRETTY SUCCESSFULLY I'M MEMBERS
UNDERSTAND THIS MAY BE A
DIFFICULT VOTE FOR SOME OF YOU.
BUT I WANNA MAKE SURE VERY
CLEAR ALSO THIS BILL DOES NOT
PROHIBIT THE PROCUREMENT OF ANY
ITEM BY LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
SIMPLY CREATES THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR LOCAL CITY COUNCILS AND
BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY'RE
DEPARTMENTS ARE PROCURING. AS A
FORMER CITY COUNCIL MEMBER I
SPENT ENDLESS HOURS DISCUSSING
HOW WE WOULD EVER REPLACE THE
FORD CROWN VICTORIA IT WOULD IT
BE A FORD EXPLORER OR DODGE
CHARGER. WE HAD NEVER HAD A
NEARLY THE SAME AMOUNT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE PROCUREMENT
OF LICENSE PLATE READERS.
OF STINGRAY SURVEILLANCE
EQUIPMENT THE LIST GOES ON AND
ON I THINK OUR COMMUNITIES
DESERVE THIS INFORMATION I
BELIEVE THAT WHEN YOU'RE GIVING
THAT INFORMATION THEY WILL AS
THEY ALWAYS DO SUPPORT LAW
ENFORCEMENT. BUT WILL BE AFTER
TO BUILD UP A BUS A ROBUST
DISCUSSION THAT IS NOT HOW BEING
HAD IN EVERY CITY HALL AND EVERY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. MEMBERS IS
PRETTY SIMPLE I SIMPLY SAY THAT
IF LAW ENFORCEMENT DETERMINES IT
NEEDS MILITARY CALIBER EQUIPMENT
I BELIEVE THE PUBLIC HAS A RIGHT
TO KNOW. NOT ONLY WILL THIS
CREATE MORE TRANSPARENCY BUT I
BELIEVE ULTIMATELY WILL HELP
BUILD TRUST BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE PEOPLE THEY
ARE SWORN TO PROTECT I ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND WITHOUT MADAM
CLERK WAS OPEN THE ROLL-ON
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO'S WHO.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE
YEAH.
THERE.
THANK YOU SIR.
THAT'S BECOME OF THE CALL.
MISTER GLORIA MOVES THE CALL
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK IN A
FILE ORDER TO ITEM NINETY FOUR
AB TWENTY SIX.
TO.
BUT A QUICK PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SIX FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AND
ACTUALLY THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY TWO PROVES
THE ADMINISTRATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFELINE PROGRAM.
PACIFIC LEE DISPEL DIRECTS THE
PUBLIC UTILITY COMMISSION OR
CPUC. TO ESTABLISH A SIXTY DAY
PORT PRES ALLOW PARTICIPANTS TO
ENROLL IN RECERTIFY THEIR
ELIGIBILITY. INTO THE LIFELINE
PROGRAM ELECTRONICALLY.
MANAGE TAKEN SINCE THE BELL WAS
HEARD IN NOW.
ASSEMBLY COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE ADDRESS CONCERNS
RAISED.
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
STAKEHOLDERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU ARRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SINGLE
REQUEST TO SPEAK BENEFIT PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
BUT A PERKY MAKE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS NINE. THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM NINETY FIVE AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY FOUR MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
ACTUALLY THE HEALTH CARE SERVICE
PLANS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY.
MADAM SPEAKER IN MEMBERS AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY FOUR WILL
REQUIRE THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE ANNUALLY
INVESTIGATE PROVIDER COMPLAINTS.
THAT IT HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLAN
HAS UNDERPAID OR FAILED TO PAY
THEM IN THEIR FOR THEIR SERVICES.
IF THE D. M. H. SEE DETERMINES
THAT A HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLAN
HAS ENGAGED IN A PATTERN OF
UNDERPAYING A PROVIDER. THIS
BILL REQUIRE THAT THE PROVIDER
IS REIMBURSED FOR THEIR LOSSES
OCCURRED. PLUS INTEREST AND THAT
THE ADMINISTRATIVE FINE EQUALS
THE UNDER PAYMENT PLUS INTEREST.
THIS WILL ESTABLISH A PENALTY
SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH TO DISCOURAGE
FUTURE VIOLATIONS.
AS WE STRUGGLE WITH HOW TO
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HEALTHCARE TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS WE MUST ADDRESS
THESE EXTERNAL COST DRIVERS THE
DO NOT CONTRIBUTE. TO HEALTH
SERVICES OR PATIENT CARE. THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN NO NO VOTES.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MATTER QUICKLY IS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MEADOW PARK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES.
ICE FIFTY THREE KNOWS. THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NINETY SIX AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY ONE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY ONE BY SOME AMENDMENT AS
AREA AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
SEISMIC SAFETY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IN THIS AREA YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE WOULD
REQUIRE BUILDING DEPARTMENTS AND
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO CREATE AN
INVENTORY OF POTENTIALLY
SEISMICALLY VULNERABLE BUILDINGS.
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTION AND
SUBMITTED TO THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
CREATE A STATEWIDE INVENTORY
CALIFORNIA HAS THOUSANDS OF
BUILDINGS THAT ARE KNOW TO
PRESENT A HEIGHTENED EARTHQUAKE
RISK OF DEATH INJURY AND DAMAGE.
BASED ON THEIR AGE STRUCTURAL
SYSTEM SIZE AND LOCATION. THESE
BUILDINGS POSE A MAJOR THREAT TO
OUR AFFORDABLE HOUSING STOCK AND
ECONOMY.
WHILE SOME CRITICS.
UP I'M UP I'M I'M SORRY WHILE
MOST WILD SOME CITIES MOST
NOTABLY LOS ANGELES AND SAN
FRANCISCO HAVE IDENTIFIED
VULNERABLE BUILDINGS AND
IMPLEMENTED MANDATORY RETROFITS.
LARGE PARTS OF THE STATE HAVE
NOT AN ACCURATE STATEWIDE
BUILDING VULNERABILITY MAP IS AN
ESSENTIAL FIRST STEP IN
DEVELOPING LONGER TERM SOLUTIONS.
TO MITIGATE THE EFFECTS OF A
MAJOR EARTHQUAKE
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAISE
YOUR RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
CALIFORNIA'S OF EARTHQUAKES THEY
EVEN AFTER EXPERIENCES WITH THE
RECENT NATURAL DISASTERS ACROSS
ALL OF OUR STATE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE KNOWLEDGE OF OUR MOST
DANGEROUS ZONES.
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE CREATES
AN INVENTORY. A POTENTIALLY
SEISMICALLY VULNERABLE BUILDINGS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES HAS NECESSARY
INACCURATE INFORMATION.
THIS IS THE ESSENTIAL FIRST STEP
IN A MULTI PRONGED EFFORT TO.
TO BEING ABLE TO MITIGATE THE
EVENTS OF A LARGE SCALE
EARTHQUAKE. IT IS FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ADEQUATE PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
MISS.
MADAM COURT PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE ON TELLY THE VOTES EYES
FORTY ONE NO TWENTY THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM AT NINETY SEVEN
AB TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE BY
SOMEONE MEMBER QUIRK ACTUALLY
THE ENERGY.
THANK YOU OF SOME MEMBER QUIRK.
THANK YOU THIS BILL IS ABOUT
ONE THING AND THAT'S KEEPING THE
LIGHTS ON.
WITH THE.
COMING OF THE.
CCA'S.
COMMUNITY.
ARE DISTRICTS THAT ARE
DELIVERING ELECTRIC SERVICES.
WE HAVE AVOID IN THE SYSTEM.
WHERE? ELECTRICAL FACILITIES.
IT SHOULD BE CONTRACTED FOR
DON'T GET CONTRACTED FOR.
BECAUSE HE UTILITIES DON'T KNOW
WHO THEIR CUSTOMERS ARE GONNA BE.
AND THE.
COMMUNITY AGGREGATION GROUPS
HAVE NOT COME ON YET.
SO WE HAVE WHAT WE HAVE A
PROBLEM HERE.
APPOINTED THIS BILL IS TO
IDENTIFY.
WHICH OF THOSE.
ELECTRICAL DISTRIBUTION.
.
DON'T USE ME ELECTRICAL
GENERATION FACILITIES ARE
ESSENTIAL AND NEED TO BE KEPT
ONLINE AND THAT'S WHAT THE BILL
IS ABOUT PURE AND SIMPLE.
CPU TO SEE TOGETHER WITH THE I
SO THE CCA IS.
AND. THE ONLINE UTILITIES
WE'LL GET TOGETHER. AND
DETERMINE WHAT THE ESSENTIAL.
ELECTRICAL GENERATION STATIONS
ARE.
THE.
AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
WILL BE ASKED.
WHAT?
ARE OF THESE OF THE PLANTS THAT
YOU HAVE TO KEEP.
ARE.
THERE WILL BE ABOUT.
WELL THE ESTIMATE IS ABOUT
TWENTY FOUR GIGA WHAT'S WORTH
PLANTS.
PROBABLY TWENTY TWO GIGAWATTS OF
THE MURDER SENSUAL.
YET WE HAVE PLANTS GOING OUT
TODAY WITHOUT CONTRACTS
AND THE I SO HAVING TO GET THEIR
ENERGY ON AN EMERGENCY BASIS.
IN THE BELLY DOES ALLOW FOR THE
SEE YOU THE.
AIR RESOURCES BOARD TO GIVE AN
OPINION IF THERE'S A CHOICE.
BETWEEN.
A COUPLE OF PLANTS BOTH OF WHICH
CONSERVE THE SAME.
.
AREA IF ONE OF THEM GENERATES
MORE POLLUTION THAN THE OTHER.
THEN WILL HAVE THE ONE THAT
GENERATES.
THE LEAST POLLUTION CONTINUE TO
HAVE IT.
OUR ELECTRICITY GENERATION THE
ONE THAT.
DOES MORE.
THE ONE OF THEM THAT DOES MORE
POLLUTION WILL NOT GO FORWARD.
THAT'S THE ONLY ROLE FOR THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD.
I NO PEOPLE HAVE CONCERNS.
ARM AND I WILL WORK VERY HARD TO
ALLEVIATE ANY CONCERNS PEOPLE
HAVE ABOUT THAT. I'M GOING TO BE
WORKING WITH ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO ASSURE THAT WE
KEEP OUR LIGHTS ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON.
THANK YOU MADAM. CHAIR OUT
MEMBERS.
.
AS VICE CHAIR OF THE UTILITY AND
ENERGY A.
COMMITTEE ARE.
I SUPPORTED AND VOTED FOR THIS
WHEN IT CAME.
TO THE COMMITTEE AND.
BUT THIS IT THIS IS JUST SIMPLY
NOT THE BILL THAT WE VOTED ON
AND SO I RELUCTANTLY I'M GOING
TO HAVE TO RISE IN OPPOSITION.
WELL I AM HOPING
THAT THE THE STAKEHOLDERS WILL
IN FACT IF.
IF THEY WOULD LIKE TO
TO WORK THROUGH THIS AND.
GET IT BACK TO THE KIND OF BILL
THAT WE CAN ALL SUPPORT.
AS OF RIGHT NOW.
VALUE BUT JUST DON'T GET THERE.
AND DUMP I'M GONNA HAVE TO
RELUCTANTLY UP. TO ASK FOR A NO
VOTE.
.
LET'S TRY TO RETURN THERE'S TO
THE KIND OF BILL IT WAS BECAUSE
IT DID RECEIVE A LOT OF
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. WAS HEADING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND YET
THE AMENDMENTS APPROPRIATION I
THINK OF DICK DERAILED A VERY
GOOD BILL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MELENDEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
AYE AYE.
I CERTAINLY CAN APPRECIATE THEM
THE COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE
FROM FRESNO BUT I THINK MEMBERS
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THIS IS THE
ONLY BILL THAT'S LIKE THAT IS
TRYING TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION. ABOUT THE
NECESSITY OF NATURAL GAS IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS NOT PERFECT I
DON'T THINK THE AUTHOR IS
SUGGESTED THAT IT IS BUT I THINK
THE THE. DECISION NOW BECOMES DO
WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD TO FORMULATE POLICY AND
NOT LET THE ISSUE. JUST FADE
AWAY INTO THE BACKGROUND IT IS
FOR THAT REASON THAT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES THANK YOU MY ASSEMBLY
COLLEAGUES.
ARM I WILL WORK VERY HARD
TO GET A BILL THAT MY.
ASSOCIATE FROM.
FRESNO CAN SUPPORT.
I WANT TO AND I'VE TALKED WITH
APPROPRIATIONS THEY'RE WILLING
TO WORK WITH ME ON THIS.
SO THAT WE CAN GET A STRONGER
BILL. THAT BUT AGAIN.
AS MY FRIEND FROM RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SAID.
THIS IS ALL WE HAVE TO KEEP THE
LIGHTS ON RIGHT NOW.
AND NOBODY CARES MORE ABOUT THAT
THAN I DO. AND I THINK YOU ALL
DO LET'S KEEP THE LIGHTS ON AND
VOTE FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITHOUT MEDICAL PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE
MISTER QUIRK MOVES TO CALL
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THOUGH OKAY THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I'M SEEING A LOT OF
EMPTY SEATS ON THE FLOOR.
WE HAVE DONE ABOUT FORTY BILLS.
WE HAVE ANOTHER EIGHT TO GO.
WE'RE GONNA FINISH TONIGHT.
AND SO IF.
YOU HAVE NO ABSOLUTE REASON TO
BE OFF THE FLOOR I ASK THAT YOU
STAY IN YOUR SEAT SO THAT WE CAN
DEAL GET BILLS. UP IN OUT
ALTHOUGH WE MAY BE GETTING THE
DEBATE OVER THESE BILLS ARE
STILL GOING ON CALL WHICH MEANS
WE STILL HAVE TO DEAL WITH THEM.
SO PLEASE MEMBERS STATE TO THE
FLOOR LET'S GET MOVING LET'S GET
ON A ROLL.
A MORE BILLS AGO.
THANK YOU.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM NINETY EIGHT
AB TWENTY SIX NINETY SEVEN MADAM
QUICKLY STREET. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX NINETY SEVEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GALLAGHER AND
ACTUALLY THE WILDLIFE HABITAT.
THANK YOU AS A MEMBER GALLAGHER.
WELL AS GET THIS ROLLING.
I THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
SEVEN WOULD ESTABLISH AN
INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO ENCOURAGE
LANDOWNERS TO MAINTAIN COVER
CROPS ARE NATURAL VEGETATION. ON
IDLED AGRICULTURAL LANDS
TO PROVIDE HABITAT AND NESTING
COVER FOR WATERFOWL ANOTHER
WILDLIFE IT'S A GOOD BILL AND
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENIOR REQUEST TO
SPEAK MEADOW CREEK WAS OPEN THE
RIGHT.
ALL MEMBERS ROAD DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
BUT A QUICK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE ON TELLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY SIX KNOWS ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
PASS TEMPORARILY AND ITEM NINETY
NINE MOVING TO ITEM ONE HUNDRED
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SEVEN
MADAM PURPLISH THREE.
SOME OF ALL TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
SEVEN BY SOME MEMBER HOLDEN AND
ACTUALLY THE COLLEGIATE ATHLETES
THANK YOU AS A MEMBER HOLDEN. I
THINK A BETTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
SEVEN A BILL TO ENHANCE
PROTECTION FOR COLLEGE STUDENT
ATHLETES.
WELL IMPROVEMENTS OF THE WAY
COLLEGE ELLIE ATHLETES ARE
TREATED HAVE BEEN MADE OVER THE
PAST TWO DECADES.
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN OUT OF THE
GOODNESS OF THE IN SITU AIDS
HEART.
IT HAPPENED BECAUSE ATHLETES IN
ADVOCATES FOUGHT FOR FAIRNESS IN
QUESTION A SYSTEM THAT IS
EXPLOITIVE.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO GIVE COLLEGE
ATHLETES EVEN MORE TOOLS IN
CHALLENGES OF A OR ABUSES THEY
MAY FACE. ON CAMPUS.
WE CONSTANTLY SEE EXAMPLES OF
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND ATHLETES
DEALING WITH ABUSE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SEVEN SIX
TO ADDRESS PROBLEM.
THE DRESS PROBLEMS IN A NEW WAY.
BY EDUCATING AND EQUIPPING
COLLEGE ATHLETES TO BE EVEN
BETTER ADVOCATES
FOR THEMSELVES AND PROTECTING
THEM AS THEY DO IT.
IT REQUIRES SCHOOLS TO INFORM
STUDENTS OF THEIR RIGHTS WITH
DOCUMENTATION AND PUBLIC SIGNAGE.
INCLUDING WHO THEY'RE MANDATED
REPORTERS ARE.
IT ALSO PROTECTS STUDENTS BY
PROHIBITING RETALIATION BY
SCHOOLS OF A STUDENT REPORTS
VIOLATIONS OF ANY OF THE STUDENT
ATHLETE.
BILL OF RIGHTS.
IT ALSO ALLOWS SCHOOLS TO
CREATED DEGREE COMPLETION FUND
WHICH IS A MECHANISM SCHOOLS
COULDN'T CHOOSE TO CREATE AND
SHOES. HOW IT WOULD BE USED?
THIS BILL IS PERSONAL TO ME.
BEFORE I STARTED IN MY ROLE IN
PUBLIC SERVICE. I PLAYED COLLEGE
BASKETBALL IS SAID TO GO STATE
UNIVERSITY. AND WHILE THE IN
SITU A WAS NOT THE BILLION
DOLLAR ORGANIZATION IT IS TODAY.
I HAVE FIRSTHAND EXPERIENCE AND
KNOW WHAT IT IS LIKE.
TO BE A COLLEGE ATHLETE.
THESE COLLEGE ATHLETES ARE
PUTTING EVERYTHING ON THE LINE
AND RISKING THEIR BODIES EVER
PSALM ONE INJURY AWAY FROM
LOSING EVERYTHING.
OTHERS ARE AT RISK OF LOSING IT
ALL FOR SPEAKING OUT FOR THEIR
TEAM OR ANY ABUSES THEIR
EXPERIENCE IN US COLLEGE COACHES
HAVE THE POWER TO KEEP THEM. ON
OR OFF THE FLOOR.
NOTHING IN THIS BILL REQUIRES
COLLEGES TO OR UNIVERSITIES
TO CREATE POLICIES THAT VIOLATE
INSITU A RULES.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLL UP.
OKAY PLEASE CLOSE THEIR AUNT
TALLY THE VOTES EYES FORTY SEVEN
NO ZERO.
THAT MOTION PASSES THAT MEASURE
PASSES MOVING TO ITEM ONE A ONE
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY EIGHT.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SEVEN FORTY EIGHT
PRICE ONLY MEMBER CHAO AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY IN ELECTION
INFRASTRUCTURE. BANK HE WAS A
MEMBER CHAO YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ON MADAM
SPEAKER. AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT WILL ESTABLISH A VOLUNTARY
PILOT PROGRAM FOR UP TO FIVE
COUNTY ELECTION OFFICIALS. TO
HAVE AN INDEPENDENT
CYBERSECURITY ASSESSMENT OF
THEIR ELECTION INFRASTRUCTURE
ACCESSIBLE THROUGH THE INTERNET.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN GOVERNOR BROWN
SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA
CYBERSECURITY INTEGRATION CENTER.
TO ADDRESS CYBER INCIDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT INCLUDES AGENCIES LIKE THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES OH
YES.
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY C. D.
T. AS WELL AS THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT C. M. D.. IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN CALIFORNIA ALSO ENACTED
A. B. SIX SEVENTY TWO REQUIRED
THESE AGENCIES TO ANNUALLY
CONDUCT INDEPENDENT SECURITY
ASSESSMENTS.
STATE AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS.
THIS BILL TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT IS AN EFFORT TO TAKE WHAT
WE HAVE LEARNED. BY PULLING OUR
STATE CYBERSECURITY EXPERTISE
AND APPLY THE RESOURCES IN
CRITICAL AREAS INCLUDING
ELECTIONS.
IT DOES SO BY ESTABLISHING A
PILOT PROGRAM TO PERFORM.
SECURITY ASSESSMENT SIMILAR TO
A. B. SIX SEVENTY OF OUR
ELECTION INFRASTRUCTURE IN
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES.
ALL OF THE RESULTS ARE
CONFIDENTIAL AND NOT DISCLOSE
SCHOOL TO THE PUBLIC. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SEEING THEIR REQUEST TO SPEAK
MEDICAL PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE?
BUT A QUICK PLEASE CLOSE A
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM ONE ARE TO AB TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY NINE MADAM QUICKLY THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
NINE BY SOME A MEMBER BONTA AND
ACTUALLY STATE GOVERNMENT.
SOME MEMBER BONTA YOUR READINESS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I MISS
SPEAKER MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES.
AFTER THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE. I AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE WOULD
SIMPLY ADD MOBILE OF FRIENDLY TO
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT CODE TO
ENSURE THAT STATE GOVERNMENT
WEBSITES ARE ACCESSIBLE.
TO THOSE WITH THE MOBILE DEVICE
AND WOOD ALSO INCLUDE A SECTION
THAT ENSURES FUTURE STATE
GOVERNMENT WEBSITES WILL BE
MOBILE FRIENDLY AS WELL THE BILL
WAS ON CONSENT AND ASSEMBLY
PRIVACY COMMITTEE HAS RECEIVED
ZERO NO VOTES. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN THE
RIGHT. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MEDICALLY PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO ITEM
ONE OH THREE AB TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY ONE ADEQUATE PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
ONE BY SOMETHING MEMBER MARK
STONE AND ACTUALLY AGRICULTURAL
LABOR RELATIONS.
THANK YOU US A MEMBER STONE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS WHEN THE
AGRICULTURAL LAOR RELATIONS
BOARD MAKES A DECISION ON A
DISPUTE BETWEEN AND AGRICULTURAL
WORKER AND AN EMPLOYER.
SOMETIMES THE RESOLUTION DOES
NOT COME FOR IT CAN BE YEARS
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS SET THE
TIMELINE AND ASK SAILOR BE TO
FINALIZE THE DECISION WITHIN A
YEAR. AT THAT IS OF COURSE
DECISIONS THAT ARE NOT BEING
APPEALED. OR HAVE OTHER
CONSTRAINTS AROUND THEM THESE
ARE DECISIONS THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE LEAVE WORKER WITHOUT
PAY OR WITHOUT REMEDY THAT.
THEY ARE OWED FOR AT.
WORK THAT THEY HAVE DIED IN THE
FIELDS SO THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
THIS BILL AND REFER RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MADAME QUICK PLEASE OPEN THE
WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRING TO
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND. HELP.
ADEQUATE PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
ON TELLY THE VOTES EYES FORTY
ONE KNOW TWENTY THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
I DON'T WANNA POUR AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY ONE METAPHOR PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY ONE BY SOME OF HER LOW
NECKLINE FARMS THANK YOU AS A
MEMBER LOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MINUTES IT REMEMBERS AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY ONE AS A BALLISTICS
IMAGE.
BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN A REQUEST TO
SPEAK BENEFIT PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES AYES
FIFTY TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
I DON'T WANT NO FIVE AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE BY SELLING
MEMBER RUBIO AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
SO MEMBER RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER TO DAN
PRESENTING AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE A BILL THAT WILL
HELP INSURE OUR LACTATING
STUDENTS ARE PROVIDED WITH THE
BASIC NEEDS NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE
ACADEMIC SUCCESS.
A GROWING NUMBER OF HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS ARE
PROVIDING ADEQUATE LACTATION
SPACES FOR THEIR STUDENT BODY.
HOWEVER INADEQUATE SPACES ARE
UNSANITARY UNSANITARY LACTATION
ACCOMMODATIONS.
WITHIN OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS STILL EXIST AND
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED AS A
SERIOUS HEALTH AND GENDER
INEQUITY ISSUE.
I THINK YOU'RE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEING A NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN. MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
BENEFIT YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
I DON'T WANT NO SIX AB TWENTY
NINETY ONE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINETY ONE
BY SALLY MEMBER GRAYSON AND
AFTER IN A FIRE PREVENTION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
TO YOU ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINETY ONE. LIABILITY CONCERNS
AND THE COST OF INSURANCE HAVE
CONSISTENTLY BEEN CITED AS
ROADBLOCKS TO THE EXPANDED USE
OF PRESCRIBED FIRE AN IMPORTANT
TOOL FOR MANAGING FIRE RISK IN
PROMOTING FORCED HEALTH.
WHILE INSURANCE FOR LANDOWNERS
LANDOWNERS IMPRINT PRACTITIONERS
IS IS AVAILABLE IT IS OFTEN
PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE SO AB
TWENTY NINETY ONE ADDRESSES THIS
ISSUE IN TWO STEPS FIRST
ESTABLISHES A PRESCRIBED BURN
MANAGER. CERTIFICATE OF
SPECIALIZATION WITHIN THE
LICENSED PROFESSIONAL FORESTER
PROGRAM SECOND IT DIRECTS
CALIFORNIA TO DEVELOP AN
INSURANCE OPTION FOR CERTIFIED
BURN MANAGERS THAT WOULD LOWER
COSTS AND IMPROVE LIABILITY
PROTECTION. THIS BILL IS NOT
PRESCRIPTIVE AS TO THE TYPE OF
PRODUCT CALIFORNIA SHOULD OFFER
BUT IT DOES REQUIRE THE GOAL TO
INCREASE USE A PRESCRIBED FIRE.
BY PROVIDING A RECOGNIZE BURN
MANAGER CREDENTIAL AND A
MECHANISM FOR REDUCING THE COST
OF INSURANCE FOR PRACTITIONERS
AB TWENTY NINETY ONE WHEN THE
COURAGE EXPANDED USE OF AN
IMPORTANT TOOL FOR MANAGING
WILDFIRE RISK. CONSERVING
FIREFIGHTER OF FIREFIGHTING
RESOURCES PROMOTING FOREST AND
WATERSHED HEALTH AND REDUCING
THE IMPACT OF TREE MORTALITY AND
MEGA FIRES ON THE CLIMATE.
THIS BILL IS NOT RECEIVED A NO
VOTE AND HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN
I'VE.
THANK YOU SEEN A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MATTER QUICKLY IS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM ONE OH SEVEN AB TWENTY ONE
OH SIX MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE OF SIX
BY SOME A MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND ACTUALLY TO INSTITUTIONAL
PURCHASERS OF AGRICULTURE
PRODUCTS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA. MASS
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES A. B. TWO
ONE OH SIX IS A BILL. THAT
BEGINNING IN TWENTY ONE WILL
TAKE THE CURRENTLY EXISTING BIT
PREFERENCE FROM FIVE PERCENT TO
TEN PERCENT. FOR STATE PURCHASES
RELATED TO CALIFORNIA GROWN WITH
CALIFORNIA PACK AGRICULTURE
PRODUCTS OVER THOSE PRODUCED AT
A STATE. THIS BUILDS ON
SUCCESSFUL EFFORT PUT FORWARD BY
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SALINAS
VALLEY. A. B. EIGHT TO TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING OF NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY SIX KNOWS ONE THAT MEASURE
PASSES. I DON'T WANNA WAIT AB
TWENTY ONE TWELVE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE TWELVE
BY SOME THE NUMBER SANTIAGO AND
ACTUALLY THE CRISIS INTERVENTION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY ONE TWELVE WOULD REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO APPLY FOR A FEDERAL
GRANTS THAT WOULD PROVIDE
FUNDING TO DEVELOP COMMUNITY
BASED MENTAL HEALTH CARE CRISIS.
SPONSOR PLAN.
THERE'S CURRENTLY NO OPPOSITION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
I DON'T WANT NO NINE AB TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO MEDICAL PLEASE
READ. THE LEGAL TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BY SIGN NUMBER REYES
AND OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO MEDI
CAL
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO ENSURES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES.
MEETS ITS STATE AND FEDERAL
MANDATES FOR BLOOD LEAD TESTING.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT TO NOTIFY CHILD'S
PARENT OR GUARDIAN OF LEAD TEST
REQUIREMENTS AND INFORM THEM OF
WHEN TESTS ARE MIS.
IN ADDITION IT REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT ANNUAL REPORT ON THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROGRESS OF MEETING
THESE REQUIREMENTS.
LASTLY IT ENSURES A D. H. CS
DOES NOT CONTRACT WITH MANAGED
CARE PROVIDERS WHO ARE NOT
COMPLIANT WITH MANDATED BLOOD
LET TESTS.
WITH STUDIES ILLUSTRATING THAT
YOUNG CHILDREN IN LOW INCOME
AREAS ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY LEAD EXPOSURE.
ENSURING THAT CHILDREN MEDI CAL
ARE RECEIVING THEIR FEDERALLY.
AND STATE MANDATED BLOOD LET
TESS WILL HELP SAVE ITS NUMEROUS
CHILDREN FROM A MYRIAD OF
PERMANENT AND DEVELOPMENTAL
PROBLEMS.
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO CREATES
MECHANISMS FOR BETTER REPORTING
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
ON CHILDREN'S TEST COMPLIANCE
AND RESULTS.
AND RESULTS AND INCREASED
COMMUNICATION AND NOTICE TO
PARENTS AND PROVIDERS.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TO CHILDREN WHO ARE
AT RISK FOR LEG EXPOSURE. WILL
BE MORE LIKELY TO RECEIVE THEIR
BLOOD LET TESS AND THE STATE
WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE MORE
INFORMATION ON THE GENERAL
POPULATION SUFFERING. FROM BLOOD
EXPOSURE.
TODAY THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES CAN ONLY VERIFY.
TWENTY EIGHT PERCENT
OF CHILDREN ON MEDI CAL WHO HAVE
RECEIVED THIS FEDERALLY AND
STATE MANDATED BLOOD LET TEST.
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO IS ONE
STEP. TO HELP MAKE SURE THAT
NUMBER. TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
NUMBER INCREASES.
IT IS FOR THESE CHILDREN FOR
WHICH I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO REQUEST TO SPEAK MADAM
PARK WAS OPEN THE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. ITEM ONE TEN AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY SIX MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ THAT SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY ONE THIRTY SIX BY FAMILY
MEMBER BONDS AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES IN CALIFORNIA
APPROXIMATELY FORTY PERCENT OF
WOMEN ARE VICTIMS OF INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY SIX WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
COUNTY OF ALAMEDA. TO ESTABLISH
A LEE THOU T. ASSESSMENT PILOT
PROGRAM TO DEVELOP TOOLS FOR
FIRST RESPONDERS TO ASSESS THE
LETHALITY OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PERPETRATORS AND CONNECT VICTIMS
WITH SERVICES THIS BILL HAS
LOCAL SUPPORT. AND NO OPPOSITION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN TO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM ONE ELEVEN AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT MADAM QUICKLY THREE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE THIRTY
EIGHT BY SOME THE MEMBER DAVID
CHIU AND OTHERS THAT KIND
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO. MY COMMITTED
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT IS ABOUT SECOND
CHANCES AND PUTTING PEOPLE TO
WORK. IN CALIFORNIA AT THIS TIME
EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE ARE DENIED
ACCESS TO NEARLY THIRTY PERCENT
OF ALL JOBS.
THE EIGHT MILLION REPRESENT
THOSE ADULTS WHO HAVE BEEN A AN
ARREST OR CONVICTION RECORD
WHICH BARS THEM FROM APPLYING TO
THIRTY PERCENT OF ALL JOBS IN
ALMOST EIGHTEEN HUNDRED.
DIFFERENT OCCUPATIONS THAT
REQUIRE A STATE LICENSE
CERTIFICATE OR CLEARANCE BY
BOARD OR AGENCY.
ALL TO OFTEN INDIVIDUALS ARE
DENIED AN OCCUPATIONAL LICENSE
OR HAVE IT REVOKED OR SUSPENDED
BASED ON PRIOR ARRESTS OR
CONVICTIONS THAT ARE OLD.
UNRELATED TO A JOB OR DISMISSED
BY JUDGE.
THERE'S AN IRONY THAT DUE TO
THESE LICENSING BARRIERS.
MANY WHO RECEIVE SPECIFIC JOB
TRAINING WHILE INCARCERATED
CAN'T GET A LICENSE TO DO THAT
JOB WHEN THEY GET OUT. IN FIELDS
LIKE COSMETOLOGY CONSTRUCTION
LANDSCAPING AND AUTO REPAIR.
THE INABILITY OF AN EX OFFENDER
TO GET A JOB UPON REENTRY IS A
SIGNIFICANT REASON OUR STATE HAS
ONE OF THE HIGHEST RECIDIVISM
RATES IN THE COUNTRY.
TO THIS END THIS BILL SAYS THAT
A NONVIOLENT CONVICTION THAT'S
OLDER THAN FIVE YEARS OLD. CAN'T
BE USED TO DENY REVOKE OR
SUSPEND THE LICENSE UNDER THE
PURVIEW OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. UNLESS IT IS
DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE DUTIES
OF THAT JOB.
THE BILL SPECIFICALLY REFERENCES
THE DIFFERENT CRIMES CONSIDERED
VIOLENT THAT CAN ALWAYS BE
CONSIDERED.
THIS BILL ALSO PROHIBITS SPORTS
REQUIRING AN APPLICANT TO SELF
DISCLOSE CRIMINAL HISTORY IF
THAT INFORMATION CAN BE OBTAINED
THROUGH DOJ BACKGROUND CHECKS.
AND REQUIRES THE COLLECTION OF
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA REGARDING
APPLICANTS DENIED A LICENSE.
WITHOUT FAIR CHANCE LICENSING
POLICIES. WITH FAIR CHANCE
LICENSING POLICIES WE CAN
PROVIDE ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY FOR
ALL REDUCE RECIDIVISM AND
PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY. I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR OF BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS FOR BEING MY JOINT
AUTHORED.
FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS WHO SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
FOR NOT OPPOSING THIS BILL AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS INTO IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY AND. REITERATE THE POINT
THAT THIS BILL ADDRESSES TWO
THINGS.
REDUCING OVER REGULATION AND
ADDRESSING RECIDIVISM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER REQUEST
TO SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
MR TO MOVE THE CALL.
WE ARE LEFT IN THE CALL.
I'M NOT A ONE ELEVEN WITH THE
CALL PLEASE.
ALMOST ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CHEAP.
MISTER CHIU OF THE CALL.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM ONE TWELVE AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE MISTER
CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE FIFTY
THREE BY SOME REMEMBER THURMOND
ACCOLADE IF HE'S.
THANK YOU MISTER THURMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT. AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE A BILL
THAT SEEKS TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
FOR OUR STUDENTS.
PARTICULAR LGBTQ STUDENTS IN
GRADES SEVEN THROUGH TWELVE.
THE DATA SHOWS THAT THE
STUDENTS OFTEN EXPERIENCE VERY
HIGH RATES OF PHYSICAL
HARASSMENT.
VERBAL HARASSMENT. WHICH LEADS
TO AND BULLYING WHICH LEADS TO
HIGHER RATES OF SUDDEN SAID BE
USE IN HOMELESSNESS. AND SADLY
SOMETIMES SUICIDE.
OF THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE
TEACHERS WITH TRAINING ON HOW TO
CONNECT STUDENTS TO RESOURCES ON
THE SCHOOL SITE. AND IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT SPECIALIZE IN
SUPPORTING LGBTQ STUDENTS.
WITH THE SUPPORTS OUR STUDENTS
WILL SKIP YOUR CLASSES THERE
EARN HIGHER GRADES AND THEY WILL
BE BETTER AND HEALTHIER AND AND
BE WELL SUPPORTED.
I ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS
BILL ON BEHALF OF ALL STUDENTS
AND HELP TO GIVE A POSITIVE
EXPERIENCE OR LGBTQ STUDENTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
HIGHS FORTY TWO KNOWS TEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES ITEM ONE THIRTEEN
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY ONE MISTER
CLERK PLEASE READ.
SO MIDDLE TWENTY ONE SIXTY ONE
BY SOME REMEMBER DAVID CHIU AND
OTHERS AND I PLAYED A HOUSING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIP. I CAN
MANAGE SEEKER COLLEAGUES WE ALL
KNOW THAT OUR STATE IS
EXPERIENCING THE WORST
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IN OUR STATE
HISTORY.
ARE AND WHILE WE ARE SPENDING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AROUND THE
STATE TRYING TO TACKLE IT AND
HOMELESSNESS IMPACTS THE COST OF
OUR STATE'S HEALTH CORRECTIONS
SOCIAL SERVICES. AND PUBLIC
SAFETY SYSTEM WE DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT WORKS AS OTHER
STATES HAVE FOUND HAVING DATA
WILL HELP US UNDERSTAND THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS AND WHAT ARE
AFFECTED POLICIES. THIS BILL
WILL FOR THE FIRST TIME REQUIRE
IN CALIFORNIA THE STATE WIDE
COLLECTION OF DATA ON
HOMELESSNESS BY ESTABLISHING A
STATEWIDE DATABASE TO COMPILE
THE STATE ACROSS DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS. AND HOMELESS
MANAGEMENT INFORMATION SYSTEMS
AND COLLECTING DATA FROM STATE
AND LOCAL AGENCIES ON WHO WAS
HOMELESS WISE PERSON HOMELESS
THE SERVICES PROVIDED WHAT
PROGRAMS WORK AND GAPS IN
COVERAGE.
TO SOLVE HOMELESSNESS WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND IT I APPRECIATE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR THIS
MEASURE AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK. PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES.
I WAS FORTY SEVEN KNOWS THIRTEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES ITEM ONE
FOURTEEN AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
ONE MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
ONE BY SOME REMEMBER FRAZIER AN
ACCOLADE TO INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY PRESENT AB TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY ONE. AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY ONE FOCUSES ON
INDIVIDUALS WITH IN
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES IN
THEIR GOALS.
IT ENSURES THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES COORDINATE EFFECTIVELY
WHEN SERVING INDIVIDUALS. WITH
ID DE.
CAN YOU BELIEVE THIS ISN'T
ALREADY HAPPENING.
EMPLOYMENT RATES FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITY REMAINS
ABYSMALLY LOW.
THIS BILL PUSHES US FORWARD TO
EMPOWER CALIFORNIANS TO ATTAIN
THEIR GOALS BY PLACING
IMPORTANCE ON INDIVIDUALS.
AN INDIVIDUAL'S PLANS TO DO
TOWARDS EMPLOYMENT.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK U. SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER QUICK PLEASE OPEN
THE RIGHT. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY ONE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES ITEM
ONE FIFTEEN AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
TWO MISTER QUICKLY THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
THAT ACCOLADE THE PRIVACY.
MR LEVINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TO
CREATE A SITE LINK TO THE
CONSUMER INFORMATION CENTER WEB
PAGE THAT. PULLS TOGETHER ALL
THE PRIVACY POLICIES OF PERSONAL
DATA POLICIES OF ONLINE
PLATFORMS INCLUDING SOCIAL MEDIA
WE'VE ALL HEARD CONCERNS FROM
CALIFORNIANS ABOUT. DATA PRIVACY
THIS BILL SEEKS TO HELP INFORM
THEM OF THOSE POLICIES ASPIRIN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM ONE SIXTEEN AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY SIX MISTER CLERK PLEASE
READ. SOME PEOPLE TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY SIX BY SOME REMEMBER
THURMOND ACCOLADE TO EDUCATION
FOR.
SO MEMBER THURMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
ARISE PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY SIX
A THIS IS A BILL THAT SEEKS TO
HELP US PREPARE OUR STUDENTS FOR
THE JOBS. OF TOMORROW IN JOBS
AND TECHNOLOGY AYE IT'S BEEN
ESTIMATED THAT THERE WILL BE A
MILLION AND A HALF JOBS IN
TECHNOLOGY THAT FEW YEARS. AND
THAT IN CALIFORNIA WE WILL HAVE
ONLY HALF THE APPLICANTS UNLESS
WE INCREASE WHAT WE DO IN THE
AREAS OF SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY
ENGINEERING AND MATH AND AND
STEM OR STEAM FOR ARTS. OF THIS
BILL RECOGNIZES THAT WE HAVE A
TEACHER SHORTAGE IN MANY AREAS
INCLUDING IN STEM AND STEAM
RELATED AREAS. AND IT CREATES AN
INCENTIVE TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF TEACHERS WHO PURSUE A
CREDENTIAL IN THE CALMEST DAM
TEACHER.
IT DOES THAT IT BY PROVIDING
RESOURCES TO THOSE WHO COMPLETE.
THEIR TRAINING WHO COMPLETE A
CERTIFICATE A CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM AND WHO ACTUALLY TEACH
IN THE FIELD OF STEM ON BEHALF
OF OUR STUDENTS IN A WORKFORCE
OF TOMORROW. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY SIX.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MISTER CLARK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW THE BOATS I SIXTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY NINE MISTER CLERK PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY NINE BY SIMPLY RIVER
SANTIAGO AND ACTUALLY THE
HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES IN MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION ARE FOR.
SOME MEMBERS SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU MANAGE A BIGGER.
I'VE MOST OF YOU KNOW YEARS AGO
WE ALLOCATED A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE QUEEN OF THE BACKSIDE.
AND WHILE WHILE THE CLEAN OF THE
STALL LONGER THAN WE WANTED TO
WE ALSO FOUND THE PARKWAYS WERE
NEEDED TO CLEAN UP.
AND IT AND WE NEED TO CUT
ADDITIONAL CONTROLS AND
OVERSIGHT ON INTERIOR CLEAN UP.
AND THIS BILL AND WHAT EXACTLY
DO JUST THAT.
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION THE DB
AMENDMENTS COMING IN THE SENATE.
A TO TALK WITH THE BUDGET.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OF
NOR DEBATE MISTER QUICK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MISTER QUIRKE MAKE CLOTHES THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE
SIXTY KNOWS ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM ONE EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY TWO
OH SEVEN MISTER CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO OH
SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER EGGMAN
ACCOLADE A SEXUAL ABUSE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THE GROUND SPEAKER MY
MEMBERS TO A TWENTY TWO OH SEVEN
SIMPLY ASK THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES TO LOOK AT BEST
PRACTICES AND SEE HOW OUR KIDS
WHO ARE. A IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM A SEXUALLY
EXPLOITED AND AND IN THE.
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM A HOW WE'RE
TRACKING THOSE TWO ENDS THAT WE
BEST IN ANNA AND IMPLEMENT. BEST
MODEL SERVICES SO THAT WE CAN
MORE EFFECTIVELY TRACK HOW KIDS
WHO MIGHT BE INTO DISTANCE
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS ARE BEING
TREATED I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE FOR THIS.
BIPARTISAN OUT SO FOR UNANIMOUS
BILL.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER QUICK PLEASE OPEN
THE. MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY FOUR
KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM ONE NINETEEN AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN MISTER QUICKLY STREET.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS.
SOME BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER NUMBERS.
IN ALL BUT ONE STATEWIDE
ELECTION SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE
A MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA VOTES
HAVE BEEN CAST ON VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS.
CALIFORNIA LAW ALREADY REQUIRES
COUNTIES TO HAVE A FREE ACCESS
SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS A VOTE BY
MAIL VOTER. TO DETERMINE IF HIS
OR HER BALLOT WAS RECEIVED BY
THE ELECTIONS OFFICIAL AND IT
WAS COUNTED.
BUT OTHER JURISDICTIONS HAVE
ADOPTED MORE EXTENSIVE VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOT TRACKING IN
NOTIFICATION SYSTEMS THAT CAN%
HELP IMPROVE VOTER PARTICIPATION
AND REDUCE THE NUMBER OF VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOTS. THAT ARE
INVALIDATED.
AB TWENTY TO EIGHTEEN REQUIRES
THE SECRETARY OF STATE TO
DEVELOP A SYSTEM FOR USE BY
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS THAT
ALLOWS OF VOTER TO RECEIVE TEXT
OR EMAIL NOTIFICATIONS. ABOUT
THE STATUS OF HIS OR HER VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOT AS IT MOVES THROUGH
THE POSTAL SYSTEM AND AS IT IS
PROCESS BY THE ELECTIONS
OFFICIAL.
NOT ONLY WILL THE SYSTEM GIVE
VOTERS GREATER PEACE OF MIND
WHEN CASTING A BALLOT BY MAIL.
BUT IT ALSO HELPS ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS TAKE STEPS TO REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS THAT ARE UNABLE TO BE
COUNTED.
AB TWENTY TO EIGHTEEN IS
SUPPORTED BY SECRETARY OF STATE
ALEX PADILLA AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU S. SOME EVER HARPER
YOU RECOGNIZE.
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS AS VICE CHAIR THE
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE MAINTAINING THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTION SYSTEM
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO ME.
BUT THIS BILL I BELIEVE IS
UNNECESSARY VOTERS CAN ALREADY.
I VERIFY WHETHER THEY'RE VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOT HAS BEEN COUNTED OR
NOT THEY CAN VISIT THEIR COUNTY
REGISTRAR'S WEBSITE TO CHECK ON
THE STATUS OF THE BALLOT.
ADDITIONALLY GOVERNOR BROWN
VETOED A VERY SIMILAR BILL TO
THIS ONE.
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN WOULD
IMPLEMENT A COSTLY SYSTEM THAT
IS UNNECESSARY CONSIDERING THE
READ CURRENT RESOURCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO VOTERS.
NOW SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU A SOME MEMBER BAKER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT HAVE
OF THIS BILL IN PARTICULAR
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S ALL THE
MORE IMPORTANT THE WAY WE HAVE
CHANGED OUR LIVES IN CALIFORNIA
WITH RESPECTIVOS BY MAIL BALLOTS.
AND TO WITH ME ALL MAIL IN
BALLOTS AND WHO CAN PICK UP YOUR
BALLOT IN DELIVER YOUR BALLOT IT
IS ESSENTIAL FOR THE INTEGRITY
OF ELECTIONS THAT WE EMPOWER
CALIFORNIA VOTERS TO BE ABLE TO
CHECK IN THAT. THE SMARTEST
FASTEST MOST EFFICIENT WAY
POSSIBLE WHETHER THEY'RE BALLOT
HAS BEEN RECEIVED AND WHAT HAS
HAPPENED TO THAT BALLOT NOT ONLY
SO THEY ARE ARE HAVE THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED. AND THE
BEST WAY POSSIBLE TO CONFIRM
THAT THERE BALLOT HAS BEEN
PROPERLY HANDLED BUT THEY'RE
ABLE TO TAKE THE QUICKEST ACTION
POSSIBLE THAT YOU CAN DO IF YOU
RECEIVE ELECTRONIC NOTIFICATION.
AND ALSO BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN
AGAIN AND AGAIN MEASURES THAT GO
TO TRYING TO INCREASE VOTER
TURNOUT.
AND PARTICIPATION IN OUR
ELECTIONS M. THAT I DON'T THINK
ARE AFFECTED THIS IS ONE THAT I
ACTUALLY THINK IS EFFECTIVE
BECAUSE VOTERS WILL BE ABLE TO
SAY I I'M ACTUALLY HEARING FROM
MY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
PROACTIVELY AND WHEN I'M
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING. ONE OF THE
NUMBER ONE TOOLS WE CAN HAVE TO
INCREASE THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ELECTIONS IS MAKING SURE EVERY
SINGLE VOTERS TOLD HATE YOUR
BALLOT WAS OR WAS NOT RECEIVED
WAS ACTUALLY REJECTED SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MISTER
BERMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM DOUBLE
AND.
FOR FOR A
THE SIZING
SOME OF THE VALUES OF THIS BILL
I KNOW THAT IT DOES.
ANOTHER COLLEAGUE MENTIONED
THAT A SIMILAR BILL WAS VETOED
THAT WAS NOT SIMILAR IT WAS NOT
A SIMILAR BILL AT ALL.
THIS BILL IS VERY DIFFERENT
THAN AB TWENTY EIGHTY NINE WHICH
WAS VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR LAST
YEAR. AB TWENTY EIGHTY NINE
REQUIRE COUNTIES TO NOTIFY VOTE
BY MAIL BY VOTERS IF THEY'RE
BALLOTS WERE NOT COUNTED.
THAT BILL IMPOSED A STATE
MANDATE WHICH AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN DOES NOT.
IN ADDITION THE SYSTEM REQUIRED
UNDER AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN
WILL PROVIDE VOTERS WITH MUCH
MORE COMPREHENSIVE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE STATUS OF THE ROBOT
NOW BALLOTS. AND IMPORTANTLY
WOULD NOTIFY VOTERS IF THERE'S A
PROBLEM WITH THEIR BALLOT WHEN
THERE'S STILL TIME TO TAKE
ACTION AND HAVE THAT BALLOT
COUNTED. IF YOU SUPPORT TRYING
TO GET MORE PEOPLE TO VOTE AND
MAKING SURE THAT THE BALLOTS
ACTUALLY COUNTED YOU SHOULD
SUPPORT THIS BILL I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THE CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE RIGHT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MISTER CLARK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE.
AND TALLY THE VOTES ICE FIFTY
ONE NO ELEVEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE TWENTY AB
TWENTY TO TWENTY MISTER QUICKLY
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO
TWENTY BY SOME REMEMBER BONTA
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION THANK YOU S.
SOME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
WILL EXPAND ON THE SIGNIFICANT
STRIDES. MADE BY THE STUDENT
ATHLETE BILL OF RIGHTS.
PROTECT COLLEGE ATHLETES UNDER
CURRENT LAW THE STUDENT AT THE
BILL OF RIGHTS ONLY APPLIES TO
INTERCOLLEGIATE ATHLETIC
PROGRAMS AT FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION.
THAT RECEIVED TEN MILLION OR
MORE IN ANNUAL REVENUE DERIVED
FROM METEORITES FOR
INTERCOLLEGIATE ATHLETICS THIS
MEANS FORTY THREE. CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS WITH COLLEGIATE ATHLETIC
PROGRAMS IN DIVISION ONE AND TO
HAVE THE AUTONOMY TO DETERMINE
WHETHER TO PAY FOR ATHLETES
MEDICAL EXPENSES IF THE ATHLETE
GETS INJURED. ADDITIONALLY
COLLEGE ATHLETES WHO GET INJURED
DURING PRACTICE OR GAME ARE NOT.
PROTECTED FROM LOSING THEIR
ATHLETIC SCHOLARSHIPS AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY WILL REQUIRE
INSTITUTIONS THAT GENERATE OVER
TEN MILLION DOLLARS.
TO PAY THE DEDUCTIBLES FOR
COLLEGE ATHLETES WHO SUFFER
SPORTS RELATED INJURIES AND FOR
THE COST OF ONGOING MEDICAL
TREATMENT FOR AT LEAST TWO YEARS
AFTER A STUDENT HAS GRADUATED.
OR LEFT THE UNIVERSITY
FURTHER AB TWENTY TO TWENTY
REQUIRE SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE AN
EQUIVALENT SCHOLARSHIP IF THE
STUDENT ATHLETIC SCHOLARSHIP IS
NOT. RENEWED DUE TO AN INJURY
WITH AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY WE CAN
GIVE COLLEGE ATHLETES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THE ABILITY TO
SUCCEED BOTH IN THE CLASSROOM
AND ON THE FIELD WE OUGHT NOT
TURN OUR BACKS ON A COLLEGE
ATHLETES IN THE MOMENTS WHEN
THEY NEED US MOST I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR. YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO RIP TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES
AYE AYES FORTY TWO KNOWS
EIGHTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM ONE TWENTY ONE AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY TWO MISTER CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO TWENTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE CRIME
PREVENTION AND INVESTIGATION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY TO TWENTY TWO WOULD
REQUIRE ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES.
TO LOG RECOVERED CRIME GUN DATA
INTO DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S.
AUTOMATED FIREARM SYSTEM.
WITHIN SEVEN DAYS OF RECOVERY.
UNDER CURRENT LAW POLICE AND
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS ARE
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT CRIME GUN
INFORMATION DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AUTOMATIC.
AUTOMATED FIREARM SYSTEM HOWEVER
OTHER BRANCHES OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT SUCH AS C. H. P..
ARE NOT STATUARY EARLY A QUITE
REQUIRED TO DO SO.
AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO WILL
HELP LAW ENFORCEMENT DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
BETTER RECOGNIZE PATTERNS IN GUN
TRAFFICKING.
FIGURING OUT HOW CRIMINALS ARE
GETTING THEIR HANDS ON GUNS AND
WORK TO PREVENT ANOTHER INNOCENT
LIFE FROM BEING TAKEN TOO SOON.
ARM I WILL ALSO ADD THAT JOB.
THE PEOPLE WHO. ACTUALLY DO THIS
WORK IN TERMS OF PUTTING THINGS
ON THE DATABASE.
* TO EXTEND THE TIME TO SEVEN
DAYS WHICH WE DID SO IMMEDIATELY.
SO SO FAR AS I KNOW THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION. ARM I REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER QUICK PLEASE OPEN
THE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES ITEM
ONE TWENTY TWO AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY SIX MISTER CLERK PLEASE
READ.
SO MIDDLE TWENTY TWO TWENTY SIX
BY SOME REMEMBER PATTERSON
ACCOLADE TO VICTIMS OF CRIME.
MISTER PATTERSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM BUT AS SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
SIX WILL HELP VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. BY CLARIFYING
THAT THE VICTIM MAY SEEK
RESTITUTION IN ORDER TO PAY FOR
INCREASED RESIDENTIAL SECURITY.
BECAUSE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS NOT
CLASSIFIED AS A VIOLENT FELONY
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ARE
FREQUENTLY UNABLE TO SEEK
RESTITUTION FOR THE COST OF
INCREASING HOME SECURITY. THIS
IS AN OBVIOUS LOOPHOLE IN THE
LAW THAT THIS BILL WILL CLOSE AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY SIX WILL ALLOW
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE TO
SEEK RESIDENTIAL SECURITY
RESTITUTION. EVEN IF THE
PERPETRATOR IS NOT SENTENCED TO
JAIL THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHERE I VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN KNOW DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER QUICKLY IS OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MISTER CLARK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE ON TELLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
SIX KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM ONE TWENTY THREE AB TWENTY
TO TWENTY EIGHT MISTER QUICKLY
ST.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO TWENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
OTHERS AND ACCOLADES EDUCATION
FINANCE SOME NEVER WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THINKING MEN SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS IS CINEMA COUNTY
ALONE OVER SEVENTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS EXPAND EXTEND.
EXPERIENCED EXTENDED SCHOOL
CLOSURES DUE TO THE NORTH BAY
FIRES.
ACCORDING CINEMA COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION NEARLY FOURTEEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY STUDENTS AND
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY STE.
TEACHERS LOST THEIR HOMES
WITH A VACANCY RATE OF TWO
PERCENT PRIOR TO THE FIRES ARE
STRONG CONCERNS THAT MANY
STUDENTS AND STAFF WILL NOT
RETURN TO THEIR SCHOOL OF ORIGIN.
AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT WOULD
ARE ELEAZER IN THE AREAS ARE
SUBJECT TO THE.
TO THE GOVERNOR'S TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WILDLIFE WILDFIRE
DISASTER DECLARATION NEW
EXPERIENCE DISLOCATION OF PUPILS
TO RECEIVE SUPPLEMENTAL
APPORTIONMENT FUNDING BASED ON
THEIR AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE
PRIOR TO THE WILDFIRES.
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN FUNDING
CAN CAUSE SIGNIFICANT CUTS IN
PROGRAMS AND LOSS OF PERSONAL.
ARE THE PERSONNEL DESPITE AN
EXPECTATION THAT MANY OF THESE
CHILDREN WERE RETURNED AFTER THE
THREE YEAR BECAUSE
RECONSTRUCTION PERIOD. DUE TO
CIRCUMSTANCES BEYOND THE CONTROL
OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS FUNDING IS
NEEDED TO PROTECT EDUCATIONAL
QUALITY AND MEET UNFORESEEN
COSTS IN THE INTERIM. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM ONE TWENTY FOUR A BE TWENTY
TO THIRTY THREE MISTER QUICKLY
THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO THIRTY
THREE BY SOME REMEMBER KALRA
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE TO MEDI
CAL THANK YOU SOME MEMBER KALRA
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY TO THIRTY
THREE WOULD INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF SLOTS AVAILABLE UNDER THE
ASSISTED LIVING WAIVER PROGRAM.
BY UP TO EIGHTEEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED EXPAND GEOGRAPHIC
REPRESENTATION THE PROGRAM ON A
REGIONAL BASIS INCLUDED MANY
RULE COMMUNITIES THAT. DON'T HA
DOT DON'T CURRENTLY FALL UNDER
THE PROGRAM OUTLINED
REQUIREMENTS THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS AND ADDRESS VARIOUS
PROGRAMMATIC ELEMENTS THAT
IMPACT ITS EFFECTIVENESS.
THIS IS A LIVING WAIVER PROGRAM
TAKE SENIORS IN NURSING HOMES
WHO DON'T NEED THAT LEVEL OF
CARE. AND PLACE THEM OF PLACES
THEM IN ASSISTED LIVING FACILITY
OR ALLOW SENIORS TO REMAIN AT
HOME WITH YOUR PURPOSE SERVICES
AND THEREBY AVOID BEING PLACED
IN A NURSING HOME.
IN BOTH CASES BY AVOIDING THE
HIGH COST OF NURSING HOME CARE
SPECIALS THAT LEVEL OF CARE IS
UNNECESSARY PROVIDES A DRAMATIC
COST SAVINGS TO THE STATE.
FURTHERMORE IT FREES UP VALUABLE
NURSING HOME BEDS FOR THOSE WHO
TRULY NEED THEM A WIN WIN FOR
EVERYONE.
CURRENTLY THE DEMAND FIRST
LIVING WAIVER PROGRAM HAS
OUTPACED SUPPLY AND OPERATES
WITH A SIGNIFICANT WAIT LIST
ACCORDING TO THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTSSCORECARD. ALMOST
ELEVEN PERCENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S ONE HUNDRED ONE
THOUSAND NURSING HOME RESIDENTS
OR ELEVEN THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
ARE IDENTIFIED AS HAVING LOW
CARE NEEDS.
BY EXPANDING DISABILITY WAIVER
PROGRAM WE GET PLACE THOSE
ELEVEN THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS IN
THE MORE APPROPRIATE SETTING
THAT THEY BELONG AND WHAT THEIR
BEST CARE FOR AND WHERE THEY
WOULD BE HAPPIEST. AND THIS
COULD ALL BE DONE AT A
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS TO THE STATE
BUT THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER QUICK PLEASE OPEN
THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IN THE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
MR CLERK.
PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTES AYE SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM ONE TWENTY FIVE AB TWENTY
TO THIRTY FOUR MISTER CLERK
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
TO THIRTY FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER
JONES SAWYER AND ACTUALLY TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. SELLING NEVER
JONES SAWYER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY TO THIRTY
FOUR WHICH WILL PROVIDE STUDENTS
WHO ARE TESTIFYING IN EMPLOYEE
DISMISSAL HEARINGS. THAT INVOLVE
DEGREE JUST ACTS WHICH SIMILAR
WITNESS PROTECTION THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO MINORS AND OTHER
LEGAL SETTINGS THIS BILL WOULD
SIMPLY PROVIDE ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGES.
QUESTION TO YOU THEY CLOSED
CIRCUIT TELEVISION OR VIDEOTAPE
DEPOSITION AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
IT AND HEARING TESTIMONY BY A
STUDENT.
THIS BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
THAT A SUPPORT PERSON BE
APPOINTED TO EACH CHILD WITNESS
TO ACCOMPANY THEM THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS.
ALLOWING THE USE OF THESE
PROTECTION WILL REDUCE THE RISK
OF TRAUMA THAT CAN OCCUR WHEN
VICTIMS FACED THEIR ABUSER.
MEMBERS JUST BILL IS LIMITED TO
DISMISS SO HEARINGS INVOLVING
EGREGIOUS ACTS AGAINST CHILD IT
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS AND HAVE
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU AYE
VOTE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MISTER CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE. ON MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY NINE
KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS ABOUT OBJECTION WE ARE
MOVING BACK IN ORDER TO ITEM
NINETEEN AB TWENTY NINE NINETY
FIVE MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE NINETY
FIVE BY SOME REMEMBER CARILLO
AND OTHERS ARE NOT WILLING TO
SIT ELECTIONS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CAREER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY NINE NINETY
FIVE A MEASURE THAT EMPOWERS
HOMEOWNERS TO DEFEND THEMSELVES
AND THEIR CHILDREN. FROM THE
DEVIL DEBILITATING EFFECTS OF
LET LET PAINS IN THEIR HOMES.
COLLEAGUES A CERTAIN PAINT
MANUFACTURERS.
CERTAINLY PAINT MANUFACTURERS
KNOWINGLY SOLD THE PAINT FOR USE
IN HOMES ACROSS THE STATE FOR
DECADES AND WITH THE HEALTH AND
WELL BEING. OF GENERATIONS OF
FAMILIES
THESE ARE FAMILIES THAT PUT
THEIR HARD EARNED MONEY TOWARDS
BUYING A HOME THE AMERICAN DREAM.
ONLY TO FIND OUT THAT THROUGH NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN THEIR WALLS
WERE COVERED IN A TOXIC. THAT
WOULD AFFECT THEIR CHILDREN'S IQ
LEVELS AND BRAIN DEVELOPMENT.
WE SHOULD ALL BE OUTRAGED AND
DEMAND THAT THESE COMPANIES BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE. ON TOP OF THAT
THE PERVASIVENESS OF LEAD PAINT
IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR REVEALED A DISTURBING
PRACTICE WHERE CERTAIN PAIN
COMPANIES CONTINUOUSLY.
PUT PROFITS ABOVE THE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND HEALTH.
IN RECENT COURT CASES IT WAS
REVEALED THAT THESE GUILTY PAIN
COMPANIES THOUGHT THIS US MOSTLY.
PUBLICITY ISSUE NOT A PUBLIC
HEALTH ONE.
AND ADMITTED THAT MOST CASES OF
LEAD EXPOSURE WERE OF LITTLE
CONCERN.
BECAUSE THEY WERE IN THE HOMES
OF.
NEGRO AND PORTO RICAN FAMILIES.
IN RESPONSE AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY FIVE DOES TWO THINGS.
FIRST IT CALLS OUT THE PRESENCE
OF LEAD PAINT FOR WHAT IT IS. A
POISON THAT IS A DAMAGE TO
PROPERTY AND A HEALTH HAZARD.
THIS ENSURES THAT HOMEOWNERS CAN
MOVE TO REMOVE LED BEFORE THEIR
CHILDREN GET HURT. NO ONE SHOULD
HAVE TO WAIT FOR THEIR BABY TO
GET POISONED BEFORE THEY CAN
TAKE AN ACTION TO REMOVE THAT
THREAT.
SECOND THE BILL THAT THE CLEAR
AND FAIR STANDARD FOR HOMEOWNERS
TO TAKE ACTION.
BY STARTING THE TIMELINE FOR
HOMEOWNERS TO TAKE ACTION WHEN
THEY HAVE A POSITIVE TEST OF
LEAD PAINT IN THEIR HOME. WOULD
GIVE THEM THE ABILITY TO TAKE
ACTION RIGHTS WHEN THEY NEEDED.
THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
AND PREVENTION THE CDC STATE
THAT THERE IS NO SAFE LEVEL OF
LEAD IN CHILDREN'S BLOOD.
ANY AMOUNT NO MATTER HOW TRACE
IS TOXIC.
UNFORTUNATELY THESE INJURIES ARE
FELT ALL ACROSS THE STATE FROM
EUREKA TO SAN DIEGO IN LOS
ANGELES THE CDC FOUND
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE FIVE PERCENT
OF CHILDREN. HAD ELEVATED.
LEVELS OF LEAD.
IN SOME AREAS THE FRESNO
THIRTEEN POINT SIX PERCENT OF
CHILDREN TESTED HAD ELEVATED
LEAD LEVELS. NEARLY THREE TIMES
THE RATE FOUND IN FLINT MICHIGAN
DURING THE CITY'S WATER
CONTAMINATION CRISIS LET ME
REPEAT THAT AGAIN. NEARLY THREE
TIMES THE RATES FOUND IN FLINT
MICHIGAN.
THE SHEER GRAVITY OF THIS ISSUE
DEMANDS ACTION AND THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE HOMEOWNERS HAVE THE
LEGAL POWER TO PROTECT THE
SAFETY. NOT ONLY OF THEIR HARD
EARNED PROPERTIES BUT MOST
CRITICALLY OF THEIR FAMILY AND
LOVED ONES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE
YOUR ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS
AFTER THIRTY FIVE YEARS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY IN TWENTY
THREE YEARS AS A CONTRACTOR.
I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT WE'RE
TAKING THE WRONG APPROACH.
ADD THIS LEAD BASED BILL.
LISTEN.
THE FOR THE PEOPLE WE WANT TO
PROTECT THE PEOPLE THAT ELECTED
US TO BE HERE THE CONSUMER.
WE DON'T WANT TO PROTECT THE
PAINT COMPANIES AND WE DON'T
WANT TO PROTECT THE TRIAL
LAWYERS WE WANT TO PROTECT THE
PEOPLE WHOSE VALUE OF THEIR
HOMES. WILL BE DIMINISHED.
BY THIS PROCESS
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS START OVER
AND START LOOKING AT WHAT THE
COST WILL BE TO REMEDIATE LEAD.
IN THESE PRE NINETEEN FIFTY ONE
HOMES.
THIS MONEY COULD BE ABSOLUTELY
OUT OF REACH
IF WE DO NOT LOOK.
AT THE ABSOLUTE COST.
SOME OF THESE HOUSES HAVE
WINDOWS THAT ARE COMPLETELY
WOULD WAINSCOTING CROWN MOLDING
SIX PANEL DOORS.
THE COST COULD BE ABSOLUTELY
PHENOMENAL.
BUT IF WE LOOK AT IT INCOME FROM
THIS APPROACH WE COULD BE GIVING
MONEY TO PEOPLE. COUPLE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IF IT WAS A FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR BILL AND THEN
DUMP THE PUBLIC NUISANCE BURDEN
ON THE. CONSUMER.
THAT'S NOT FAIR.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE THE START
OVER PROTECT THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT WE WERE ELECTED TO PROTECT.
THIS IS THE WRONG APPROACH I BEG
YOUR INDULGENCE TO REFUSE THIS
BILL AND WE START OVER IN A
PROCESS THAT DOES.
PROTECT THE PEOPLE THAT WE ARE
HOLD DEAR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID CHIU.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
COLLEAGUES I KNOW ALL OF US HAVE
BEEN THINKING ABOUT THIS ISSUE
AND WHAT I WOULD ASK EVERYONE.
TO THINK ABOUT IS HOW INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT IT IS.
AFTER DECADES OF FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN BEING POISONED BY
MANUFACTURERS WHO KNOWINGLY
DECEIVED THE PUBLIC.
AND AFTER A TWENTY YEAR LAWSUIT
TO HOLD THESE COMPANIES
ACCOUNTABLE. THESE COMPANIES ARE
CONTINUING TO DECEIVE THE PUBLIC.
AND I WOULD ALSO SUGGEST TO SEE
PAUL DID TO SEE POLICYMAKERS
HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
I'VE PLENTY OF DOCUMENTS TO.
EXPLAIN I THINK WE ALL DO OF WHY
THE DECEPTION IS OCCURRING. BUT
I WOULD AGREE WITH THE LAST
SPEAKER ARE THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US IN THE COMING WEEKS IN
THE COMING MONTHS. TO WORK
TOGETHER TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
ADDRESS THAT AND THAT IS WHY I
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT WITH THE
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL TO MOVE IT
FORWARD. WE HAVE TO KEEP THIS
CONVERSATION GOING. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO THIS THE
WHOLE PIC COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE
BECAUSE IF WE DO NOT IF WE DO
NOT ACT.
DURING THIS SESSION IT IS VERY
POSSIBLE THAT THESE PAINT
COMPANIES WILL COMPLETELY BE
ABSOLVED OF THEIR RESPONSIBILITY
COMPLETELY BE ABSOLVED OF THEIR
LIABILITY. AND THAT.
THAT'S.
PENALTY.
COULD.
LEYVA ON THE TAXPAYERS OF
CALIFORNIA BY THE END OF THIS
YEAR THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO ACT
THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD TO KEEP THE CONVERSATION
FOR GOING. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO FURTHER REQUEST TO
SPEAK ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND I KNOW THAT THIS HAS
BEEN A A LONG PROCESS TO GET
HERE. I THINK AT THE END OF THE
DAY WE ALL WANT TO ENSURE THAT
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA ARE
ABLE TO PROTECT THEIR AMERICAN
DREAM. OF HOMEOWNERSHIP.
THIS IS WHY EVEN THE REALTORS
ASSOCIATION PHI MAY READ.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
STATED IN IN A STATEMENT THAT
PAYING COMPANIES ARE USING SCARE
TACTICS ON CALIFORNIANS TO COVER
FOR THEIR OWN WRONGDOING.
TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO.
WE ALL WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR CHILDREN ARE PROTECTED.
THIS IS ABOUT HOW WE AS A BODY
ARE GOING TO ADDRESS THE FACT
THAT PAIN COMPANIES PURPOSELY
SOLD PAINTS WOULD LEAD.
TO COMMUNITIES ACROSS OUR STATE.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO TURN TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND SAY THAT WE
PREFERRED TO BE WITH THE PAIN
COMPANIES?
VERSES THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE NEED TO THINK LONG AND HARD.
ABOUT WHAT THIS BODY REPRESENTS.
HOW WE PROTECT CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNERS HOW WE PROTECT
FAMILIES AND HOW WE PROTECT
CHILDREN?
THE NEXT GENERATIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS OUR STATE
NO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE MOVING
TO ITEM FIFTY EIGHT EVEY TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY ONE MISTER CLERK
PLEASE THREE. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY ONE BY SOME
WE'VE EVER EGGMAN AND OTHERS ARE
NOT RELATED TO EDUCATION FINANCE
IN THE CLEAR HERE TO SEE THEIR
UP TO QUEBEC IMMEDIATELY.
SOME MEMBER EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THINK ABOUT SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY AND PRESENTING AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY ONE THE HIGHER
EDUCATION FACILITIES BOND ACTIVE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
SPAWN WOULD GENERATE SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS REVENUE FOR
CONSTRUCTION OF NEW FACILITIES
AND DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND
UPDATES ON ALL FACILITIES
EXISTING FACILITIES AND PROVIDE
FOR STUDENT HOUSING.
HISTORICALLY BARDS HAVE BEEN
USED TO FUND LARGE CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS IN OUR SYSTEM.
BOTH THE.
K. THROUGH TWELVE AS WELL AS
HIGHER EDUCATION.
THIS FUNDING FOR PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET A FAILED
TO KEEP PACE WITH NEED THIS
ISSUE WHEN YOU SEE HAVE BEEN
LEFT OUT OF THE RECENT BOND
MEASURES.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE HAD A
BOND FOR AFTER PRIMARY SCHOOL
BUT THAT EXCLUDED OR SEE ISSUES
IN UC'S.
WE NEED TO INVEST IN THE REST OF
OUR PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM NOT ONLY OUR CURRENT
FACILITIES LACKEY NECESSARY
MAINTENANCE.
BUT OUR SYSTEM IS ALSO TURNING
AWAY TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS EVERY YEAR
LAST YEAR WAS OVER THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA STUDENTS DID
NOT HAVE A SEAT. IN WHICH TO SIT
IN ONE OF OUR INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER LEARNING.
WE ARE PROJECTED TO FALL
MILLIONS OF GRADUATE SHORT OF
THE JOB MARKET BY TWENTY THIRTY.
AND MUST EXPAND OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE IN ORDER OFFER
OPPORTUNITIES TO ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS.
MY COMMUNITY IS HOME TO MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE WE DON'T HAVE OUR OWN
HIGHER. A OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION A
AND WE ARE DON'T HAVE ONE WITHIN
FIFTY MILES OF US
OTHER AREAS IN THE STATE BASE
ALSO THE LACK OF EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCES.
IF WE REALLY WANT TO TAKE
CALIFORNIA FORWARD WE MUST FIND
WAYS TO EXPAND. THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR PEOPLE BUT WE DON'T TALK TO
ANYBODY WHO DOESN'T SAY WE NEED
A MORE EDUCATED WORKFORCE.
UNLESS WE PUT OUR MONEY WHERE
OUR MOUTH IS THAT WE WE ALL GET
LEFT BEHIND. WHERE THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
IT'S TIME TO REALLY START MOVING
FORWARD INVESTING IN OUR FUTURE
INVESTING IN HIGHER EDUCATION
PER CALIFORNIANS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE?
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO FIRST THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON FOR
HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. AS
WELL AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO AS A JOINT AUTHOR I AM
PROUD TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BOND.
IN SPEAKING TO COUNTLESS
CONSTITUENTS STUDENTS FACULTY
STAFF AND ADMINISTRATORS IS BEEN
MADE CLEAR TO ME THAT THERE IS
AN OVERWHELMING NEED FOR THIS
BOND.
MANY CSU AND UC CAMPUSES SPACE
SEVERE BACKLOGS AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE
STUDENTS DESERVE OPTIMAL
LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS AND THIS
BILL WILL HELP US ENSURE THAT
THEY HAVE THE WORLD CLASS
EDUCATION SYSTEMS THAT WE
INTENDED. MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED
THAT THE LACK OF PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY IN HER IN HER
COMMUNITY CENTRALLY IN CONTRA
COSTA OVER A MILLION RESIDENTS
HAVE NO DIRECT ACCESS TO PUBLIC
FOUR YEAR. SO A STATE UNIV.
INSTITUTION
SO WHAT OTHER REGIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA ARE IN SIMILAR
SITUATIONS AND THIS BILL WOULD
POSITIVELY IMPACT COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE.
THIS BILL IS A SMART INVESTMENT
FOR THE FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA
THIS IS THE KIND OF INVESTMENT
THAT WILL BUILD FACILITIES THAT
WILL LAST A LIFETIME.
TURN OUR.
TURNOUT FUTURE LEADERS AND
CONTRIBUTE TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY FOR YEARS TO COME. THANK
YOU AND I URGE I URGE I A AND I
VOTE IN YOUR SUPPORT IN THIS
MEASURE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'D TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY ONE THE HIGHER
EDUCATION FACILITIES BOND ACT OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
THIS BOND HAS POINTED OUT WILL
GENERATE APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN REVENUE FOR
CONSTRUCTION OF NEW FACILITIES
AND IMPROVEMENT IN EXISTING
FACILITIES.
WE HAVE DONE A LOT IN THIS IN
THE STATE TO TALK ABOUT K.
FOURTEEN EDUCATION.
WE PUT A LOT OF RESOURCES INTO
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE PUT A
LOT OF TRYING TO PUT MORE
RESOURCES THERE ARE KATE WELL.
AND WHAT IS HAPPENING IS THAT WE
HAVE FAILED TO PUT THE EQUAL
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES INTO RC
ISSUES AND I UC SYSTEM.
THE LAST BOND WE HAD WITH THOSE
CAMPUSES WAS IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX
AND SO WE REALIZED THAT WE'RE
KIND BEHIND IN TERMS OF
CONSTRUCTION AND DEVELOPMENT
THAT'S THERE. WE MET WITH THE
CHANCELLOR OF THE C. ISSUE WHEN
WE MET WITH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UC CAMPUS. THEIR ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE THEY
RECOGNIZE THAT THE EXPECTATION
OF CALIFORNIANS IS THAT EACH ONE
OF THEIR CHILDREN WHO QUALIFY
WILL HAVE A PLACE TO GO TO
COLLEGE. AND HE SAYS WE'VE DONE
A LOT TO ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO DO
THE TWO YEAR EXPERIENCE TO GET.
THOSE TWO YEARS UNDER THEIR BELT
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO THIS THE
BASICALLY AB COURAGE'S THEM HE
SAYS TO GET ON THE ON RAMP. TO
EDUCATION BUT YET WHEN THEY GET
ON THEIR THE FREEWAY AT THE C.
ISSUE IN THE UC'S ARE CROWDED.
WE TURN DOWN SOMETHING LIKE
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND STUDENTS
THIS PAST YEAR WHICH IS ENOUGH
TO FILL A GOOD SIZE CAMPUS.
WE HAVE A LOT TO DO IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BUT BUILDING OUR
C. ISSUE NOW YOU SEE OUGHT TO BE
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS
WE DO. WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE
WEALTH OF THE STATE HAS BEEN
BUILT ON THE BACK OF OUR C.
ISSUE WHEN I UC SYSTEMS.
THE FACT THAT WE ARE CONSIDERED
THE HIGH TECH THE STATE IS
REALLY BECAUSE OF THOSE SYSTEMS
THAT ARE ABLE TO EDUCATE OUR
CHILDREN AND TO KEEP OUR
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA WORKING
AND CONTRIBUTING TO SOCIETY.
MOST OF YOU IN THIS BUILDING
HAVE HAD SOME CONTACT WITH THE
C. ISSUE OF THE UC YOU'VE BEEN A
GRADUATE OF A NEW BEEN A
GRADUATE STUDENT UNDERGRADUATE.
YOU HAVE CHILDREN WHO ATTENDED
THOSE INSTITUTIONS YOU LOOK FOR
TO YOUR CHILDREN BEING ABLE TO
GO THERE AND I KNOW ONE OF THE
REAL TRAGEDIES OF A FAMILY LIES
IN THE FACT THAT WHEN YOU. GET
CHAVEZ THAT ALL THEY CAN TO
QUALIFY.
AND THEN TO APPLY AND NOT BE
ABLE TO ATTEND AND SO I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK BUT TO THE
FUTURE WE'VE BEEN STRUGGLING
EVERYONE IN THIS HOUSE HAS BEEN
STRUGGLING TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE CAN EXPAND THE C. ISSUES
IN THE UC SYSTEM. WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT VARIOUS KINDS OF GROUPS
AND WE'VE WE'VE BEEN VERY
FRUSTRATED WITH THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE MADE A COMMITMENT AND A
PROMISE TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT THEIR
INSTITUTIONS WILL BE THERE FOR
THEM AND YET WHEN IT COMES DOWN
TO THE REALITY IS MANY OF OUR
FOLKS CANNOT. GET TO A GREATEST GIFT WITH
ISSUE AND THE UC EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOU I BOTH PUT AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY ONE. SO WE CAN
FINALLY DO SOME THINGS THAT WE
KNOW NEED TO HAPPEN AND WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE MEET THE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE
FUTURE THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
AND I RESPECT YOU. ASKED WE AYE
BOTH TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY ONE.
THANK YOU SEEING THAT NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MISTER
QUIRK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE COULD DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
FIVE NO NINE.
ON THE URGENCY EYES FIFTY FIVE
NO NINE ON THE MEASURE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS I'M PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL.
ON ITEM EIGHTY A. B. THIRTY
EIGHTY ONE.
THE COURT PLEASE POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FORTY
TWO NO SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES
.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LOOK
THE CALL ON ITEM NINETY SEVEN AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE MISTER
QUICK PLEASE POST. A MEMBERS
VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FORTY
FOUR
BEFORE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT THE
SOCIAL MEDIA DISCLOSE ACT.
LAST YEAR I AUTHORED AB TWO
FORTY NINE THE CALIFORNIA
DISCLOSE ACT WHICH WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW IT REPRESENTS THE
STRONGEST CAMPAIGN ADVERTISEMENT
DISCLOSURE LAW THE COUNTRY.
POLITICAL ADS ARE NOW REQUIRED
TO ADHERE TO NEW FORMATTING
EARMARKING RATE EARMARKING
REGULATIONS MAKING IT EASIER FOR
VOTERS TO KNOW WHO THE TRUE
FUNDERS ARE BEHIND
ADVERTISEMENTS.
AB TWENTY ONE ANY EIGHTY EIGHT
THE SOCIAL MEDIA DISCLOSE ACT.
WILL SIMPLY EXTEND THE NEW
CAMPAIGN FINANCE DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS TO POLITICAL ADS
APPEARING ON SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS.
AS MOST OF US ARE WELL AWARE
WITH INCREASING FREQUENCY PEOPLE
ARE GETTING THEIR NEWS AND
INFORMATION VIA SO FORBES
.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING
AGAIN NOT LEAVE THE COUNTRY ON
DISCLOSURE IN SOCIAL MEDIA
POLITICAL ADVERTISEMENTS HAVE
WITH THAT I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER ACOSTA YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR I
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE ON A COUPLE OF THE ISSUES
PROTECTING THE MICRO TARGETING
ETCETERA. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE THE WORK ON THIS BILL
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT WE HAVE
TRANSPARENCY. YOU KNOW IN ALL OF
OUR.
ADVERTISEMENT THAT WE DO THAT
THE PUBLIC KNOWS ARE WHO ARE
FUNDING CAMPAIGNS IN CALIFORNIA
BUT MOST OF ALL THAT WERE ABLE
TO STILL HAVE A A GOOD FREE
EXPRESSION IN EXCHANGE WITH OUR
CONSTITUENTS WITH PEOPLE THAT
WERE TRYING TO REACH. I THINK
THIS GOAL.
THE EX IN THE THIS BILL IS
REACHING A HAPPY MEDIUM THERE
AND SO I MA POLICE AT THIS POINT
TO SUPPORT THE BILL BUT OUT I
WANT TO CONTINUE TO WATCH IT.
AND WORK WITH.
THE AUTHOR AS IT MOVES THROUGH
THE REST OF THE PROCESS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THINK YOU A SUMMER QUIRK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED
I JUST WANT TO SAY HOW IMPORTANT
DISCLOSURE IS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF NEGATIVE
CAMPAIGNING AGAINST OUR INCOME
THE D. A.. WHO I LOVE? AND I
JUST LOOKED AT THE.
THE PIECE OF PAPER THAT SAID
FUNDED BY GEORGE SOROS.
WHAT THE HELL IS HE DOING IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY THANK YOU PLEASE
VOTE I?
THINK YOU SEEN THE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
MISTER MULLIN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I THINK YOU MEMBERS FOR THE
DISCUSSION.
.
I DON'T BELIEVE GEORGE SOROS HAS
WEIGHED IN ON THIS BILL.
BUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND LET'S PUT
A BIG BIPARTISAN VOTE UP ON THE
BOARD IF WE MAY.
THANK YOU WITHOUT MR CLICK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY SEVEN
KNOWS SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS I'M PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON A FILE ITEM TWENTY AB
TWENTY NINE THIRTY FIVE MISTER
CLERK PLEASE POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MR CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FORTY NINE KNOWS WELL THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
I'M PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL ON
ITEM TWENTY NINE SORRY.
ON ITEM SIXTY SEVEN AB THIRTY
TWO ZERO SEVEN.
THE COURT PLEASE POST. MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES ICE FORTY
FIVE KNOWS TWENTY THREE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE GOING TO LIFT THE CALL
AND ITEM TWELVE AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY SIX
THE CLERK PLEASE POST.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
THE CHARM OF THE CALL.
I PREPARE TO LIFT THE CALLING
ITEM TO SEVENTY ONE A BE
SEVENTEEN NINETY THREE MISTER
CLERK PLEASE POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY TWO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS WERE LIFTING THE CALL ON
ITEM TWENTY SEVEN AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY ONE MISTER QUIRK PLEASE
POST.
THIS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES FORTY FIVE KNOWS
THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE LOOKING THE CALL AN ITEM
FOR A FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE
EIGHTY THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE
MISTER CLERK PLEASE.
PLEASE.
PLEASE POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE
.
YOU CLICK YOU MAKE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW THE VOTES ICE FORTY
ONE KNOWS THIRTY TWO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
I AM PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL
ON A FILE ITEM ONE ELEVEN AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT MISTER
QUIRK PLEASE PUT. MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY FOR KNOWS TWENTY FIVE THAT
MEASURE POWER
MEMBERS OF THAT OBJECTION WE
ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIFTY
FIVE AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX
MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SIX BY SOME REMEMBER MULLIN
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE THE CHILD
CARE SERVICES.
THANK YOU SOMEWHERE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
PRESENTING AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SIX.
IN TWO THOUSAND THREE THE
LEGISLATURE ESTABLISHED THE
FIRST INDIVIDUALIZED COUNTY
CHILDCARE SUBSIDY IN SAN MATEO
COUNTY MY FATHER FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JEAN MULLIN. WAS
A CO AUTHOR ON THE BILL'S MATTER
FACT RECOGNIZING THE DIVERSE
NEEDS OF REGIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA SAN MATEO SOUGHT TO
INCREASE FLEXIBILITY FOR
FAMILIES AND HIGH COST COUNTY
SUCH AS OURS.
THE FLEXIBILITY SUPPORTED A SAN
MATEO AND SUBSEQUENTLY SAN
FRANCISCO WERE SO SUCCESSFUL
THAT TODAY THERE ARE A TOTAL OF
THIRTEEN COUNTIES THAT ARE ABLE
TO USE OUR INDIVIDUALIZED
PROGRAMS TO SAID EXCEPTIONS.
STATEWIDE REQUIREMENTS FOR
FAMILIES LIVING IN RECEIVING
SERVICES IN THOSE COUNTIES.
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE EXCEPTIONS
ARE CREATED INEQUITIES AMONG
COUNTIES.
AFTER WORKING IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE A
LEGISLATURE THE PILOT COUNTIES
AND A CHILD CARE STAKEHOLDERS TO
STREAMLINE THE PROGRAMS THE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTIONS OFFICE HAS
IDENTIFIED THE AREAS. WHERE THE
COUNTIES HAD MOST SUCCESS?
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX MAKES A
NUMBER OF STATEWIDE CHANGES TO
SUBSIDIZE CHILDCARE CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS THAT
WILL ALLOW US TO BETTER SERVE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN EVERY
COUNTY IN OUR STATES. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN THAT NO REQUEST
TO SPEAK MISTER CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROAD. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND.
TALLY THE VOTES I SEVENTY THREE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS I'M PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON ITEM SIXTY FOUR AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY THREE MISTER
CLERK PLEASE POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
MISTER CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES ICE
FORTY TWO KNOWS TWENTY EIGHTH
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WERE MOVING TO
ITEM FOUGHT THE FILE ITEM EIGHTY
ONE A. B. THIRTY ONE TEN MISTER
CLERK PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY ONE TEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MULLIN OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO
ATHLETIC TRAINERS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY STATE IN
THE COUNTRY THAT DOES NOT
REGULATE THE PROFESSION OF
ATHLETIC TRAINING.
AB THIRTY ONE TEN ESTABLISHES
THE ATHLETIC TRAINING PRACTICE
ACT THE BILL CREATES THE BOARD
OF ATHLETIC TRAINING. ANY
REGISTRATION MECHANISM TO
REGULATE ATHLETIC TRAINERS IT
ALSO PROTECTS THE ATHLETIC
TRAINER TITLE FOR THOSE WHO ARE
NATIONALLY CERTIFIED. ATHLETIC
TRAINERS ARE HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE OFTEN
CHARGED WITH MANAGING SERIOUS
MEDICAL CONDITIONS SUCH AS
CONCUSSIONS HEAT ILLNESS SUDDEN
CARDIAC ARREST. AS WELL AS
MUSCULOSKELETAL ISSUES LIKE
DISLOCATIONS AND FRACTURES
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO ACCURATE
SYSTEMIC WAY FOR THE PUBLIC TO
REPORT EVIDENCE OF HARM AGAINST
ATHLETIC TRAINERS. FOR THOSE
POSING AS ATHLETIC TRAINERS AND
HAVE THOSE REPORTS TRACKED
THERE'S ONLY ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE
AB THIRTY ONE TEN REQUIRES THAT
THOSE PROVIDING ATHLETIC
TRAINING SERVICES REGISTER WITH
THE BOARD OF THAT ATHLETIC
TRAINING. WHICH WILL MAINTAIN
INFORMATION ON ATHLETIC TRAINERS
WHERE THEY ARE LOCATED AND THE
SERVICES THAT THEY PROVIDE. THE
BILL ALSO RESERVES THE ATHLETIC
TRAINER TITLE FOR THOSE WHO ARE
NATIONALLY CERTIFIED. A
CALIFORNIA INTERSCHOLASTIC
FEDERATION SURVEY OF ATHLETIC
DIRECTORS WITHIN APPROXIMATELY
NINETY FIRST NINETY PERCENT
RESPONSE RATE INDICATES THAT
THERE ARE ATLEAST ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY HIGH SCHOOLS CURRENTLY
EMPLOYING AN INDIVIDUAL. WHO IS
PRACTICING AS AN ATHLETIC
TRAINER WITHOUT THE APPROPRIATE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING? THIS
MEANS ATHLETES MAY BE UNDER THE
CARE OF INDIVIDUALS WHO LACK THE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING TO ACT AS
AN ATHLETIC TRAINER. THE
INTRODUCED AB THIRTY ONE TEN AS
A LICENSE YOUR BILL I ACCEPTED
MAJOR AMENDMENTS IN THE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE TO
SCALE BACK SIGNIFICANTLY.
THERE'S A MISCONCEPTION THAT%
THIS IS STILL A LICENSE YOUR
BILL. IF YOU REHABILITATE OFF
YOU'LL SEE THAT IS NOT A LICENSE
REBEL THIS BILL ESTABLISHES A
REGISTRATION MECHANISM FOR
ATHLETIC TRAINERS. AND RESERVES
THE ATHLETIC TRAINER TITLE FOR
THOSE WHO ARE NATIONALLY
CERTIFIED AND REPRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANT STEP.
IN THE RECOGNITION OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF CALIFORNIA'S IN
THE ROLE PLAYED BY CALIFORNIA'S
ATHLETIC TRAINERS AND I ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING THAT NO REQUEST
TO SPEAK MISTER CLARK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTES ICE FORTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL IN ITEM TWENTY EIGHT AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY MISTER CLERK
PLEASE POST. MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLL
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES FORTY THREE KNOWS
TWENTY TWO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY FOUR
MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE SIXTY
FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER BLOOM
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE TO HOUSING.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'M A VERY PLEASED TO BE
PRESENTING THIS BILL AND. LET ME
START BY LETTING YOU KNOW THAT
MY OFFICE HAS COME TO AGREEMENT
WITH THAT OPPOSITION ON THIS
VERY CONTENTIOUS BILL INVOLVING
THE ELLIS ACT AND IT'S A. NEEDED
REFORM CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION OF GREATER LOS
ANGELES AND OTHERS ARE NO LONGER
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AS
WE'VE AGREED TO AMENDMENTS WHICH
WE WILL TAKE IN THE SENATE.
THE ELLIS ACT EXPRESSLY
PROHIBITS WITHDRAWING LESS THAN
ALL THE UNITS FROM THE RENTAL
MARKET AND THE LAW IN THE CASE
THAT THERE'S ONLY ONE WITHDRAWAL
DATE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
CALCULATING RENTAL AMOUNTS. WHEN
UNITS ARE RE OFFERED FOR RENT
BUT THERE IS ALSO LANGUAGE
GOVERNING THE TENANTS LEASE
TERMINATION DAY. THAT SEEMS TO
ALLOW MULTIPLE WITHDRAWAL DATES
IN ADDITION THERE'S NO PROVISION
THAT SPECIFIES THAT THERE'S ONLY
ONE DAY. THAT APPLIES OF THE
PROPERTIES PUT BACK ON THE
RENTAL MARKET.
AS A CONSEQUENCE SOME LANDLORDS
HAVE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THIS
CONFUSION AND REMOVED UNITS FROM
THE RENTAL MARKET. RETURNING
THEM IN A PIECEMEAL FASHION AND
THEREBY AVOIDING THE ACT'S
RESTRICTIONS INNOVATING RENT
CONTROL.
THEY ARE ALSO OR HAVE ALSO
APPLIED DIFFERENT WITHDRAWAL
DATES TO DIFFERENT UNITS.
AND CLAIMING THAT RETURNING ONE
UNIT TO THE MARKET DOES NOT
OBLIGATE THE LANDLORD TO RE
OFFER OTHER UNITS TO FORMER
TENANTS.
THIS IS ALLOWED LANDLORDS TO
EFFECTIVELY WITHDRAWAL LESS THAN
ALL THE UNITS FROM THE RENTAL
MARKET AND IN FACT. NEVER
ACTUALLY LEAVE THE RENTAL MARKET
AT ALL WHILE STILL HAVING
SUCCESSFULLY EVICTED ALL THE
EXISTING TENANTS IN INCREASING
RANTS AGAIN CONTRARY TO THE
INTENT.
THE VERY CLEAR INTENT OF THE
ALICE ACT.
ACCORDING TO THE RIGHT CONTROL
JURISDICTION'S THE COURTS ARE
MISINTERPRETING THE LAW AS A
RESULT OF SOME A A VERY FEW
NUMBER OF LANDLORDS. SO IT'S
EVEN MORE IMPERATIVE TO CLARIFY
WHAT THE LAWS MEANT ALL LONG.
THIS IS BEEN A DIFFICULT AND
VERY TENSE CONVERSATION.
BETWEEN TENANT ADVOCATES AND
LANDLORDS.
AND THIS BILL GIVES TENANTS SOME
SECURITY IN KEEPING THEIR HOMES
AT A TIME WHEN HOMELESSNESS FOR
OUR POOR SENIORS DISABLED AND
EVEN WORKING CLASS. IS A REALITY.
AND MANY TIMES FOLKS RE JUST A
PAYCHECK OR RENT INCREASE AWAY.
I FROM HOMELESSNESS TO THE LACK
OF ROOM READILY AVAILABLE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHEN THEIR
DISPLACED AS A RESULT OF THE
ELLIS ACT. SO THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT IMPROVEMENT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU THANK A MENACE BAKER
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. I WANNA JUST TAKE A
MOMENT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS WORK IN ADDRESSING AND
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL TO WHERE WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO GET. A WHEN THE METS NOT
JUST OF THE MOST INTENSE HOUSING
CRISIS IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY
BUT A SEVERE TENDING CRISIS AND
ADDICTION CRISIS. THE ELLIS ACT
WAS INITIALLY LEGISLATED TO
ALLOW PROPERTY OWNERS TO LEAVE
THE RENTAL MARKET A BUT I THINK
MANY CAN AGREE THAT IT HAS BEEN
GAINED IN RECENT YEARS. ARE IN
CITIES THAT DO HAVE RENT CONTROL
THIS BILL STRIKES THE RIGHT
BALANCE BETWEEN TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS RIGHTS AND AS A JOINT
AUTHORED THIS BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EVERYONE'S
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I BELIEVE THAT TEN YEARS WAITING
IS MUCH TOO LONG I THINK THIS IS
A DISTORTION OF THE MARKET. I IN
FACT I CREATES DISINCENTIVES ALL
ON CREATING NEW HOUSING WITH IN
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK IT
ACTUALLY EXACERBATE THE HOUSING
CRISES WITH OUR STATE. LET'S NOT
VIOLATE PROPERTY RIGHTS OF
PROPERTY OWNERS WITHIN
CALIFORNIA LET'S THE FAN THEM AN
INCREASE I ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
INVEST IN HOUSING IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. I URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK.
MISTER BLOOM WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
MISTER BLOOM LOOKED SO CALL
THE RULES COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING IMMEDIATELY IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE ROOM.
RULES COMMITTEE MEMBERS PLEASE
REPORT TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
ROOM
MEMBERS.
WE ARE MOVING BACK IN ORDER ON
THE FILE. ITEM ONE TWENTY SIX AB
TWENTY TO FORTY SEVEN MISTER
CLERK PLEASE THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO FORTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE FOSTER
YOUR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TO FORTY SEVEN.
WHICH WILL ENSURE FOSTER YOUTH
ARE NOT UNNECESSARILY MOVED FROM
ONE PLACE IT. TO THE OTHER.
THIS BILL CREATES A PROCESS FOR
PLACEMENT CHANGES AND REQUIRES.
SOCIAL WORKERS TO CREATE A PLAN.
WITH CONFLICT RESOLUTION
PRACTICES.
LET ME PAUSE
FOR A MOMENT.
IN THE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE.
WE HAD.
A YOUNG LADY.
TO COME AND TESTIFY.
WELL THIS BILL.
SHE WAS SIXTEEN YEARS OLD.
SHE'D ALREADY BEEN.
MOVE THIRTY TWO TIMES.
A FOSTER YOUTH BEING MOVED
THIRTY TWO TIMES.
THE LAST TIME.
THE SOCIAL WORKER CAME TO HER
HIGH SCHOOL.
BROUGHT THREE TRASH BAGS WOULD
HER BELONGINGS IN THIS.
IN THOSE TRASH BAGS.
THAT OUR SHOES.
SOME CLOTHES.
THIS IS A FOSTER YOU'VE.
AND THIS IS WHAT'S BEEN TAKING
PLACE OFF FOSTER YOU.
SHE TOLD THE COMMITTEE.
AT THAT TIME.
WHAT LITTLE DID THEY KNOW. THAT
YOU CANNOT PLACER FUTURE IN A
TRASH BAG.
YOU CANNOT MUFFLED HER VOICE
IN A TRASH BAG.
BECAUSE YOU CANNOT PLACE HER
FUTURE.
YOU CAN OPT PLACER HOPES AND
DREAMS IN A TRASH BAG.
FOR YOU TO BE PUT REAP MOVE FROM.
YOUR WHOLE THIRTY TWO TIMES
THERE'S NO STABILIZATION THERE.
THERE'S NO CONTINUITY.
YOU'RE BEING STRIPPED FROM ANY
FRIENDS OR FAMILIES YOU MAY HAVE
GATHERED ALONG THE WAY THAT'S
WHY THIS BILL IS IN PORT TO
CREATE. SUCH A STRUCTURE.
SO TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN IS A
SAFE AND THOUGHTFUL BUILD
DEVELOP BY YOUTH.
WHO ARE FOSTER YOUTH WHO HAVE
BEEN FOSTER YOU'VE
AND THAT BILL IS BEFORE US TODAY?
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED NO
OPPOSITION.
AND HAS RECEIVED A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN OUR RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHERE I VOTE ON ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TO FORTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I THINK YOU BETTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AYE AYE AYE RISE JUST AT
THE TO RAISE A POINT I I
UNDERSTAND THE THE RIGHTEOUSNESS
OF THE ISSUE. BUT I WOULD ALSO
OFFER TO YOU THAT YOU TALK TO
ANY ONE OF YOUR COUNTIES.
YOU TALK TO YOUR SOCIAL WORKERS
WORKING IN CPS.
AND YOU ASK THEM WHAT THEIR
CASELOADS ARE.
IT SHOULD BE ABOUT FIFTEEN TO
ONE.
OFTENTIMES IT'S A HUNDRED TO ONE.
SOCIAL WORKERS ARE UNDERPAID
OVERWORKED DON'T HAVE THE KIND
OF RESOURCES THEY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO SPEND THE TIME WITH KIDS
THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH FOSTER HOME
PLACEMENTS TO BE ABLE TO MOVE A
CHILD FROM ONE SAFE ENVIRONMENT
TO ANOTHER. THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
RESOURCES TO HELP THOSE FOSTER
THE BEHAVIORS THAT ARE FOSTER
YOUTH COME TO US AFTER THIRTY
TWO MOVES THERE'S A HUGE AMOUNT
OF TRAUMA THAT HAS OCCURRED IN
THAT CHILD'S LIFE. THAT THEY
NEED INCREDIBLE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES SO A SOCIAL GREW HAS
THAT CHILD WOULD NINETY NINE
OTHERS ON THEIR CASE LOAD IT IS
VERY DIFFICULT SO WELL I SUPPORT
THIS BILL I JUST THINK ADDING
MORE.
REQUIREMENTS FOR SOCIAL WORKERS
DOES NOT REALLY ADDRESS THE
UNDERLYING ISSUE OF THE LEVEL OF
POVERTY THAT EXIST IN OUR
DISTRICTS THAT CREATE A
OFTENTIMES.
ENVIRONMENTS FOR ABUSE TO OCCUR
BUT THAT IT IS FINE TO BE ABLE
TO SAY WE NEED TO DO MORE FOR
OUR FOSTER KIDS BUT IT WE CAN'T
ADDRESS THE RATIOS THAT
EVERYBODY HAS SAID WE'RE NOT
DOING RATIOS. FOR FOSTER KIDS
AND CPS WORKERS THEN WE ARE JUST
CREATING ANOTHER ISSUE I AM
COURAGE AYE VOTE ON THIS AND I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO THINK ABOUT WHO
WHO ARE PLACING THE BURDEN TO BE
ABLE TO DO MORE. WHEN THERE ARE
DOING A WHOLE LOT WITH WITH WITH
NOT MUCH THANK.
THANK YOU SEEING THAT NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A SURLY APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUE. OF FOR MAKING US
AWARE OF A GREATER NEED IN THAT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN THIS THIS
PARTICULAR AREA BUT UNTIL SUCH
TIME COMES WE ARE STILL HAVING
FOSTER YOU. BEING DRAMATICALLY
AFFECTED BY HAVING THEIR ENTIRE
LIVES STRIPPED AWAY MULTIPLE
TIMES WHERE THEY CAN NOW LONGER.
HAVE FRIENDS ON GO TO CHURCHES
AND WHICH OF THEIR FOSTER HOME
I'M IS IN THAT PARTICULAR
COMMUNITY THEY'RE BEING BOUNCED
AROUND MAKE IN THEIR TRAUMA
CONTINUES.
TO FASTER CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD AND SO THIS BILL HELPS
CREATE A CERTAINLY A STRUCTURE
WITH SOCIAL WORKERS.
HAVING THE INPUT TO PROVIDE A A
BENCHMARK.
BEFORE A CHILD IS ACTUALLY
BEING MOVED FROM ONE HOME TO THE
OTHER KEEP IN MIND THAT THE
CHILD HAS TO BE REMOVED FOR
SAFETY REASONS THEY STILL HAVE
THAT ABILITY TO DO THAT. ALL I'M
SAYING IS THAT WE SHOULD HAVE A
PROVIDE SOME KINDA STABILIZATION
STRUCTURE FOR CHILD TO GROW UP
JUST LIKE ALL OF OUR CHILDREN'S
HAVE THAT KIND OF ENVIRONMENT IN
OUR OWN HOMES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHAT I BOTH. A TWENTY TO FORTY
SEVEN.
NAMES GIPSON WITH THAT CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
I'M MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE.
TELEVOTE. AYE SIXTY TWO NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS ARE FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SIX
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO SEVENTY
SIX BY SOME REMEMBER BURKE
ANOTHER SNACK RELATE TO
INSURANCE.
MS BURKE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY SIX.
I AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SIX IS
THE RESULT OF MANY HOURS OF
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS OVER THE
PAST TWO YEARS THAT INCLUDED
POLICY AND FISCAL COMMITTEE
STAFF MEMBERS AND DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE AND ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES. AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY
SIX PROVIDE STATUTORY CERTAINTY
ON HOW AN INSURER WILL CONDUCT
ELABORATE SURVEY TO DETERMINE
THE PREVAILING AUTO BODY LABOR
RATE IN A SPECIFIC GEOGRAPHIC
LABOR MARKET.
LIBERATE SURVEYS ARE NOT
MANDATED BUT INSURANCE I DO CAN
TALK TO VOLUNTARY SURVEY USE IT
AS A TOOL FOR TWO MAJOR REASONS
THE FIRST TO FIGURE OUT WHAT A
FAIR PRICE TO PAY IN A LOCATION
FOR RUN OF THE MILL REPAIR JOBS
AND THE SECOND. TO PROVE TO THE
PART INSURANCE AN INSURER ACTED
FAIRLY IN THE EVENT AN AUTO BODY
REPAIR SHOP COMPLAINTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT.
AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY SIX
PROVIDES AN ALTERNATIVE
METHODOLOGY TO CONDUCT A
VOLUNTEER LABOR RATES SERVING.
PACIFIC LENA AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY SIX ADOPTS THE LOCAL
WORK DEVELOPMENT AREAS
ESTABLISHED BY THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT AS THE
LABOR MARKET OF AUTO BODY SHOPS.
THAT WOULD BE SURVEY BY THE
INSURER THERE WAS AN AMENDMENT
OUT OF ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH THE INTENT
LANGUAGE THAT WILL MAP.
THAT MAP WILL FURTHER BE DEFINED
THE BILL ALSO SPECIFIES THAT
ONLY QUALIFIED BODY SHOPS MAYBE
SURVEYED THAT SURVEY RESPONSES
SHOULD BE NOT INCLUDED ANY
DISCOUNTED RATES AND THE EXACT
QUESTIONS THAT MUST BE INCLUDED
ON EACH SERVING.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL REQUIRES
THAT CPAS
SPECIALTY REPAIR SHOP BE HANDLED
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS BETWEEN
THE INSURER AND THE AUTO BODY
SHOP.
A PREVAILING LABOR RATE
DETERMINED BY A SURVEY IS A
STARTING POINT OF THE
NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN AN AUTO
BODY SHOP AND THE INSURER. AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SIX STATES
THE PREVAILING AUTO BODY YOU
LABOR RATES SURVEYS RESULTS
SHALL NOT BE PRESUMED TO BE A
MAXIMUM OR MINIMUM. THAT SHOULD
BE PAID TO SETTLE A SPECIFIC
CLAIM IS SIMPLY A STARTING POINT
TO BEGIN NEGOTIATIONS.
AS A RESULT OF EXTENSIVE
NEGOTIATIONS A NEW CAR DEALERS
ARE NEUTRAL ON THE BILL AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
DISCUSSION FOR THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE.
NICHOLAS BERG MISTER DALY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AS A CO
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL I RISE IN
SUPPORT.
THIS BILL'S GOAL IS A FAIR
BALANCE BETWEEN WHAT BODY SHOPS
GET PAID TO FIX OUR CARS AND
WHAT INSURANCE POLICY
POLICYHOLDERS HAVE TO PAY IN
PREMIUMS. OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS THERE HAVE BEEN EXTENSIVE
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS AMONG ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES. THOSE
MEETINGS HAVE CERTAINLY BEEN
PRODUCTIVE THANKS TO THE AUTHOR
MISS BURKE.
THIS IS VERY VERY CHALLENGING
ISSUE AND MORE WORK REMAINS TO
BE DONE I'M CONFIDENT SHE WILL
FINISH OFF THIS.
THIS A CHALLENGING PROJECT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
COOLEY. YOUR RECOGNIZE.
COLLEAGUES ARE RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. IT IS LONG BEEN A
FEATURE OF CALIFORNIA'S
INSURANCE CO DATING BACK TO THE
EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS.
THAT INSURANCE COMMISSIONER JOB
IS TO.
ADMINISTERING.
THAT DEPARTMENT ACCORDS WITH
STATUTE.
SO THIS TAKES AN AREA WHERE
THERE'S BEEN SOME DISPUTE AND
PROVIDES CLEAR STATUTORY
GUIDANCE.
THIS IS VERY MUCH THE APPROACH
UNDER THE CODE GENERALLY IN
CALIFORNIA. THE LEGISLATURE
GIVES GUIDANCE TO THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER WHO THEN BECOMES A
CODE ADMINISTRATOR TAXI TWELVE
NINE TWENTY ONE A OF THE
CALAVERAS INSURANCE CODE WHICH
STATES. THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES
IT'S A VERY BASIC IDEA THAT IS
BEING CARRIED FOR IN THIS BILL.
ON OUTSTANDING MEASURE.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY SAYS
SUPPORT SUPPORT THE WIRES TO
PROFIT SIX.
MS BURKE.
OPEN THE ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON THEM AS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
ICE FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS ONE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM.
THIRTY SEVEN.
THAT'S AB TWENTY FIFTY SIX BY MR
EDUARDO GARCIA.
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIFTY SIX
BY SOME REMEMBERED WHAT OVERSEE
AN ACCOLADE A MOBILE HOME PARKS
IN MAKING AN APPROPRIATION THERE
FOR.
MR GARCIA.
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
THIS BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE
DEPARTMENT TO MAKE LOANS FROM
THE FUN. WE QUALIFIED NONPROFIT
HOUSING SPONSORED LOCAL PUBLIC
ENTITY TO ACQUIRE. OR
REHABILITATE MOBILE HOME PARK
WHERE NO LESS THAN THIRTY
PERCENT OF THE RESIDENTS ARE LOW
INCOME.
SPILL WOULD ALSO AUTHORIZED THE
DEPARTMENT MAKE GRANTS FROM THE
FUND TO A RESIDENT ORGANIZATION
OR NONPROFIT. HOUSING SPONSORED
TO ASSIST PARK RESIDENTS WOULD
NEEDED REPAIRS OR EIGHTY EIGHT.
DISABILITY REPAIRS RESPECTFULLY
ASK AYE BUT THIS IS A FIFTY FOUR
VOTE BILL.
DAVIS GARCIA SCENE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS SO. THAT A VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOR ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
MR GARCIA.
GARCIA MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR.
THIS IS AB TWENTY FIVE ELEVEN BY
MR CHOW.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE ELEVEN
BY SOME THE RIVER CHAO AND
ACTUALLY TO THE INTERNET.
MR CHOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH ON
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO START OFF BY STATING
THAT WE HAVE JUST REACHED AN
AGREEMENT. TO REMOVE THE
OPPOSITION OF AMAZON FACEBOOK
COUNTY.
INTERNET ASSOCIATION AND TECH
NET BY COMMITTING TO TAKE A
NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS WHEN THE
BILL REACHES.
SENATE.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE AS FOLLOWS.
NUMBER ONE REMOVING SECTION
EIGHT REGARDING SOCIAL MEDIA TO
APPLY TO ALL SELLERS SO LONG AS
IT DOES NOT WEAKEN CURRENTLAW.
THREE REASONABLE STEPS AT THE
POINT OF SALE OR UPON DELIVERY
FOR SAFE HARBOR DESCRIBING STEPS
THAT ARE PERCEIVED. REASONABLE
WHICH COULD ALSO BE USED AS
AFFIRMATIVE DEFENSE AND FIVE
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION TO JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY.
AND NOW THE BILL ITSELF
A RECENT CASE YOU ARE A NEWS
STORY DETAILED HOW A FOURTEEN
YEAR OLD BOY WAS ABLE TO
PURCHASE ONLINE BB GUNS THROWING
KNIVES AND A HUNTING KNIFE. ALL
WITHOUT HIS PARENTS CONSENT OR
KNOWLEDGE
THOSE ITEMS ARE ILLEGAL TO SELL
TO ANYONE UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN.
HOWEVER IN THIS SITUATION A
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD WAS ABLE TO
BUY THESE ITEMS BECAUSE. THERE
WAS NO CHECK TO SEE IF THE
PURCHASER WAS OVER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN.
THE BILL AB TWENTY FIVE ELEVEN
WOULD REQUIRE ONLINE RETAILERS.
YOU TAKE REASONABLE STEPS TO
ENSURE THE PURCHASER OF PRODUCTS
ILLEGAL TO SELL TO A MINOR IS OF
LEGAL AGE.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
NEIGHBORS SHOUT MR LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT I
AFTER HEARING A.
OF MY COLLEAGUE MY SEAT MATE
WITH RESPECT TO TAKING MANY OF
THE AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE
SECTION EIGHT TO BE.
DELETED THE BILL APPLY TO ALL
SELLERS AND MANY TO CLARIFY THAT
THE BILL APPLIES TO THE POINT OF
SALE OR UPON DELIVERY A SAFE
HARBOR DESCRIBING THE STEPS THAT
ARE PER SE REASONABLE. AND
FINALLY DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
TO JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
WITH THAT A COMMITMENT I
APPRECIATE OF THE AUTHORS.
STATEMENT IN THAT REGARD AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I'VE.
MRMEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
MISTER SPEAKER.
AS THE OLDEST MEMBER OF THE TECH
CAUCUS.
AND HEARING NOW THAT THE AUTHOR
HAS TAKEN.
.
THOSE.
A AMENDMENTS I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL.
THEY MISSED MEDINA MISTER I'M
SORRY THERE MAY BE A POINT OF
ORDER BY DR.
I'M THE OLDEST MEMBER THANK YOU.
CLERK WILL NOTE.
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
WAS GOING TO RISE IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL I'M VERY HAPPY THAT
THE AUTHORS TAKING AMENDMENTS
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE TO VOTE ON
THE BILL AND PRINCE ALBEIT
OPPOSITION TODAY. BUT I LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING AMENDMENTS
AND HOPEFULLY GET IN A POSITION
OF SUPPORT THE FUTURE.
FAMOUS OBERNOLTE
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
CORD BLOOD IN THE ROLE I'M EVER
SO.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO GO?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE ICE FORTY NINE KNOWS
THIRTEEN. THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO WITHOUT
OBJECTION MOVE TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM NUMBER. EIGHTY THREE THIS
IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY THREE AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY FIVE BY MISTER
KALRA THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
FIVE BY SIMPLY MEMBER KALRA AN
ACCOLADE HOME CARE SERVICES.
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
UP.
IS I BILL TWENTY FOUR TO DEFY
THE LAWS CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO PROVIDE
UPON REQUEST WERE SPECIFIED
THEY'VE ORGANIZATION. A RECORD
OF ONLY THE NAME AND PHONE
NUMBERS OF.
AND PHONE NUMBER OF NEWLY
REGISTERED TO REREAD XIN HOME
CARE AIDES.
THE BILL WOULD PROHIBIT A LABOR
ORGANIZATION FROM SHARING OR
USING THIS INFORMATION FOR ANY
PURPOSE OTHER THAN EMPLOYEE
TRAINING ORGANIZED
REPRESENTATION. AND ASSISTANCE.
LAST YEAR I AUTHORED AB FIFTEEN
THIRTEEN WHICH WAS VETOED BY THE
GOVERNOR BECAUSE OF THE CONCERN
THAT HOME CARE AIDES WERE
ALREADY IN THE SYSTEM WERE NOT
AWARE. OF OTHER INFORMATION
WOULD EVENTUALLY BE DISCLOSED OF
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS ARE
MAKING AB TWENTY FOUR OF. FIFTY
FIVE A PERSPECTIVE MEASURE THE
SHARES ONLY INFORMATION I'M
REALLY REGISTERING OR RE
REGISTERING HOME CARE AIDES AN
OPT OUT PROVISION ALLOWS ANY
HOMECARE AIDE TO CHOOSE NOT TO
PARTICIPATE.
AB TWENTY FORTY FIVE GRAMS HOME
CARE IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BENEFIT FROM TRAINING AND
ORGANIZE THAT MAY NOT BE READILY
AVAILABLE TO THEM. THESE
SERVICES CAN HELP HOME CARE
AIDES ADVANCE THEIR CAREERS
INCREASED LEVEL OF CARE THEY
PROVIDE THAT ARE INVALID UP TO
THE STATE SHOULD TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF HIS OUR AGING POPULATION
CONTINUES TO INCREASE.
ADDITIONALLY OB.
THIS IT PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY
PRICKLY FOR MANY OF THOUGH HOME
CARRY COMPANIES THAT MIGHT BE
STRUGGLING.
AT THIS TIME TO WORK. WITH
LABOR ORGANIZATIONS TO ENSURE
GOING FORWARD THAT THERE ARE
PROPER.
.
BOTH BURKE ISSUES THAT ARE DEALT
WITH AS WELL AS WELL AS OF
ISSUES REGARDING TIME LINES THAT
ALLOW FOR MORE OF OUR ELDERLY TO
HAVE CARE. THEN THE RESTRICTIONS
THAT CURRENTLY OF MIGHT EXIST
FROM THE STATE WITHOUT ARE
SIMPLY ASPIRIN AIBO.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA MISS.
MISS MILK THIS MELENDEZ.
IT'S GOMEZ BAKER.
MISS BAKER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
THIS BILL. IS ONE THAT GIVES
OUR CONSTITUENTS PRIVATE
INFORMATION OVER A TO A THIRD
PARTY. NOT TO PROTECT THEM BUT
TO ALLOW THE THIRD PARTY TO I'M
HAVE SPECIAL ACCESS SPECIAL
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT WITH
THEIR PRIVATE INFORMATION.
IN ORDER TO UNIONIZE AND WE
DON'T DO THAT FOR ANYTHING ELSE.
AND THERE ARE MANY PROVISIONS
THAT WE HAVE VOTED ON RECENTLY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE
PROVISIONS IN EMPLOYMENT
AGREEMENTS THAT ARE NOT FORCED
UPON EMPLOYEES IN THE NAME OF
HELPING THEM.
YET WITH THIS WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE GIVING AWAY
THEIR PRIVATE INFORMATION. AND I
BELIEVE
AND I THINK WE ALL SHOULD AGREE
THAT THE GOVERNMENT.
SHOULD HOLD ON TO THAT PRIVATE
INFORMATION AND NOT GIVE IT OUT.
UNLESS THERE IS A VERY NARROW
MOST PUBLIC HEALTH OR PUBLIC
SAFETY REASON AND IT'S
LEGITIMATE.
AND FAVORING ONE PARTICULAR USE
I AND MAKING.
OUR EMPLOYEES THE THE HEALTH
CARE AIDES HAVE TO OPT OUT IS
NOT A LEGITIMATE REASON IN
ADDITION THE PROVISIONS OF OPT
OUT THAT ARE IN THIS BILL ARE
VAGUE. LOTS OF OTHER LEGISLATION
THAT WE'VE SEEN BEFORE IS THAT
OPT OUT PROVISIONS THIS LACKS
ANY OF THOSE SPECIFICATIONS FOR
HOW THE OPT OUT HOUSE TO HAPPEN
IN BY NGUYEN. AND FINALLY YES
THE GOVERNOR DID VETO IT VERY
SIMILAR BILL LAST YEAR WAS GLAD
THAT HE DID THAT. AND WHILE THIS
MAKES THE REVIEW THIS MAKES IT
APPLY TO PROSPECT OF EMPLOYEES
IT'S ALSO FOR ANY WHO ARE GOING
TO BE RENEWING THEIR LICENSE SO
IT STILL COVERS ALL THE SAME
EMPLOYEES EVENTUALLY. THE LAST
YEAR'S VETO BILL COVERED WE
SHOULD BE MUCH MORE RESPECTFUL
OF THE PRIVATE INFORMATION OF
THESE HOMEMADE WORKERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
MS MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THE FIRST
ONE BEING WE'VE WHICH IS THE
ORGANIZATION THAT IS WORKING.
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE WITH RESPECT TO
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN A SEXUAL
ASSAULT VICTIMS IN ADDITION
CRIME SURVIVORS RESOURCE CENTER
ALLIANCE SUPPORTING PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES OPPOSED TO A
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SERVICES
ORGANIZATION. THERE'S A NUMBER
OF ORGANIZATIONS
AND.
I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
WHILE THIS BILL.
I BELIEVE ALLOWS FOR A MEMBER
TO OPT OUT.
.
REALLY IT SHOULD BE A SITUATION
WHERE YOU HAVE TO OPT IN.
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
AID DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIM
WHO IS STILL IN THE HOME WITH
HER ABUSER. AND THEN SHE STARTS
GETTING PHONE CALLS
FROM PEOPLE FROM THIS
ORGANIZATION BECAUSE HER NAME IS
ON THE LIST AND SHE FORGOT TO
OPT OUT YEAR DON'T YOU THAT
CAUSES HER GREAT HARM YOU PUT
HER IN A VERY. DANGEROUS
SITUATION TO TRY TO EXPLAIN HER
ABUSER NO I DIDN'T GIVE THAT MAN
MY PHONE NUMBER I DON'T KNOW HOW
WE GOT MY PHONE NUMBER.
THIS IS THIS IS NOT GOOD POLICY.
AT THE VERY LEAST.
IT SHOULD BE THAT THEY HAVE TO
OPTED NOT OPT OUT SO GIVEN THE
FACT THAT ALL OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL I WOULD URGE A NO VOTE.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
FIVE PRECISELY BECAUSE OF THE
CONCERN FOR THIS WOMEN BASED
WORKFORCE.
HOME CARE AIDES ARE MAJORITY. OF
WHOM ARE WOMEN WORK LONG HOURS
IN ISOLATED SETTINGS AND THEY'RE
IN A SITUATION WHERE THEY REALLY
CAN'T FIND OUT ABOUT THE RIGHTS.
THEY CAN'T FIND OUT ABOUT
ADEQUATE TRAINING AND SUPPORT
REPRESENTATION HOME CARE AIDES
CAN REALIZE OUR RIGHTS EXPRESS
THEIR FULL POTENTIAL TO CARE FOR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WHEN
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO PEOPLE WHO
CAN REPRESENT THEM.
THIS IS VERY CLEAR EVERY PERSON
AND I I THINK IT'S ALMOST
OFFENSIVE TO SUGGEST THAT A
WORKER CAN'T FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MARK THE OPT OUT PROVISION IF
THEY ARE IN A DANGEROUS
SITUATION.
WHILE I RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE
THAT SOME PEOPLE DO NOT WANT
THEIR PHONE NUMBER IN NAME GIVEN
TO A UNION. THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO DO IN FACT A BASS
MAJORITY OF OUR HOME HEALTH CARE
WORKERS THIS IS NOT PERSPECTIVE
NOBODY AUTOMATICALLY GETS PUT ON
THE REGISTRY. ANYTIME BEFORE
THERE'D THEIR NAME AND THEIR
PHONE NUMBER IS GIVEN OUT
THEY'LL HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
OPT OUT I'M SORRY BUT THERE IS
NO OTHER WAY TO ENSURE.
THAT OUR HOME HEALTHCARE WORKERS
CAN UNDERSTAND AND FULLY UTILIZE
THEIR RIGHTS AT WORK WHICH ARE
VERY ISOLATED WORKPLACE WITHOUT
THIS PROVISION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MISTER SANTIAGO YOUR RECOGNIZE.
I WOULDN'T WANT TO REPEAT WHAT
MY COLLEAGUES SIDE.
I AND I RISE IN SUPPORT. BUT I
WANT TO BE VERY VERY CLEAR.
THIS BILL HAS HAS.
HAS GOTTEN OUT OF THIS HOUSE
FOR THE MOST CLOSE TO FIFTY
VOTES.
AND THIS IS THE MORE WATERED
DOWN VERSION OF IT.
SIMPLY ONLY ALLOWS FOR THE NAME.
AND TELEPHONE NUMBER AN EMPLOYEE
CAN OPT OUT AND LET'S BE VERY
VERY CLEAR IF THERE ARE FILLING
THIS OUT AT WORK.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE REMINDED
PLENTY OF TIMES
BY THEIR EMPLOYER TO OPT OUT.
AND IN FACT
I WOULD VENTURE TO SAY THEY'D BE
CAMPAIGN FROM THE EMPLOYER. TO
REQUEST AN EMPLOYED OPT OUT SO
THAT SHOULD BE A CONCERN.
BEGIN WITH.
IT'S I RESPECTFULLY WOULD ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
UNDERSTANDING THAT ALL THE
PROVISIONS IN THERE FOR A FOR
SAFETY ARE INCLUDED MEANING A
PERSON CAN OPT OUT.
AND IT'S A MUCH SIMPLER BILL
THAT WOULD SEEK TO ADDRESS THE
VETO MESSAGE
THANK YOU.
SAY NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE MISTER KALRA YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR RISING IN SUPPORT.
AS INDICATED THIS IS A MORE
NARROW VERSION THAT THAT.
PASSED LAST YEAR AND AGAIN THE
PRIMARY CONCERN RAISED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS THE
PROSPECT VERSE RETROACTIVE
NATURE THAT HAS BEEN ADDRESSES
SO ANYONE THAT'S CURRENTLY ON
THE REGISTRY WILL NOT. I HAVE
ANY.
WILL HAVE NOT THEIR NAME AND
PHONE NUMBER DISCLOSE JUST UP
GOING FORWARD WHEN THEY RE
REGISTER THE HARD OPTION TO OPT
AND WITH NEW EDITIONS THE HARD
OPTION AS WELL TO OPT OUT AND
I'LL JUST SAY LOOK.
AS MENTIONED BY MY COLLEAGUE OF
SAN DIEGO THIS IS A WORK FORCE
THAT IS PRIMARILY WOMEN. OF THAT
BASS RAMPANT WAGE THAT THAT WORK
IN ISOLATION THEY PAY SEXUAL
ASSAULT. ARE THEN THEY FACE POOR
TRAINING IN AYE IN MANY CASES
SOME CASES THEY DON'T. FOR THOSE
THAT DO SEEK THE OPPORTUNITY OF
MY TO HAVE A BETTER TRAINING TO
HAVE REPRESENTATION I'D TO HAVE
SOMEONE THEY CAN GO TO THIS IS
AN OPTION FOR THEM.
AND I THINK THAT WHEN WE SEE
FOLKS THAT.
PICK AND CHOOSE WHAT THEY WANT
TO STAND UP FOR WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE I THINK IT REALLY.
BRINGS TO LIGHT THE HYPOCRISY OF
WHETHER WORK WE REALLY HAVE
FOLKS
I THAT ARE FULLY COMMITTED TO
EVERY ASPECT OF WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE PARTICULARLY THOSE
THAT ARE LOW WAGE WORKERS THAT
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY.
ON A ONE ON ONE BASIS WORKING
IN ISOLATION SPEAK UP FOR
THEMSELVES BUT THROUGH
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO NOT JUST HAVE
REPRESENTATION BUT HAVE TRAINING.
OF THAT IS WORTHY OF THE WORK
THEY'RE DOING IN CARING FOR OUR
ELDERLY AND OUR SENIORS WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA AND
WITHOUT.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO THOUGH?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE. AND TALLY
THE VOTE ICE FORTY ONE.
NOS TWENTY EIGHT
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS IT IS FIVE OH FIVE.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A THIRTY
MINUTE BREAK FOR DINNER. THIS IS
RECESS UNDER CALL THE SPEAKER
DEMOCRATS WILL BE IN THE CAUCUS
ROOM.
REPUBLICANS WILL BE IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE ROOM THIS IS A THIRTY
MINUTE RECESS.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO RETURN
TO THE FLOOR AT FIVE THIRTY FIVE
FIVE THIRTY FIVE PM TO RESUME
BUSINESS ON THE FLOOR
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN SESSION.
I WOULD ASK THAT MEMBERS.
PLEASE BEGIN RETURNING TO THE
FLOOR.
WE STILL HAVE OVER FORTY ITEMS.
TO DISPENSE WITH A NUMBER OF
BILLS ON CALL.
PLEASE RETURN OF FLOOR AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE SO WE MAY RESUME THE
BUSINESS OF THE HOUSE
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN TO THE
FLOOR WE ARE GOING TO RESUME
BUSINESS
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
TAKING UP BUSINESS.
IMMINENTLY.
WE ARE WITHOUT OBJECTION GOING
TO BE MOVING TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINETY THREE.
I BELIEVE DOCTOR ARAMBULA IS
READY TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
NINETY THREE. WHICH IS AB.
TWENTY SIX FORTY NINE I WOULD
ASK THAT MEMBERS RETURNED TO THE
FLORENCE IN AS POSSIBLE.
DOCTOR RAYMOND IS GOING TO
PRESENT THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX FORTY
NINE BY SOME REMEMBER ARAMBULA
AN ACCOLADE TO WATER.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
TODAY I PRESENT AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY NINE.
THIS BILL HAS BEEN AMENDED AND I
HAVE WORKED HARD TO GET TO THIS
POINT.
AND JUST AS WE HAVE WORKED TO
REMOVE THE OPPOSITION FROM THE
LOCAL WATER AGENCIES.
I AM COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS WHO HAVE
SHARED CONCERN AND HAVE SET UP A
MEETING FOR NEXT WEEK IF THIS
BILL IS ABLE TO GET OFF THE
FLOOR HERE TODAY.
AB TWENTY SIX FORTY NINE HAS TWO
PARTS.
THE FIRST PART CODIFIES INTO LAW
WOULD GOVERNOR BROWN INCLUDED IN
THE EXECUTIVE IN HIS EXECUTIVE
ORDER. DURING THE WORST OF THE
DROUGHT.
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER CREATED A
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAY TEMPORARY
WATER.
RIGHT PERMITS.
IT DIRECTS THE STATE WATER BOARD
TO PRIORITIZE TEMPORARY WATER
RIGHT PERMITS FOR PROJECTS THAT
ENHANCE THE ABILITY OF LOCAL OR
STATE AGENCIES.
TO CAPTURE HIGH RUNOFF FOR
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE.
THE GOAL OF THESE PERMITS
IS TO CAPTURE HIGH PRECIPITATION
EVENTS
AND TO STORE WATER UNDERGROUND
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE FLOW OUT
INTO THE OCEAN.
UNDER TWENTY SIX FORTY NINE THE
DIVERSION OF WATER. FOR
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE WOULD BE
CONSIDERED A BENEFICIAL USE.
WE WILL NEED EVERY TOOL IN ORDER
FOR CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED
BASINS.
BECOME COMPLIANCE TO THE
UPCOMING IMPLEMENTATION
DEADLINES. OF THE SUSTAINABLE
GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT ACT.
MANY COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE ARE FACING CHALLENGES OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGMA.
ALTHOUGH AB TWENTY SIX FORTY
NINE WILL DEMONSTRATE OR
STATEWIDE COMMITMENT TO MEETING
SUSTAIN ABILITY UNDER SIGMA. IT
WILL ALSO HELP THOSE WHO ARE
SUFFERING THE MOST.
LIKE MANY.
WHO LIVE IN THE SMALL TOWNS IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WITHIN
MY DISTRICT?
THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
KIRK LIBERAL.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOUGH?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT
ICE FORTY THREE NO SIX A MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WERE GOING TO
MOVE TO.
TAKE UP FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE.
THAT'S MR MCCARTY.
AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER MCCARTY
ANOTHER PERSON THAT RELATE TO
HEALING ARTS.
IT'S MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS
ANOTHER MEASURE THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON THIS YEAR DEALING
WITH THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC. AND
THE GOAL OF THIS MEASURE IS
SIMPLE TO GET MORE DOCTORS AND
PHYSICIANS ACROSS CALIFORNIA TO
TREAT THOSE ADDICTED.
TWO OPIOIDS WITH A MEDICALLY
ASSISTED TREATMENT KNOWING IT
THIS IS REALLY WHAT'S OUT
WORKING OUT THERE TO GET PEOPLE
TO TO.
.
TO GET RID OF THEIR ADDICTION
HOW THIS WOULD HAVE POSITIONS
INSURGENTS COMPLETE.
ONE OUR OF ONE TIME CONTINUE
EDUCATION A COURSE ON THE
TREATMENT OF OPIOID DID THAT
DEPENDENT.
PATTON SPECIFICALLY ON ABOUT
OPTIONS RELATE TO MEDICALLY
ASSISTED TREATMENT THE REALITIES
IF YOU GO TO AN E. ARE TODAY
WITH A BROKEN FOOT. YOU CAN WALK
OUT WITH THE PRESCRIPTION FILLED
WITH PAIN KILLERS
THE FEATHER INDIVIDUAL GOES ANY
ARE ITS ADDICTED. TO HEROIN OR
OPIOIDS THINK IT'S THE SAME
DOCTOR IN THOSE DOCTORS DON'T
ALWAYS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TREAT THAT PERSON WITH MEDICALLY
ASSISTED. TREATMENTS
AND SO THIS WOULD ENABLE OUR ONE
HOUR COURSE FOR PEOPLE ON THE
CONTINUING EDUCATION TO BRIEF
THEM. AND GET THEM ENGAGED IN
OPTIONS.
OTHER THAN PROVIDING A PAIN
KILLERS FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THIS TRAINING WOULD COUNT
TOWARDS THE REQUIRED FIFTY HOURS.
OF CONTINUED EDUCATION FOR
PHYSICIANS DO WANT TO NOTE THAT
AFTER THE LAST COMMITTEE HEARING
WE WORKED WITH SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION BY A CALM TO REMOVE
THEIR OPPOSITION'S. EVER
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE CMA
ANOTHER POSITION GROUPS
AND IDEAS TO FURTHER IMPROVE
THIS MEASURE AS IT GOES ALONG TO
THE SENATE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
MISS WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AYE RISES A PROUD COAUTHOR OF
AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN.
OPIOID DEPENDENCE HAS BECOME A
LEADING FORM OF DRUG ABUSE IN
THE UNITED STATES AND DRUG
OVERDOSES HAVE BECOME THE NUMBER
ONE CAUSE OF ACCIDENTAL DEATH.
IN OUR COUNTRY.
DESPITE THE INCREASING SUCCESS
OF MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENTS FOR OPIOID ABUSE LESS
THAN TWO PERCENT OF CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL PROVIDERS ARE CERTIFIED.
TO PRESCRIBE THIS TYPE OF
TREATMENT.
SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT ACCESS THE
BEST WAY TO INCREASE ACCESS IS
TO GET MORE PROVIDER CERTIFIED
SO THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY TREAT
THIS EPIDEMIC AND HELP OUR FOLKS
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AREAS. WHERE?
MATH IS ONE OF THE BEST USE DUH
REMEDIES FOR FIGHTING THE
EPIDEMIC.
AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN WILL
HELP WITH THIS LACK OF ACCESS BY
REQUIRING DOCTORS TO BECOME
CERTIFIED.
TO PRESCRIBE THESE LIFESAVING
DRUGS THANK YOU AND I URGE AND I.
THEY MISS WALDRON DOCTOR WOULD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AYE AYE I'M PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AB TWO TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY SEVEN IT'S ESTIMATED THAT
NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS BETWEEN THE AGES OF
TWENTY AND SIXTY NINE HAVE A
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER. AND MAY
REQUIRE MEDICALLY ASSISTED
TREATMENT TO GET WELL.
AS WE KNOW THESE NUMBERS ARE
GROWING. MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS IS
DESPERATELY NEEDED AND IT IS
QUICKLY EVOLVING THIS BILL SEEKS
TO FURTHER EDUCATE ARE
PHYSICIANS. SO THEY MAY BETTER
SERVE OUR FAMILY AND FRIENDS AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THAT WOULD.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE WRONG TIVA. AT FORTY ONE
KNOWS ELEVEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. BANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THERE IS A COMMITTEE
REPORT AT THE DESK I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO HAVE THE
COMMITTEE REPORT DEEMED READ.
AND TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
SIXTY THREE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
TO TAKE UP AB TWENTY FIFTY FIVE
TODAY WITHOUT REFERENCE FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
CALDERON YOU ARE AGAIN RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY
NINE BE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
JONES SAWYER TAKE UP LATE
AMENDMENTS TO ITEM NINETY NINE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN OR SIX.
AND MISS WALDRON.
WE OPPOSE THAT MOTION.
MISS WALDRON IS WITHHOLDING THIS
IS A RULE SUSPENSION MOVED BY.
MISTER CALDERON AND SECONDED BY
MISTER GIBSON.
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE.
CORD BLOOD NO ROLL-ON CALDERON
ASKING FOR NYE MISS WALDRON AND
NO.
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR IT AYE.
IS WALDRON AND NO.
ON THE RULES SUSPENSION.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL EYES FORTY FOUR
KNOWS TWENTY THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP.
MISTER JONES SAWYER IS
AMENDMENTS THIS IS ITEM NINETY
NINE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN OH SIX.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
CLERK WILL READ.
WITH AMENDMENTS.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY SEVEN OH SIX
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME
MEMORABLE JONES SAWYER MISS
JONES SAWYER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS FOR AB TWENTY SEVEN
NO SIX THESE AMENDMENTS ARE
TECHNICAL IN NATURE MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU AYE
VOTE.
THEY MISS JONES SAWYER.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT TO PRINTER.
YOU MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED IN
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE SEVEN
SEVEN POINT TWO I RE REFERRING
TWENTY SEVEN OF SIX.
TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
AND NOW MEMBERS WERE GOING TO
MOVE TO TAKE UP.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP.
MR LEVIN'S AB TWENTY FIFTY FIVE
WITHOUT REFERENCE
FILE.
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIFTY FIVE BY SOME
REMEMBER LEVINE AN ACT RELATING
TO LEGISLATIVE ETHICS.
MICHELINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AB TWENTY FIFTY
FIVE REQUIRES LOBBYISTS TO TAKE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT TRAINING.
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL IRIS PERSPECTIVE OUT FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THE MISSILE MAIN SCENE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE TO
GO.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTES EYES SIXTY TWO NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS A CORRECTION ON MY
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO.
REFERRAL. THE REFERRAL IS TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE
NOT TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE.
THAT'S MISTER JONES SAWYER SIDE
OF
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
FILE ITEM SIXTY EIGHT. A. B.
THIRTY TWO TWENTY TWO BY MISTER
O'DONNELL.
FILE ITEM.
SIXTY EIGHT THIRTY TO TWENTY TWO
A. B. THIRTY TWO TWENTY TWO
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TWO TWENTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL
ACCOLADE PUBLIC WORKS MISTER
O'DONNELL.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB THIRTY
TWO TWENTY TWO DEFINES PUBLIC
WORKS TO INCLUDE CHARTER SCHOOL
FACILITY PROJECTS.
THAT RECEIVE FUNDING THROUGH
CONDUIT REVENUE BONDS.
THIS WOULD ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK ON THESE
PROJECTS RECEIVE PREVAILING WAGE
AND ALLOW THEM TO BENEFIT FROM A
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS.
CONDUIT REVENUE BOND IS
FINANCING COORDINATED BY A
PUBLIC ENTITY SUCH AS THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FINANCING
AUTHORITY UNDER THE TREASURER'S
OFFICE.
THE STATE LOSES REVENUE ON THES
BONDS AS INVESTORS DO NOT PAY
TAXES INTERNED THE BORROWER
BENEFITS BY RECEIVING LOWER
INTEREST.
UNDER EXISTING LAW CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITIES THAT ARE
FUNDED BY STATE BONDS ARE
REQUIRED TO COMPLY. WITH
SURVEILLING WAGE AND. HIGHER
CONSTRUCTION STANDARDS UNDER THE
FIELD ACT.
PROJECTS THAT ARE FUNDED WITH
CONDUIT. UP BONDS HOWEVER DO NOT.
WE MUST ENSURE THAT THOSE
WORKING ON THE STATE'S SUBSIDIZE
DOT PROJECTS ARE SKILLED AND
QUALIFIED.
IS A POLICY THAT KEEPS GIVING.
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS WHICH HAS A PROVEN
PROVEN IMPACT ON OUR ECONOMY.
THIS BILL IS MODELED AFTER A
SIMILAR BILL THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED JUST A FEW YEARS AGO.
DEFINING PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS
TO INCLUDE GENERAL ACUTE CARE
HOSPITALS ALSO FUNDED BY CONDUIT
BOND.
CONDUIT REVENUE BONDS ARE
STRICTLY ASTRONAUT.
THEY MITCHELL DONALD MISTER
HARPER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AS A
FORMER SCHOOL BOARD TRUSTEE I
FEEL IS VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
KEEP FUNDING IN THE CLASSROOM TO
BENEFIT ALL OF OUR STUDENTS.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL WILL
TAKE FUNDING AWAY FROM THE
STUDENTS OF CHARTER SCHOOLS BY
FORCING CHARTER SCHOOLS.
TO HAVE CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS BE
SUBJECT FAILING WEIGHT
REQUIREMENTS FUNDING FOR
TEACHERS LEARNING MATERIALS AND
OTHER EDUCATIONAL SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS WILL BE REDUCED BECAUSE
IT IS AS VIEW. BECAUSE IT IS A
ZERO SUM GAME.
A CONDUIT BONDS AT THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS USE TO FINANCE PROJECTS
ARE NOT PUBLICLY FINANCED AND
SHOULD NOT BE SUBJECT TO THE
PREVAILING WAGE REQUIREMENTS.
STATE COSTS FOR ADMINISTERING A
PROCESSING THESE BONDS ARE
INCLUDED IN THE COST OF THE
BORROWER IN THE STATE IS NOT
LIABLE FOR ANY DEFAULT.
THIS BILL IS NOTHING MORE THAN
AN ATTACK ON THE SUCCESS OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN ORDER TO PAD
THE POCKETBOOKS OF UNIONS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NOVO
ON THIS BILL.
YOUR HARPER.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER O'DONNELL YOU
MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH.
AS ONE OF THE CLERK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS.
RYSZARD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AND ABOUT
CLERK WILL CLOSER ON TIED ABOUT
ICE FORTY TWO KNOWS EIGHTEEN
THAT MEASURE HOUSES.
MEMBERS WHEN I MOVED TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO THIS IS.
AB TWENTY SIX OH EIGHT BY MR
STONE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX AWAY BY
SOME REMEMBER MARK STONE AN
ACCOLADE HEALTH PROFESSIONS.
MR STARR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
FOSTER YOU LEAD A DIFFICULT LIFE
AND THE SUICIDE RATES THE DRUG
ABUSE RATES THE NEGATIVE
OUTCOMES ARE FAIRLY PREVALENT
WITH THEM.
BUT THERE'S ALSO A TREND THAT A
LOT OF FORMER FAST YOUTH ARE
INTERESTED IN AND THAT IS
GETTING BACK INTO THE SYSTEM.
TO BE SOCIAL WORKERS GOING TO
GRADUATE SCHOOL AND THEN HELPING
OTHER FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND
OTHERS IN THE SYSTEM.
THERE'S AN EXISTING PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES GRANTS TO FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH PRIORITIZING FORMER FOSTER
YOU.
WE GIVE THEM A LITTLE BIT OF A
LIFT AND SOME MONEY TO HELP THEM
WITH GRADUATE SCHOOL.
WHAT AB TWENTY SIX AWAY DOES
EXPAND THAT PROGRAM TO REACH
JUST A FEW MORE OF THOSE FORMER
FOSTER YOU?
THERE HAD BEEN SOME OPPOSITION
WHO WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
THIS WAS JUST FOR FORMER FOSTER
YOU. SAW THE TAKING AMENDMENTS
IN THE SENATE TO EXPAND IT TO
KIDS AT RISK. WITH SOME
PREFERENCES TO FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH BECAUSE YOU KNOW THAT IS
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'M VERY
VERY INTERESTED IN.
AS WELL AS WE WERE ASKING FOR. A
A TEN DOLLAR BI ANNUAL FEE WHICH
IS WHICH WOULD BE FIVE DOLLARS A
YEAR WERE GOING TO DROP THAT TO
TWO DOLLARS AND FIFTY CENTS A
YEAR. AS THE FEE THAT WILL BE
CHARGING ON THIS BILL SO WHERE.
WERE KIND OF ROLLING BACK THE
PROGRAM A LITTLE BIT BUT GETTING
THE BENEFIT OF REACHING OUT TO
MORE FORMER FOSTER YOUTH TO GET
THEM ENGAGED GO TO GRADUATE
SCHOOL. AND BE A PART OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND WITHOUT I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTES.
THINGS STONE.
Z. NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR STONE MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL. ON FILE ITEM NINETY.
CB TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN BY
MISTER KALRA CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
MEMBERS WHEN I MOVED TO FILE
ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN.
THAT IS AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
SEVEN.
MY DOCTOR ARAMBULA CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE NINETY
SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER ARAMBULA
ANOTHER PERSON ACCOLADE TO THE
UNIVERSITY SERVED POPULATIONS IN BOTH.
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND URBAN
AREAS.
BY COMBINING SPECIALIZED
COURSEWORK
STRUCTURING CLINICAL
EXPERIENCING ADVANCING
INDEPENDENT STUDY AND MENTORING.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA HAS A LACK
OF ROBUST PRIMARY CARE WORK
FORCE.
DURING MY TIME AS AN EMERGENCY
ROOM DOCTOR I SAW FIRST HAND THE
SHORTAGE OF MEDICAL DOCTORS IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
THIS INCREASE IN THE ENROLLMENT
OF MEDICAL STUDENTS IN PRIME
WILL ENSURE THAT WE ARE JUST NOT
JUST SUPPORTING THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE.
BUT REMOVING BARRIERS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR STUDENTS OF COLOR
WITHIN THE MEDICAL FIELD.
AND PARTICULARLY THROUGH PRIME
WILLIAM WE WILL BE ABLE TO SERVE
THE NEEDS OF THE UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS WHO ARE AT GREATEST
RISK.
I URGE YOU ALL TO JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING THIS BILL SO WE CAN
INVEST IN OUR STATE'S HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE AND WORK TOWARDS
A HEALTHIER CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU AND I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW THE VOTE
I SIXTY FOUR KNOWS ZERO I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ON THE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO REFERRAL.
ON TWENTY SEVEN NO SIX THE
COMMITTEE IS THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO RETURN
TO FILE ORDER.
WE HAVE A FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
EIGHT.
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY EIGHT.
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY THREE.
BY MISS REYES CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO NINETY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAY AS
AN ACCOLADE TO EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES.
MS RACE YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I PRESENT TO YOU AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY THREE WHICH REDUCES
BARRIERS FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE ALREADY SERVED THEIR TIME.
TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
EMPLOYMENT THAT REQUIRES AN EMT
LICENSE.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA HAS NEARLY
EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE WITH
CRIMINAL RECORDS THAT IS ONE IN
EVERY FIVE CALIFORNIANS.
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY PERCENT OF
ALL JOBS IN OUR STATE REQUIRE AN
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSE.
MANY OF THESE LICENSES HAVE
REGULATIONS WHICH IMMEDIATELY
DISQUALIFY ANYONE WITH A PRIOR
CONVICTION REGARDLESS OF THE
DEGREE HOW LONG AGO THE
CONVICTION WAS.
OR ANY TYPE OF REHABILITATION
COMPLETED.
IT HAS BEEN SHOWN THAT THE BEST
MEASURE AGAINST RECIDIVISM IS
GETTING A JOB TO SUPPORT
YOURSELF AND YOUR FAMILY.
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY THREE
ADDRESSES A LICENSING FOR EMTS.
AND SIX TO PROVIDE THE PATH. FOR
MEMBERS OF OUR CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION QUICK CAMPS.
WHERE APPROXIMATELY FOUR
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED INMATES
WITH NON VIOLENT CONVICTIONS
HAVE VOLUNTEERED TO BATTLE FIRES
AND DO WORK TOWARDS OUR
CONSERVATION EFFORTS?
TO HELP THEM TO BE ELIGIBLE.
GET THE REQUIRED LICENSES TO USE
THEIR SKILLS
THAT THEY HAVE LEARNED ONCE THEY
ARE NO LONGER INCARCERATED.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO APPLY TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO MEET THE
CRITERIA SET OUT IN THE LANGUAGE
OF THE BILL.
AND THOSE WHO HAVE ALSO
DEMONSTRATED. CONSIDERABLE
REHABILITATION.
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY THREE SIX
TO PROVIDE FAIRNESS
IN THIS PROCESS Y. NOT
CONTINUING TO PENALIZE SOMEONE
LONG AFTER THEY HAVE PAID THEIR
DEBT TO SOCIETY. AND ARE SIMPLY
TRYING TO RETURN TO BEING A
PRODUCTIVE MEMBER OF SOCIETY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THE US RESPONSE CREEL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY THREE US BOTH
A CO AUTHOR AND A SOMEONE WHO
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE OF.
MEASURES OUR STATE NEEDS TO
IMPLEMENT IN ORDER TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY HOMEBOY INDUSTRIES
WHICH IS LOCATED IN MY DISTRICT.
THEY'RE SAYING IS NOTHING STOPS
A BULLET LIKE A JOB.
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY THREE WILL
REMOVE LICENSING BARRIERS FOR
MANY CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
ALREADY BEEN WORKING IN THE
FIELD FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
WELLING CAR INCARCERATED AS WELL
AS REDUCING THESE OVERLY
RESTRICTIVE BARRIERS. THAT HAVE
PREVENTED OTHER QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS
WE SHOULDN'T LET A SINGLE
SENTENCE BECOME A LIFE SENTENCE.
THE INCREASED ABILITY TO GAIN
EMPLOYMENT WILL HELP TO LOWER
RECIDIVISM RATES AND WILL HELP
MAKE OUR COMMUNITY SAFER AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CREEL SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM THIS REISSUE MAY CAUSE
IF YOU WISH.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
OR CULTURAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE
LOCAL CLOSER ALL TIE VOTE I
FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY THREE
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS AND FILE ORDER THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY NINE AB
TWENTY THREE. SEVENTEEN DOCTOR
EGGMAN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
SEVENTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER
EGGMAN OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO
EMPLOYMENT. DOCTOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTEEN EXTENDS WHISTLEBLOWER
PROTECTIONS TO THOSE A. PATIENT
MIGHT ADVOCATES WORKING WITH THE
MENTAL MENTALLY ILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IBOOK.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN SEEING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
IN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
SORRY ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
HAVE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ROLE TALLY
VOTE.
I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY IS AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY FOUR CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY RULE TWENTY THREE
THIRTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
THURMAN AN ACCOLADE TO
EMPLOYMENT.
MR THURMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
A RICE PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY FOUR. OF THIS IS A BILL
THAT DEALS WITH A WORKPLACE
INJURIES AND ILLNESSES.
THE BILL ALLIANCE WITH RECENT
FEDERAL ACTIVITY.
TO REQUIRE EMPLOYERS
TO PROVIDE ELECTRONIC
SUBMISSIONS.
OF ILLNESS AND INJURY OUR
RECORDS.
THIS BILL WOULD TRIGGER A NEW
LAW SHOULD THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT MOVED AWAY FROM SUCH
A PRACTICE AND WOULD REQUIRE.
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS TO DO THE
SAME.
ON BEHALF OF KEEPING OUR
WORKFORCE SAFE AND AT WORK I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MISTER THURMAN SAYING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
CLARK WELL CLOSER OLD TOWN ABOUT
ICE FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY ONE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY ONE S AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY SIX CORPORAL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
THIRTY SIX BY SOME A MEMBER
SALAS AN ACT RELATING TO
VEHICULAR AIR POLLUTION.
MISTER SALAS HE MAY OPEN.
THEY WERE SPEAKER MEMBERS I
LISTA RIGHT BY OUR KIDS MEASURE
RETROFITS REPLACES THE OLD
SCHOOL.
BUSES FOR KIDS SO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE.
I THINK IT WAS SOUTH SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE CORP LOCAL
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE ON.
BUT THIS
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE CLERK WELL?
CLOSER ROLLINS HIVE ON ICE FORTY
FOUR KNOWS TEN THAT MEASURE
PASSED
.
MEMBERS AND FILE ORDER FILE ITEM
THREE THIRTY EIGHT.
BY MISTER LIVING CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER
THE PAIN OF ACCOLADE ITALO
AGENCIES.
MR LIVING THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT REQUIRES TALENT
AGENCIES TO MAKE EDUCATIONAL
MATERIALS ABOUT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT NUTRITION. AND EATING
DISORDERS AVAILABLE TO THEIR
ARTISTS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THEY MISS LEVINE SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLUB CLUB IN
THE ROLE ON MEMBERS FOUND SARAH
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED THE SENATE
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY THREE IS AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY TWO BY MISS BURKE
THE CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE FORTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE
ANOTHER PERSON ACCOLADE CANCER.
THIS BURKE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
PRIORITY BILL REQUIRING HEALTH
PLANS INSURANCE AND D. H. C. AS
TO COVER BREAST AND OVARIAN
CANCER PREVENTION
RECOMMENDATIONS. AS MADE BY THE
U. S. PREVENTIVE SERVICES TAX
FORMS IS IMPERATIVE THAT ALL
HIGH RISK WOMEN EVEN THOSE
WITHOUT SYMPTOMS OR DIAGNOSIS OF
BREAST OR OVARIAN CANCER BE
IDENTIFIED IN GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE
SCREENINGS. COUNSELING AND
TESTING AS RECOMMENDED BY THE U.
S. PREVENTIVE SERVICES TASK
FORCE ESPECIALLY GIVEN THAT
WOMAN OF COLOR ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY DYING DUE TO
THE OBSTACLES. TO RECEIVING
HEALTHCARE SERVICES RELATED TO
PREVENTION EARLY DETECTION AND
HIGH QUALITY TREATMENT.
UNDERSTAND PATIENTS RISK FOR
DEVELOPING BREAST OR OVARIAN
CANCER CAN ARM THE PATIENT AND
THEIR MEDICAL TEAM WITH
APPROPRIATELY WATCH FOR AND
PREVENT NEW CASES OF CANCER. AS
WELL AS SIGNIFY SIGNIFICANTLY
ALTERING CANCER TREATMENT IF A
PATIENT SHOULD DEVELOP CANCER.
SEVERAL OTHER STATES HAVE
ALREADY ENACTED SIMILAR
LEGISLATION CALIFORNIANS WOMEN
ESPECIALLY THOSE AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES ARE THE SAME
PROTECTIONS AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY TWO ENJOYS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND CO AUTHORS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK GOODNESS BURKE MISS
WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AYE RISES OF PROUD JOINT
AUTHOR OF AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
TWO.
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO IS A
VITAL BILL FOR THE HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIA WOMEN IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT ALL WOMEN RECEIVED THE
GENETIC TESTING AND COUNSELING.
THAT THEY NEED.
BREAST AND OVARIAN CANCER. DOES
NOT DISCRIMINATE IT DOES NOT
CARE WHETHER RICH OR POOR IT
DOES NOT CARE WHAT YOUR
POLITICAL VIEWS ARE AYE URGENT
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CARPOOL OPEN THE WRONG. ON
MEMBERS OF THE SITE VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
THOUGH.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL ANTI ABOUT AYE SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY FOUR AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY THREE BY MISTER DAVID CHIU
CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY THREE FORTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVID
CHIU INOCULATED REAL PROPERTY AS
YOU KILL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
THREE ADDRESSES SEVERAL
IMBALANCES IN THE TENANT NOTICED
AN EVICTION PROCESS.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT WERE IN THE
MIDST NOT JUST OF A HOUSING
CRISIS BUT ATTENDING CRISIS AND
AN ADDICTION CRISIS. EVICTIONS
CREATE MARKS IN A PERSON'S
RECORD BAR SOMEONE FROM MOVING
INTO A SAFE NEIGHBORHOOD PREVENT
SOMEONE FROM MOVING INTO PUBLIC
HOUSING. AND IS LINKED TO JOB
LOSS HOMELESSNESS AND SCHOOL
INSTABILITY.
THIS BILL CAN HELP PREVENT
AVOIDABLE EVICTIONS
OUR STATE CALIFORNIA'S IN A
MINORITY OF STATES THE PROVIDES
ONLY A THREE DAY COUNTER NOTICE.
FOR NON PAYMENT OF RENT THE BILL
WOULD PROVIDE TENANTS WITH THREE
COURT DAYS. REALLY EFFECTIVELY
BUSINESS DAYS TO PAY RENT TO
COMPLY WITH THE TERMS OF RELEASE
PROVIDES TENANTS WITH FIVE COURT
DAYS AS OPPOSED TO FIVE COUNTER
DAYS WHICH IS CURRENT LAW. TO
RESPOND TO THAT ACTION LAWSUIT
AND REQUIRES LANDLORDS TO FILE
PROOF OF SERVICE OF THE SUMMONS
AND COMPLAINT WITH THE CLERK
PRIOR TO THE TIME A CLERK ENTERS
A DEFAULT JUDGMENT.
I SIGNIFICANTLY AMENDED THE BILL
THIS PAST WEEK I ALSO COMMITTED
TO THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION TO MAKE CHANGES. TO
ADDRESS ANONYMITY OF WITNESSES
AND WORKING ON THE ISSUE
REGARDING THE PROCESS OF SERVICE.
AND I APPRECIATE CA BEING FINE
WITH THIS BILL MOVING OFF THE
FLOOR WITH THAT I HOPE THAT
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO VOTE FOR THIS
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK DR VOTE.
THEY WHICH YOU.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK LOCAL AROUND. MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THOUGH
.
HOWEVER SERVICE OUT OF THE
THIS CHIU MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO TAKE
UP FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
TWENTY FIVE AB TWENTY TO FORTY
BY MISTER GRAYSON.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO FORTY BY
SOME REMEMBER GRAYSON AN
ACCOLADE COURTS.
MISTER GRAYSON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
CURRENT LAW EXEMPTS POLICE
OFFICERS COUNTY SHERIFF'S.
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROLMAN AND
YOU SEE CSU CAMPUS POLICE FROM
SERVING ON A CRIMINAL JURY THIS
BILL AB TWENTY TO FORTY PROVIDES
A MODEST BUT WHOLLY APPROPRIATE
UPDATE. TO THE JURY SELECTION
PROCESS BY EXTENDING THIS
EXEMPTION TO PROBATION PAROLE
AND CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
THIS IS NOT A QUESTION OF
CONVENIENCE OR EVEN HARDSHIP.
IT'S ABOUT THE FUNDAMENTAL
FAIRNESS OF OUR TRIAL BY JURY.
THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS CORRECTLY POINTED OUT
THIS CONCERN HAVING POST
CONVICTION PEACE OFFICERS
INVOLVED IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
PROCESS DOES. RAISE POTENTIAL
CONFLICT OF INTEREST NOW AND DO
THEY SUPERVISE THE RELEASE AND
PROBATION OF AN OFFENDER BUT
POST CONVICTION OFFICERS ALSO
ACT AS AN ARM OF THE COURT BY
PREPARING REPORTS AND MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE BENCH. SO
NOW YOU CAN UNDERSTAND THAT IT
WOULD BE A COMPLETELY UNFAIR FOR
A PERSON TO BE UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF A PAROLE OFFICER
WHO VOTED.
TO CONVICT THEM OF A CRIME
ACCORDING TO THE PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION WHO
SUPPORT THE BILL THE FACT THE
POST CONVICTION OFFICES HAVE
DIRECT IN CONSTANT CONTACT WITH
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO HAVE BEEN CONVICTED OF
CRIMINAL OFFENSES REYES IS A?
RISK THAT MAY HAVE A DIFFICULT
TIME ENTERTAINING THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE FOR
THOSE WHO ARE MERELY ACCUSED AB
TWENTY TWO FORTY IS A
COMMONSENSE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM. THAT ENHANCES THE
INTEGRITY OF A TRIAL BY JURY IT
AS WE SEE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
BOTH IN THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
AND PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS GRAYSON SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE ANTI ABOUT EYES
FORTY NINE NEWS THREE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE OUT FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX.
AS MISTER KALRA AS A. B..
TWENTY NINE.
FORTY SIX
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE FORTY
SIX BY FAMILY MEMBER KALRA AND
ACTUALLY TO EMPLOYMENT.
MISTER KALRA. THANK YOU MISS
SPEAKER MEMBERS A BETWEEN NINE
FORTY SIX INCREASES THE STATUE
IMITATIONS FOR FILING A WORK
RETALIATION CLAIM FROM SIX
MONTHS TO THREE YEARS. REPLACE
TOLERATION OCCURS IN EMPLOYERS
DISCHARGED THREATEN A DISCHARGED
TOMORROW SUSPENDER SUBJECT
EMPLOYEES TO ADVERSE ACTION
INCLUDING THREATS OF DEPORTATION
FOR EXERCISING THEIR RIGHTS AND
THE LABOR CODE.
RETALIATION IS NOT ONLY
PERVASIVE BUT ALSO A GROWING
PROBLEM TO THE CURRENT POLITICAL
CLIMATE SO ON IMMIGRATION. A
BETWEEN NINE FORTY SIX PROVIDE
EMPLOYEES A THREE YEAR PERIOD OF
TIME TO FILE RETALIATION CLAIM
ALIGNING WITH THE TIME TO FILE
WAGE CLAIMS ELIMINATE ANY
CONFUSION. THE ATTORNEY'S FEES
PROVISIONS PROPELLING EMPLOYEES
ENCOURAGES A PROTECTION WORKERS
TO BRING SUCCESSFUL ACTIONS FOR
ABUSE OF VIOLATIONS SLICKLY
ASPIRIN AIBO.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WAS OUT OF THOSE
MISTER KALRA MOVES A CALL
EVERS BACK IN FILE ORDER.
WE ARE FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY FIVE
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY SEVEN BY
MISTER BERMAN.
KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE SIXTY
SEVEN BY SONY MEMBER BERMAN AND
ACTUALLY THE VITAL RECORDS.
MISTER BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES. AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY SEVEN WOULD ALLOW A NEW
ONE PAGE DEATH CERTIFICATE TO BE
<c.red>SSUED TO CORRECT TECHNICAL</c>
TYPOGRAPHICAL AND NON
SUBSTANTIVE ERRORS ON AN
ORIGINAL DEATH CERTIFICATE.
CURRENTLY WHEN A DEATH
CERTIFICATE AS AMENDED THE
AMENDMENT IS STAPLED TO AN
ORIGINAL DEATH CERTIFICATE. AS A
SECOND PIECE OF PAPER AND THE
ORIGINAL DEATH CERTIFICATE IS
LEFT ON ALTERED I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY SEVEN.
THINGS BERMAN SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE YOUR OWN TALENT
A VOTE.
I SIXTY EIGHT. NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
SIX A. B. TWENTY THREE SIXTY
EIGHT BY MISTER CALDERON.
YEAH FOR ME TONIGHT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE SIXTY
EIGHT BY FAMILY MEMBER CALDERON
AND ACTUALLY THE NOTARIES PUBLIC.
WHICH CALDERON. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER EXISTING LAW REQUIRES.
A CONSUMER TO APPEAR IN PERSON
BEFORE A NOTARY TO OBTAIN NOTARY
NO DON'T TAURIEL ACTS.
DOCUMENTS.
ACTS ON DOCUMENTS SUCH AS A DEED
OF TRUST OR POWER OF ATTORNEY AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY UPDATES THIS
AUDIT. ANTIQUATED SYSTEM BY
AUTHORIZING REMOTE ONLINE ARISES
XIN CALIFORNIA BY PERMITTING AN
ONLINE NOTARY APPROVED BY THE
SECRETARY OF STATE.
TO TAKE THE ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OR
OATH OF A SIGNER. WHO APPEARS
BEFORE THE NOTARY BY SECURE OR
TWO WAY INTERACTIVE AUDIO AND
VIDEO COMMUNICATION CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO KEEP UP WITH THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY? INNOVATION AND
IMPLEMENT THIS NEW TECHNOLOGY IN
A SAFE SECURE AND CONSUMER
FRIENDLY WAY AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY PROVIDES A FRAMEWORK AND I
THINK YOU IN RESPECT WE ASK FOR
MY VOTE.
NAMES CALDERON SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
OUR CLUB MOREAU. ON MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OF OUR DESIRE TO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
I BELIEVE WE ARE MOVING TO TAKE
UP FILE ITEM ONE.
THIRTY SEVEN.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY THIS IS
MISTER HOLDEN CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
AND ACTUALLY THE LEAD EXPOSURE.
WHICH ROLLED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. TO
ADOPT REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE
THAT CHILD CARE CENTERS DRINKING
WATER IS LEAD FREE.
DRINKING WATER OUT MOST
CHILDCARE CENTERS IS NOT TESTED
FOR LEAD. THIS IS A PROBLEM
BECAUSE MANY WATER PIPES FAUCETS
FIXTURES.
STILL IN USE CONTAIN LEAD IN
OVERTIME THIS LEAD CAN LEACH
INTO THE DRINKING WATER.
YET WE KNOW YOUNG CHILDREN ARE
THE MOST HARMED BY LEAD BECAUSE
THEY ABSORB MUCH OF THE LEAD
THEY INGEST.
ACCORDING TO AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS AND THE CENTERS OF
FOR DISEASE CONTROL THERE IS NO
SAFE LEAD. LEVEL OF LEAD.
FOR CHILDREN.
LET IS SEVERE NEUROTOXIN
EVEN MINUTE AMOUNTS OF LEAD IN
THE BODIES OF VERY YOUNG
CHILDREN CAUSE HARM TO THEIR
CENTRAL NERVOUS SYSTEM. AND THIS
HARM APPEARS TO BE IRREVERSIBLE.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY WILL
HELP YOU KEEP OUR YOUNGEST
CHILDREN SAVED BY ENSURING THEY
ARE NOT IN JUST A LEAD THROUGH
THE WATER THEY DRINK.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION IN
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISS HOLDEN SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARP LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
KIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT.
I SIXTY FIVE.
KNOWS ONE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO STAY
WITH MISTER HOLDEN.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTY TWO.
AB THIRTY ONE FORTY SIX.
AGAIN MISTER HOLDEN.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE FORTY
SIX BY SELLING MEMBER HOLDEN AND
ACTUALLY THE OIL AND GAS
NATURALLY YOU MAKE IT ALL BUT. I
THINK YOU CAN MISTER SPEAKER.
ARE MUCH LIKE ACTIVE PRODUCTION
SITES IDLE AND ABANDONED OIL AND
GAS WELLS CAN LEAK POLLUTION
INTO OUR MOST NECESSARY
RESOURCES LIKE AIR AND WATER.
AB THIRTY ONE FORTY SIX FOCUSES
ON THE AIR POLLUTION IMPACTS
FROM LEAKING IDLE AND ABANDONED
WELLS.
THIS BILL CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR GREATER TRANSPARENCY AND
WILL AID IN IMPROVING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES BY
ACCUMULATING DATA. ON AIR
POLLUTION.
I DON'T ABANDONED WELLS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE PRESENTED
PROBLEMS FOR COMMUNITY EXPOSURE
IN THE RECENT PAST.
AND THE TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN REPORT BY THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. LOOKING AT LA
COUNTY IS ONE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ACTIVE
INACTIVE WELLS FOUND THAT ORPHAN
WELLS. ARE OFTEN IMPROPERLY
ABANDONED OR LEFT IDLE. WHICH
MAY RESULT IN COMMUNITIES BEEN
IMPACTED BY HYDROGEN SULFIDE AND
PETROLEUM ODORS THESE CHEMICALS
CAN CAUSE HEADACHES NOSEBLEEDS
AND NAUSEA.
AND TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO
ABANDONED WELLS IN ECHO PARK
NEAR LOS ANGELES WERE FOUND
LEAKING COMPOUNDS IN A DENSELY
POPULATED DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY. FORCING LIMPLY
EXCAVATES. EVACUATION AND
EXPOSURES.
WHEN WE UNCOVER THE DATA OF
THESE TWO ABANDONED WELLS IT WAS
FOUND THAT THE GHASTLY LEVEL
LEAKAGE LEVELS WERE ADDED NEAR.
THE EXPLOSIVE LIMIT WHICH IS A
VERY DANGEROUS CONDITION FOR THE
HOMEOWNERS AND THE FIRST
RESPONDERS WHO HAD NO IDEA THAT
ONE OF THE WELLS WAS EVEN THERE.
WHEN THESE WELLS LEAK INTO
RESIDENTIAL COMMUNITIES THAT IS
OFTEN TIMES THE STATE THAT BURNS
THE COSTS OF RELOCATING
INDIVIDUALS. CLEANING UP IN
REPAIRING THE SIDE.
THIS BILL CAN SAVE THE STATE
MONEY BY HAVING THE DATA SOONER
SO WE DID NOT REACH CRISIS
LEVELS OF EMISSIONS.
WE ALL REMEMBER LISA CANYON AND
CONTINUE TO FEEL THE EFFECTS.
WHO IS THE CANYON SHOWS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN WELLS GET OLDER AND
ART MAINTAIN?
THEY LEAGUE.
THEY LEAK AND PRESENT A HAZARD
FOR COMMUNITIES AND FIRST
RESPONDERS.
OTHER STATES IN THE U. K. HAVE
STUDIED THIS ISSUE AND FOUND
THAT IDLE WELLS DO IN FACT LEAK.
PENNSYLVANIA FOUND THAT I TO
WELLS LEAK.
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR NEARLY
THIRTY PERCENT OF THE STATE'S
METHANE POLLUTION.
WITH BETTER MONITORING IN BETTER
DATA UPFRONT WE CAN AVOID THESE
CRISIS IS IN THE FUTURE. THE
OPPOSITION HAS BEEN ARGUING THAT
THESE REQUIREMENTS ARE
DUPLICATIVE.
I WANNA BE EXTREMELY CLEAR ON
THIS POINT.
SOME OIL AND GAS WELLS ARE
SUBJECT TO AIR EMISSION TESTING
BY CAR. BUT THE VAST MAJORITY
ABOUT EIGHTY PERCENT OF AYE TO
WELLS ARE NOT SUBJECT TO THIS
AIR TESTING.
SPECIFICALLY THE CARD
REGULATIONS DO NOT REQUIRE
LEAKAGE TESTING ON ALL OIL WELLS.
IMPORTANTLY EVEN IF TESTED.
KNOW THE INFORMATION IS REQUIRED
TO BE MADE PUBLIC.
OUR BILL WILL MAKE AIR MISSION
TESTING ON WELLS THAT ARE TO BE
PLUGGED IT ABANDONED. WITHIN A
QUARTER MILE.
FROM HUMAN OCCUPANCY PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE.
THERE ARE FEDERAL STANDARDS ON
LARGE OIL AND GAS OPERATIONS TO
REPORT THEIR MISSION ON A YEARLY
BASIS.
HOWEVER THESE FACILITIES REPORT.
BASED ON ESTIMATES USING
STANDARD EMISSION FACTORS.
AB SIX SEVENTEEN REQUIRES CARP
TO IDENTIFY COMMUNITIES OVER
BURDENED BY AIR POLLUTION AN
ESTABLISHED COMMUNITY AIR
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT PLANS.
BUT WITH ONLY WHAT WOULD ONLY BE
IMPLEMENTED IN A FEW SELECT
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE AND
DOESN'T PROVIDE DATA ON WHETHER
I DON'T WELLS OUTSIDE OF THESE
COMMUNITIES. ARE LEAKING.
FURTHERMORE IF YOU ARE DOING
TESTING UNDER AB SIX SEVENTEEN
THAT WOULD QUALIFY IN EXEMPTS
YOU FROM THE TESTING UNDER OUR
CURRENT BILL.
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY NARROW THE
SCOPE OF THE BILL FROM WELLS
WITHIN A HALF MILE OF HUMAN
OCCUPANCY TO ONLY WELLS THAT ARE
TO BE PLUGGED IN ABANDONED
WITHIN A QUARTER MILE. FROM
HUMAN OCCUPANCY.
WE HAVE ADDED A SUNSET DATE OF
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY SIX SO
THIS ISA SHORT PROGRAM TO
COLLECT EMISSIONS DATA THAT
COULD BE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE. TO
BETTER INFORM POLICY MOVING
FORWARD.
RECENT AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL
ENSURE THAT OIL AND GAS
OPERATORS WILL NOT BE SUBJECT TO
DUPLICATIVE TESTING REQUIREMENTS.
IN FACT THE BILL EXPLICITLY
STATES THAT AN OPERATOR WHO HAS
CONDUCTED TESTING ON A WELL
PURSUANT TO FEDERAL STATE OR
LOCAL REQUIREMENTS WITHIN THREE
MONTHS.
DOES NOT HAVE TO PERFORM THAT
TESTING AGAIN THIRTY SECONDS OF
HIS ROLE THAT I'M HAPPY TO
COMMIT TO AMENDING THE BILL IN
THE SENATE. TO STATE THAT AN
OPERATOR WHO HAS CONDUCTED
TESTING ON WELLS DOES NOT HAVE
TO PERFORM THE TEST AGAIN.
I WOULD SIMPLY STRIKE THE THREE
MONTH CURRENTLY IN SECTION TO.
THE WELL OPERATORS WILL STILL
HAVE TO REPORT THE DATA THEY ARE
COLLECTING THROUGH THE EMISSION
TEST AND MAKE IT PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE. IDA WELLS ARE ONLY IN
RURAL AREAS THERE IN URBAN AND
SUBURBAN AREAS THEIR NEXT DOOR
PARKS UNDER OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR
BACKYARDS IN NEAR WHERE WE WORK.
STUDIES FROM OTHER STATES HAVE
SHOWN IDA WELLS LEAGUE WITH
THIRTY THOUSAND IDA WELLS IN
CALIFORNIA THIS TIME WE KNOW.
THE HEALTH IMPACTS THEY ARE
CAUSING OUR FRIENDS OUR FAMILIES
WHO LIVE NEAR THESE WELLS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
I THINK IT WAS HOLDEN MISTER
MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WOULD LIKE
TO. THANK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
PASADENA FOR INTRODUCING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
BILL. TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
STATE BETTER UNDERSTANDS THE
IMPACTS OF UNPLUGGED EIDOLON
ABANDONED WELLS AND THE IMPACT
THEY HAVE ON OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND OUR WORKERS SAFETY WE ALL
HAVE A MANY OF THESE UNPLUG I
DON'T ABANDONED WELLS WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE PROTECTING.
OUR COMMUNITIES SO I URGE.
MY COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
MS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I STAND
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
ONE FORTY SIX BECAUSE OF THE AIR
EMISSIONS IMPACTS FROM IDLE OIL
WELLS IN MY DISTRICT.
IN FACT THIS BILL IS SO
IMPORTANT THAT I HAVE ASKED THE
AUTHOR TO ADD ME AS A PRINCIPAL
CHO AUTHOR WHEN THE BILL AS
AMENDED IN THE SENATE.
THE INGLEWOOD OIL FIELD IS
PERHAPS THE LARGEST AND MOST
DENSELY CONNECTED URBAN OILFIELD
IN THE NATION AND AS I STATED IT
RESIDES IN THE FIFTY FOURTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
THE OIL FIELD AND ITS WELLS ARE
LOCATED NEAR HOMES CHILD CARE
CENTERS AND OUTSIDE PLAYGROUNDS
USED BY MY CONSTITUENTS.
AND SOME OF THOSE WELLS ARE
LEAKING DUE TO THEIR AGE.
I THINK MOST FOLKS START LEAKING
BASED ON THEIR AGE.
PEOPLE HEREBY SUFFER.
I'M TRYING TO MAKE SURE FOLKS
ARE LISTENING THIS IS IMPORTANT.
PEOPLE IN CLEARLY SUFFER AND
COMPLAIN OF THE FOOT. MOVING
SYMPTOMS PRIOR THE LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH.
WITH SYMPTOMS SUCH AS HEADACHES
NAUSEA VOMITING AYE NOSE AND
THROAT IRRITATION IN ADDITION TO
TROUBLE BREATHING.
AT PRESENT THE OILFIELD HAS ONLY
TWO MONITORS THE INGLEWOOD OIL
FIELD HAS ONLY TO WHO MONITORS
WHICH IS NOT NEARLY ENOUGH
CONSIDERING THE SIZE OF THE OIL.
FIELD IS NEARLY ONE THOUSAND
ACRES.
AB THIRTY ONE FORTY SIX WOULD
REQUIRE REPORTING AND DATA
COLLECTION TO MAKE AIR EMISSIONS
FROM IDLE AND ABANDONED OIL
WELLS PUBLIC. IT ALSO APPLIES TO
WELLS THAT WILL BE PERMANENTLY
CLOSED.
I WANT TO STRESS ALONG WITH THE
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL THAT THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL ARE NOT
WHOLLY DUPLICATIVE.
WHILE SOME WELLS ARE ALREADY
SUBJECT TO AIR EMISSIONS TESTING
BY CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD. BUT EIGHTY PERCENT OF
THEM ARE NOT.
IF SIGNED INTO LAW THIS BILL
SAYS THAT IF A WELL HAS BEEN
TESTED IN THE PAST THREE MONTHS
AN UNDERCURRENT HAY ARE THE
RULES OIL COMPANIES WILL NOT
HAVE TO RETEST THE WELLS THEY
WILL NOT HAVE TO RETEST THE
WELLS.
KEY PART OF THIS LEGISLATION
CALLS FOR THE PUBLICLY POSTING
TESTING RESULTS AND REPORTS.
TODAY'S CONSUMERS INCLUDING US
HAVE GOTTEN USED TO POSTING.
CALORIE COUNTS INGREDIENTS AND
NUTRITIONAL VALUES FOR OUR FOOD
WE CERTAINLY BEEN LIKE IN THE
BEGINNING BUT WE HAVE BECOME
USED TO IT AND NOW WE WANT ALL
THE TIME.
SHOULDN'T THEY ALSO GET POSTINGS
ABOUT WHAT IS IN THE AIR THAT WE
BREATHE.
IT IS TRUE THAT NOT ALL
EMISSIONS ARE CAUSED BY OIL
FIELDS BUT AS WE CONTINUE TO
TACKLE THE ISSUES OF POLLUTION
TOXICITY AND CLIMATE CLEANLINESS
IT IS IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHAT IS
IN THE AIR. AND WHERE IT COMES
FROM I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE ON ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE
FORTY SIX.
THANK YOU MISS COME LATER THOUGH.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL COMMENT ON
THE BILL MISTER HOLE YOU MAY
CLOSE WE WISH.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO SAY
NO TO LEAKAGE AND YES A THIRTY
ONE FORTY SIX.
THANK YOU IS HOLDING CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
IS THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESERT OF THE
MISTER HOLDEN MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL.
ONLINE FILE ITEM.
NINETY TWO.
AB TWENTY SIX FORTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO WISH TO VOTE?
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS OUT OF THE
.
DOCTOR WOULD
PAGING DOCTOR WOULD.
DOCTOR WOULD REPLACE IS A CALL
.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE UP. FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE BY
MISS CARILLO.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY ONE BY FAMILY MEMBER
CARILLO AND ACTUALLY THE WATER
USE EFFICIENCY. MISS CARILLO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE. A BILL
THAT TAKES COMMON SENSE STEPS TO
SAVE WATER BY IMPLEMENTING. BY
IMPROVING LANDSCAPE DESIGN
IRRIGATION SYSTEMS AND URBAN
WATER USE PRACTICES REDUCING
WATER USE ON URBAN LANDSCAPE
STATEWIDE HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
SAVE THE EQUIVALENT OF FOUR
TIMES THE AMOUNT OF WATER USED
BY THE ENTIRE. CITY OF LOS
ANGELES IN ONE YEAR.
WATER EFFICIENCY LANDSCAPE CAN
ALSO RESULT IN LESS INSTABILITY
IN URBAN WATER DEMAND AND
IMPROVE THE FINANCIAL HEALTH AND
SAVINGS OF OUR WATER UTILITIES.
AND CONSUMERS AND CUSTOMERS AB
THREE AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
ONE ADVANCES SEVERAL PROVISIONS
TO IMPROVE LANDSCAPE WATER USE
EFFICIENCY IN CALIFORNIA. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS OF THAT WE CAN BETTER
PROTECT. THIS MOST PRECIOUS
RESOURCE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS KOREA.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COR CLUB THERE ALL ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
HOME MEMBERS VOTERS HAD ABOUT
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE. AND
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
ONE.
NOS TWENTY EIGHT THAT MEASURE
PASSES
FILE ORDER.
THIS IS.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY EIGHT AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN BY MS
IRWIN COOPERATE.
SOME LEGAL TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
SEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER IRWIN AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO
AGRICULTURE. MS IRWIN.
THANK YOU AB TWO THREE SEVEN
SEVEN WOULD FUND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR FARMERS AND
RANCHERS SEEKING TO TRANSITION
TO CLIMB A SMART.
AGRICULTURAL AND HELPS SMALL
AGRICULTURE AND HELP SMALLER
OPERATIONS THAT MAY NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO APPLY FOR THESE
GRANTS SPECIFICALLY THE BILL
REQUIRES THAT FIFTEEN PERCENT OF
THE ANNUAL BUDGET OF THE STATE
WATER EFFICIENCY AND.
ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM ALTERNATIVE
MANURE MANAGEMENT PROGRAM IN
HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM BE USED TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
FARMERS AND RANCHERS. THIS WILL
IMPROVE IMPROVE FARMER
PARTICIPATION PROJECT
IMPLEMENTATION AND THE IMPACT OF
CLIMATE SMART. AGRICULTURE
PROGRAMS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER WHEN SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLUB WILL OPEN THE RIGHT.
MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO WAS ARE TO VOTE ALL NUMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW IT AYE SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY NINE.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY ONE BY
MISS CARILLO.
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY ONE BY FAMILY MEMBER
CARILLO AND ACTUALLY THE
VEHICULAR AIR POLLUTION.
THIS CARILLO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY ONE A BILL THAT
HELPS THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD A ARE A ARE BE.
IN THE FIGHT AGAINST VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY DESIGNED TO INVADE
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN AIR LAWS. NEW
MOTOR VEHICLES ARE SUBJECT TO
EMISSION TEST BY THE AIR BE TO
VERIFY COMPLIANCE WITH
CALIFORNIA MISSION LAWS HOWEVER
DIVISIVE DEVICES EXIST THAT CAN
ENABLE A VEHICLE TO FULL.
EMISSION TESTING IN A PROMINENT
EXAMPLE IT WAS DISCOVERED THAT
VOLKSWAGEN HAD INSTALLED THE SO
CALLED DEFEAT DEVICES AND MANY
OF THEIR CARS. THESE DEVICES
WERE DISCOVERED IN PART DUE TO
REAL WORLD TESTING DATA THAT
HELP DETECT THESE DEVICES. WHICH
WERE PREVIOUSLY UNDISCOVERED
BOWL AND LABORATORY SETTINGS
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE GREAT
STRIDES IN CLEANING UP THE AIR
IN FIGHTING AGAINST POLLUTANTS.
BUT VW'S DECEPTIONS WAS
PARTICULARLY DAMAGING BECAUSE
MANY PARTS OF THE STATE STILL
EXPERIENCE SOME OF THE WORST AIR
QUALITY IN THE NATION AND THESE
DEVICES ALLOW THE EMISSIONS OF
TOXIC POLLUTANTS. WHICH
INTENSIFIES THIS PROBLEM AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY ONE. WOULD
PARTNER WITH THEY ARE BE WITH
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS ASSOCIATED
WITH LABORATORIES AND EXPERTS IN
ORDER TO ENHANCE. OUR MOTOR
VEHICLE EMISSIONS TESTING
PROGRAM AND DISCOVERED THESE
DEFEAT DEVICES AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY ONE WOULD ALSO GET THEY
ARE BE THE ABILITY TO SECURE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. TO PERFORM
INDEPENDENT TESTING IN ORDER TO
STAY AT THE FOREFRONT OF
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA'S AIR FROM
THOSE WHO WOULD VIOLATE OUR LAWS
POLLUTE OUR ENVIRONMENT. AND
HARM OUR RESIDENTS
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
HUNDREDS AND HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND ZERO NO
VOTES AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CREEL.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM COURT LOCAL ROLL-ON DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE SENATE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLE.
TELL AYE VOTE.
I FIFTY SIX.
KNOWS NINE.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE VERY MOVED TAKE UP
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY TWO BY MISTER
GIPSON
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY TWO BY SOME A MEMBER
GIPSON AND EXPLAIN THE FIRE ARMS
MAKING A PREPARATION THERE FOR.
MISTER GIPSON.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY TWO SIX TO CLOSE THE
GHOST GUN LUPO BY REQUIRING
STATE BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR
PURCHASING OF GUN PARTS AND ALSO
REATE A NEW LICENSE STRUCTURE
FOR GUN PARTS DEALERS.
NOT TOO LONG AGO.
THERE WAS A SHOOTING IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHERE A MAN MURDERED.
FIVE PEOPLE INCLUDING HIS WIFE.
WITH THE GHOST GUN.
THIS MAN WHO WAS PROHIBITED FROM
PURCHASING A FIREARM.
SO HE TOOK TO THE INTERNET TO
BUY GUN PARTS TO BUILD HIS OWN.
THIS WAS ALSO THE CASE IN SANTA
MONICA AND TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN.
WHERE A MAN ATTEMPTED TO
PURCHASE A FIREARM BUT WAS NOT
ALLOWED AFTER CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOUND HIM
IN ELIGIBLE?
HE THEN RESORTED TO BUILDING HIS
OWN GUN.
WHICH THEN HE USED TO KILL FIVE
PEOPLE AND INJURE.
SEVERAL OTHERS.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES BACKGROUND
CHECKS FOR BOTH GUN SALES AND
AMMUNITION.
YET SILENCE ON THE TREATMENT OF
FAR OR PRECURSOR.
THIS BILL INTENSE TO IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY BY PREVENTING
CRIMINALS AND THOSE WHO SHOULD
NOT OTHERWISE POSSESS A FIRE ARM.
FROM GAINING ACCESS WHILE
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF GUN
OWNERS.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
JUST TWO MONTHS AGO A MAN WAS
ARRESTED IN MY DISTRICT.
AGE THIRTY SEVEN WHO PLED GUILTY.
HE WAS MATTER FACTORING AND
MAKING A QUE FIFTEENTH AT A ARE
FORTY SEVENS IN MY DISTRICT.
MY UNDERSTANDING THROUGH ARTICLE
HE AND HIS WIFE WAS BOTH
APPREHENDED ARRESTED AND PLED
GUILTY FOR MAKING THESE GUNS.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
ON ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY TWO.
THANK YOU MISS GIPSON MISTER
HARPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
WILL IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY.
THE LACK OF A DEFINITION FOR
FIRE ARM PRECURSOR PARTS WILL BE
CONFUSING FOR THE PUBLIC AS TO
WHAT IS AND WHAT IS NOT COVERED
BY THE BILL'S CRIMINAL PENALTIES.
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE IS ALREADY BEHIND WHEN
IT COMES TO TRACKING DOWN THE
MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE BELIEVED AND
ILLEGAL POSSESSION OF FIREARMS.
CURRENTLY WILL TAKE MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE YEARS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE JUST TO CLEAR
UP THAT EXISTING BACKLOG.
WE SHOULD NOT ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE TO FOCUS ON
KEEPING FIREARMS AWAY FROM THOSE
ARE BELIEVED ILLEGAL POSSESSION.
OF THEM RATHER THAN DIVERT THEIR
ATTENTION TO THE TRANSACTION.
OR THE TRANSACTIONS OF
PRECURSOR PARTS.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS BILL
IS INCOMPLETE AND I BELIEVE NOT
READY FOR PRIMETIME I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE
ON THIS BILL.
MISTER BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES SOMEONE OUT THANK.
OUR COLLEAGUE FOR BRINGING
FORWARD AT THIS BILL TO CLOSE
THE GHOST GUN LOOPHOLE OUR.
GUN VIOLENCE EPIDEMIC IN
CALIFORNIA AND THROUGHOUT THIS
COUNTRY REQUIRES CONTINUED BOLD
ACTION IN CALIFORNIA'S ONGOING
LEADERSHIP THE GHOST GUN
LOOPHOLE. HAS SERVED AS AN END
RUN AROUND CALIFORNIA'S REQUIRED.
BACKGROUND CHECKS THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE TO HELP
ADDRESS THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY WISH BONTA MS WALDRON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND THE
BACKGROUND CHECK TO PRECURSOR
PARTS. THE INABILITY TO USE THE
FEDERAL INSTANT BACKGROUND CHECK
SYSTEM FOR AMMUNITION HAS
ALREADY LED TO AN AMMUNITION
BACKGROUND CHECK. BEING
ABANDONED IN NEW YORK STATE NOW
WE WANT TO ADD A A REQUIREMENT
TO PRECURSOR PARTS TO SUFFERED
THE SAME PROBLEMS THAT WE'VE
SEEN IN OTHER STATES BECAUSE THE
CURRENT BACKGROUND CHECK SYSTEM
COULD NOT BE USED. FOR FIREARM
PARTS AND ACCESSORIES.
THIS LICENSING A BACKGROUND
CHECK LAW WILL IN TURN COST THE
STATE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
IMPOSE MORE COSTS ON LAWFUL GUN
OWNERS WHILE CRIMINALS WILL
CONTINUE TO CIRCUMVENT THE LAW
HIRED IN THE OVAL.
MR MATHIS YOUR. YES QUESTION TO
THE AUTHOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
YES HOW ARE YOU GONNA DETERMINE
KNOW WHEN THE PART IS A PRE
DATED IS A PRECURSOR OF NOT.
AND HOW WAS LAW ENFORCEMENT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO JUDGE THAT.
BEING THAT PARTS ARE NOT MARKED.
I ANSWER MY CLOTHES.
GIBSON'S GOING TO ADDRESS THAT
IS CLOSE TO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
MEANT MAN FINISH MYSTERY THING
MISTER IT WITH WITH THAT
QUESTION BECAUSE
YOU CAN BECAUSE THE PARTS ARE
DATED. ON AND THEN FURTHER MORE
MEMBERS.
HOW? IS OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
GONNA KNOW WHAT THE DATE OF
THESE PARTS ARE THAT THIS BILLS
YOU CAN'T ENFORCE IT. IT CAN'T
BE DONE IT'S A COMPLETE WASTE OF
TIME. IN GOING AFTER THE PARTS
IS NOT A WAY TO STOP A GHOST GUN
LOOPHOLE ARENA THIS WHAT WE NEED
TO DO IS GIVE. LAW ENFORCEMENT
BETTER ABILITY TO GO AFTER BAD
GUYS.
THIS BILL DOESN'T DO THAT. I ASK
FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS MATHIS SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBER SEEKING.
RECOGNITION.
MISTER GIBSON YOU MAY CLOSE ON
THE ADAM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU ALREADY
ANSWERS ON THE TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
OF APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION.
AGAIN AS I INDICATED THAT THERE
WAS A SITUATION IN MY DISTRICT
WHERE AN INDIVIDUAL TOOK TO THE
INTERNET AND ALL MAKE GUNS.
HE MADE IT A QUE OF A ARE
FIFTEEN AND ALSO A. K. FORTY
SEVEN THESE ARE GUNS AGAIN
MEMBERS THAT YOU CAN UP EASILY
MAY.
BY WAY OF THE INTERNET.
THIS IS A GOOD BILL THE
LANGUAGE WAS WORKED ON CLOSELY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
WHO BROUGHT US THIS LANGUAGE
THIS BILL CAME UP LAST YEAR ON
THE GOVERNOR VETOED IT WE
NARROWED THE BILL WE WORK WITH A
PARTNER JUSTICE AND OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT. UP OFFICERS AND
AGENCIES IN ORDER TO MAKE THIS A
BETTER BILL I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
BETTER BUILT BEFORE YOU TODAY
THIS WILL GO A LONG WAY IN TERMS
OF SAVING LIVES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
WITH THAT THE CLERK WILL OPEN
ROLL-ON MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF THE.
AS FORTY TWO KNOWS TWENTY SIX.
I MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
ONE AB TWENTY.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY FOUR BY
DR ARAMBULA CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY FOUR BY FAMILY MEMBER
ARAMBULA AND ACTUALLY THE
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT.
DOCTOR REGULAR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY FOUR WILL
REMOVE BARRIERS TO SOME OF THE
MOST EFFECTIVE AND INNOVATIVE
TREATMENTS.
OF SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDER AND
OVERDOSE.
REVERSAL IN MEDICATION ASSISTED
THERAPY COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS
MATT.
MATT IS THE USE OF MEDICATIONS
IN COMBINATION WITH COUNSELING
AND BEHAVIORAL THERAPIES.
TO PROVIDE A WHOLE PATIENT
APPROACH TO THE TREATMENT OF
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS.
THE AMENDMENTS REFLECTED IN
PRINT WERE IN ERROR AND I
COMMITTED TO THE CHAIR OF
APPROPRIATIONS.
THAT WE WOULD MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD NOW BUT CORRECT THE
ERROR IN THE SENATE TO CONFORM
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS ACTION.
THE FURTHER AMENDMENTS WILL
LIMIT THE BILL TO OPIOID USE
DISORDER. TO INSERT A TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR SUNSET TO REMOVE
CERTAIN MEDICATIONS NOT RELATED
TO OPIOID USE DISORDER. AND TO
STRIKE THE PRESUMPTION OF
MEDICAL NECESSITY AND TO INSTEAD
SPECIFY A PLAN SHALL NOT DENY
COVERAGE PENDING A DETERMINATION
OF MEDICAL NECESSITY IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE DRUG TREATMENT IN AN
EXPEDITIOUS MANNER.
IN TAKING THESE AMENDMENTS THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HAS REMOVED
THIS FROM THEIR JOB KILLER LIST.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY FOUR WILL
HAVE A DIRECT AFFECT IN REMOVING
BARRIERS TO ACCESSING HIGH
QUALITY EVIDENCE BASED CARE AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTES ON AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
FOUR.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA SEEING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CARPOOL OPENER ALL I'M.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE ANTI VOTE EYES FIFTY
NO SIXTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
TWO AB THIRTY TO FIFTY SEVEN
CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TO FIFTY
SEVEN BY THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES AND ACTUALLY
THE NATURAL RESOURCES.
MISTER MURATSUCHI THANK YOU
MEMBERS AB THIRTY TO FIFTY SEVEN
IS THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE. A CLEANUP BILL THAT
UPDATES CIVIL SERVICE
REQUIREMENTS AND MAKES OTHER
TECHNICAL CHANGES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS MURATSUCHI.
SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE QUIRK
LIBERAL.
UNDERSTANDS OUR VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE ANTI THAT I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIVE THE
CALL.
ON FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN
THIS IS AB TWENTY FIFTIES
SIX MISTER EDUARDO GARCIA.
CORPORAL POST. MEMBERS VOTER
WISH TO VOTE THIS TAKES FIFTY
FOR ALL MEMBERS VOTER WISH TO
VOTE.
THIS IS A FIFTY FOUR VOTE BILL.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR OWN TIME ABOUT AYE
AYES FIFTY SEVEN NO SEVENTEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'RE NOW GOING TO LIFT
THE CALLING FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO.
THIS IS A B. THIRTY ONE FORTY
SIX BY MR HOLD IN THE CLERK WILL
POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE ON WHICH TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
MISTER HOLDEN REPLACES A CALL
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY FIVE CLEAR
PROPOSED.
THIS IS
A. B. FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY FIVE CARILLO.
CLERK WILL POST. ON MEMBERS
VOTER WHICH TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES EYES TWENTY NINE
KNOWS THIRTY ONE THAT MEASURE
FAILS
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE UP.
FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE.
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY FIVE BY
MISTER BONTA.
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE TWENTY
FIVE BY SOME THE MEMBER POTS AND
ACTUALLY LIEUTENANCY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AND COLLEAGUES.
CALIFORNIA LAW CURRENTLY ALLOWS
LANDLORDS TO E. VIC'S TENANTS
WITHOUT PROVIDING A REASON FOR
EVICTION.
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE BILL THAT
REALLY REQUIRES LANDLORDS TO
LIST THE REASON FOR ADDICTING
ATTENDANT ON THE EVICTION NOTICE
THEY ARE ALREADY. REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
A RESPOND TO A SCENE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE.
EYES FIFTEEN KNOWS THIRTY.
THAT MEASURE FAILS
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX
THIS IS AB NINETEEN FORTY BY MR
MCCARTY THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
.
SHE MCCARTY REPLACES A CALL.
WE ARE GOING TO.
MISTER GLORIA.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY THREE.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
AND ACTUALLY THE MENTAL HEALTH
MAKING A PREPARATION THEREFORE.
MR LAURIA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
PRESENT AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
THREE WHICH IS A VERY STRAIGHT
FORWARD BILL. ADDRESSES
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT ALL THE LAST A
COUPLE OF DAYS ON THIS FLOOR
THINGS LIKE OPIOID ADDICTION
HOMELESSNESS MENTAL ILLNESS
CRISIS. GUN GOT INVOLVED.
SCHOOLS THE LIST GOES ON AND ON
THERE IS A MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
IN OUR COUNTRY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS WE MUST DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT. NOW SOME OF
YOU MAY KNOW BECAUSE OF THE
STATE AUDIT THAT THE STATE IS
CURRENTLY COUNTIES ARE CURRENTLY
SITTING ON. TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN ON EXPENDED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES MONIES.
THIS IS A AT THIS IS I THINK I
OUTRAGE IN THE CONTEXT OF WHAT
WE SEE IN OUR COMMUNITIES WITH
HOMELESSNESS.
WITH A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
WITH DEPRESSION WITH ANXIETY
WITHIN TEMPERAMENT AMOUNT OF
HOPE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
NICK COUNTY ALAMEDA A HUNDRED
AND FOUR MILLION DOLLARS UNSPENT
IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY FORTY SIX
MILLION FRESNO CA NINETY FIVE
MILLION LOS ANGELES SEVEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN MILLION
ORANGE COUNTY. A QUARTER OF A
BILLION DOLLARS NOT SPENT.
ALL OF US HAVE TOWN HALL
MEETINGS ALL OF US HAVE
CONSTITUENTS ASK IS WHAT ARE WE
DOING ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS WHAT ARE WE DOING ABOUT
THE OPIATE ADDICTION. QUESTION.
MANY OF YOU KNOW THAT THERE ARE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS LITERALLY
AVAILABLE TO ADDRESS THIS NEED
AND YET COUNTIES ARE NOT
SPENDING THIS MONEY THIS BILL IS
RELATIVELY STRAIGHTFORWARD.
COUNTIES ALREADY MUST SPIN THESE
DOLLARS WITHIN THREE YEARS BUT
AS YOU CAN TELL WITH THE TWO
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS ARE
SEEN ON THEY ARE NOT DOING IT.
THIS BILL SIMPLY SAYS AFTER
THREE YEARS OTHER PUBLIC
AGENCIES CITIES SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
HOUSE MIDDLE DISTRICTS CAN APPLY
FOR THESE FUNDS.
BIG ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
YOUR CITIES TO HELP UP PROVIDE
HOMELESS OUTREACH TEAMS FOR THE
POLICE DEPARTMENTS FOR YOUR
HOSPITALS TO HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
BEDS IN THEIR EMERGENCY WARDS
FOUR YEAR SCHOOLS TO HAVE MONIES
FOR SCHOOL COUNSELORS TO TALK TO
CHILDREN WHO ARE CRISIS. THIS IS
WHAT THIS BILL PROVIDES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO FOR THE
COUNTIES THAT A REFUSING TO
SPEND THESE DOLLARS WERE SAYING
TO THEM TIMES UP. WILL
REALLOCATE BEAST MONIES TO
COMMUNITIES THAT WILL USE THESE
FUNDS MEMBERS IS A TWO THIRDS
VOTE I RECOGNIZE THE COUNTIES
ARE AGAINST IT BUT IF YOU CANNOT
EXPLAIN WHY YOU'RE COUNTY HAS
THESE ON EXPENDED DOLLARS PILING
UP IN THEIR COFFERS. THEN I ASK
YOU TO JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING
THIS MEASURE A MODEST REFORM
THAT WILL MAKE I THINK AN
IMPORTANT DIFFERENCE IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF MANY
CALIFORNIANS. ARE THE
CONSTITUENTS ARE PAINT THIS TAX
NOW AND YET TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS OF IT IS GOING
ON SPENT WE CAN DO BETTER OUR
CONSTITUENTS NEED US YOU BETTER
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE THOUGH.
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I THINK IT WAS SPEAKER I RIDE IN
SUPPORT OF TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
THREE IT'S QUITE TRUE. AND WHEN
PEOPLE COMPLAIN ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
THEY'RE GOING TO THEIR CITY
COUNCILS OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND WE ARE OFTENTIMES
HAPPENS BECAUSE A FORMER CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER STUCK HOLDING
THEIR BAG AND HAVE VERY.
VIRTUALLY NO CONTROL OVER PROP
SIXTY THREE MONEY THAT GOES TO
THE COUNTIES HAVE ALSO BEEN A
PART OF THOSE PLANNING
COMMITTEES THAT GO ON FOR EVER
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL TO THINK HOW
WE'RE GONNA SPEND THAT MONEY.
THIS MONEY WAS ALSO JUST TO DO
PREVENTION WELL FRIENDS AWAY
PASS PREVENTION NOW PREVENTION
REALLY IMPORTANT BUT WE HAVEN'T
INTERVENTION CRISIS ON OUR HANDS
AND IF WE CAN'T FIND A WAY TO
ACCESS THE MONEY THAT HAS
ALREADY BEEN SET ASIDE. WE HAVE
A LOT OF TROUBLE IN FRONT OF US
SO WHAT IS STILL A LOT OF
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS THIS
CONVERSATION NEEDS TO CONTINUE
ON SO WE CAN REALLY FIND A WAY
TO GET THE MONEY THAT'S ALREADY
THERE. GET PEOPLE OFF THE
STREETS IN THE SERVICES THEY
NEED INTO HOUSING GET OUR
STREETS CLEAN GET OUR PEOPLE
HEALTHY I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
MISTER COOLEY.
COLLEAGUES ON PLEASE RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL LAST YEAR
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION HAD
A RECOMMENDATION THIS AREA THAT
THE.
THERE BE A PUBLIC.
PUBLICATION STATEWIDE OF
COUNTIES THAT HAVE BEEN EXPENDED
FUNDS
I HAD THAT BILL THE GOVERNOR
VETOED THAT BILL.
IT WAS SIMPLY GOING TO PUT
INFORMATION OUT THERE ABOUT
THESE DOLLARS WHICH ARE
DISCUSSING IN THE CONTEXT OF
THIS BILL.
PUT OUT THERE IN THE PUBLIC
REALM WHAT MONEY WAS AVAILABLE
THAT BILL WENT TO THE GOVERNOR
AS I SEE IT WAS A NUMBER ONE
HOOVER COMMISSION.
RECOMMENDATION HE VETOED IT.
SO I ACTUALLY THINK THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT EVOLUTION.
IF
IF WE CAN'T GET APPROVAL TO
SIMPLY HAVE THE INFORMATION OUT
THERE ON INTERNET WEBSITE.
THEN I THINK
CREIGHTON A SYSTEM SO THAT
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE CLOSE TO
THE SCENE OF ISSUES UNDERSTAND
THE LOCAL PROBLEMS SEE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM.
SEE THE DOLLARS WHICH ARE NOT
BEING EXPENDED THEIR DISTRICT SO
THAT THEY CAN GET THEIR VOICE
AND SAY.
WE CAN DO THIS IN ONE OF OUR
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES MONNOW
INDIO.
DEL NORTE
THIS IS A BILL THAT WILL EMPOWER.
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA IN ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES TO IDENTIFY
LOCAL NEEDS AND BRING THAT
FORWARD THIS IS NOT AS MUCH A
BILL ABOUT RELEASING DOLLARS.
AS A BILL ABOUT RELEASING ENERGY.
ON PROBLEMS IN CRUISE UP AND
DOWN THE STATE I THINK IS A
FUNCTION OF US AS LAWMAKERS WE
SHOULD BE TRYING TO RELEASE
ENERGY IN OUR COMMUNITIES. THIS
IS AN EXCELLENT BILL HONORED
TONIGHT VOTE.
THEY WHICH COOLEY MISTER
MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I JUST WANT
TO ADD TO ALL THE BUILDING ANGER
OVER THIS ISSUE OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH RESERVES I CHAIR THE
JOINT LESS AN AUDIT COMMITTEE
AND WE HAD A. A HEARING JUST A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO AND THERE
WAS BIPARTISAN ANGER OVER
TESTIMONY OVER SIXTY PERCENT AND
RESERVE IS BEING HELD ON THESE
MENTAL HEALTH DOLLARS THAT NEED
TO BE SPENT ON OUR STREETS.
HELPING THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
SUFFERING AND SO WE NEED TO MAKE
CHANGES AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THE WHISPERS YOU MISTER DALLI.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I.
REGRETFULLY HAVE TO STAND UP IN
OPPOSITION FOR FOR SOMEBODY WHO
SERVED.
SIXTEEN YEARS ON THE BOARD OF AS
THE PROBLEM IS NOT.
THE FACT THAT.
THEY'RE NOT SPENT THE MONEY WE
IF YOU REALLY WANT TO GET THE
SERVICES TO THE FOLKS ON MIL
HELP YOU NEED TO.
REMOVE THE BARRIERS THERE ARE
HARD TO GET THIS MONEY OUT.
THERE ARE THERE SO MANY
REGULATIONS RULES ON THE PROP
SIXTY THREE MONIES AND I WOULD
SHARE WITH YOU THE CITIES. AND
THE SPECIAL DISTRICT I WOULD.
I'VE NEVER SEEN SPECIAL IS TO
GIVE. THESE GUYS SERVICES BUT
THE CITY WILL HAVE THE SAME
BARRIERS THAT ARE THE COUNTIES
ARE FACED WITH. AND SO I URGE
YOU KNOW VOTERS WE GO BACK AND
WE ACTUALLY REMOVE THAT
REGULATED REGULATORY PROCESSES
THAT ALLOW US TO GET THE
SERVICES THESE FOLKS.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT ADAM FROM
MY COLLEAGUES TO THE FAR NORTH.
AT.
PERHAPS THAT WAS THE CASE IN
YOUR COUNTY.
BUT I'M I RISE IN SUPPORT OF OF
THIS BILL BECAUSE WE WE HAPPEN
TO LIVE IN A COUNTY. WHERE
THERE'S JUST A REFUSAL TO SPEND
THIS MONEY THAT THERE'S JUST NO
POLITICAL WILL? TO SPEND THE
MONEY ON THE SERVICES THAT ARE
NECESSARY BECAUSE THERE'S THIS
IDEA THAT BY SOMEHOW HOARDING
THIS MONEY THAT THEY'RE IN A
BETTER FISCAL POSITION
REGARDLESS OF THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE PEOPLE DYING ON THE STREETS
OF SAN DIEGO. WE HAVE OTHER
ENTITIES WILLING TO PUT IN
SERVICES TO DO THE HARD WORK TO
ABIDE BY BY THE INITIATIVE AND
ACTUALLY PROVIDE SERVICES SO
WHEN YOU HAVE A A SUPERVISOR A
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS LIKE WE
HAVE IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY THERE
IS NOTHING ELSE BUT DESPERATION
THAT WE CAN. DO THAT TO PRESENT
A BILL LIKE THIS I WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR PAYING
FOR THIS BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AYE I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL I
JUST WANT TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
OF OF THE.
ALLOWING THE MONEY TO COME OUT
I SIT ON SOMEONE ELSE ON HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES BUT ON
SOMEONE WE HAD A LONG LONG.
PAINFUL DISCUSSION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ABOUT RELEASING THE
MONEY AND WHY THAT THE REASON
THAT THEY HAD NOT
SO I.
WANT TO ASSURE YOU THAT WE'RE
WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
REGULATIONS ARE LEFT IT FROM THE
STATE BECAUSE THAT WAS THE
BIGGEST ARGUMENT. ABOUT ONE OF
THE COMMENTS WAS THAT THE
PROCESS IS VERY COMPLICATED AND
ONE OF THE COMMENTS THAT I MADE.
WAS WHY THE PROCESS SO
COMPLICATED AND THEY SAID I
ASKED THEM WHO CREATES THE
PROCESS AND THEY CREEK PROCESS
MY QUESTION TO THEM IS OR MY
COMMENT TO THEM WITH YOU CANNOT
COMPLAIN ABOUT A PROCESS THAT
YOU CREATE. AND SO THE ISSUES
THAT YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT ARE
BEING ADDRESSED THROUGH SOMEONE.
THIS IS IN COORDINATION WITH
THAT WE ARE WORKING VERY DID A
VERY HARD.
THE.
CHAIR OF SOMEONE IS ONBOARD
WITH THIS I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK
FOR HIM BUT. WHEN WE WERE IN
COMMITTEE WE WERE TALKING TO THE
DEPARTMENT ABOUT MAKING THOSE
REGULATIONS LOOSER SO THAT THE
COUNTIES CAN.
ACCESS THAT MONEY AND THIS
ISN'T GOING TO.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA BUT.
.
THE THIS BILL IT IN CONJUNCTION
WITH OUR EFFORTS IN SOMEONE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT MONEY IS
RELEASED TO THE COUNTY SOLD TO
ADDRESS YOUR ISSUE WE ARE
WORKING REALLY HARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE DEPARTMENTS ARE
RESPONSIVE TO THE COUNTIES. AND
THAT THAT MONEY IS RELEASED AND
SO THIS BILL IS IN CONJUNCTION
WITH OUR REQUEST AND SOMEONE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT MONEY IS
RELIEF. THANK YOU.
MISS QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND MISTER
SPEAKER.
I ACTUALLY RISE TO ASK US TO
TAKE A PAUSE ON THIS AND
ALTHOUGH I RESPECT MY COLLEAGUES.
UP I WANT TO BE THE FIRST TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT ORANGE COUNTY
IS WITH THE COUNTY THAT REALLY
HAS HAD THE MOST MONEY AND HAS
SPENT THE LEAST.
THIS IS A PROBLEM IT'S A PROBLEM
THAT WAS MENTIONED THAT MANY
PEOPLE ARE ASKING WHERE ARE
THESE FUNDS HOW MUCH DO WE HAVE
AND WHY HAVEN'T WE USE THOSE.
AND WHEN I LOOKED OUT IT IT'S
OVER TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THIS IS SERIOUS WHEN WE'VE HAD A
WHAT HAS BEEN FRONT PAGE NEWS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY REALLY. OUGHT
WITH TWO TO THREE THOUSAND
PEOPLE LIVING IN ANA RIVER BED.
WE HAD A FEDERAL JUDGE COME MEN
AND DEMAND THAT WE START TO USE
THESE FUNDS.
BUT.
BECAUSE OF AS WAS SAID SOME
UNWILLING NO SOMETIMES A.
BARRIERS MULTIPLE REASONS THOSE
FUNDS HAVE NOT BEEN USED SO I
COULD EASILY STAND UP HERE AND
SAY WILL TAKE THAT MONEY USE IT
SOMEWHERE ELSE OF SOMEBODY ELSE
CAN USE THAT. KIND OF THE USE IT
OR LOSE IT THEME AND AS AN
EDUCATOR I'VE SEEN THAT AND MARK
OUR PROFESSION MANY TIMES. BUT
MY.
REQUEST IS WE KNOW THERE'S
HOUSING ISSUES WE KNOW THERE'S
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES WE KNOW
THERE ARE LOCAL ISSUES AND BY
SAYING IF YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
USE THAT LET'S SWEEP IT UP
SOMEWHERE ELSE THAT MAKES.
I IT EVEN MORE OF A PROBLEM SO I
DO NOT SUPPORT THIS BECAUSE WE
JUST HAD AN AUDIT WE KNOW THE
MONEY IS THERE AND SO I SAY
LET'S GO BACK TO OUR COUNTIES.
LET'S MAKE SURE THEY'RE CLEAR
AND GIVE THEM ANOTHER ADDITIONAL
TIME TO USE THAT MONEY AND THEN
BY ALL MEANS.
TAKE IT IF THERE BUT LET THAT
KNOW THE CLARITY OF WHAT'S BEING
PROPOSED HERE AND I WILL BE THE
FIRST TO TALK TO MY COUNTY. BUT
BY TONIGHT JUST SAYING LET'S GO
AHEAD AND TAKE IT TO ANOTHER
COUNTY WE ARE GOING TO THEN BE
MAKING.
PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE
PARTICULARLY IN ORANGE COUNTY
EVEN WORSE SO I WILL BE ON THE
PHONE TONIGHT WITH OUR
SUPERVISORS BUT I ASK FOR A NO
VOTE TONIGHT.
MISTER FRAZIER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES.
I HAPPEN TO SERVE ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH CAUCUS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WAS SENATOR JIM BELL.
AND IN THESE MEETINGS THAT WE'VE
HAD WE'VE HAD REPORTS BY.
THE AUDIT COMMITTEES AND AND
AND MESA GOING FORWARD TELLING
US HOW INEFFECTIVE THE PROCESS
HAS BEEN. I WANT BECAUSE OF
THESE REPORTS I'VE GONE OUT IN
MY DISTRICT AND TOURED MENTAL
HEALTH FACILITIES NOW YOU
REMEMBER THERE WAS A
DIMINISHMENT. OF MENTAL HEALTH
HOSPITALS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND DUE TO THAT WAS THE THE
REASON FOR PROP SIXTY THREE.
SO NOW IN MY MY DISTRICT WE
DON'T HAVE PEDIATRIC. OF.
OF CRISIS BEDS.
WE DON'T HAVE PEDIATRIC ANYTHING
BUT WE HAVE TWENTY THREE BEDS
FOUR OF A COUNTY OF IF YOU KNOW
HUNDRED.
OR FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE YOU
THINK ABOUT.
WHAT IT WOULD TAKE TO BE ABLE TO
DO TO ACCOMPLISH THIS TASK?
THERE'S NOTHING MOVING FORWARD.
YOU GO TO CRISIS YOU GET TWENTY
THREE HOURS IF IF THEN YOU'RE
BUMPED OUT OF CRISIS THEN YOU GO
TO THE THE HOSPITAL FOR. FOR
POSSIBLY SEVENTY TWO ON A FIFTY
ONE FIFTY THEN AFTER THAT YOU
END UP IN COUNTY JAIL.
WE DON'T HAVE CAPACITY.
WHAT WE OUR IS HURTING THE
PEOPLE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO HELP?
SITTING ON THIS MONEY WAITING
ANOTHER YEAR.
BY HOLDING OFF IS GONNA DO
NOBODY ANY HARM WHAT WE NEED TO
DO IS MOVE THIS BILL OUT.
AND WORK ON IT SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE. TO HELP THE PEOPLE
THAT THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
VOTED FOR PROP SIXTY THREE.
TO HELP THIS PROBLEM.
I ABSOLUTELY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THINGS FRAZIER.
SHE BROKE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I FEEL
COMPELLED TO FOLLOW UP ON A FROM
MY COLLEAGUE FROM FULLER TIN.
SHACKS WHO REALLY HIT THE NAIL
ON THE HEAD.
IN ORANGE COUNTY HOW WE HAVE
OVER TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
TO ADDRESS THIS
AND I COME AT THIS FROM SERVING
AT THE VA WHERE BACK IN THE TWO
THOUSANDS TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF
HOMELESS FOR VETERANS.
WELL I ALSO STARTED A HOMELESS
TASK FORCE ON THE DANA POINT
CITY COUNCIL BUT I REALIZE THE
GOVERNMENT WASN'T THE ANSWER SO
ON THAT. TASK FORCE WE PUT
ORGANIZATIONS TO DO THIS FOR A
LIVING WE HAVE FAMILY ASSISTANCE
MINISTRIES
A CATHOLIC CHURCH THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE PUT ALL THESE GROUPS
ON. AND WHAT THE COUNTY NEEDS TO
DO IS THEY NEED TO OUR OF P. THE
MONEY OUT TO THESE GROUPS TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES.
THE COUNTY CANNOT MANAGE THIS ON
THEIR OWN.
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM FULLER TO
MENTION A JUDGE HAD TO STEP IN
FOR THE COUNTY OF ORANGE TO EVEN
DO ANYTHING.
THE FIRST ACTION WAS TO CLEAR
ATTEND CITY BY ANGEL STADIUM.
THIS IS MORE THAN JUST
HOMELESSNESS
THEY FOUND DRUG ADDICTS THEY
FOUND TEN THOUSAND NEEDLES THEY
FOUND A CRIME SYNDICATE THEY
FOUND THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
STOLEN BICYCLES. THEY FOUND SEX
RINGS IN THESE HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS
SO.
AGAIN I COULDN'T AGREE MORE WITH
MY COLLEAGUE FROM FULLER TEN
THAT WE NEED TO HOUND ON THE
COUNTY SUPERVISORS TO COME UP
WITH A PLAN LOCALLY. AND GET
THAT MONEY OUT TO THE
PROFESSIONALS THE DO THIS FOR A
LIVING I ASK FOR NO VOTE ON THIS
AND LET'S GO BACK TO OUR
COUNTIES AND URGED HIM TO
DEVELOP A PLAN. TO GET THE HELP
TO THE PEOPLE ON THE STREETS.
I. THINK MR PEROT.
DOCTOR WEBER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY THREE.
YOU KNOW WE'VE TALKED A LOT IN
THIS HOUSE ABOUT OUR NEEDS I'VE
HEARD MANY OF YOU GET UP WELL
JUST A FEW SECONDS AGO AND TALK
ABOUT THE GROWING OPIUM. KIND OF
ADDICTION PROBLEM THAT YOU'RE
HAVING IN YOUR COMMUNITY AND
SOME OF THE US TALK EXTENSIVELY
ABOUT THE HOMELESS AND ON AND ON
AND ON. AND YET ARE COUNTIES ARE
THAT REALLY THE ARM OF THE STATE
WHOSE TASK IS TO BASICALLY
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAMS THAT WE
PUT IN PLACE.
IF THEY'RE NOT GOING TO DO THAT
THEN WE BECOME INEFFECTIVE EVEN
IN OUR ABILITY TO MEET THOSE
NEEDS. AND I'M SURE MOST OF YOU
HEARD FROM YOUR MEMBERS OF THESE
I HEAR FROM CONSTITUENTS WHY
DON'T WE HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES WHY DON'T WE HAVE ME
MONEY FOR MENTAL HEALTH WHY
DON'T WE HAVE COUNSELING
PROGRAMS OF ALL THESE THINGS.
AND I'M SAYING TO THEM WELL WE
FUNDED IT WE GAVE IT TO THE
COUNTY WE DID THIS DO THAT AND I
COUNTY HAS NOT DONE ANYTHING
WITH IT. THERE IS NO
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE MONEY
THAT'S THERE IN TERMS OF US AS
THE AGENCY THAT GAVE THEM THE
MONEY TO DO THE PROGRAMS THAT
WE'VE IDENTIFIED. AND SO IF
WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO THAT THEN
WHO THE HECK ARE WE. I MEAN
WE'RE GIVING MONEY AND WOULD NOT
A DEMANDING THAT THEY USE IT I
DON'T BELIEVE THERE ARE COUNTY
FOLKS ABED STUPID THAT THEY
CAN'T FIGURE OUT HOW TO USE THE
MONEY THAT THEY GET THAT WE'VE
GIVEN THEM. SOME OF YOU GIVEN
GREAT RECOMMENDATIONS PARTNER
WOULD NONPROFITS ALL THOSE
THINGS ARE ELIGIBLE THE A THAT
THEY CAN DO. THEY CHOOSE NOT TO
AND THAT'S ONE OF THINGS WE HAVE
TO DEAL WITH IT'S NOT THAT THE
LACK OF INFORMATION MOST OF OUR
COUNTIES HAVE STAFF HAVE PEOPLE
WHOSE JOBS ARE TO RUN THE COUNTY.
TO DEAL WITH IT THE VARIOUS
ISSUES TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
MANAGEMENT OF THE RESOURCES IS
THERE AND IF THEY GET YOU GOING
TO GIVE THEM A COUPLE YEARS THIS
EXPENDABLE AND THEY CAN'T FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DO IT. THAN SOMEONE
ELSE TO TAKE THE RESOURCES
THEY'RE NOT THERE TO BANK THE
MONEY THAT THEY'RE TO IMPLEMENT
THE PROGRAMS THAT THE STATE HAS
PUT IN PLACE FOR THEM TO DO WITH
THE DOLLARS THAT WE'VE GIVEN
THEM. SO I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOUR
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS I KNOW
ABOUT MINE AND SO MANY OTHERS
THAT THAT ARE NOT MEETING THE
NEEDS OF THE PEOPLE IN THOSE IN
THOSE COUNTIES. AND THEY AND
THAT THE BECAUSE THE COUNTIES
ARE SO LARGE IN THE CONSTITUENCY
GROUPS ARE SO HUGE THEY CAN
PRETTY MUCH HIDE AND NOT
SPENDING MONEY. SO I REALLY
THINK THAT IS NOW TIME THAT WE
THE FISH OR CUT BAIT YOU GOTTA
DO WHAT YOU GOTTA DO AND THEY
KNOW BECAUSE MOST OF YOU HAVE
COMPLAIN TO THEM. YOUR
CONSTITUENTS HAVE COMPLAINED
THAT WOULD NOT GETTING THE
SERVICES THAT WE NEED AND WHEN
WE SIT AROUND AND TALK ABOUT THE
GROWING HOMELESS PROP POPULATE
PROBLEM WE TALK ABOUT THE DRUG
ADDICTION PROBLEM WE TALK ABOUT
THE BASICALLY THE RACIAL ISSUES
IN COUNTIES AND ON AND ON AND ON.
IF THEY'RE NOT GOING TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM THEN WE NEED TO LET
SOMEONE
THE SCHOOLS OR THE CITY OR
SOMEONE ELSE THAT AREA HANDLE IT.
I GUARANTEE YOU IF THIS PASSES
THEY WILL FIGURE OUT HOW TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA THEY WILL FIGURE OUT
HOW TO USE THE MONEY THEY'RE NOT
GONNA LET THIS MONEY GO AWAY
THAT'S FOR SURE. THEY WILL THEN
GET UP AND DO WHAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO WOULD JUST
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAMS THAT
APPEAR SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I BOTH THE TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY THREE. THAT WE STOP*
FOOTING AROUND AND MAKE UP MY
MIND THAT THIS IS WHAT WE WANT
TO DO AND THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
MONEY WE GIVE THEM BECAUSE THAT
WE HAVE ALMOST NO OF THE ARM. OF
THE OTHER THAN THE COUNTY AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL TO IMPLEMENT THESE
PROGRAMS I HOPE YOU WILL JOIN US
FOR ONCE AND AND BASICALLY GOLF
AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY THREE.
I DUCKED WEBER.
MR MATHIS.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
AS MY COLLEAGUE STATED EARLY WE
DID DEBATE THIS INSULT ONE.
AND WE DID TALK ABOUT HOW YOU
KNOW THE COUNTIES NEED TO DO A
BETTER JOB.
ABOUT SPENDING THESE MONIES.
AND I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE
WITH THAT I THINK WE ALL AGREE
THAT. WHEN IT COMES TO MENTAL
HEALTH WE ARE EXTREMELY LACKING
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ON
HELPING OUR PEOPLE OUT.
HOWEVER.
WITH A V. TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
THREE.
IT WHAT THIS BILL ACTUALLY DOES
IS IT STRIPS AWAY THAT MONEY
THAT WE NEED FOR MENTAL HEALTH
AND GIVES IT.
TO THE CITIES FOR PET PROJECTS.
SO I'LL ASK YOU TO VOTE NO ON
THIS LET'S KEEP THE MONEY WITH
THE COUNTIES OF MENTAL HEALTH
BUT LET'S HAILED OUR COUNTIES TO
DO THE RIGHT THING. IT IS SPINEL
MONEY ON MENTAL HEALTH WHERE IT
BELONGS.
BEGIN MEMBERS I ASK FOR A NO
VOTE KEEP THE MONEY WITH MENTAL
HEALTH DO NOT LET IT GO TO CITY
PET PROJECTS.
THINK THIS MATHIS SEEING.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
MISTER GLORIA YOU MAY CLOSE.
MISTER GLORIA. YOU MAKE LOVE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
WAS THAT WE SPARKED A PRETTY
GOOD DEBATE HERE THIS EVENING I
THINK IT'S CLEAR THAT THIS HOUSE
WANTS TO SEE CHANGE AND IT COMES
TO PROP SIXTY THREE. ARE VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIA WENT TO THE POLLS
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR
FOURTEEN YEARS AGO AND AUTHORIZE
THIS TAX IN THAT LENGTH OF TIMETHIS TAX IS.
YIELD AT ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TODAY AFTER AS
THE STATE AUDITOR REPORTED TWO
POINT FIVE BILLION OF IT SITS IN
ACCOUNTS ACROSS THE STATE. NOT
HELPING A SINGLE SOUL WHO IS
GRAPPLING WITH THE ISSUES OF
MENTAL ILLNESS
MEMBERS NOT ONE OF YOU CAN HAVE
A TOWN HALL MEETING WE DON'T
HAVE CONSTITUENTS THEY'RE
TALKING TO YOU ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS.
YOU ALL HAVE HOME THAT VETERANS
WHO RETURN TO YOUR DISTRICTS
DEALING WITH POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS ANOTHER MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES ALL OF YOU HAVE
ISSUES OF ADDICTION. AYE IN YOUR
COMMUNITIES ALL OF YOU KNOW THAT
CHANGE HAS TO HAPPEN THE
COUNTIES HAVE HAD FOURTEEN YEARS
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT THIS THEY
HAVE TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS HOW MANY ISSUES DO WE
SPEAK ABOUT ON THIS FLOOR. WE
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS THEM IN
THIS PARTICULAR CASE WE HAVE TWO
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS WORTH
OF RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THIS
THIS BILL IS AGAIN VERY SIMPLE
THEY ALREADY HAVE THREE YEARS
THEY MUST BEEN THESE DOLLARS.
BACKED INTO THREE YEARS IT IS A
IT IS A IS A HOLLOW.
DEADLINE BECAUSE THEY KEEP THE
MONEY THEY HOLD IN THE COUNT
THIS AS THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT CITIES THAT HOSPITAL
DISTRICTS OTHERS CAN APPLY FOR
THESE MONIES WE CAN SAVE LIVES
WITH THIS MONEY. THIS MONEY
THING A BANK ACCOUNT DOES NOT
SAVE A SINGLE LIFE BUT WE CAN DO
MORE I HEAR THE CONCERNS IN THIS
ROOM I WANT EXTREMELY CLEAR THIS
BILL IS A WORK IN PROGRESS I
WORK WITH EVERYONE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE GET REAL CHANGE ON THIS
BECAUSE TIME'S UP ON THE
COUNTIES WE MUST DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS CHALLENGE IF YOU HAVE
A HOMELESS PERSON YOUR DISTRICT
IF YOU HAVE A VETERAN GRAPPLING
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS IF YOU HAVE
CHILDREN WHO NEED A COUNSELOR.
YOU NEED TO VOTE FOR THIS BILL
YOU HAVE NO CHOICE I ASK YOU FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
NAMES GLORIA WITHOUT CLERK WHO
OVER THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS THOUGH
IS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DECIDED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR
MISTER GLORIA MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS I AM GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL.
ON.
MR HOLDINGS FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO
WHICH IS A B. THIRTY ONE FORTY
SIX THE CLERK WILL POST.
HOMEOWNERS VOTER WISH TO VOTE.
WELL MEMBERS VOTER WHICH TO VOTE.
SURE HOLDEN REPLACES A CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM FIFTY.
AB TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO FILE ITEM
SIXTY THREE FIRST.
THIS IS
THREE FIRST AND THIS IS AB
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR.
THIS IS MISTER. THURMOND.
IF MR THURMOND WANTS TO TAKE
THIS ITEM UP AT THIS TIME.
COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY FOUR BY SOME A MEMBER
THERE MEANT AND THAT KIND OF
HEALTH FACILITIES.
MR THURMAN YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES ARISE RESENT AB
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR. THIS
IS A BILL THAT SEEKS TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES.
AGAINST HOSPITAL CLOSURES THAT
WOULD HAVE DISASTROUS IMPACTS.
ON MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES TO
SET THE CONTEXT.
ALLOW ME TO TALK ABOUT WHAT HAS
HAPPENED AND IS HAPPENING. IN MY
DISTRICT.
I JUST A FEW YEARS AGO.
THE MAIN HOSPITAL SERVE.
MANY OF THE CONSTITUENTS IN THE
RICHMOND SAN PABLO AREA CLOSEST.
LEAVING MANY AND MY COMMUNITY.
WITHOUT IN EMERGENCY ROOM AND
WITHOUT VITAL SERVICES
TO SUPPORT OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND CREATING LONG DELAYS IN THE
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT INDIVIDUALS
TRAVEL TO SEEK EMERGENCY CARE.
AS WE SPEAK ANOTHER HOSPITAL.
IS PREPARING TO CLOSE AND
ANOTHER LOSS EMERGENCY ROOM AND
WE'RE SEEING. THIS TREND ALL
ACROSS THE STATE.
THE BILL BEFORE YOU.
ENVISIONS.
A PROCESS WHERE WHEN THEY WILL
BE A HOSPITAL CLOSURE. THAT WE
WILL MAXIMIZE AS MUCH NOTICE TO
THE COMMUNITY AS POSSIBLE SO THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS KNOW ABOUT THE
CLOSURES.
WE'VE HEARD FROM MANY OF YOU HAD
CONCERNS ABOUT.
THE ORIGINAL DIRECTION OF THE
BILL.
AND.
BEFORE YOU IS A MOCK UP OF HOW
WE INTEND. TO MODIFY AMEND THE
BILL.
TO PRIORITIZE PROVIDING MORE
COMMUNICATION.
OF WHAT IS ALREADY REQUIRED THE
PROVIDING MORE TIME FOR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO GET INPUT
ABOUT A CLOSURE SO THAT. THEY
CAN MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS
ABOUT THEIR HEALTH CARE NEEDS.
A VOTE FOR THIS BILL TONIGHT.
IS A VOTE TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH.
WE INTEND AMEND THIS BILL TO
REMOVE ANY REFERENCE TO APPROVAL
OF A CLOSURE FROM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. THIS BILL SIMPLY.
WILL BE AMENDED.
TO SAY THAT WE MUST GIVE AS MUCH
NOTICE AS POSSIBLE. TO OUR
RESIDENTS
WHEN THERE IS A PROPOSED CLOSURE
OF A HOSPITAL OR REDUCTION IN.
IN MEDICAL SERVICES
IN BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC
INTERESTS.
AND PROTECTING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU WAS THERE IN.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE BILL.
COR CLUB IN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
MR THURBER MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS OF FIFTY.
AB TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED BY MISTER
KALRA CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY CONSUMER
LOANS.
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
BUT WITH THE OPTION TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED FOR YOU
TODAY.
BY NOW WE HAVE ALL COLLECTIVELY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS ISSUE.
BY NOW WE'VE ALL HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY PROCESS AND DIGEST
HOW PREDATORY LENDING. HARMS OUR
COMMUNITIES.
BY NOW WE SHOULD ALL KNOW THAT
WE'VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RIGHT A WRONG.
TO CORRECT A MISTAKE MADE THIRTY
FIVE YEARS AGO THAT ALLOWED
PREDATORY LENDING TO GAIN A
FOOTHOLD. IN OUR STATE.
UNDER THE PRETENSE OF INCREASING
COMPETITION TO LOWER RATES THIS
LEGISLATURE. REMOVED THE RATE
STRUCTURE FOR LOANS BETWEEN
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED AND TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN SUCCESSIVE
LEGISLATIVE SESSIONS IN THE
EARLY NINETEEN EIGHTIES.
HOWEVER ALTHOUGH WE HAVE SEEN
COMPETITION INCREASED OVER THE
LAST THREE DECADES WE HAVE NOT
SEEN A DECREASE IN RATES.
RATHER WE HAVE WATCH RATES
SKYROCKET WERE MANY LETTERS NOW
ISSUE LOANS WITH INTEREST RATES
ANYWHERE FROM ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT TO AS HIGH AS THREE
HUNDRED PERCENT.
IN FACT ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT NEARLY SIXTY
PERCENT OF INSTALLMENT LOANS A
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED TO FIVE
THOUSAND HAD A PR IS A HUNDRED
PERCENT. OR HIGHER.
THESE ARE UNCONSCIONABLE
INTEREST RATES THAT PLACE
SERIOUS AND DEBILITATING IMPACTS
ON THE. ECONOMIC SECURITY AND
CREDIT OF LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES.
DEEP ALL RATES ARE CALMLY AS
HIGH AS FORTY PERCENT OR HIGHER.
BUT IS TO THAT IS AT LEAST TWO
OUT OF EVERY FIVE LOANS OR MORE.
THIS IS NOT ACCESS TO CREDIT.
THIS IS ACCESS TO UNIMAGINABLE
UNMANAGEABLE DEBT. AND DESTROYED
CREDIT.
THIS IS NOT JUST A POLICY ISSUE
THIS IS A MORAL ISSUE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
PERJURY LETTERS NOT JUST USE
EXORBITANTLY HIGH INTEREST RATES
TO ENTRAP BORROWERS.
THE USE LENDING TRACTORS THAT
MISLEAD MISREPRESENT ULTIMATELY
PENALIZE HARDWORKING AND
IMPOVERISHED COMMUNITIES.
THEY SPECIFICALLY MARKET TWENTY
SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR LOANS NOW WHY
IS THAT. TO GET ABOVE THE LOAN
CAP THAT EXISTS A TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED AND WHERE THEY MARKETED
ON HIP HOP STATION SPANISH
LANGUAGE STATIONS IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. HOW DO I KNOW THIS
BECAUSE MY DISTRICT HAS ONE OF
THE HIGHEST DENSITIES A
PREDATORY LENDING STORE FRONTS
IN THE STATE?
IN FACT THERE ARE MORE FINANCIAL
LENDERS IN CALIFORNIA. THE THERE
ARE MCDONNELL'S.
OVER THE PAST TWO MONTHS WE HAVE
WORKED HARD TO RESPOND ALL
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE ASSEMBLY
BANKING AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
WHICH HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED BY THE
AMENDMENTS MADE EARLIER THIS
WEEK. I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
BANKING ON WORKING WITH US ON
THOSE.
I KEPT MY DOOR OPEN TO ALL
PARTIES ESPECIALLY THE
OPPOSITION TO WORK WITH ME ON
THIS BILL.
HOWEVER MANY HAVE REFUSED TO
NEGOTIATE BECAUSE THEY'RE
UNWILLING TO DISCUSS ANYTHING
UNTIL THE RATE CAP IS REMOVED
FROM THIS BILL.
THAT THAT'S WHAT IT TAKES TO
BRING THEM TO THE TABLE BUT THAT
IS SOMETHING I'M UNWILLING TO DO.
BECAUSE IT IS A FUNDAMENTAL
PANACHE PROTECTION THAT EXISTS
IN AT LEAST TWENTY EIGHT OTHER
STATES AND IS EXPLICITLY
PROVIDED TO FOR UP. FOR OUR
ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY UNDER THE
FEDERAL MILITARY FUNDING ACT.
WHY SHOULD CALIFORNIA STATE THAT
IS REGULARLY REFERRED TO AS A
LEADER?
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION EQUALITY
AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE
TAKE A STEP BACKWARDS A STEP
BEHIND OTHER STATES SUCH AS
FLORIDA GEORGIA KANSAS ARKANSAS.
KENTUCKY IN OKLAHOMA ALL WHO
OPERATE CAP LOWER THAT THIRTY
SIX PERCENT TODAY.
MANY HAVE BEEN TOLD BLOOD
REFUSED TO MEET WITH OPPOSITION
BUT ARE NOT ALLOWED CREDIT SURE
IS TO BE CALCULATED OUTSIDE THE
RATE CAP AND THAT WE HAVE
SHIFTED THE GOAL POSTS ON THE
BILL. ALL OF THIS IS UNTRUE.
FROM THE BEGINNING WE ASSURE
THAT THIS BILL IS MODELED AFTER
THE MILITARY LENDING ACT WHICH
IS MORE RESTRICTIVE THAN AB
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED. AND A CLOSE
ALL REQUIRES ALL CHARGES FEES
AND PRODUCTS TO BE CALCULATED
WITHIN THE THIRTY SIX PERCENT
CAP.
ADDITIONALLY AMENDMENTS MADE
THIS WEEK ALLOW CREDIT INSURANCE
TO BE OFFERED AND CALCULATED
OUTSIDE THE CAB ORIGINATION FEES.
TO BE CALCULATED OUTSIDE THE CAB.
WE'VE WORKED HARD TO RESPOND TO
AN ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF
RESPONSIBLE LENDERS AND ALTHOUGH
SOME DO NOT SUPPORT. SUPPORT
THIS BILL IT DOES REFLECT THEIR
CURRENT BUSINESS PRACTICES.
THIS BILL AS A MODEL COMPROMISED
NEITHER LENDERS NO CONSUMER
ADVOCATES ARE PERFECTLY HAPPY.
HOWEVER THERE ARE BOTH CERTAINLY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
INCLUDING A HUNDRED DIFFERENT
ASSUME ADVOCATES AND
JURISDICTIONS LIKE THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES CITIES SAMPSON'S GO.
CITY OF SAN JOSE AND OTHERS.
PRE FINAL POINTS.
FIRST OF ALL.
THIS IS A BIPARTISAN ISSUE
THIRTY SECONDS MISTER KALRA TWO
THOUSAND SIX GEORGE W. BUSH SET
A POLICY OF THIRTY SIX PERCENT
CAPITA ALL LOANS. PRESIDENT
OBAMA FURTHER STRENGTHENED IT
AND.
UP IF THOSE MONIES THIRTY STATES
HAVE LOANS A BUBBLE CAPS LOWER
THAT. NUMBER TWO. ESTATES WERE A
CAB THIRTY SIX PERCENT BELOW
EXIST CREDIT DID NOT DRY UP YES
PREDATORY LENDERS UPTOWN TO
RESPONSIBLE LETTERS CREDIT IS A
SOCIALLY MINDED BANKS ENTERED
THE MARKET DO WHAT IS RIGHT.
FINALLY PREDATORY LENDING IS
EXPANDING PEOPLE OF COLOR SENIOR
SERVICE MEMBERS AND VETERANS ARE
BEING TARGETED AT HIGHER RATES
IF WE DO NOT WE DO NOTHING TO
REGULATE. ALL INSTALLMENT LOANS
WOULD ONLY CONTINUE TO GET WORSE
ART CONSTITUENTS BETTER ING
INSIST.
BETTER INSTINCTS TO DETEST.
THE SCOURGE OF PREDATORY LENDING
OUR OWN BETTER INSTINCTS DEMAND
THAT WE ACT AND WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
MISTER TANG. HERE RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU BUT SPEAKER I RISE.
AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF AB
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED.
LOANS UNDER FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A RETREAT TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED TO FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL LOANS.
THE LOANS THAT PEOPLE NEED WHEN
THEY'RE IN DESPERATE NEED OF
PAYING BILLS PAYING RENT MAKING
CRITICAL CRITICAL FINANCIAL
DECISIONS.
AND ONE OF THE REASONS I'M
SUPPORTING MISSED MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN JOSE'S BILL. IS A STORY
THAT I READ ABOUT IN THE LA
TIMES.
IT TALKED ABOUT A WOMAN JOANNE
HANSON HANSON FOR MENTAL SO
SANTA MARGARITA.
TWENTY FIFTEEN SHE WAS ACTUALLY
QUITE DESPERATE SHE NEEDED TO
PAY HER MEDICAL BILLS.
SHE WOULD RUN OUT OF ALL
DEFERRED OPTIONS
SO SHE WHERE IF YOU TOOK A LOAN
FOR A LITTLE BIT OVER FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND A HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
PERCENT INTEREST.
BUT THE HUNDRED IS SIXTEEN
PERCENT INTEREST IN WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE.
OVER SEVEN YEARS THE SHE HAD TO
PAY.
SHE HAS TO PAY FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE DOLLARS A MONTH.
FOR SEVEN YEARS.
FOR A TOTAL PAYMENT BACK OF
FORTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SO THAT MEANT THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS WITH AN
INTEREST.
SHE BY OUR FIVE THOUSAND TO
THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
ABSOLUTELY HAD TO BE PAID BACK
IN INTEREST.
NOW THIS LONGER CRITICAL WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THE COMMUNITIES
HERE HAVE ACCESS TO THESE LOANS.
BUT WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT PEOPLE AREN'T BEING TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF AND UNFORTUNATELY
THE FOLKS GOING TO GET THESE
LOANS.
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE AGAIN IN
DESPERATE STRAITS.
THERE YOU SEE PEOPLE WHO DON'T
HAVE THE BEST CREDIT THEY DON'T
HAVE A LINE OF CREDIT THEY'RE
NOT HOMEOWNERS TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
MENTORS PEOPLE PAY MEDICAL BILLS
PEOPLE PAYING. OTHER SORTS OF
OUR CREDIT CARD BILLS THINGS
THAT ACTUALLY ARE PAST DUE.
SO.
WE NEED TO FALL WITH SO MANY
OTHER STATES HAVE ALREADY DON.
IN SAID A REASONABLE INTEREST
RATE WHERE AGAIN LENDERS CAN
MAKE MONEY OKAY THE MAKE MONEY.
BUT
THE SAME TYPE THAT CONSUMERS
DON'T GET DOLLARS BUT THEY DON'T
SET. THE. FUTURE.
BACKWARDS IN ORDER TO GET THESE
LOANS AND THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN RENT OR FOOD
OR PAIN DOCTOR LENDERS.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
DRIVER.
MISTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
MEMBERS WE'VE WORKED VERY HARD
IN THIS LEGISLATURE THE LAST
NUMBER OF YEARS TO ADDRESS
POVERTY. IN CALIFORNIA WE PASSED
THE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT AND
EVERY YEAR WE ADD TO THAT WE
STRENGTHEN CAO WORKS WE
STRENGTHEN ALL THESE PROGRAMS
THAT ACTUALLY WORK TO LIFT
PEOPLE UP OUT OF POVERTY. AND
YET WHERE ONE OF THE LAST LARGE
STATES THAT ALLOWS.
RUN AWAY INTEREST RATES THAT
THEN TAKE THOSE SAME PEOPLE WE
ARE TRYING TO HELP WITH TAXPAYER
DOLLARS AND SEND ALL OF THAT
MONEY. INTO POTS WHERE THEY GET
INTO THESE DEBT CYCLES THAT THEY
CANNOT GET THEMSELVES OUTTA.
SO WE ARE KIDDING OURSELVES IF
WE THINK WE CAN BENEFIT THE POOR
AND NOT PUT STRUCTURES IN PLACE
TO TRY AND PROTECT THEM. FROM
PREDATORY LENDERS THERE ARE
PLENTY OF OTHER STATES HAVE DONE
THIS MANY OF THE STATES HAVE PUT
CAPS AND AND THOSE INDUSTRIES
SURVIVE.
PEOPLE DO HAVE ACCESS TO CAPITAL
WHICH IS ONE OF THE MAJOR
CONCERNS IN FACT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING IN THE LEGISLATURE TO
THE BANKING COMMITTEE. TO ENSURE
THAT THERE ARE. FLEXIBLE
PRODUCTS OUT THERE FOR PEOPLE TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF GET
THE CAPITAL THAT THEY NEED.
BUT WHY SHOULD JUST A FEW
PREDATORY LENDERS BE ABLE TO
PULL THAT MUCH MONEY OUT OF OUR
THE POOREST CALIFORNIANS IT IS
UNCONSCIONABLE AND I RESPECT
THAT. ARE AUTHOR FROM.
SAN JOSE IN THE WORK THAT HE HAS
DONE ON THIS HE'S ACTUALLY MOVE
THIS BILL QUITE AWAYS TRYING TO
DEAL WITH THE OPPOSITION TRYING
TO COME UP WITH REASONABLE
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THIS. I
RESPECT THAT WORK AND I THINK WE
NEED TO PASS THIS BILL TODAY AND
KEEP THIS.
CONVERSATION MOVING AND REALLY
ADDRESS THE ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTES.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS CRITICAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION FORWARD. I HAPPEN TO
LIKE HIM TO LIVE IN A DISTRICT.
IN FACT A COMMUNITY WHERE THERE
IS LITERALLY A A LOAN AVAILABLE.
ON EVERY SINGLE BLOCK
IT'S NOT THE KIND OF LOW THAT'S
AVAILABLE TO YOU AND I.
IT'S A KIND OF LOAN WHERE WHEN
YOU BORROW FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
BECAUSE YOUR MOTHER HAS DIED OR
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO GET
IMMIGRATION PAPERS IN ORDER. YOU
END UP SPENDING THE REST OF YOUR
LIFE IN A CYCLE OF POVERTY
TRYING TO PAY BACK THAT FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH ENDS UP
FORTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS AS WE
SAW FROM THE LA TIMES ARTICLE.
THAT'S ALL THAT'S AVAILABLE.
I KNOW WE CAN DO BETTER THAN
THAT. I KNOW THAT COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE WHERE THERE IS A
DESPERATION.
FOR CAPITAL IN ORDER TO KEEP
YOUR HEAD ABOVE WATER THAT WE
CAN PUT SOME SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE
THAT ACTUALLY PROTECT CONSUMERS
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I
REMEMBER THIS BILL COMING TO THE
FLOOR. IN AUTHORS DONE A GOOD
JOB IN MEETING WITH AND THE
OPPONENTS BUT THE INDUSTRIES ANY
IS WILLING TO MEET MORE.
BUT IF WE'RE NOT WILLING TO TAKE
THAT STEP FORWARD AND SAY THAT
THIS IS REALLY AN ISSUE AN ISSUE
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AND
WE NEED TO START WORKING ON IT.
THAT IT'S NEVER GOING TO CHANGE.
AND SO TODAY I ASK EVEN IF IT'S
NOT THE PERFECT BILL THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE AS A AS A CO AUTHOR
ON THIS BILL I ASK THAT YOU MOVE
IT FORWARD SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO
ENSURE. THAT THERE IS SOME
REASONABLE WAY FOR INDIVIDUALS
TO LIVE THEIR LIFE TO BORROW A
LITTLE MONEY WHEN THEY HAVE TO
WITHOUT SPENDING THE REST OF
THEIR LIFE IN A CYCLE OF DEBT
BECAUSE THEY FACED EMERGENCY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
MR.
THURMOND YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
FAMOUS SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
ARE RISING SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED.
YEAH SIMPLY PUT THERE SHOULD BE
SOME CAP ON THE INTEREST THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE ASKED.
PAY ON A LOAN THIS BILL DOES NOT
SAY THAT YOU CAN'T MAKE A LOT.
OUT WE RECOGNIZE THAT FOR MANY
OF THIS HAS BECOME A CHOICE OF
OF LANDING A BORROWING. A THIS
BILL SIMPLY SAYS THAT TO CREATE
A SCENARIO.
WHERE WHAT YOU'RE PAYING?
IS GENERALLY JUST THE INTERESTS.
I SHOULD NOT BE THE CASE TO PAY
A HUNDRED PERCENT.
A PAY AN INTEREST RATE THAT IS A
HUNDRED PERCENT.
FOR TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
LOAN SHOULD NOT BE THE CASE.
TO HAVE A FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
LOAN.
BECOME FORTY.
SOME THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH OF
DEBT.
SHOULD NOT BE THE CASE.
I KNOW FOR A FACT THIS AUTHOR
WANTS TO WORK WITH THIS SECTOR.
AND WITH THE INDUSTRY.
TO FIND BALLOTS THAT RESPECTS
THAT THERE ARE THOSE WHO WANT TO
STILL USE THESE PRODUCTS.
BUT SIMPLY SAY THAT NO ONE
SHOULD BE COUCHED
OR BE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF.
AND THAT FOR THOSE WHO.
HAVE THE LEAST OPTIONS TO HELP
THEM THEY SHOULD NOT BE PUT INTO
A SITUATION. WITH A PUT AT RISK
THEIR CREDIT HISTORIES PUT AT
RISK THEIR FAMILIES ARE PUT AT
RISK THEIR POSSESSIONS A PUT AT
RISK.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU AYE VOTE
ON AB TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED.
ALL DISCUSSION HAVING CEASED.
KALRA YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES WHO ROSE
IN THE CO AUTHORS OF THOSE. IN
THE ADDITIONAL COAUTHORS OF NINE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS TO SANDERS
CAUGHT IN THIS BILL AND EVERYONE
THAT'S. ENGAGED AYE AS INDICATED
THING I'VE LITERALLY SPENT
HUNDREDS OF HOURS SINCE LAST
YEAR. ON THIS BILL MEETING OF
MUCH OF THAT TIME WITH
OPPOSITION. I TO TRY TO CRAFT A
REASONABLE BALANCE THAT
CURRENTLY DOESN'T EXIST IN OUR
STATE THAT DOES EXIST IN DOZENS
OF OTHER STATES. HOUSE WHEN I
THINK OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE FROM
ACROSS THE AISLE MANY OF WHOM
HAD REALLY A GREAT INPUT. AND I
KNOW ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE ISSUE AND HOW JUST ASK
EVERYONE. TO CONSIDER GIVEN THE
OPTION OF THIS ISSUE MOVE
FORWARD. OF ANY CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED IN THE FINAL
HOUR ARE CERTAINLY THINGS THAT
I'LL TAKE UNDER CONSIDERATION.
AND I REALLY RESPECT.
MY FELLOW MEMBERS GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING THIS BILL
UP THANK YOU.
WITH THAT CLERK LIBERAL. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
CLOSER ALL.
TALLY VOTE.
I TWENTY FIVE NO TWENTY THREE
THE MEASURE FAILS.
SURE CALDERON YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHORS PLEASE
MOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. ITEM FIFTEEN AB
THIRTY ONE OF FOUR COOPER AND
ITEM FORTY ONE AB TWENTY THREE A
THREE THURMAN.
LOCAL NO.
MEMBERS WE STILL HAVE A NUMBER
OF BILLS ON CALL
THAT WAS REALLY VOTE CHANGES.
IF YOU WISH MS BAKER FROM YOUR
DESK.
THIS BAKER FROM YOUR DESK.
AB TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN NOTE I.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BAKER ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN NOTE I.
MISTER MAYES.
AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY SIX I DID
NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES.
SOME ABLE TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY SIX
AYE TOUGH VOTING.
MS QUIRK SILVA.
AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE I TO KNOW
VOTE.
A SOME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
ASSIGNABLE EIGHTEEN FIFTY AND
NINE I IT'S NOT VOTING.
MS QUIRK SILVA AGAIN.
WITH MY MAKE.
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY THREE NO TO
KNOW VOTE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN NINETY
THREE.
NO TO NOT VOTING.
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE NO TO
KNOW VOTE.
SAWYER QUICKSILVER.
SOME WILL THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE
NOTES NOT VOTING.
AND AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY THREE
I TOOK NO.
SOMETHING OUR QUIKSILVER
ASSEMBLY PLANT TWENTY THREE I TO
KNOW.
MISTER BIGELOW.
THANK YOU.
AB THIRTY ONE NINETY FOUR NO TIE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BIGELOW.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE NINETY
FOUR NOTES I.
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY NINE AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY ONE I TO
KNOW.
IT'S ONLY EVER OBERNOLTE.
ASSEMBLY TWENTY THREE EIGHTY ONE
I TO KNOW.
MISTER KANSEN CHU. GO ON AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE NOTE TO
AYE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KANSEN CHU.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY NOTES I.
DOCTOR QUIRK.
OUR A. B. TWENTY TO FORTY AYE TO
NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK.
SYMBOL TWENTY TO FORTY ITES NOT
VOTING.
MISTER KALRA.
BUT NUMBER THIRTY AB THIRTY
THIRTY AYE TO NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AS A LABEL
THIRTY THIRTY AYE TOP VOTING.
MR GRAYSON. AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
THREE I TO NOT VOTING.
IF I AM EVER GRAYSON SABLE
TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE. I IT'S
NOT VOTING.
MISTER LACKEY.
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY SEVEN NO T.
S..
SIMON LACKEY.
ASSIGNABLE TWENTY SIX FIFTY
SEVEN NOTE I.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM NINETY TWO. AB
TWENTY SIX FORTY ONE THIS IS
DOCTOR WOULD CARPOOL POST.
I'M MEMBERS VOTER WISHED ABOUT
THIS
FIFTY FOUR.
Z. FIFTY FOR VOTE FILL ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW THE VOTE.
I SPEEDY FOR KNOWS THIRTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS ARE VERY TO LIVE THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM THIRTY FIVE
MAYBE NINETEEN THIRTEEN.
BY MISTER KALRA.
CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO
VOTE.
HOMEOWNERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
CLOSER ROLE.
ANTI OF EYES TWENTY FOUR.
KNOWS TWENTY NINE.
THAT MEASURE FAILS.
AND CRADLE OF THE CALL FILE ITEM
NINETY AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN BY KALRA CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS HAD WHICH TO VOTE
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL TIE THAT
ICE FORTY ONE.
KNOWS THIRTY THREE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PREPARE TO LIFT THE CALL FILE
ITEM TWELVE AB TWENTY FIVE.
FORTY SIX BY.
MR CHOW.
CORPORAL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WISHED ABOUT.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL AND TALLY THE VOTE
AYE AYES FORTY FOUR DOES TWENTY
EIGHT THAT MEASURE.
HOUSES.
PREPARE TO LIVE THE CALL FILE
AND THIRTY SIX AB NINETEEN FORTY
BY MR MCCARTY CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WHICH TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS HER DESIRED ABOUT
MISTER MCCOY YOU NEED A THREE POINTER.
MR MCCARTY REPLACES THE CALL
.
PREPARE TO LIVE THE CALLER FILE
ITEM SIXTY THREE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT.
SEVENTY FOUR BY MISTER THURMAN
CLERK WILL POST.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
TALLY.
THE VOTE EYES TWENTY FIVE KNOWS
THIRTY ONE.
THAT. MEASURE FAILS.
PREPARE TO LIFT THE CALL ON FILE
ITEM SIXTY TWO.
AB.
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY THREE BY
MISTER GLORIA CORPORAL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE.
S. TAKES FIFTY FOUR
THOSE ROLE AND HOW YOU VOTE
EYES FORTY NINE KNOWS TWENTY
FOUR THAT MEASURE FAILS.
MORE PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL
ON FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY FOUR BY
MISTER BLOOM.
THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL
ALL MEMBERS HER WISH TO THE
WE'RE GONNA REPLACE THE CALL
WE
MISTER DALLI.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FIRST.
AB THREE TWO TWO TWO.
FROM NO TO AYE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DALLY.
AS UNABLE THIRTY TO TWENTY TWO
NOTES I.
PREPARE TO LIFT THE CALL FILE
ITEM SIXTY SIX AB TWENTY NINE
FORTY SIX MISTER KALRA CLERK
WILL POST.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW THE THE VOTE.
I SIXTEEN KNOWS TWENTY NINE THAT
MEASURE FAILS
.
FILE ITEM FIFTY TO WERE LEFT IN
THE CALL ON FIFTY TWO THIS IS AB
TWENTY SIX OH EIGHT MINISTERS
DOWN THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WISH TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WHICH DEVELOP
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES FIFTY FOUR. KNOWS TWENTY
FOUR.
THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
WE CAN ENTERTAIN THOUGH CHANGES
MISSED YOUR BLOOM FOR YOUR VOTE
CHANGE.
YOU ARE A BLUM AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY FOUR. ITEM NO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY FOUR ITEM NO.
AND MR BONTA FOR YOUR VOTE
CHANGE.
BONTA ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX
FORTY NINE I TEND NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA AT SOME
LEVEL TWENTY SIX FORTY NINE I
IT'S NOT VOTING
VOTE CHANGES.
IT IS FRIEDMAN FROM YOUR DEATH
THANK YOU. AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY FOUR YES TO NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY FOUR I CANNOT VOTING
CALL ON FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY FOUR BY
MISTER BLOOM.
PURPLE POSTS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WHICH TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER WRONG TIED ABOUT EYES
TWENTY FIVE KNOWS THIRTY FIVE
THAT MEASURE FAILS
MEMBERS PREPARED TO LIFT THE
COLUMN FILE AND WHEN THIRTY FOUR
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE.
A PROPOSED.
UNDERSTUDY WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM
WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TOWN ABOUT AYE AYES
FORTY TWO KNOWS TWENTY SEVEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES
JUST A FEW MORE BILLS ON CALL
MEMBERS
SEVERAL OF THE CALL ON FILE
ITEM THIRTY SIX SAYS AB NINETEEN
FORTY.
MCCARTY CORPORAL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
WE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE. AND
TALLY THE VOTES.
I THIRTY FIVE KNOWS THIRTY FIVE
THAT MEASURE FAILS
.
MEMBERS I AM GOING TO RECOGNIZE.
MS BAKER FROM MY DESK ON THE
FLOOR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
WE CAN'T DO THIS JOB WITHOUT
REALLY GREAT STAFF.
WHO WERE SUPER HARD?
FOR ALL OF US.
SOME OF THEM HAVE BEEN IN THIS
BUILDING WORKING VERY HARD FOR
MANY MANY YEARS AND I HAVE ONE
OF THEM STANDING NEXT TO ME AND
TONIGHT IS OUR LAST NIGHT SHE'S
RETIRING FROM THE INSIDES OF
THIS BUILDING.
NAME IS AARON TODAY SHE'S BEEN
MY CHIEF OF STAFF FOR A LITTLE
BIT OVER A YEAR AND HAS SURVIVED
PERHAPS ONE OF THE MOST INTENSE
OFFICES.
AND.
ALSO HAS WORKED FOR MANY
MEMBERS.
.
FOR MANY YEARS OVER SEVEN YEARS
IN THIS BUILDING. WE CAN'T DO IT
WITHOUT THEM I HAVE BEEN
PRIVILEGED TO HAVE HER SERVE ON
OUR TEAM IN VERY VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THE LATE NIGHTS ALL THE HARD
WORK AND ALL THE FINE. AND
SOMETIMES THE NOT FUN.
AND SO MEMBERS.
I WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU. TO
MY CHIEF AARON TODAY FOR ALL THE
WONDERFUL TWELVE AND A HALF
MONTHS THAT YOU SURVIVED AND ALL
THE MANY YEARS OF GREAT SERVICE
TO THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE CAUCUS. AND
EVERYONE IN THIS BUILDING PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THANKING AARON TODAY
MEMBERS REPAIR TO LIFT THE CALL
ON FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO AB
THIRTY ONE FORTY SIX HOLDING HER
PROPOSED. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH
TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE EYES THIRTY.
THOSE THIRTY FIVE. THAT MEASURE
FAILS.
MEMBERS.
SINCE.
SESSION HAS GONE INTO OVERTIME.
THE LAST FEW NIGHTS.
LET ME TAKE A QUICK MOMENT TO
THANK OUR CHIEF CLERK DAWSON
WILL SEND AS WELL AS A GAS STAFF.
LONG HOURS BECAUSE THEY HAVE PUT
IN THIS WEEK.
SIMPLY CAN'T ACCOMPLISH OUR TASK
WITHOUT THEIR TREMENDOUS WORK
AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
OUR CHIEF SERGEANT BRIAN CUSTIS
IN AS WELL AS THE REST OF THE
SERGEANTS.
PERSISTING AFTER HOW LONG.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR GOOD WORK.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
MONDAY JUNE FOURTH FLOOR SESSION
ONE PM ALL OF THEM ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED RETAIN
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MS BAKER MOVES A MISTER COOLEY
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY JUNE
FOURTH AT ONE PM IN THE QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED
LADIES FIRST.
THANK.
QUIRK SILVA AB TWO THREE FOUR
THIRTY THREE. I TO KNOW VOTE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA IS A
LITTLE TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE.
I KNOW.
AND MOTION BY GALLAGHER TO
SUSPEND RULES NO TWO I.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
ON THE MOTION TO SUSPEND THE
RULES NOTES I.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY THREE. I
CANNOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO NINETY
THREE.
I DO NOT VOTING
.
GALLAGHER AB TWO TWO SEVEN SIX
NO TO NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO SEVENTY
SIX NOTES NOT VOTING